this course is a practical and Hands-On
introduction to machine learning with
python and scikit learn for beginners it
is designed and taught by Akash NS who
is the CEO and co-founder of Jovian
you'll learn about a bunch of common
machine learning models and different
types of machine learning by the end of
this course you'll be able to
confidently build train and deploy
machine learning models in the real
world the topic for today is linear
regression with psychic learn this is
the first topic we are covering in
machine learning with
python and in fact one of the things
we'll try and do today is to apply
linear regression to a real world
problem and we'll try to predict medical
expenses using this
technique so here's an overview of what
we are going to cover today just a quick
outline so first we'll start by stating
a typical problem statement for machine
learning then we will download an
explore a data
set then we will perform linear
regression with one variable using psyit
learn then we'll perform linear
regression with multiple variables and
don't worry if these terms don't make
sense right now they will by the end of
this
session then we'll use categorical
features for machine
learning learn how to apply that in
general not just for linear regression
we will also talk about regression
coefficients and feature
importance how do you interpret the
outputs of a model that you
create and then we will apply linear
regression to some other data
sets this tutorial is an executable
jupyter notebook hosted on Jovian and
you can run this online on binder or you
can run this on your computer as well
you can also run this on Google collab
and that's perfectly fine
too
so here's the problem that we will solve
today and using this problem we will
Define the terms machine learning and
linear regression in the context of this
problem and then later we'll generalize
their
definitions let's read the problem
carefully and then we'll think about how
we can approach this
problem Acme Insurance Incorporated
offers affordable health insurance to
thousands of customers all over the
United States and as the lead data
scientist at Acme you are tasked with
creating an automated system to estimate
the annual medical expenditure for new
customers using information such as
their age sex BMI children smoking
habits region of residents Etc why are
you asked to do that because estimates
from your system will be used to
determine the annual insurance premium
which is the amount paid every month or
every
year that is offered to the
customer so your job is to figure out
when a new customer applies for medical
insurance based on information like
their age sex BMI
Etc how much they might incur in medical
bills in an average year if you can find
that information along with some other
information can be used to
determine what you should charge the
customer for insurance and this is a
typical problem that you'll face and
it's a typical example of a machine
learning problem where you want to
replace some manual decision making or
one one piece of a manual decision-
making process with some automation so
in this case for example you may need an
expert who has seen customers for
several decades to figure out based on
this information what their medical
information might look like or if you're
a data scientist you can figure that out
using data and that's what we're going
to create today
you need some data to actually figure
this information out but fortunately
because Acme Insurance already has
thousands of
customers they have given you a CSV file
so here's a CSV file that your manager
or whoever is working on this project
has given you and this CSV file contains
historical data let's say from the past
year for over 1,300 customers so you can
see here we have information like age
sex B Mi the body mass index number of
children whether this person is a smoker
or not which region of the country they
belong to and the actual medical charges
they incurred in the previous year all
right so we have some historical data
and we would want recent historical data
not going too far behind because medical
charges can change due to inflation and
due to other reasons as
well so that's the data you have and
your job is to create some kind of a
system which can take this information
age sex BMI children smoker region for a
new customer and estimate what their
charges are going to be over the coming
year okay and here's a source for this
data set this is a popular data set that
is used in machine
learning now before we proceed further
just take a moment to think about how
you can approach this
problem let's begin by downloading the
data
so we will download the data using the
URL retrieve function from URL li.
request this is a simple function that's
already present in the python standard
Library URL
Li so let's get the URL into a variable
called medical charges URL and let's
import from URL li. request from URL li.
request the URL retrieve function and
let's call URL retrieve with the medical
charges URL and let's download the data
to this file file medical.
CSV okay so now we have a file medical.
CSV which should have the required
data
next is to create a pandas data frame
using the downloaded file to view and
analyze the data so let's install the
pandas Library using pip and then we
import pandas using the Alias
PD and then we call pd. read CSV and
give it the name of the CSV file
and here we have the data frame so the
first step is to get the data into your
jupyter notebook no matter what kind of
problem you're working on whether it is
Data analysis or machine
learning and one way to get the data is
by downloading it using URL lib the
other way to do it is you can go file
open and then you can click the upload
button
here you can click the upload button
here and upload the file from your
computer we've also looked at other ways
to download data sets for example from
kaggle and we will apply all of these
different techniques at different points
in this course so here's the
data and this data contains
1,338 rows and seven
columns each row of the data set
contains information about exactly one
customer our objective is to find a way
to estimate the value in the charges
column using the values in the other
columns now if we can do so for
historical data then we should be able
to estimate the charges for new
customers too simply by asking forther
information like age sex BMI Etc maybe
in an application form okay so let's
first check the data type for each
column we go medical DF
doino
and we have seven columns age and age
seems to be an integer sex seems to be a
string as you can see here male and
female so actually it's more of a
categorical column but let's just call
it a string for now BMI seems to be a
floating Point number and you can see
here in BMI we can have these decimals
age can also have decimals but it looks
like we've only collected the integer
portion of the age so that's what we're
working
with then we have children this is the
number of children the customer has and
this is again an integer and typically
this would be a number like 0 1 2 3 then
we have smoker whether the person smokes
or not and this has a yes no answer so
this was probably a tick box somewhere
in a form so this is also a categorical
column which we have in the form of a
string right now then we have a region
so it seems like there are different
regions customers can belong to like
Southwest southeast northwest Northeast
seems like there are four of them but
we'll have to
check and finally we have the actual
annual medical
charges incurred by the
customer so there are numeric columns
and then there are categorical or string
columns and among the numeric there are
integers and floating Point numbers as
well now one good thing here is that
there are no null entries if you see
here non-null count that is 1338
which is also the total number of
entries so that means that there are no
empty values in any columns so none of
the columns contain any missing values
and that already saves us a fair bit of
work but don't worry we will deal with
missing values in future
lessons next let us look at some
statistics for the numerical
columns so if we call Medical DF do
describe that is going to give us
information like the count mean standard
deviation minimum minum and all the
percentiles like 25 percentile 50
percentile which is the median 75
percentile and the maximum and this is
always a good thing to do at the very
beginning just to see if the data the
range of data makes
sense and I would say that the data
makes sense seems like the average age
is around 40 seems like the standard
deviation is 15 minimum is 18 maximum is
64 okay we already know that 18 is the
minimum age 64 is the maximum age they
both seem reasonable but this also tells
us that perhaps the insurance company
does not take applications below the age
of 18 or above the age of
64 then we have the BMI so with the BMI
it seems like the minimum is 15 so the
BMI just to give you a sense
is the mass of a person in kilograms
divided by the square of their height so
it's a ratio of mass or weight to the
square of a person's height in meters so
BMI this is in the units kilogram per
meter Square so it seems like the BMI is
the minimum is around
15.96% variation in the charges from
1,000 to
64,000 not only that you can also see
that if you check the 50% Mark 50% of
people have their medical charges under
$10,000 or even 75% have it under
$116,000 so that means there is a huge
skew or there are several outliers in
the charges column and we'll see that in
more detail once we study the
visualizations but even just by looking
at these numbers you can tell some of
these things the mean is 13,000 but the
50% Mark is 9,000 so there's a bit of a
skew in the
data so this is what you should do
whenever you load up a data frame just
look at the data just look at all these
statistics and try and draw whatever
inferences you can in this case once
again there don't seem to be any
incorrect values like negative ages or
ages greater than 200 let's say or any
negative values everything seems nice
and clean so somebody has put together
this data set for
us made sure that it is pristine all the
data is valid and there is no missing
data that makes our job a lot
easier so that was downloading the data
so let me just
save my project at this point I'm just
going to import the Jovian library and
click Jovian doc commit make sure you're
saving your notebook from time to
time so now we've downloaded the data so
let's start by doing what we know let's
start by just doing some exploratory
analysis and visualization and let's see
where that can take
us we will visualize the distributions
of values in some of the columns and we
will also find the relationships between
the charges columns and the other
columns because we have to use the other
columns to predict
charges and we will use the libraries
Matt plot lib seon and plotly for
visualization plotly specifically
because it will give us some interactive
charts and save us some coding but a lot
of all of these plots can be done using
just Matt plot Li and cbon as well and
I've linked to some tutorials here that
you can check out in case you want to
refresh or learn one of these
libraries so I'm going to install these
libraries first using
pip
all right and then I'm going to import
these libraries so I'm going to import
plotly do Express which is a high level
API that makes it really easy to create
plotly interactive charts then I'm going
to import matplot lib and I'm going to
import matplot li. pyplot as PLT this is
how typically mat plot lib is
imported and finally I'm going to import
cbon as SNS so these are all the
conventional ways in which these
libraries are imported one last thing we
have is matte plot lib in line the
purpose of this line is to ensure that
any charts that you create they show up
as outputs within your jupyter notebook
and not as popups because when you close
a popup the chart goes
away all right so now we have imported
the libraries one other thing I'm going
to do is
just change some settings which which
will improve the default style and the
font sizes for our charts we're just
going to make the font sizes a bit
larger and use the dark grid style for
cbon this will only apply to Mt plot lib
and cbon not to
plotly okay let's begin with the First
Column age and age is a numeric column
the minimum age in the data set is 18
and the maximum age in the data set is
64 so we can visualize the distribution
of age using a
histogram essentially trying to find out
how many
people how many customers we have for
every age from 18 to 64 so that means we
need 64 minus 18 + 1 or 47 bins one for
each
year and that way we'll be able to
visualize it using a histogram another
useful plot is a box plot a box plot is
also quite useful because it tells you
the minimum the maximum the median and
all the quartiles so that can give you a
sense of the distribution of of where
the 50% point lies and using plotly we
can actually create both of these charts
with just one line of code we say px.
histogram pass in the medical DF data
frame and then we specify that we just
want to use the age on the
x-axis and we want to use 47 bins and we
want to give the charter title distrib
bution of age now by adding this
marginal equals box
parameter plotly will also plot a box
plot right
above the histogram for
us so here's what the distribution of
age looks like you can see here at the
age of 18 we have 69 customers at the
age of 19 we have 68 then we have
anywhere from 20 to 30 customers at
every age seems like a lot of people
here in the range of 40 to 50 and then
here we have the highest age which is 64
and nobody beyond the age of
64 it's a nice uniform distribution
almost if you just ignore these two
values you can see that the midpoint is
around
39 and the quartiles are also equally
balanced on each
side so the distribution of Ages in the
data set is almost uniform with 20 to 30
customers for every age except for the
ages of 18 and 19 which seem to have
over twice as many
customers compared to other
ages now to explain this piece the
uniform distribution might simply arise
from the fact that there is not a big
variation in the number of people at any
given age between 18 and 64 in the
United States for example if we open up
this other chart that's available online
this tells you the population in
different age ranges so you can see here
15 to 19 20 to 24 25 to 29 so it seems
like the and it split across male and
female but the overall population you
can clearly see across different age
groups is fairly
similar and you can assume that there is
a certain percentage of people of
certain percentage of population that
takes their insurance
from Acme Insurance Incorporated so
that's why you see this kind of a
distribution which reflects the overall
population this is always something that
you should check whenever you have a
data set does the data you have reflect
the distribution of the overall
population or not well in this case in
one case it does
not and I will let you figure out why
this might be the case can you explain
why there are over twice as many
customers with the ages 18 and 19
compared to other
ages if I have had to guess I would
probably guess that maybe Acme insurance
is offering a lower insurance premium if
you sign up before the age of 20 that
could be one reason and also because
maybe 18 is the legal age for you to be
able to get insurance at least from this
company so a lot of people as soon as
they turn 18 get the insurance that
could be one of the other
reasons but neither of these we can
assume we would have to then go and
verify if this is indeed the case maybe
even look at some industry averages if
you can find some Reports
online okay so that was the distribution
of age it was mostly uniform with a
couple
of years where we had twice as many
people next let's look at the
distribution of body mass
index once again we are going to create
a histogram of the body mass index and
this time we are going to to use uh the
red color and we're going to have a box
plot once
again so here is the distribution of the
body mass index and this looks very
different it seems like it is
distributed according to a gosan
distribution or what is also called a
normal
distribution here's what a normal
distribution looks like so if you have a
certain population of data yeah this is
the one so if you have a certain
population of data
where most of the values are centered
around a single value the what is called
the mean and then you have a decreasing
probability as you go away from that
mean that's called a normal or goian
distribution right and this is exactly
what is visible
here why is this goian and why is the
previous one
normal I'll let you think about that but
what we can notice here with BMI is that
most people have a BMI or a body mass
index around 30 maybe in the range of 25
to 35 and then as you get further
away fewer people seem to have that BMI
so 25 to 35 roughly speaking might
represent the average
human in terms of the ratio of weight to
height and here's how you can interpret
body mass index values or this is how
they're typically
interpreted less than 18.5 is considered
underweight and then 18.5 to 24.9 is
considered normal to overweight is well
25 to 29.9 is considered overweight
slightly more than 30 30 to 39 is
considered obese and greater than 40 is
considered morbid obesity now this is an
important factor from the health
perspective
typically people are expected to be in
the normal to overweight
range if they are underweight then they
are more susceptible to certain diseases
and if they are obese or even midly
obese then they are more susceptible to
certain illnesses as well and this is
why this is one important piece of
information that is requested in your
insurance form so as we perform this
analysis as you see with age you can see
with age that there may be a certain
relationship between age and medical
charges and you can try and guess what
that relationship might be and then
there may be a certain relationship
between BMI and medical charges as well
with BMI I'm guessing somewhere in
between might be lower medical charges
if you to either extreme maybe you will
have higher medical
charges now let's look at the most
important column the distribution of
charges and before I look at the
distribution do you want to take a guess
on what the distribution of charges is
going to look like just think about it
we've already seen the the description
we've already seen the statistics for
it so here we are creating a histogram
once again px. histogram and we have a
medical data frame the DF the data frame
on the x-axis we want to show charges
and we also want to show a box plot
above the histogram and then we want to
set the title to annual medical charges
but we have
another important section here this is
called
smoker so what we're doing is we want to
split the histogram of charges for
smoker versus not non-smoker so we have
a column smoker and we're going to use
that to split the data and here's what
that gives
us green represents people who have
responded Yes to smoker and no gray
represents people who have not responded
Yes to Smoker so you can see here that
people who are not smokers seem to have
lower medical lower annual medical
charge chares in fact most people in
general overall seem to fall in
the maybe like 5,000 what is this 2,000
to
$115,000 expense category so most people
are spending between $2,000 to $155,000
not more than that which is not a very
high expense and then there are some
people who need to spend a lot every
year and there is a stock difference
between people who smoke and people who
do not it seems like 50% the median for
nonsmokers is 7,300 and the medium for
smokers seems to be
34,000
now it's not entirely clear if this is
because they are smokers if it is just
generally true that you will have a
higher medical if you smoke regularly or
is it that more people who smoke are
taking life insurance and maybe fewer
people who smoke do not smoke are taking
life insurance so we don't know what
this means all we know is that people
who have responded Yes to Smoker seem to
have
have a higher median medical
expense but in general you can see that
this follows the exponential
distribution or more appropriately this
is called the power law so in the power
law what happens is you have a lot of
people along the smaller numbers you
have a lot of people which who have a
very low expense and then you can see
this exponential
decrease in the medical charges and if
you were to separate out smokers and
non-smokers and plot them separately so
you would see that for nonsmokers you
have this exponential decay and maybe
for smokers you have that as well but it
seems like there are two sections maybe
this is just general smokers and this is
maybe smokers with some ailments right
so there is something to discover here
why we are seeing this kind of a pattern
maybe do we need another category of
like light smokers and heavy smokers we
might need to look into this but at the
very least we're already starting to
observe some trends that the charges
have that for most most customers the
annual medical charges are under $10,000
$14,000 and only a small fraction of
customers have higher medical expenses
possibly due to accidents major
illnesses or genetic diseases and this
is what happens most of the population
is healthy most of the population
probably does not need to go to a
hospital every year maybe except for a
few checkups regular checkups but some
people unfortunately either have
accidents or major Ines or genetic
diseases right so that's why they may
incur a
higher medical expense and the second is
that there is a significance difference
in medical expenses between smokers and
nonsmokers while the median for smoke
nonsmokers is 7,300 the median for
smokers is close to
35,000 okay so next up here's an
exercise for you visualize the
distribution of medical charges in
connection with some other factors like
sex and region so maybe replace this by
sex and replace this by region and see
if you see a similar disparity across
males and females or across different
regions okay so while we're talking
about the smoker column let's try and
visualize the distribution there so
let's just see how many examples we have
for each so it seems like out of the
1300 or so people we have
thousand or so have responded no for
smoker and around 274 have responded Yes
so about 20% of the customers are
smokers and we can visualize this using
a histogram as well so we say px.
histogram we pass in the data frame for
X on the X column we have smoker and
let's break down the visualization by
sex this time so here you can see that
yes represents people who responded Yes
to smoker and that number seems to be in
total about 268 or so and no represents
people have responded no but this is
also broken down by sex so you can see
that about 115 females said yes and 159
males on the other hand 517 males said
no and 547 females so it seems that
smoking is more common among males and
this is something that you should try
and
verify this is something that you you
should try and verify and similarly it
also seems like 20% of the customers
have reported that they smoke so this is
also again something that you should try
and verify see if this matches with the
national average and you can assume that
the data was collected in 2010 this data
set has been around for about 10 years
now the reason you should verify these
things as you're performing this
analysis and the reason you should
perform this analysis in the first place
is to understand if the distribution of
the data that you
have match is the distribution of the
population itself right if your data
contains 90% smokers but in the general
population there are only about 10%
smokers then any analysis that you do or
any model that you build will be wrong
because it will be built under the
assumption that 90% of the inputs that
are coming to the model are going to
have yes in smokers so that's why
wherever you're building a model make
sure that the distributions of each
column match the distributions of the
populations
where the model will be
applied so with that we've looked at the
individual columns you can also try and
visualize the distribution of sex region
and children and report your
observations okay so now having looked
at some individual
columns we can now visualize the
relationship between charges which is
the value that we wish to predict and
the other
columns
I would guess that age would be one of
the most important factors in
determining your medical expenses so
let's visualize the relationship between
age and charges using a scatter
plot so we use px. scatter we pass in
the data frame medical
DF we pass in the data frame medical
DF and on the x-axis we want to show the
age on the y- axis we want to show the
charges and we will show a single point
on the chart for each
customer now whenever you have a SC
scatter plot you should also use the
opportunity to maybe add some color so
maybe let's color the points based on
whether the person is smoker or not and
let us just set the opacity of points to
08 because we have over a thousand
customers so we may have some
overlapping points so just so so that we
able to better see the data let's just
reduce the opacity a little bit of the
points and finally we just setting a
title as
well okay so now we have this
chart and this looks very interesting I
can see three clear clusters
here here's what I can see I can see
three clear clusters of points and Each
of which seems to form line with an
increasing slope you can see that this
seems to roughly lie in a line of course
it goes up and down but roughly you can
see a linear Trend here and then you
have the second cluster which also seems
to have a somewhat linear Trend as
increasing with age but if you look
carefully you have a mix of smokers and
non-smokers in this
cluster it's possible that this is
actually two different clusters which
just happen to fall in a similar place
for example if I turn off
smoker
this is what we get so it seems like
among nonsmokers most people incur a
fairly low medical expense that goes
from 0 to 5,000 at age 18 and goes up to
13 to 15,000 at age
64 but then there are some as we said
there are maybe 5 10% of people who
unfortunately due to accidents genetic
ailments or just major illnesses have to
spend a lot
more
and then there's probably a similar
Trend here for smokers you can see here
this is seems to be the Baseline so
probably if you're just smoking don't
have any other ailments this is where
you are and then here you have another
group of
people so it's possible that these are
people who are smokers and have ailments
or as there was one suggestion maybe it
is a combination of being a smoker and
also being uh obese so it's possible
that is that could be the reason for
this so it's worth investigating but you
can see here there are two clear
sections maybe you need a smoker and a
heavy smoker section maybe that makes a
big difference maybe two cigarettes a
day doesn't make a difference but 20
does so all of these interesting tends
here and that's what we've summarized
here and this is the general thing that
you should do in your exploratory
analysis Whenever You observe a trend
summarize it and try to offer some
explanation and you can mention clearly
that there are certain hypotheses like
where you using the terms like it's
possible which means that this is
something to be verified and then
presumably which means that okay you
have one cluster for smokers and one
cluster for smokers with medical issues
or it could be smokers uh who are also
obese so we don't know we'll have to
study this we'll have to dig deeper and
try and figure it out so I'll leave that
as an exercise for you and there are
definitely more inferences that you can
draw from the above chart so I'll let
you draw that as well for for example
what percentage of people lie outside
the norm so this how many people lie in
this region and how many people lie
outside so what are the number of
outliers let's look at BMI this seems
again to be an important factor so let's
visualize the relationship between body
mass index and charges using another
scatter plot once again we will use px.
scatter on the x-axis this time we will
use BMI on the y- axis we will use
charges and we will color the points
once again using the smoker column and
we will set the opacity to 08 and we
will set on Hover we'll also show the SE
so that when you hover over a point you
have some more information and we set a
title for the
chart so here's what the chart looks
like and now you can see that the
picture is starting to get a little
clearer so if you see here if I turn off
yes you can see that there seems to be
no real relationship between BMI and
medical charges maybe BMI is a flawed
metric maybe it doesn't really make
sense you can see here that you have
numbers all over the place and if
anything you have some outliers here
somewhere in between in the 20 to 40
range not Beyond 50 or not below 20 but
that could also be because there are
very few people below 20 or Beyond
40 but once you add in the smokers or if
you just look at the smokers you can
start to see a trend here so it's seems
like there are two major clusters below
the BMI of 30 your medical charges stay
low in about the 30k range below the 30k
range and above 30 then they seem to
increase so smoking combined with
obesity it may appear it might seem that
this might be a bad condition to be in
so this requires more investigation but
we already starting to uncover more
information at this point if you have
doubts you should probably reach out to
some somebody in the company somebody
who actually has some expertise in the
field and ask them if this is indeed the
case and all of these things are going
to be important because the model that
you
build you will have to explain why it
gives the predictions that it does a a
lot of times because there are
regulatory requirements there are
regulatory requirements in healthcare
there are regulatory requirements in
finance and a bunch of other domains as
well so that's why understanding these
relationships is
important what other insights can you
gather just try and see if you can
gather some other insights from this
graph and try and create some more
graphs to visualize how the charges
column is related to other columns for
example charges against children do you
see that there is a general increase in
charges when you have more children or
charges with sex do you see that there's
a difference between males and females
maybe compare with
region and maybe directly compare with
smoker maybe just look at the average
charges for smokers and the average
charges for
non-smokers here's a hint for you you
might want to to use the violin plot for
some of these for example if you do px.
scatter medical
DF and on the x-axis you put
children and on the y axis you
put
charges there's a problem here you can't
really tell much
because the value of children is not
continuous it goes from 0o to 1 to 3 to
four to five so we don't know if there
are Five Points here or 50 points or 500
it's very hard to tell because they're
all on top of each other so if you just
change scatter to
violin and if you've ever wondered why a
violin chart is useful now you'll see
just change it to violin now you can see
that you also have this width for this
chart the width tells you how many
values lie here relatively so it seems
like you have a bunch of values here A
bunch of values here and then you have
all these outliers and now you can
observe a general Trend you you can see
that the bulk of values shift up as we
go with the number of children
increasing so as the number of children
increases the potential medical costs
seem to slightly increase not by a lot
because there are many people who have a
very low medical cost despite having
four children there are many people who
have a very high medical cost without
despite having high children despite
having zero children okay but there is
some sort of a trend here a very weak
Trend but a trend
nevertheless so as you can tell from the
analysis the values in some columns are
more closely related to the values and
charges compared to other columns for
example age and charges seem to grow
together and BMI and charges
don't so the
relationship
between two
columns on whether they grow together or
not is often expressed numerically using
a measure called a correlation
coefficient and there's a certain
formula for it and there's a certain
meaning it has but first let's just see
how to compute the correlation
coefficient the correlation coefficient
can be computed using the docr or do
core method of a panda Series so if we
say medical DF do charges. Core Medical
DF do AG so we want to compute the
correlation between charges and age and
it seems like the correlation is.
29 okay and we'll see what that means in
just a second and then if you want to
compute the correlation between the
medical charges and the BM it seems like
the correlation here
is9 so there's definitely a higher
correlation between age and charges than
there is between BMI and
charges and maybe let's also compare
children so with children there seems to
be a even lower correlation than the
BMI okay so that's how you compute
correlation between
columns and you can also compute
correlation for categorical columns it
won't work work
directly at least I believe it won't
medical DF do smoker it won't work
directly because you need numeric data
to compute the
correlation so what you need to First do
is com com convert your categorical data
into numeric
data so here's what I'm going to
do I am going to create a new series
called smoker
numeric and how are we going to do that
we're going to take medical DF do smoker
and we can call map on it so map takes
either a function or a dictionary and it
applies it to every value so here we've
supplied a dictionary no or a dictionary
which converts no into zero and yes into
one so when you call Medical DF do
smoker. map smoker values then it
wherever you have a no that's going to
convert to zero wherever you have a yes
that's going to convert
to one so this is a very useful
technique whenever you want to quick
quickly convert some categories into
numbers let's and let's compare that
let's see medical
DF
smoker so you have yes no no no and you
have 1 0 0 0 now once it is converted
into a number you can then compute the
correlation so you see medical DF do
charges. correlation smoker numeric and
that has a correlation of
787 so now you can start to see the
trend 787 for smoker probably the
highest correlation then you have with
age 299 then you have with charges .19
and then you have with children 06 and
then there are some other categorical
columns as well so we're not just're not
done yet so here's how the correlation
coefficient is interpreted it indicates
two things it indicates strength and it
indicates the direction so the greater
the absolute value of the correlation
coefficient the stronger is the
relationship which means that if you
have a extreme value like minus one or
one
and one is pretty much the highest value
that you can get you cannot get
something higher than one or lower than
minus one that indicates a perfectly
linear relationship where a change in
one variable is accompanied by A Perfect
consistent change in the other
variable which means essentially that
these points lie on a line and there's a
geometric interpretation here so if you
have X and Y let's say age and charges
and you saw this kind of a graph that
would mean perfect correlation
correlation of one this would be
positive correlation and if you had a
chart like this where it was a line but
one increase in one led to decrease in
the other that would be a perfect
negative correlation close to minus
one but you generally have something in
between you have strong positive
correlation where these points are
distributed around the line or a weak
positive correlation where there is a
weak trend of some kind or no
correlation at all where points are all
over the place or you can have a weak
negative or strong negative correlation
right so that's the direction the sign
of the correlation coefficients
represents the direction of the
relationship if it's positive then you
have an increasing relationship if it's
negative then you have a decreasing
relationship if the correlation
coefficient is very close to zero then
you have practically no
correlation okay and the correlation
coefficient has a formula and you can
check out this formula this is simply
the sum
of x i minus the mean of x y i minus the
mean of Y added up divided by a square
root of some other
quantity I'll let you figure out what
this formula means because it's not very
important it's
simply a question of carefully looking
at each of the terms and listing out
what it means but this is the more
important interpretation that you should
have when you see correlations you see
plus one this is what you see you see
something let's say greater than5
greater than 7 this is what you should
imagine less than 05 this is what you
should imagine close to zero is this and
less than zero these are the pictures
you should have in mind okay and if you
really want to learn the mathematical
definition and the geometric
interpretation I have linked to a video
here but this picture pretty much
summarizes everything we need to know
okay now the panda data frames also
provide a Corr method to compute the
correlation coefficients between all
pairs of numeric columns so if I just
call Medical DF
docr that's going to compute the
correlation between age BMI children
charges which are the numeric columns
with
the other numeric columns and you can
see age and age so age has a perfect
correlation with itself if you plot age
with age and you can do that you can do
something like this px.
scatter you have medical
DF x equals age and Y equals
age you see that there's obviously a
perfect correlation it's a straight line
so age has a perfect
correlation but what we're interested in
is the correlation of charges with the
other columns you can see that AG has a
correlation of 0 299 with charges BMI
has a weaker correlation of1 198 and
children has a even weaker correlation
of
067 okay and finally charges with
charges obviously has a correlation of
one now this is normally displayed using
a heat map because it's difficult to
look at all these numbers and figure
things out so you can just show a heat
map like this this is called a COR
Matrix I've simply passed it into SNS do
heatmap from
cbon and this also adds some color and
helps you visualize that seems like age
and charges have a high
correlation okay so that's the
correlation Matrix and one last thing I
want to mention is the correlation
versus causation policy note that a high
correlation cannot be used to interpret
a cause effect relationship between
features two features X and Y can be
correlated if x causes y or if y causes
X you can see that in the formula if you
replace x with Y and Y with X nothing
changes it's the same formula if you
flip the axis here nothing changes the
relationship Remains the Same so it does
not give you a direction to interpret
causation in okay that's very important
X could cause y or Y could cause X or
it's possible that both are caused
independently by some other Factor Z and
the correlation will no longer hold true
if one of those cause effect
relationships is broken like if Z causes
x and z causes y but if you fix or
change whatever effect Z has on y then X
and Y will no longer be correlated so
that's why do not interpret cause effect
relationships from correlations it's
easy and a lot of people do it even
though it seems obvious a lot of people
do it but it's wrong just to give you an
example for example if you let
say created a scatter plot between race
and income you would find that maybe a
certain race has lower income and a
certain race has higher income and if
you want to create a cause effect
relationship there you could say that
income is a function of race that if you
belong to a certain race you will earn
less and then you may read more
information into that and that is
because of such and such reasons Etc but
it's possible that this is because of
something else entirely for example
racism systemic racism that may have
caused incomes to be lower for a
particular race right and once you fix
that and maybe if you control for that
if you see people who have not been
subjected for several generations to
racism you might find that you no longer
have the same correlation right so try
not to read too much into these graphs
always be careful because it's a very
natural human tendency to create these
interpretations and when it becomes even
more magnified is when these in these
correlations are captured in automated
systems computers cannot def
differentiate between correlation and
causation and decisions based on an
automated system can often have major
consequences on society so it's
important to study why automated systems
lead to a given
result and again another example of this
you may have heard about this facial
recognition technology developed by
Amazon is being used in law
enforcement and it just so happens that
because of the current because of the
current distribution
of uh people who are incarcerated
a certain race has a higher
representation in the incarcerated
population and so the model is more
likely to predict person with a certain
race is a criminal or detect them as a a
criminal and so more people are likely
to be incarcerated from the same race
right so it can actually aggravate the
problems the the problems we have in our
human systems and that is why it's very
important to be mindful of why we are
getting a certain result out of a system
that we create and realize that
determining cause effect relationships
requires human Insight we shouldn't
blindly trust computer systems okay so
that's just one small note about
correlation and causation uh that you
should keep in
mind okay so that's our exploratory data
analysis we've done a lot of analysis we
spent half the lecture just doing
analysis but it's important once
you this is a more important piece of
machine learning really which is before
you get to the actual machine learning
and then the machine learning part
becomes fairly straightforward after
that let's move on to linear regression
with a single feature and we'll Define
what linear regression is we know that
smoker and Age The Columns have the
strongest correlation with charges we've
seen that already so let's try a way of
finding or let's try a way of estimating
the value of charges using the value of
the age column we can't really use
smoker because it's just a yes no value
so
how exactly are going are you going to
use that to predict charges but the age
has a continuous value so let's do one
thing let's estimate the value of
charges using the value of age just for
nonsmokers and then we'll deal with
smokers
later so first let's create a data frame
containing just the data for
non-smokers okay when that's done we
simply pick medical DF do smoker equals
no and pick those rows of or those
columns of data from medical DF sorry
those rows of data which belong to
nonsmokers from medical DF and let's
plot it once again I'm just using a cbon
scatter plot this time don't need any
interactivity and you can see this trend
that there seems to be a generally
linear Trend that I could maybe fit a
line here although there are a bunch of
outliers so maybe I move my line up a
little bit just to account for the
average so maybe a line like this would
be ideal okay
so apart from a few exceptions the
points seem to form a line and we'll try
and fit a line using these points and
then we will use that line to predict
charges for a given age so let's just
fit a line somewhere like this and once
a line is fit let's say somebody a new
customer comes in and they provide their
information let's say they're 30 years
old then we'll just look at the line and
we'll see where the line intersects the
Y AIS or the y- value for the line at 30
and that would be maybe somewhere around
here and we would predict that their
medical charges are maybe 5,200 okay
that's how prediction Works once you get
the line you use the line to make
predictions and a line on the X and Y
coordinates has a formula like this a
line has a formula yal WX + B so as
you make changes to the value of x the
value of y changes and it is determined
by two factors so what the number W is
called the slope and the number B is
called The Intercept okay so what you do
is you pick a value for w let's say you
pick that W has the value 100 and you
pick a value for B and you say B has the
value
50 and as you change the value of x the
value of y changes and that is what
draws a line on the 2D plane basic
geometry something you would have seen
in high school and W is called a slope
because it determines how much change
you will see in Y when you make some
change in X so the rate of change of Y
with respect to the change in X is W and
B is called The Intercept because B is
the value of y when you set x equals 0
so x x equals 0 means this so that means
B is the point at which the line
intersects with the y- axis and that is
called The
Intercept so in the above case in this
graph the x-axis represents age and the
y- axis represents
charges so what we're trying to say
essentially is that we are assuming that
charges and age have the following
relationship we are saying that the
charges is some number W multiplied by
AG plus some number B and we will then
try and figure out a w and B to get the
line that best fits the data now
obviously this is not a perfect
relationship medical charges depend on a
lot more than age as we've already seen
and maybe you can't even predict medical
charges exactly because there's a lot of
uncertainty but there's a certain Trend
we are trying to capture because some
information will be more useful than no
information at least knowing that a
person at a higher age we should
probably be charged a higher premium is
useful information that we'd like to
draw
okay so here we have charges equals some
number W plus b now this number W is
also called a weight sometimes and then
this number B is called a bias so
they're called slope and Intercept in
Geometry but they are often called
weight and bias in statistics and
machine learning in any case this is the
relationship that we are assuming okay
so this technique is called linear
regression and we call this equation a
linear regression model because it is
modeling the relationship between age
and charges you are setting forward
hypothesis that the charges is some
weight w multiplied with ag plus some
number
B so this is our model this literally
this equation is our model and then the
numbers W and B are called the
parameters or the weights of the model
so the model has a structure or an
equation and the model has some
parameters as you change these
parameters you will still have a line
the structure will be maintained but the
line will move around so the model will
give different predictions when you
input a certain age it will give a
different output for charges as you
change the values of w and
B finally the values in the age column
of the data set are called the inputs to
the
model and the values in the charges
column are called the targets so we
assume that when we multiply the inputs
with this number W and add B we are
going to get something close to charges
and we want to get as close as possible
so that's our linear regression model
it's called linear regression because
it's a line and we're trying to fit the
line so we're trying to make sure that
the line fits as closely as possible
with the
points now this equation is well and
good but we would like to express it in
a way that we can compute which is using
code so we can turn this equation
into a function so let's define a helper
function estimate charges which takes an
age it takes a value of w it takes a
value of B and it multiplies the weight
with age and gives us and adds the B
bias and gives us the result which is an
estimate for the
charges so this function estimate
charges is our very first model our
first machine learning model and we'll
Define machine learning in just a second
now we don't know what values we should
pick for w and B I'm just going to
assume the weight of 50 and I'm just
going to assume the bias of 100 let's
see how it works
out I don't expect it to be perfect we
can call estimate
charges on a single age so let's say now
we have estimate charges we call it on
the age 30 and we pass in W and B you
would get that the estimated charges are
1,600 is that correct let's see for 30
we are estimating that the charges are
1600 1600 would be somewhere here so it
seems too low so I think my guess is bad
uh I can even maybe check
40 so then for 40 I'm saying my estimate
is 21100 okay still seems pretty bad
because 2100 would be somewhere around
here so I guess my line is going
something like this it is going below
these points uh so maybe I should try
and verify that in some way here's what
we can do let me take all the values in
the age column nonsmoker DF do AG so
this is a list of all the ages right
let's just get a list of all the
ages okay these are all the ages that we
have in the data set and let us get the
estimated charges from our model using
these ages okay so we put in into
estimate charges we put in ages we put
in W and B so w has a value 50 B has a
value 100 and we're going to do W
multiplied by ages plus b now because
this is an umpai array these same
operator multiplication and addition
work just fine for an entire array of
data and not just a single value so
let's look at estimated
charges so here are the estimated
charges it seems like for the age 18 the
estimated cost is 1,000 and then for age
28 it is500 and so on and you can
compare them with the actual charges
which is nonsmoker DF do
charges
and you can already see that these are
pretty bad you have 1,000 here and you
have 1,700 here you have 1500 here and
you have 4,500 here so we are way
off let's plot what this looks like so
maybe first I'm going to do a scatter
plot yeah so if I do a scatter plot this
is what it looks like you can see that
the age and the estimated charges have a
linear relationship and that's what we
assumed we have assumed a linear
relationship between them and this is
what the graph looks like so it might be
even easier to just plot it as a line
instead of a scatter plot so I'm just
going to
put PLT do plot which creates a line and
just make it a red line so we don't need
actual points to tell us that it forms a
line we can just draw a line and now if
you want to predict let's say at 45 what
is the charges so the charges would be
around 2400 or so so now we have a model
we give the model some data some age and
it gives us an output but we want want
to know how good our model is and for
doing that we can just plot this line on
top of the scatter plot for the actual
data so here's what we'll do we get the
actual data which is nonsmoker DF do
charges this is the actual data that we
want to
predict we get our estimates we first
plot our estimates we say PLT dotplot
ages and estimated charges as a red line
and then we plot a scatter plot of the
actual data ages and the actual charges
that people have incurred in our data
set okay so here's what it looks like
this is our estimate based on the
current value of w and B which we have
chosen which is 50 and 100 and these are
the actual
values of the points of the different
customers that we have so obviously this
is pretty bad this looks quite bad but
let's try and improve this we now have a
starting point and we maybe know that
hey maybe my weight needs to be higher
because as I go from 30 to 40 the
increase needs to be higher so maybe I
need need a higher weight and maybe the
bias is okay I don't see any problem if
I had a line like this it would probably
intercept somewhere here so maybe B
should be around 2,000 I don't know U so
I've just defined this function try
parameters which takes W and B and it's
going to get the ages it's going to get
the targets it's going to first get the
estimated charges using the estimate
charges function and uh it's going to
plot the line it's going to plot the
scatter plot and we can call parameters
with different values of w and B to see
what value best fits the
data so here we are calling try
parameters with 60 and 200 slightly
better than 50 and 100 no good
still let's maybe go high let's go let's
increase weight to 5 400 and let's
increase the biasp to
5,000 okay that seems to have moved up
the line by quite a bit maybe if I just
shift down the bias a little bit if I
maybe instead of doing 5,000 here if I
put
in 3,000 let's say maybe that might be
better okay maybe
2,000 so as I'm changing the value of B
the line is moving down maybe
th000 you can see that the line is
moving down maybe
500 maybe I need to go negative
even
okay maybe I need to go negative so
maybe go
600 yep maybe
go
-2000
yep yeah so there you go you can now
start to see what's happening As you
move the line as you change the bias and
as you change the weight the line shifts
and moves up and down so with when you
change B that is going to move the line
up and down and when you
change W that is going to increase or
decrease the slope of the line let's say
we set the weight to zero that makes the
line flat let's say we set the weight to
a
th000 that makes a line really steep so
maybe you want to go somewhere between
like around 500 and that's what we want
to go with so that's how you try and fit
a line so here's an exercise for you try
various values of w and B to find a line
that best fits the
data just try it out spend Maybe five or
10 minutes trying out various values and
you will be able to get to a pretty good
point by just guessing and as you saw
that what you do is you look at the line
and then you compare it with the points
and you see if you need to move the line
down if you need to move the line down
decrease the value of B then if you need
to increase the slope increase W if you
need to decrease the slope decrease W so
you already have a strategy in place
that you can apply each
time now as we change the values of w
and B manually trying to move the line
visually closer to the points we are
learning the approximate relationship
between age and
charges so wouldn't it be nicer if a
computer could try several different
values of w and B and learn the
relationship between agent charges
because ultimately now once we've
established that there's going to be a
linear relationship we just need to move
the line around up and down left and
right change its slope and we should be
able to get to the right
point
well to do this we need to solve a
couple of problems one we have eyes and
we can see that the line is far away
from the points but the computer does
not have eyes so to speak so we need a
way to measure numerically how well the
line fits the points that's the first
thing okay second we are able to guess
which way we should move W and B by
looking at how far the line is from the
points but again we are applying a lot
lot of insight here so once we measure
the fit of the line we need a way to
modify W andb to improve the fit of the
line okay so we need a way to measure
how well the line fits the points and we
need a way to improve W and B once we
have made a measure and we realize that
this measure is bad so if we can solve
the above problems this will be a
breakthrough because it should then be
possible for a computer to determine W
and B for the best fit line starting
from a random G
s so let's solve the first
problem
now we want to compare our models
predictions with the actual targets and
this is the method that we can follow we
calculate the difference between the
targets which is the actual charges from
the data set and the predictions from
our
model and this difference is called the
residual so for each Target you have a
bunch of targets here the targets are
simply the actual Char charges so we we
have non-smoker
DF do
charges these are the targets and then
you have the predictions which is the
estimated charges this is what our model
has predicted for the input data so
predictions
is estimated
charges okay and this is for a
particular value of w and
B so what we do is we subtract each
prediction from the corresponding Target
so this is going to tell us how far away
our prediction is from a Target but the
problem is some predictions may be lower
than the target some predictions may be
higher than the target so to remove
negative values we Square all the
elements in the difference uh Vector let
me remove this Matrix term here yeah so
we Square all the elements to remove
negative values so you subtract 1, -
1725 that's 725s and then you square it
25 squ then you do 1500 minus 4449
that's again some negative value square
it at some points you may have positive
values maybe you have 2,600 here and
1600 here so uh you get a positive value
square it so we take the residuals each
difference is called a residual then we
Square all the
residuals then we calculate the average
of all those elements in the result
right so we have all of these residuals
we simply add up all the squares of
residuals and calculate the average so
now we have this minus the actual Target
squared uh plus this minus the actual
Target squared plus this minus the
actual Target squar divided by the total
number of um entries we
have and finally we take the square root
of the result okay seems like a
complicated process but it's actually
fairly straightforward what it's giving
us is called the root mean squared error
so let's break that down error is simply
the difference between the targets and
the predictions so that is the error but
of course if you just add up errors
positives and negatives May cancel out
so that's why we squared it so now when
we Square it all the errors become
positive and then we take their average
so that gives us the average squared
error or mean squared error but then we
want to take the square root again
because we want to interpret the number
that we get as a dollar value
essentially so now when we took squares
we converted the difference in Dollars
into dollar squar so we just took take a
root again and that just gives us a
dollar value so that's why this is
called the root mean squared
error and it tells us on average how far
away we are how far away each point is
from the line now this is not the only
way to do it there is also something
called the root mean absolute error
where you do not take squares you
actually take the absolute value which
means you simply ignore the sign and the
difference between root means squared
error and root mean absolute error
is simply that outlier
have a big factor or outliers contribute
highly in a squared error because the
the greater the error the greater it
square is going to be so it's going to
be a bigger factor in the overall error
okay so that's just one thing to keep in
mind but root means squared error make
sure you understand this this is the
average on average how far away we are
from the line right and this is the
formula which is exactly the same thing
prediction minus actual squared sum over
all the predictions divided by n square
root of that and this is how you can
visualize root mean squared error so
these are the so suppose this is a line
and then these are the actual Target
points for each point you calculate how
far away it is from the prediction and
the prediction is simply the point on
the line at the same x value so this is
a prediction this is the actual point
you calculate the residual for that
point and then you add up the squares of
all the residuals take their average and
take the square
root so these are all different ways to
look at the root me squ error but let's
look at it in a way that we understand
best which is using Code so I'm going to
install the numpy library here and
import numpy as NP and then I'm going to
Define this function rmse which takes a
set of targets it takes a set of
predictions first we get Target minus
predictions that's the error we Square
it we take the mean and then we take the
square root mean squared
error all right so now we have a way to
tell how bad our model is
so let's compute the root means squared
error for a model with a sample set of
Weights here is the weights 50 and 100
this this is what we started out
with and here are the here's what that
line looks like the line made by these
weights now let's get some predictions
so let's get these are the targets the
targets are simply non-smoker DF do
charges and the predictions are simply
by calling the model or putting the
weights and the inputs into the model so
the age I'm taking the the list of Ages
putting that into the estimate charges
function along with the weight and bias
that will give us some prediction so
that will give us for each of these ages
in the actual data set the point on the
line
where the point on the line is what
we'll see in
prediction specifically the Y portion of
the point on the line or the y
coordinate of the point on the line for
that age now we can compute the root
mean squared error between the targets
and the predictions and it seems like
the root means squar error is
8461 so how do we interpret this number
well on average each element in the
prediction differs from the actual
Target by 8461 that's not the exact
interpretation but it's pretty close and
this is how we can look at it so is that
good or is that
bad well visually we can tell it's
bad but even on average you can see that
the values of charges go anywhere in the
range of maybe 2,000 to uh 15,000 here
right normally for somebody who does not
have high high medical
expenses so if you're trying to predict
a value between 2,000 to 15,000 and you
are off by
8,000 I think that would be pretty bad
even considering that you have some
outliers because these outliers are
small in number I think 8,000 would be
pretty bad maybe I would be willing to
live with an error of maybe four or
5,000 at most but 8,000 is just all over
the place and you can tell the same
thing by this line as well this is too
far away from the actual
data so that's how you interpret the
root mean squared error and this error
is also called a loss because it
indicates
how bad the model is at predicting the
target remember the difference between
the two things which is targets and
predictions will be higher and then the
squares will be even higher and the
average will will be higher and so the
square root will be higher if the
targets are very far away from the
predictions that means if your model is
really bad then the root me squared
error is going to be very high that's
why it's called a loss because it
represents the information loss in the
model remember we are not capturing the
actual relationship we're simply
modeling the relationship and all models
are wrong it's just that some are useful
how do we figure out which models are
useful by looking at the loss the lower
the loss the better the model right the
higher the loss the more noisy or the
more useless the model
becomes so let's do one thing before we
train a computer to figure out the
lowest loss let's try and do it manually
so I have this try parameters function
here which takes a set of weights and
biases and then makes some predictions
using our estimate charges function and
plots a graph at the end I have also
computed the loss for the predictions
made for these weights and biases and
I've printed the loss so here's what
that looks like
this is the graph this is the same line
we have and the rmsc loss of
8461 now let's take up the challenge to
try and fix the rmsc loss let's try and
make it as low as possible so one thing
that's clear is that I should be
increasing the slope of the line let me
make this
300 okay that did not do much okay this
is not the slope this is the slope let
me make this
350 all right that Push It Up by quite a
bit maybe let me push it down a bit let
me push it down by
4,000 yep that's getting pretty close
and I've already arrived at a rmsc loss
of
4991 so that's what you want to do and
you can experiment here you can try and
get it to as low a value as possible and
now you have a very clear Target you
don't have to figure it out visually but
you can see as the rmsc loss gets CL
gets lower
you will see that the line gets closer
and closer to the points it will not lie
exactly in between the points because we
have all these outliers that we need to
account for but it should lie somewhere
along this region right so 350 andus
4,000 is my best guess let's see if you
can beat
that and try and come up with a general
strategy for bet for finding better
values of w and B just by looking at the
loss not necessarily by looking at the
graph but just by looking at the loss
here's one strategy that I will suggest
if you have a weight if you have a
certain W and a certain
B try slightly increasing W if that
reduces the loss then you can increase W
by a large amount if that does not
reduce the loss price slightly
decreasing W if that reduces the loss
then maybe you can reduce W by a
significant
amount if that does not help try the
same with b or maybe try the same with w
and B in parallel okay and this strategy
of just trying a small change and seeing
whether it leads to an increase or
decrease and then taking a larger step
in that direction which is sort of know
assume you're blind and or you're in a
dark room and you have to figure out
which way to go down which way goes down
right if if it's not an uneven surface
that you're on so you put one foot and
you put one foot and you realize okay
this is higher ground and you put one
another foot and you realize okay that
is lower ground if you want to go
downhill then you step take a couple of
steps maybe along the lower ground and
then you repeat the process so this
strategy is called the gradient descent
strategy and it can be implemented
mathematically using uh derivatives but
that's what we want to come up with
right so we need a we need a strategy to
modify the weights and the bi and the
biases which is
the the parameters of our model to
reduce the model to reduce the loss and
improve the fit of the line to the data
and there are a couple of strategies
that are used to do do this one is
called the ordinary least squares
method and the way it works is using
some Matrix operations and some Matrix
inversions it directly arrives at the
best value of w and B so it uses a
combination of calculus and linear
algebra to directly give you the values
of w and B it works well for small data
sets like data sets with a few thousand
rows of data but for larger data sets it
is very inefficient and sometimes it
takes up a lot of memory so for that you
have this another technique called the
stochastic gradient descent technique
which is what I just talked about which
is Imagine like you on a hill and it's
dark and you want to figure out how to
go down you just take steps in each
Direction figure out which direction
goes down and then take a few steps in
that direction and then repeat right so
that's called stochastic gradient
descent uh you can check out these
videos for some explanation of how these
Works some mathematical explanation in
general we're not going to look at it in
a lot of detail because because you will
never have to implement these it helps
to understand them but in general you
won't and you can't really Implement
these you will mostly have to depend on
the libraries to do this and the more
important skill for you is to know how
to use these rather than to understand
the mathematical
representation but yeah ordinary res
squares works well for small data sets
uses some direct Matrix computations
gradient descent works well for larger
data sets and uses a iterative approach
so here's a visualization of how
gradient descent works it starts out
with a flat line and then it slowly
improves both the weight so you can see
now it is improving the bias so far but
once it gets close enough it's going to
start turning the line so it's going to
start changing the line so it computes
the loss it figures out whether it
should increase or decrease the weight
it figures out whe whether it should
increase or decrease the bias or the
intercept and that's how it keeps
changing the line step by step and then
it gets to the very close to the best
fit line and it works really well for
large data sets where you have millions
or tens of millions of data points so
you will be applying linear regression
to some really large data sets and
that's where you'll get to see gradient
descent in
action okay and it is actually quite
similar to our own strategy of just
gradually moving the line closer to the
points so that's what we are going to do
now in practice you will never have to
implement either of these methods
yourself you can use a library like pyit
learn to do this for you so I'm going to
install this Library pyit learn pyit
learn contains functions modules for
doing machine learning with python it's
one of the most most used libraries in
the world for machine
learning and we are going to start out
by using the simplest function that it
offers which is the linear regression
class so let's use the linear regression
class from psyit learn to find the best
fit line for age versus charges using
psyit learn so I'm going to install pip
install pyit learn all right and then
I'm going to import from pyit learn the
linear regression model the linear
regression class haven't done anything
so far it's in the linear model section
then we need to create a new model
object so we create a new model equals
linear
regression
next here's what happens you call there
every model in pyed learn has a fit
method and let's look at the help for
the fit method so the fit method takes
some parameters and take some
targets and it fits a line in the case
of linear regression it fits a line
between those parameters and targets
okay so that's what we going to do next
we are going to
fit the model to the data model. fit
takes an X which is the inputs and this
should be of the shape number of samples
which which means number of data points
we have comma number of features and in
this case we just have one feature but
important thing is that this should be a
two-dimensional Matrix or nump array
then you have this Y which should be
array like so it should either be a one
dimensional array which is simply for
each sample what is the target value or
if you can even predict multiple targets
let's say you want to predict medical
charges you want to predict travel
charges you want to predict some other
charges so you can have multiple targets
as well in our case we have only
one okay so let's now create some inputs
and let's create some targets and let's
put them into model.fit
so here's what I'm going to do from
nonsmoker DF I'm going to pick age but I
don't want to just pick age I I don't
just want to do this because this is
going to give me a series and this is
this just has one dimension remember
model do fit requires two Dimensions so
I'm just I'm going to give give it a
list of columns that I want to pick and
in the list I just want to put the
single column age okay so it's a subtle
difference here that we want we don't
want a series we want a data frame and
if you check inputs
here inputs is a data frame not a series
like you can check type of
inputs type of inputs is data frame and
inputs has the
shape yeah inputs has a shape 1064 comma
1 okay so it needs to be a
two-dimensional tensor very
important and the targets can just be an
array so and the the targets are simply
the charges so nonsmoker DF do charges
and then we check the shape of inputs
and we check the shape of targets you
have the expected shapes so now this is
everything that we've been building
towards this is the one line that does
everything that we need to do when we
set said model equals linear
regression we already mentioned to pyit
learn that we want to assume a linear
relationship between our inputs and our
targets which means we want we want our
targets which is charges to be some
weight w to be some weight w multiplied
with the age which is the input plus
some number B so now we're telling psyed
learn that hey these are some inputs for
you and these are the targets for those
inputs means these are some ages and
these are the charges for these ages can
you
please calculate the loss so maybe first
guess some random W and B and uh get the
predictions compare the predictions with
the targets see how bad your predictions
are and then use a gradient descent
algorithm or use some other optimization
strategy to improve your the values of w
and B and keep improving keep improving
keep improving till you cannot improve
anymore and then give me the final
result so that's what happens when you
call model. fit so when you say model do
fit now inside Model A line has been
fitted which means a w and a b have been
found which make the loss the mean
squared or root mean squared loss the
lowest possible so again the loss is the
loss is also coded inside the model we
don't need to worry about that
either but here's now what we can use it
for we can now make predictions using
the model so now we have a model we have
fitted our model let us try predicting
the charges for the ages 23 37 and 61 so
we say model. predict and then we give
it this two-dimensional array so in this
two dimensional array we have a bunch of
rows and in each row we have just one
column so we have the value 23 this will
be the value of age another value 37
again another value of age another value
Val 61 another value of AG so we expect
to get three values for the charges so
for this row or for this age 23 the
model predicts
4055 for this age 37 the model predicts
7796 for this age 61 the model predicts
14210 okay so it's starting to look good
remember when for smaller ages the cost
is around $4,000 and then for the larger
ages like around 60 or 64 it gets to be
it gets closer to 15,000 so it seems
like our model has done a pretty good
job let us maybe compute the predictions
for the entire set of inputs that we've
given the model so what is our inputs
our inputs are simply the ages right so
we you can see here our inputs are
simply the ages so let's give a full
list of all the ages and let's see what
the model predicts for all the
ages so this is what the predictions
look like and you can check what the
inputs are and see if these seem re
reasonable 18 28 33 uh 31 so for 18 we
predict 2719 for 28 we predict
5391 and so on maybe let's compare them
with the targets the targets is the
actual costs that these people incurred
so this person incurred a cost of 1725
and we predicted 2719 this person
incurred a cost of 4449 and we predicted
5391 this predict this person incurred
21,000 and we predicted 6
727 this person incurred 2007 and we
predicted 3520 so it's in the good range
it's not that bad it's may be off by a,
or so but when you're dealing with
values in the range of about 15,000 or
so uh the error of th000 is probably
acceptable right and it's mostly on the
higher side for lower values which is
fine too because we know that there are
a lot of outliers which are
quite high in value okay we can also
look at the loss we have this rmse
function which is the root mean squared
error so that we will take the targets
minus predictions Square all of the
numbers add up all the squares take the
average and take the square root of that
let's look at the RMS so the rmsse for
this model the root means squared error
for this model is
4662 which means on average we are off
by about
$4,600 and that's the average but when
you look at the values you'll see that
you're you're off by much less it's just
that some of these are such big outliers
that we cannot capture that relationship
with just a simple line right you can
see that this one we should be
predicting 21,000 but we get 6727 and
it's simply not possible to get that far
out of an outlier using a line so on
average we're actually doing much better
than 4662 we're probably in the 1,000
2,000 range but yeah this captures the
fact that there are a bunch of outliers
and uh in the model as well so this is
the whole process of machine learning
that you assume a certain relationship
between inputs and targets which is the
linear relationship you then find a loss
you find a way to
measure how bad your model is based on
certain random parameters that you've
picked initially and then you use some
kind of an optimization algorithm to
improve the parameters of the model in
this case W and B till you can minimize
the
loss okay
so we've gotten to a good point our
model is off by 4,000 on average which
is not too bad considering that there
are several outliers now you may be
wondering where is the W and B well in
psyit laar the W is stored in model. CF
it's stands for coefficients which are
the coefficients or the weights applied
to each individual feature in this case
we're just working with age so we have
267 is the coefficient W and then we
have B here okay so model do intercept
contains B and that is -
2091 so it seems like if you had picked
a w of 267 and a b of
2091 we would have gotten a pretty good
line and that would have been our best
that would would have been the best
possible model so when you try this out
later see how close you can get without
actually looking at the values of w and
B let's maybe just plot them once again
so here we have all the points in blue
and here we have our model our line
showing the predictions so you see that
our line is fitting quite nicely I
wouldn't say it's bad and it's slightly
above this cluster because we also want
to somehow capture the fact that there
are certain outliers at the top so if
the line was somewhere here it would
technically not be giving the right
information because it would not be
suggesting the fact that there are
outliers so to account for all these
outliers it's slightly above the data
but that's pretty good that's how you do
linear regression using psychic learn
you use the linear regression class then
you fit the model and then you generate
predictions on new data or on existing
data now the linear regression class
uses this optimization technique called
Ordinary leas squares there is another
technique called gradient descent that I
had mentioned for that you need to use
the SGD regressor so I encourage you to
try out SGD regressor it works in
exactly the same way this is the one of
the nice things about psychic learn if
you know how to use one model you know
how to use all the models it's just that
internally what's happening is
different so try out the SGD
regressor and uh train a model make some
predictions compute the LW and see if
you see any difference in the result
okay one other exercise for you is to
repeat the steps in the section to train
a linear regression model to estimate
the medical charges for smokers so till
now we've been dealing with non-smokers
so now you work with smokers and then
visualize the target and predictions and
compute the loss once again are you able
to get a better model for nonsmokers
what does that look like because for
nonsmokers we seem to have these two
clear clusters of data so that would be
worth figuring out
okay and that's it congratulations youve
just trained your first machine learning
model and machine learning is simply the
process of computing the best parameters
to model the relationship between some
feature and
targets so every machine learning
problem that we'll solve in this entire
course or in general that you'll solve
any
time will generally have three
components the first thing you will have
to decide is how do you want to model
the relationship do you want to model
the relationship as a linear equation
maybe you want to model the relationship
as a polinomial equation maybe you want
to model the relationship as some kind
of a decision tree maybe you want to
model the relationship in some other way
and there are many many many ways to
model relationships the simplest one is
is to just say that the the thing that
we're trying to predict the target is
some kind of a weighted sum of the thing
that we're trying to predict the target
is a weighted sum of the input features
that we are interested in for example we
could say that the charges is simply
some weight W1 multiplied by age some
weight W2 multiplied by number of
children some weight W3 multiplied by
BMI plus some number B some intercept
right so that's the model and every
model has parameters
that's what the machine has to learn so
to understand how good the parameters
are of the model we have a cost function
and there are several choices for cost
function but the idea for the cost
function is that it should give you a
cost which it should give you how badly
the model is performing and the lower
the cost the better the
model
okay once you have a cost function that
can be computed given some targets and
predictions
then you need to use some kind of an
optimization technique to optimize the
cost which means to change the
parameters of the model so that it
better fits the data and this is what
this entire process looks like you put
some input data into the model and you
get some outputs you put you take both
the Target and the output into the error
or the loss function you then apply an
optimization method and that
optimization method changes the weights
and biases or changes the parameters of
the model so model gets slightly better
then you put some more input data you
get some more output you take that put
that into the loss function perform
optimization and improve the model this
what we seeing here is essentially this
animation that we saw here which
is taking the line and slowly moving it
so that it perfectly fits the data right
so most of machine learning and even a
lot of deep learning is basically
glorified line fitting that's all we are
doing we are fitting lines and the fact
is that the only difference is we saying
that the relationship instead of being a
line is something else and we asking the
computer to compute the parameters in
that relationship or the parameters of
that
model okay so that's that's machine
learning and as we've seen it just it
takes just a few lines of code to train
a machine learning model using pyit
learn you start out by creating some
inputs and some targets you for example
in the inputs in this case are
non-smoker DF and we are just picking a
set of columns and currently we're just
picking one column age so the inputs
need to be a two-dimensional array then
you have targets which can be
onedimensional or twood dimensional so
you have a list of inputs and a list of
targets and then you create a model so
here we are creating this model linear
regression and most of the time
immediately you just want to fit the
model not always but most of the time so
if you just want to fit the model you
can create the object and immediately
call fit on it and that will also return
the model so you can just do this linear
regression. fit and into it you provide
the inputs and the targets and it's
going to go and do its thing it's going
to do all of this for you um this class
determines what kind of relationship you
want to assume like here you want to
assume the linear
relationship right so you fit the data
and that gives you a model then you can
use that model to make predictions so
now you can just take this model and
every time a new customer comes in you
ask them hey what's your age and they
say 32 and you put in the number 32 and
you get a certain estimate for the
medical charges that estimate can then
be used to compute their insurance
premium and off the go right so it
automates that piece of analysis which
you had to do with maybe using several
experts with years of expertise and
there's a certain error so whenever you
use a model you should be aware of what
the error in your model is or what the
loss the information loss in your
modelist so in this casee what we say is
that hey my predictions are off by maybe
about 3 or 4,000 so you may just want to
keep that in mind when you are compar
when you are calculating the insurance
premium for this person all right and
that's your three or four step process
create inputs and targets create a
training uh model uh create and train a
model generate some predictions with the
model and whenever possible you also
should have a measure of what is the
information law or what is the error in
your model so you create the input data
and then you put that into some kind of
a model and the model gives you some
predictions now you compare the
predictions with the actual
outputs and that gives you some kind of
a measurement how bad your model is your
model's really bad
initially then you run some kind of an
optimization method and that improves
your model so as you give some data into
the model it learns from the data it
makes better predictions then you give
it some more feedback back using the
loss function it makes a better
prediction and it gets better over time
if you can just grasp that basic idea
and see how it is translated into code
here that is enough to get started and
it is a fundamentally different way of
thinking about problems if you are
struggling with it a little bit that's
okay once you struggle through it and
once you get the idea once it clicks
what's happening here you will suddenly
realize the potential of what it makes
possible because now instead of let's
say having several years of expertise in
analyzing or evaluating insurance
applications you just have this one
system you just feed in some input and
it's going to give you an output and you
know how much it is going to be off
by and uh you can use
it what about some of the other
features so far we've used just the age
feature to estimate charges adding
another feature like BMI is very
straightforward so we simply assume this
this relationship now instead of saying
charges is some weight W plus b now we
say that hey for calculating the medical
charges we give some weight to the age
and some weight to the BMI and then we
have this other intercept term which is
simply to just move the line up or down
of course now this is no longer a line
it's linear in the sense that there is
still a linear relationship you're not
doing squares or cubes or anything but
this becomes now a plane in three
dimensions essentially if you see the if
you put age BMI and charges on each
Dimension this becomes a plane in three
dimensions so now we are working with a
plane but still called a linear
regression simply a linear combination
or a weighted average of the age and BMI
the charges so how do we apply this in
code the exact same four steps create
inputs and targets so the inputs are
from non-smoker DF we take age and we
take the body mass index and then the
targets are simply the charges the only
only change we made here is
this the way to train the model and
create the model is the same so you
create linear regression you call do fit
and then you put in the inputs and the
targets no change here it's
automatically going to detect that now
you have two columns of data then you
generate
predictions you generate predictions by
passing the inputs into model.
predict and then finally you compute the
LW so this is not something that you
have to do strictly speaking you just
once the model is trained at fit you can
make predictions on any new input data
right at this point of course we don't
have any other input data we just have
the original inputs so we just fast back
the original inputs but you call model.
predict inputs and that's going to give
you a set of
predictions and then you have rmse you
compute the loss so whenever you
calculate some predictions it's always a
good idea to like if you have the actual
targets which we do for the inputs just
compare the predictions of the model
with the actual targets for those inputs
and get the
loss and you can see here we now go from
the loss of what's that 466 2505 to 4662
312 so clearly BMI did not create a
major impact and you can see why because
BMI has a very weak
correlation especially for
non-smokers and you can even see this in
this 3D scatter plot uh sorry in this
scatter plot between BMI and charges so
you can see here that you have BMI and
you have charges and there's no real
relationship that you can see here like
there's no line that you can see and
that's why the correlation is low and
that is why even though we included BMI
now even though we included BMI now you
are unable to see any Improvement in the
loss the loss Still Remains 4662 there's
a very minor Improvement of a less than
a dollar on
average let's also check the parameters
of the model you will find that the
parameters have also not changed much so
this is the parameter for age so for age
we're still using the weight of 266 this
is the model this is- 2293 so you can
see that these are still quite close to
the original parameters the parameters
that we had here
were 267 and 2091 so the parameters have
still remained the same for age and for
The
Intercept yeah 266 for age that is the
weight applied to H that is W1
here you can see W1 this is
266 and this is The Intercept minus 2293
and you can see that the parameter or
the weight applied to the BMI is very
small which means BMI has very low
weightage and you can see why it has a
tiny contribution to the charges for
nonsmokers and even that is probably
accidentally and this is something that
you may want to report to your company
that hey there seems to be no relation
between BMI and medical charges should
we even be looking at
BMI and another important thing to keep
in mind here is that you cannot find a
relationship that does not exist if your
boss came to you and said I want to
create I want you to create a model that
uses the BMI and nise medical charges
you should just go back and tell them
there's no relationship here no matter
what machine learning technique you use
no matter how much data you give me
there is simply no relationship here all
I'm seeing is this you can't expect to
fit a line to
this and you can verify that train a
linear regression model to estimate
charges using just the BMI see if you
expect it to be better or worse than the
previously trained model it should be
worse but it's something that you should
verify maybe even visualize it by
plotting the
graph once again when you have a single
when you have a
single feature you should be able to
plot it easily once you go beyond one
feature Beyond one input there's no easy
way to visualize and let's go one step
further let's add a third numeric column
so here we have W1 * age W2 * BMI W3 *
charges plus b and you can see here the
correlation between charges and children
so the correlation here is38 it is lower
than age but it is higher than BMI and
we can see this using this this is
called a strip plot similar to a violin
plot but we show actual points here so
you can see that there are a lot of
these points
around at the lower values here and then
there are more points at the higher
values here so you can see a somewhat
increasing Trend there's definitely a
somewhat increasing Trend here and
that's why you have a slightly positive
correlation although very
small and now to use children once again
we create the inputs and targets which
is we use age we use BMI and we use
children create then we train a model so
we say linear regression do fit inputs
and
targets then we generate some
predictions so we say model do predict
inputs so we pass in the inputs this
time we have three three columns of data
and then we compute the LW for those
predictions so these are the targets and
these are the predictions from our model
for the input
data and the loss is 4,600 so there's a
slight reduction in the loss we went
from what's that we went
from 4662 to 4608 so we on average
like the loss reduced by
$50 that's better than
nothing and this increas is definite
this change is definitely greater than
in the case of BMI okay so now an
exercise for you is to St repeat the
steps in this section to train a linear
regression model to estimate medical
charges for smokers so use all the
numeric columns and visualize the
targets and predictions to compute the
law and here's another thing we can do
this time let's consider the entire data
set let's maybe ignore the distinction
between smokers and non-smokers and see
if we can still fit a line so we now
repeat the steps in this section to
train a linear regression model on the
entire data set so all I'm changing here
is now instead of using non-smoker DF
I'm going to use medical DF which is the
entire data set consisting of smokers
and
non-smokers I'm going to consider age
BMI and children as the inputs and I'm
going to consider charges as the
target I'm going to pass the inputs
which is a now a 2d tensor and it has
which has three columns of data and the
targets which is simply a series or a
array of numbers I'm going to make some
predictions and I'm going to compute the
loss and the loss is much higher it is
11,300 155 on average and you can
probably tell why we know already when
we do px. scatter
between medical
DF and you set X as age let's say and Y
as
charges and you set color as
smoker you know that all this data was
not there earlier when we were just
dealing with non-smokers when we were
dealing with nonsmokers we were just
looking at this which is obviously much
easier to fit than this like here where
do you put the line you put the line
somewhere here that's going to increase
the error with these that's going to
also have a high error with these and
these are like really far away these are
quite far away from this line here so
obviously your loss is going to become
quite High probably your model is
completely useless at this point because
most of the values you're trying to
predict are in this range of 5 6,000 and
if you're off by 11,000 then that
doesn't really make sense at
all so the next thing that you might
want to do is to start using the
categorical features for machine
learning as well now so far we've only
been using numeric columns because we
can only perform the computations with
numbers remember the computation of the
loss the optimization that is again
using calculus and linear algebra so all
of that can only be done with numbers
now if we could use categorical columns
like smoker then it would be possible to
maybe train a single model for the
entire data set which can also account
for smokers in some
fashion to use the categorical columns
one trick is to Simply convert them into
numbers and there are three common
techniques for converting categorical
columns into numbers the first one is if
a categorical column has just two
categories let's say smoker non-smoker
yes no then it's called a binary
category it simply indicates the
presence or absence of
something in such a case we can replace
the values with zero and one we can
replace no with zero and we we can
replace yes with one so now a weight
would apply when we have a smoker and
when the when the person is not a smoker
then that weight would simply not apply
right so there's a certain term that
gets added it's like a penalty that we
are adding for a person is a smoker or
not then another way to go about it is
if a categorical column has more than
two categories for example the region
then we can perform a one hot encoding
which means that we perform a new we
create a new column for each category in
that Reg so let's say for the Northeast
column Northeast region we create a
category which contains ones and zeros
ones at the places where the row belongs
to the Northeast category we can create
a northwest southeast and Southwest so
we create these four categories each of
them contain numbers and then we can
ignore the original region column so
each of these columns North Northwest
NorthEast Southwest Southeast will
contain zeros and ones and every row
will contain exactly a single one so
it'll contain three zeros and a single
one and that's why it is called one hot
encoding next if the categories have a
natural order so sometimes you may have
a natural order like this cold neutral
warm hot then they can be converted into
numbers like one 2 3 4 while still
preserving the order so it's possible
not in this problem but in some other
problem that cold neutral warm hot are
indications of temperature and there is
actually a linear relationship between
what you're trying to predict and the
temperature so in such a case it may
make sense to convert them into numbers
to preserve that order and in these case
they are called ordinals so you will
often have to decide whether you want to
convert certain categories into numbers
or you want to convert them into one H
when should you convert them into
numbers when you see that there is a
high correlation between these
categories in their original order
in the natural order and the target then
you should convert them into numbers if
you do not see a correlation if you see
things go up and down like region for
example there's no clear region there's
no clear reason why region should have
some kind of an order in determining
what kind of charges you have so you can
just convert them into one hot encoded
columns okay so let's start with the
smoker column we are going to convert
the smoker column into we're going to
add a new column called smoker code so
here this is what the smoker column
looks
like smoker versus charges so on average
the charges for smokers are close to
35,000 or 32,000 the medical charges
that's the mean but that's because you
have a lot of outliers this does not
really convey the full picture but at
least it tells us that the average is
32,000 and here for non-smokers the
average is more around 6
7,000 so now we are going to create two
codes no and yes and we we store these
we store these in a map and we call
Medical DF dosm smoker. map and then we
pass in this dictionary here what this
is going to do is this going to replace
all the no values with zero and yes
values with one so now we have smoker
codes you can check medical
DF and maybe yeah let's just check
medical DF and you see smoker you have
smoker yes smoker code One smoker no
smoker Code
Zero and we can check the correlation
now between charges and smoker code and
seems like the correlation is quite High
787 and so now we can just use the
smoker code column this should say
smoker
code so we can now just use the smoker
code column for linear regression we say
charges equals the weight W1 * H W2 *
BMI W3 * charges W4 time smoker W plus b
so age BMI children smoker code
the number and the rest of the code is
exactly the same great so we end up with
a loss of 6056 that's almost a 50%
reduction in loss we've gone from what's
that
11,000 the on average being off by
11,000 to on average just being off by
6,000 that's not as good as we had just
for non-smokers but still it's better
it's better by 50% from the previous
value so that's an important lesson
never ignore categorical data it may be
a deciding factor in what makes your
model
good let's try adding the sex column in
as well so we're going to do the same
thing if you see here it turns out that
for females the average is slightly
lower than males so I'm just going to
put zero for female and one for male as
a sex
code and we have medical DF here
you can see where we have female we get
zero where we have male we get
one and let's check the correlation so
the correlation is very low hardly
anything so we
can run the process again age BMI
children smoker code sex code and you
can see there's no real change it goes
to 6056 from what was the previous value
6.43 to 6056 .10 so hardly any change
even what whatever change is there is
less than a dollar on average so it's
not really important we can maybe even
ignore the sex column Al
together next up we have the region
column the region column contains four
values and that's why we'll need to use
one hot encoding to create a new column
for each
region here's what we want to do instead
of like Northeast northwest southeast in
the same column we want to create a
column for Northeast and put ones and
zeros there create a column for
Northwest put ones and zeros create a
column for North for Southwest and put
ones and
zeros there is a way to do this in
psychic learn and I typically just look
it up and this this process is called
one hot in coding so I typically just
look up an example so here again if you
see that there is a difference by region
so maybe region is a factor maybe
different regions based on different
average incomes have different medical
costs at different hospitals so maybe
region is a factor so we should include
it so the way you one hot encode this
data is you use this one hot encoder
class from psyit learn. preprocessing so
from sklearn we import pre-processing
and then we use pre-processing one hot
encoder and on the encoder We call we
give it the list of regions and it's
simply going to identify the list of
regions it's called fit here but it's
really all it's going to do is it's
going to find that there are four
different values Northeast northwest
southeast Southwest okay so it has
identified these
values now we can give it some input and
this could be our original inputs or
this could be something that we want to
test out later so we can give it some
input let's say we want to we have nor
we have the Northeast region so let's
say we we give it ENC do transform and
we need to give it the Northeast region
so let me just give in Northeast as the
input I need to call two array here
actually see the values so it's going to
convert Northeast into 1 0 0 0 so for
Northeast which is the first category
it's going to create a one for the rest
of the categories it's going to have a
zero let's maybe give it two colum two
rows of data so this time we give it
Northeast and
Northwest so 1 0 0 0 0 0 1 0
right now what we can do is we can take
this the original regions from our data
frame frame which are Southwest
Southeast Southeast Etc so this is
region per customer and we can put that
into encoder
transform and that's going to give us
this kind of data so now we have this
column for Northeast this column for
Northwest this column for Southeast and
this column for Southwest right all this
is doing is this process taking a
categorical column and giving us one hot
vectors and then we can insert it back
into the data frame by saying that in
medical DF we want to create four new
columns so still remember it's not part
of the data frame yet so in medical DF
we want to create four more columns and
we want to give it this data one
H okay so here after doing all of that
and you don't need to actually remember
any of that you can always look that up
but after doing all of that what we've
been able to achieve is we take the
region column Southwest southeast
northwest Northeast and we have replaced
them with these four columns Northeast
northwest southeast Southwest I've still
kept these around I've not removed these
just so that we can see and make sure
things are working
properly and now we can include region
into our model as well so we have W1 *
AG plus W2 * BMI plus W3 * charges plus
W4 * smoker W5 * sex W6 * region plus b
so the idea here is once you understand
linear regression with one variable and
you really understand it well if you
internalize how it works then all of
this is really it's a very simple
extension you don't even have to change
any of the code but all you want to
understand is that when you're working
with one variable you're trying to fit a
line and you start out with a random
line and you move the line
around you use the loss function to find
out how bad the line is and you then use
an Optimizer to slowly improve the line
and move the line around till it fits
the data to the best extent possible
which is to minimize the loss right and
then you simply have to extend it
mathematically into a bunch of other
dimensions so now we no longer dealing
with one feature we're dealing with six
but the code is exactly the
same so there you go now we have a lot
of columns age BMI children smoker code
to be honest this is not correct exactly
this is there should be like a W6 W7 W8
W9 right so W6 times Northeast W7 times
Northwest W8 time Southeast W9 *
Southwest so there are four weights here
so I should actually correct this
for every region we're actually applying
a different weight
altogether and there you go now the loss
reduces slightly more to 6041 where did
we have it earlier let's see 6056 to 641
so about a $10 decrease and you can
already see that a lot of these other
factors are not really helping it seems
like age and children and maybe just age
and uh smoker those were the two biggest
factors and the rest of them don't
really matter maybe they give you like a
1% difference but not so
much now here's an exercise for you to
try and figure out if one linear
regression model actually makes sense
for this entire data because as we
already saw just with the distribution
of age this data is not linear there is
a trend but it's not linear in any sense
at the very least if we want to have
some sort of a linear relationship we
should take into consideration the
smoker column and the way we have taken
into consideration right now the smoker
column is by giving a weight to whether
this person is smoker or not so we kind
of adding a smoker penalty here that if
smoker is one then this weight gets
added to the charges if smoker is zero
this weight does not get added to the
charges but based on whether the person
is a smoker or not we are not really
changing any of the other weights so
here's what one thing you can try out
are two separate linear regression
models one for smokers and one for
non-smokers Better Than One S single
linear regression model and what does
better mean I'll let you think about
that so try it try creating two separate
linear regression models and use all the
other parameters with normal weights
just include smokers just exclude
smokers and create two separate models
one for smokers one for
non-smokers and see if the losses for
each of those models are lower on
average let's say the losses for both
those models are in the range of 3,000
or 4,000
so that means you are better of using
two models rather than using one linear
regression
model right and that's a decision that
you will have to make as a data
scientist should I be using one linear
regression model does that make sense or
maybe B based on whether these people
are smokers or not you need to have
different linear regression models
because the slopes of the lines are
different we know that for example BMI
makes a big difference for smokers but
does not make a big difference for
nonsmokers so right now we have imposed
a single weight on on BMI but ideally
the weight applied to BMI should really
depend on whether the person is smoker
or not so all these factors have to be
taken into consideration sometimes two
linear regression models based on our
understanding of the data may be better
than
one and this also kind of leads into
something that we will cover in the
coming weeks which is about decision
trees sometimes you don't want to make a
calculation just using just weights
sometimes you want to use decisions you
want to see whether a person is a smoker
or not and then maybe you want to check
the region which region they're in and
then maybe you want to check something
else and then maybe you want to use some
kind of an averaging technique so we'll
see how to mix some of these models as
well as we go
along so a couple of model improvements
and again there is some code involved
here I will not go too deep into the
code now we're getting to the point
where you should be able to read code
yourself and figure out what it is doing
so I'm going to tell you what the idea
here is what we're going to do here and
then you need to go and figure out what
in the study or whenever you have the
time what this code means and it's
simple code not too difficult so recall
that due to some regulatory requirements
in healthcare we also need to explain
the rational behind the predictions on
our model so when we have a prediction
here's our model right okay now somebody
walks in and they have a
certain profile so these are the input
columns for that we look at in our model
and let's try to create a sample input
so we take a person of age 28 a new a
new appli that has come in maybe their
BMI is 30 maybe they have two children
maybe they are a smoker so they smoker
code is one then they are female so this
is zero and they belong to the northwest
region so this is 0 1 and 0 and zero
okay now I'm going to predict so we give
this data this one row of data into our
model and our model predicts that for
this new applicant who has come
in the the estimated medical charges are
to
29875 and then using this we charge a
certain premium to the person we also
look at other factors but this is one of
the major factors we look at so now this
person comes back to us and says hey I
would like to understand why you have
quoted me this insurance premium and
then you tell them that hey we predicted
that your medical charges would be
around
$29,000 and then they would turn back
and say okay on what basis are you
saying that my medical charges are going
to be2 $29,000 and then you would say so
model we created a model we have a data
scientist they created this model and
the model says 29,000 and then they say
yeah but please tell me why it is 29,000
and that's a fair question because
remember the issues with correlation
causation Etc we don't know what issues
you had in your data so you can't hide
behind your model and say that the model
says so that's why we're charging you
that money you should be able to explain
why your model gives a certain output
now fortunately in the case of linear
regression that is fairly
straightforward you can see here that we
know that our model is applying some
weight to the age it is applying some
weight to the BMI it is applying some
weight to the charges some weight to the
smoker some weight to the some weight to
sex some weight to region some weight to
and then it has some intercept right so
some
baseline so to compare the importance of
each feature if you have to tell them
that hey we're charge we're quoting this
value because you have a certain
BMI then we need to tell that BMI has a
certain weight in our model right so we
go here and we can check the
coefficients of our model the
coefficients of our model
are the coefficients of our model are
256 339 475 so these are the weights
applied to the model okay now based on
these weights if we compare W1 is for
age W2 is for
BMI W3 is for charges W4 is for
smoker so you might be tempted to say
this point that look we we apply a very
high weight to smokers and $23,000
we''ve accounted for simply because
you're a smoker right and that could be
fine in certain cases in smoker because
smoker is a simple plus or minus column
a simple zero or one column it makes
sense but if you notice the weights
carefully and to help you notice it
carefully I've actually put them into
this data frame if you notice the weight
carefully it seems like BMI has a higher
weight than age BMI has a weight 33 9
while age has a weight 256 and children
have the weight 475 so this goes
completely opposite to what we
understand we understand that age is the
age is one of the most important factors
we we saw that for non-smokers at least
BMI has no bearing and children again we
saw has no bearing so what's going on
here our models results seem to be
completely out of sync with the weights
that it is assigning to the different
features we we felt that age and smoker
so smoker definitely has a high weight
no doubt but we felt that age has a far
more important impact than BMI children
sex code Etc but it seems like even
Southwest Southeast region has minus 448
so it has a negative correlation that is
twice as high as
age so what's going on here what's going
on is
that the range of values for BMI is
limited BMI is going to be limited from
15 to 40 BM is never going to go beyond
40 and in fact in most cases it's going
to be around 30 the Northeast column is
only going to take the values zero or
one that means the maximum change that
the Northeast column can compute or then
can create in the final output of
charges is $500 not more than that on
the other hand the age even though 256
is the weight for it age can go up to 60
so it can create 256 * 60 what's that
256 time 60 it can create a difference
of
$21,000
right so the weights do not accurately
represent which features are important
because the ranges of the different
features are
different that's one issue and another
issue that happens not so much in linear
regression but in later data sets we'll
see that sometimes when one column has a
very large range of inputs like age has
a very large range of 15 to 60 and one
column has a very low range of inputs
like
region can only go 0 to one so then when
you are calculating the loss and when
you're performing any
optimizations that large number
disproportionately affects the
optimization process because ultimately
your number is your model is simply
looking at a single number the loss and
the loss is computed using all of these
inputs and outputs and weights and
everything and if some column has a very
large inputs or very large outputs
definitely very large inputs
then yeah if some column has very large
inputs then it will disproportionately
contribute to the LW so most of our
effort will be spent just optimizing for
that one
single column so that's where we perform
a certain thing called standardization
we take the values in every column from
the value we subtract the mean of the
column and then we divide by the
standard deviation of the column okay
what does that do for example let's say
BMI BMI goes in the range go BMI from
the range of 15 to 40 after applying the
standardization we subtract the mean
which means we subtract 30 from the BMI
and then we divide by the standard
deviation the standard deviation is
around six let's say after applying this
standardization the values become
centered around zero so you have the
value zero and then you have bmis
centered around zero and they are also
scaled down so that it becomes a normal
distribution
with standard deviation one and mean of
zero so the idea is we scale down all
the values to small numbers that are in
the range of 1 to minus one or 2 to
minus 2 and then their mean is also
Zer and we do that for every column so
what we do is we standardize every
column into the 0 to one range only for
the numeric columns the categorical are
already like a 0 to one so we
standardize the the numeric columns in
the minus one to one range mean zero
standard deviation one and then the
weights will make a lot more sense so
here is how you do it I I'll just show
you quickly the way to do it is again
the way to really do it is to just look
up online hey how do I perform scaling
of features in skarn so I'm just going
to import standard scaler and we take
the numeric columns age BMI children we
get the numeric data from the scaler uh
we get the numeric data from the data
frame medical DF numeric columns and we
pass that into scaler so we call scaler
do fit all it does is it computes the
mean and the variance for each of the
numeric columns so it turns out that the
mean for age is 39 and the mean for BMI
is 30 and the mean for children is one
it turns out that the VAR variance in
age is 197 variance is square of the
standard deviation the variance in BMI
is far less and the variance in children
is even lesser so now we can scale the
data so what happens now we call scaler
do transform and then we give it the
data that we want to transform so here's
the data that we want to transform which
is medical
DF
numeric calls this is the data that we
want to transform age BMI and children
and once we transform it this is what
the values will become so they will go
between minus one and one here you can
see that this is transformed to
something between minus between 0o and
one this is transformed to something
negative so these values all change
between minus one and one and then we
can take the categorical data and we can
can put it together so we take these
four rows of these three rows of
categorical data these three rows of
numerical data we take all the
categorical data and we put them all
together and it looks something like
this so these three rows let me just
take show you a couple of one row of
data so these three come from here and
then these three come from the
categorical one hot encoding and the
binary encoding
Etc all right and then we train the
model so we get the same laws this in
this case it does not really affect the
loss in linear regression that's the
scaling does not affect the loss but the
difference now is that when you look at
the weight for every feature you'll see
that the weights for the different
features now make a lot more sense so it
seems like the weight for
smoker the weight for smoker is 2.3 into
10 ^ of 4 which means 23,000 the weight
for age is
3,600 and I guess this is probably not
the best way to print it so let me
just let's just put
this model.
CF
and okay I think we'll just have to
interpret them here so the weight for
smoker is 2383 2.3 into 10 ^ 4 which is
23,000 the weight for age is 3.6 into
10^ of 3 which is 3600 the weight for
BMI is
2.71 into 10 ^ of 3 which is is
2,000 so now you can start to see that
we have different levels of weights and
now you can tell the person or you can
you can disclose that in our models
smoking has a very high weight of 23,000
so it has contributed 23,000 to the
calculation the age has a factor of$
3600 so we add $3600 for every year that
you have been alive based on your BMI
for every BMI point we add $2,000 to
your ex medical expenses for every child
you have uh it seems like this is 500 so
for every child we have we add
$572 then we have minus 1.24 9 so it
seems like for sex it's the inverse
correlation so we're actually
subtracting some money if you're male
then depending
on whether you're from a certain region
we apply a certain correction factor for
a region and one of the biggest factors
is the bias itself so one simply
represents the intercept all right now
one thing that you will have to do is
when somebody comes to
you let's say let's go back to this
person here yeah so when a new person
comes to you you will then have to scale
these values before you can put them
into the model so let's see let's get
new
customers and we have just one customer
here so the first thing we want to do is
we want to do
scaler and directly put these values in
2832 so you need to scale the numeric
values
2832 and then you can simply copy over
the actual categorical values here we
have
them and then you can just call a model.
predict and now you can see here that we
have the result
29824 but now we have a very clear
description of why we've applied
29824 roughly speaking so yeah that's
how you interpret a linear regression
model what I said earlier was about age
adding $3,600 is not completely true
because we have scaled the age but you
can give them a relative explanation
that the most important factor is
smoking then you have age then you have
BMI and these are the weightages that
apply in your case so in your case the
fa age factor is 0.1 or negative .1 and
the BMI factor is 75 and so on sorry
this is age I believe and this is
BMI so that's how you scale the uh data
okay and I guess we're going to end here
today so just a quick summary of uh how
you approach a machine learning problem
first step is to explore the data and
find different correlations between
inputs and targets understand
what leads to a certain Target maybe
even go back and do some research
whether there is a cause effect
relationship or is there just a
correlation and is it possible that the
correlation may just go away or is it
possible that the correlation is unfair
in any way for example should maybe you
should not be using race as a factor in
Computing insurance right so that's
something you should be conscious of as
a data scientist then you pick the right
model in this case we pick linear
regression you pick the right loss
functions in this case we picked root
means squared error and you pick the
right Optimizer in this case we pick uh
least squares and all of these three are
captured in uh the linear regression
class from Psychic learn so for
different problems you have to pick
different models sometimes you have to
pick decision tree sometimes you have to
pick neural networks or something else
then you scale the numeric variables and
one hot you scale the numeric variables
so that they all have a mean of zero
standard deviation of one you perform
one hot encoding for categorical data
and this is not something we covered
today but this something that we'll
cover next time about setting aside a
test set then you train a model then you
make predictions and compute the laws
now we didn't do this today but one
thing you should do is you should
actually set aside 10% of your data a
small fraction of your data just for
testing and Reporting the results of
your model because the model like the
ones we have created today are designed
to be used in the real world not only on
the data that we trained them on so what
people typically do is when they get
some data from let's say product manager
or some somebody Whoever has given us
the insurance data we take 10% of the
data and then we set it aside forever
then we do all our modeling and
everything let's say we build a linear
regression model on 90% of the data and
then when we report the loss when we
actually report the metric that hey I
built this model and uh this is the
result it gives and this is the kind of
loss that I've been able to achieve or
this is the kind of error that my model
has you should be then reporting that
error on the test data which means on
the 10% of the data which you set aside
at the beginning and did not use for
training and you can do this in psychic
learn using this train test split so
what that does it takes some inputs it
takes some targets it takes uh 0.1 like
a fraction and it gives you a bunch of
90% of the data which you can use for
training which is input strain and
Target strain and then 10% of the data
which you can use for testing okay and
we'll talk about this in a lot more
detail the next time but what you will
notice is that the score on your test
set or the loss on your test set is
going to be always higher than the loss
on your training set because your model
has not seen SE these examples so model
is bad is worse at predicting examples
that it has not seen and this is again
true a lot of machine learning models
when you put them out into the real
world they perform worse even though you
may get a really you you get like a 98%
accuracy when you're training the model
but when you put it out it's less than
30% so we will talk about a lot of
techniques in this course on how to
counter that this is called overfitting
and we'll talk in a lot of detail about
that so the right strategy is to set
aside a test set before you train a
model and then train the model and then
make predictions and compute the laws
and Report the results on your test set
and we will apply this process over and
over to several problems with different
kinds of models over the next few weeks
the topic for today is logistic
regression with psychic
learn and here is a quick overview of
the topics that we are
covering this image will give you a hint
of the problem statement that we're
looking at today so we'll start by
download loading a real world data set
from
kaggle we will explore the data set we
will perform some explor data analysis
and visualization very
little we will then split the data set
into a training validation and test set
so we'll talk about why these are
important we will talk about filling and
imputing missing values in numeric
columns we will also look at how we can
scale numeric features to a 0 to one
range we will we also look at encoding
categorical columns as one hot
vectors then we will train a logistic
regression model using the psyit learn
library then we will evaluate the model
using the validation set and the test
set that we had created and then we'll
save the model to disk and load it back
so you'll see a quite a bit of overlap
between what we're doing today and what
we did last week and that is intentional
the idea here is that the machine
learning workflow is something that you
will apply to pretty much every machine
learning problem you solve so by looking
at it multiple times with multiple data
set in the context of different machine
learning algorithms you will start to
get used to it and by the end of this
course this should become second nature
to
you and you can see instructions on how
to run the code we are currently running
it on Google collab using the runon
collab option but you can also run it on
binder it will be a little slower or you
can run it on your computer locally just
use the Run locally option by clicking
the Run button so here's the problem
statement that we're looking at today
since we want to take a practical and
coding focused approach we will learn
how to apply logistic regression to a
real world data set from kaggle uh so
here's the data set the rain in
Australia data set contains about 10
years of daily weather observations from
numerous Australian weather
stations and this data set is taken from
this data set is taken from from kaggle
if you open this link you will see here
the page where this data set is taken
from so kaggle is a platform where you
can participate in data science
competitions and kagle is also a
community where people share data sets
and data science projects now on this
data set page you will be able to browse
the data set you can see some
information about the data set as it
says this data set contains 10 years of
daily weather observations from many
locations across Australia
and the objective of this data set or
why it was created was to predict next
day rain so we'll talk about what that
is you can also see the columns in this
data set so it seems like there are
about 23 columns in the data set and you
can see that these are the first few
columns the date of the observation
starts around 2008 goes on or 2007 in
fact and goes on till 2017 it contains
information like location for example
albur canura Sydney it contains a
minimum temperature for the day at that
location the maximum temperature
rainfall evaporation Sunshine Etc so a
bunch of
different measurements of weather at
several locations day by day for almost
10 years that's the data set that we
working
with and here's a sample from the data
set just to uh give you a context of
what it looks like
now as a data scientist at the Bureau of
meteorology you are tasked with creating
a fully automated system that can use
today's weather data for a given
location to predict whether it will rain
at a location tomorrow okay so if you
look at this data set you have all these
Columns of data location Min temp Max
temp Etc a total of 23 columns not all
of them are shown here and then there
are a couple of columns at the end one
says rain today which indicates whether
it rained on this particular day and the
next is rain tomorrow which simply
indicates on whether rainfall was
recorded the next day so for 10 years of
data we have all these weather
measurements and then for each day we
have also listed whether it has rained
on that location on the next day or not
now this is very useful because now we
can use this 10 years of historical data
and create some kind of a system which
can take the data for
today and use that to predict whether it
will rain tomorrow so it's a weather
prediction system that can potentially
replace a
meteorologist so that's what we're
trying to create we want to create this
forecast specifically we want to create
this rain forecast whether it's going to
rain or not in a particular location
given its weather information for
today and here some of the information
you have so before you proceed further
just take a moment to think about how
you can approach this problem maybe try
listing five or more ideas that come to
your mind when you are executing this
notebook it's important to think about
this because machine learning requires a
change in mindset and you can see how
your original mindset is as you list out
some of these ideas and once we work
through the machine learning approach
you can try and see if you need to
change your mindset a little bit so that
the next time you come across a problem
you can think of it in terms of a
machine learning algorithm them or not
okay so in the previous tutorial we
attempted to predict a person's annual
medical
charges by looking at information like
their age the their sex their number of
children whether they're a smoker or not
and there we use linear regression in
this tutorial we are going to use
logistic regression which is better
suited for classification problems like
predicting whether it will rain tomorrow
and identifying whether a given problem
is a classification problem or a
regression problem is a very important
first step in machine learning so let's
define these terms classification and
regression
problems problems where each input must
be assigned a discrete category and
sometimes these are called labels or
classes are known as classification
problems and here's what I mean by that
by with some concrete example
rainfall prediction predicting whether
it will rain tomorrow using today's
weather data so what we want to do is
take all the information for today all
the measurements for today and then
using that either say that it will rain
or say that it will not rain okay so
there are two categories or two classes
which we want to classify these
measurements into whether these suggest
that it will rain tomorrow whether these
suggest that it
won't here's another one
breast cancer
detection this is actually something
that is used in real in the real world
predicting whether a tumor is benign
which is non-cancerous or malignant so
if a tumor is detected in your
body can we predict whether it's
cancerous or non-cancerous using
information like its radius texture Etc
so once again we are classifying tumors
into cancerous or
non-cancerous here's one more and
there's a data set that you can click
through and find to do exactly
this here's one
more loan repayment prediction
predicting whether an
applicant will be able to repay a home
loan based on factors like age income
loan amount number of children Etc so
here we're not predicting medical
charges which is like a continuous
dollar number but rather we're
predicting whether they will be able to
repay a Lo loone or not so yes or no
again a classification
problem and then there's one more
handwritten digit recognition so here
you are given pictures of handwritten
digits here you're given pictures of
handwritten digits and your job is to
identify which digit a picture
represents so you can click through and
you can discover this data set as well
in this case there are nine classes you
have to classify whether the digit is a
zero or a 1 or a 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 so
actually there are 10 classes um so
classification problems can be binary
which is yes no will rain will not rain
benign malignant um will repay the loan
will not repay the loan or they can be
multiclass where you have to assign each
input into one of many classes like
handwritten digit
recognition try and think of some more
examples of classification problems and
once you're done with this notebook once
you work through this notebook try and
replicate the steps we followed in this
notebook with each of these data sets
just to get a better sense of how
classification problems work so those
are the kind of problems that we're
looking at today but the kind of
problems that we looked at the last time
which is problems where a continuous
numeric value must be predicted for each
input are known as regression problems
and here are some examples of regression
problems medical charges prediction so
we are using in in puts like age number
of children whether the person smokes
Etc to predict exact number which is the
amount of money they will spend on
medical
expenses similarly house price
prediction given information like the
location of a house the number of
bedrooms the square foot area how many
bathrooms it has etc etc whether it has
a lawn can you predict the price of the
house so again it's a exact number it's
not a yes no or a or a category
similarly there's another data set here
of ocean temperature prediction given
information about several measurements
taken from the ocean floor can you
predict the temperature of the ocean
floor and you can check out this data
set for that and then in weather itself
if you think about temperature if we
want to predict the temperature for
tomorrow rather than whether it will
rain or not the temperature is again a
continuous number so once again this is
called a regression problem not a
classification problem we because we're
trying to predict a continuous quantity
so try and think of some more regression
problems that you may come across or you
may want to solve and you can try and
replicate the steps we followed in the
previous tutorial with each of these
data sets Okay so that's classification
and regression classification is just
classifying data into certain classes
regression technically or literally
means fitting data so trying to create a
model which can fit exactly to the numer
numic value that you want to predict
right so whenever you see regression
think continuous values whenever you
think classification think discrete
classes and we saw that linear
regression is a commonly used technique
for solving regression problems hence
the name linear regression and in a
linear regression model the target is
modeled as a linear combination or a
weighted sum of input features for
example we said that trying to predict
the medical charges can be done by
taking a linear combination of some
input features so let's say we are
looking at the input features age and
whether the person is a smoker so zero
or one so the model that we created the
last time assume that age has a certain
weight W1 and smoker 0 or 1 has a
certain weight W2 and then there's a
certain number B so you have W1 W2 and B
if you can figure out good values for W1
W2 and B then you can you can take any
value of age and any information about
whether the person or smoker is a smoker
or not and get a good estimate of their
medical charges so that was the model
that we had created the last time and
what we did was we took that model and
using that model and we took random
values of W1 W2 and B to get started we
took that model and using that model we
generated predictions for all the inputs
that we had and we compared the
predictions of our model our randomly
initialized model model assuming a
linear relationship we compared its
predictions with the actual targets or
with the actual medical charges of those
people using a loss function so called
the root means squared error right so we
compared it using a loss function and
then we trained a machine learning model
to reduce the loss function by adjusting
the weights W1 W2 and B okay that is
what a machine learning training process
looks like so here's what that looks
like we take some input data training
data so this would contain information
like age whether the person is smoker
number of children
Etc and it would also have some outputs
so we would put the input data into the
model and we would get some predictions
from the model so we would take the
predicted output from the model and we
would also take the actual output or the
real data from the training set put them
both into a loss function which was a
root means squared error in case of
linear regression and then run an
optimization method to reduce the loss
by changing the weights within the model
so that will then improve the model over
time and as we do this over and over
repeatedly for long enough the weights
get pretty good and then we can use the
model to make predictions on new data
right that's the machine learning
process that we
followed for linear regression okay and
if you want to see a more mathematical
discussion of linear regression you
should check out this uh YouTube
playlist that I have linked to here and
that will then go through in more detail
how each component fits in and how the
optimization
works so for classification problems
similarly the technique that is often
used is called logistic
regression and specifically for binary
classification problems which is the
kind of classification problem we're
looking at today just a yes no
classification so in a logistic
regression
model we start out the same way
we take a linear combination or a
weighted sum of the input features so
let's say if we just look at today's
temperature and today's rainfall and we
want to use those to predict whether it
will rain tomorrow or not so we start
out by taking a linear combination we
say we pick a weight W1 a random weight
W1 we pick a random weight W2 and Rand
and a random weight B and we fix them so
W1 w2b we fix them then we calculate
this quantity for a given an input let's
say we have some information about the
city Melbourne we take the temperature
at Melbourne we take the rainfall at
Melbourne we multiply them with W1 and
W2 and we add B okay and we get this
quantity X1 W1 plus X2 W2 plus
b then we have an additional step here
so in linear regression we were done at
this point but in logistic regression we
have an additional step we take this
quantity and then we put it through this
activation function called Sigma or
called sigmoid it's represented by this
character Sigma but it stands for
sigmoid and what the sigmoid function
does is it takes this output of this
linear combination and it squishes it
between the range 0 to 1 okay so the
exact details are not very important
about how this function does so but what
it does is it takes this linear
combination or this quantity that we get
X1 W1 plus X2 W2 plus b and it squishes
it into the range 0 to 1 and then that
value which we get out of the sigma
function
is inferred as the
probability
of the class that we're trying to
predict so since we're trying to do a
yes no prediction which is it will rain
tomorrow or it will not rain tomorrow so
the output of Sigma Z output of Sigma
will be a number between 0 and 1 and
that number will indicate what our model
thinks is the probability that it will
rain tomorrow okay and then we compare
those probabilities with the actual
values because we have historical data
we can see whether our model is
predicting the right probabilities or
not if it is not predicting the right
probabilities then we penalize it by
giving it a high loss if it is
predicting the right probabilities then
we penalize it then we penalize it less
by giving it a low loss but overall we
come up with a loss for the model and
for logistic regression the loss is
called the cross entropy loss it has a
formula like this uh again the details
are
not that important the important thing
is that there is a small change in the
structure of the model which is this
function Sigma and then this loss is a
value which is high if the model
predicts bad probabilities uh and the
loss is low if the model predicts good
probabilities okay and then once again
we train the model in the exact same way
so we take the data that we have so we
take the weather data for today put it
through the model and then we get a
prediction from the model we take the
prediction of the model and we compare
it with the actual data that we have
because this is historical data of
whether it will rain tomorrow so we have
the actual yes no yes no answers of
whether it will rain tomorrow and we
take the predictions which are
probabilities and we put them into this
loss function called cross
entropy we run that through the
optimization algorithm once again the
optimiz ation algorithms like gradient
descent least squares there are many
optimization algorithms and that is able
to then change the parameters or change
the weights and biases of the model the
W1 W2 Etc so that the model now makes
better predictions and gets a lower loss
right so this is the same machine
learning workflow that is applied except
that the details are changed the model
now instead of being a just a linear
combination also applies a sigmoid
function so it outputs numbers between 0
and 1 and then the error instead of
being a root means squared error is a
cross entropy error which is between
these yes no outputs and these
probabilities so on the one hand the
targets are like yes no or 01 while the
predictions are probabilities in the
range of 0 to 1 something like 3.
7.9 and the optimization method may also
differ but all of these parts remain the
same so that's logistic regression and
that's all we'll say about it right
right now because we want to focus on
how to build good logistic regression
models uh so if you do want to check out
internally how all of this works uh you
should once again check out this YouTube
playlist it is about 1 hour long it will
go into uh the mathematics and also show
you a more geometric
interpretation and as to why it is
called logistic regression because it's
solving a classification problem so it's
a bit confusing the name the reason is
that the output of this sigmoid function
or the Sigma function that we have that
is a number between 0 to 1 that is
called a logistic and what we're trying
to do is we are trying to fit or regress
that logistic to the data so we are
trying to get that value of between 0 to
one as close to one in the cases of
inputs which have the output yes and as
close to zero in the cases of inputs
which have the output zero so in some
sense we have even though we are working
with discrete classes yes and no we have
created this continuous quantity of the
probability and then we want to fit this
probability as close to the desired
inputs as possible so that's why it's
called logistic regression but logistic
regression is a classification algorithm
so just keep that in mind
okay so that's the machine learning
workflow
and that's basically all the theory for
today maybe if we have time at the end
we may work through an actual logistic
regression example with a few inputs but
roughly what you want to understand is
that it is a different kind of algorithm
which outputs probabilities and it uses
a different error function but the
training process is the same and it is
used for classification now
classification and regression are both
supervised machine learning problems
because they use labelled data machine
learning by label data we mean we have
some targets so for classification the
target is the class that we want to
assigned to each input rain or no
rain which we already have in our data
set and similarly for regression it is
the quantity that we want to predict for
example the medical charges both of
these are called supervised learning and
you can see supervised learning have has
classification and
regression but there are certain cases
where we do not have any labels and
mostly what we want to do is we want to
group data into clusters and that is
called unsupervised learning so we will
also look at unsupervised learning
towards the very end of this
course but our primary focus will be on
supervised learning which is
classification and regression
okay so just to come back to the problem
that we are looking at we will train a
logistic regression model using the rain
in Australia data set to predict whether
or not it will rain at a location
tomorrow using today's data and this is
a binary classification problem because
it's a yes no kind of
classification so let's start by
downloading the data the data set is on
kaggle and there are several ways to
download the data set from kaggle for
example you can download the data here
by clicking download and then upload it
to collab now collab is running on
Google servers so if you check the files
tab here this is not files from your
computer so if you want to take files
from your computer put it on collab then
you need to use the upload button to do
it so you could download the file here
the zip file and then you could upload
it to Google collab uh and then you'll
have to figure out a way to unzip it
it's a bit cumbersome another thing you
could do is kaggle has an API and you
can check it out
here so you can use this kagle API this
is a command line tool for downloading
data sets from kaggle so it looks
something like this you say kaggle data
sets download and you have to run this
on the terminal and you have to put a
API key somewhere so that's a bit
cumbersome as well the approach that we
recommend is using the open data sets
Library so this is an open source
library that we have created to make it
really easy to download kaggle data sets
anywhere so you install the open data
sets Library using pip install open data
sets then you import open data sets as
OD and then we can check the version of
the library which is 0.1.2 so always
make sure you have uh the latest version
which you can ensure by running hyphen
hyen upgrade so we've imported open data
sets as OD and then we take the data set
URL which is this URL the kaggle page
URL and we Run od. download the data set
URL so let's run that now when you run
od. download data set URL you will be
asked to provide your kaggle username
and a kagle API key now where do you
find that uh the way to do that is click
on this uh go back to kaggle so go to
kaggle.com
and make sure that you sign in on
and then click on your username then
click on
account and here you should see an
option create new API token so just
click create new API token and that is
going to download this file called
kaggle Json
to your computer now this file kaggle
Json contains the information that you
need so if you open up kagle
Json as you have opened it up
here as we've opened it up here you can
take the username so let me take the
username I'm going to put it
here and then you will need to provide
your kaggle key so I'm going to take my
kaggle key put it in here as well and
hit enter
and
now I am authenticated and this data set
has been downloaded okay you can verify
that this data set is downloaded by
looking opening up the files tab and
checking here that you have the name of
the data set here another way you can do
this instead of having to manually enter
your kaggle key is to click this upload
button and just upload the kaggle Json
file here and once you do that you will
see that your kaggle credentials are
picked up automatically okay and open
data sets is smart so it also checks
whether you have downloaded the data set
already so if it has found that you have
downloaded dat the data set already it
is going to skip the download so you can
specify Force equals true if you want to
force it to download or if you want to
force it to redownload the data set as
it has done in this case okay but
otherwise it'll just detect and it will
skip all right so now we have this
folder weather data set rattle package
downloaded from kaggle using the open
data sets Library all we need to do is
import open data sets as OD and Run od.
download provide our kaggle
credentials so let's check this folder
wether data set rattle package this is
what it's called so we check it using
os.
listd
and then in it seems like there's a
single file whether a us. CSV so let's
create the full path to this file so now
we have in train CSV the
variable we have the full path to the
file weather data set rattle package /we
a.csv we can now load the data from
weather a.csv using pandas now pandas as
you already know is a library for
working with CSV files so I'm just going
to clear my notebook outputs at the
moment just so that we can get all the
outputs from scratch so I just did edit
clear all outputs uh to remove the
previous out outputs from my previous
execution anyway so now we have PD
pandas imported as PD and we give it the
path to the file that we have just
downloaded and that creates this data
frame so here is now our data set
available to us as a data frame we have
information like the date we have
location we have minimum temperature
maximum temperature rainfall evaporation
Sunshine wind direction etc etc so there
are a total of 20
I believe there are total of 23 columns
starting from the date so if you ignore
the date for a moment because we're not
going to use date for prediction and
then the final column is the target the
final col column is what we want to
predict which is the rain tomorrow
column so we have 23 - 2 21 pieces of
information or 21 Columns of data that
we are going to use to make the
prediction for whether it will rain
tomorrow so we looking at 21 weather
features for today and hopefully that
that should give us enough information
to predict whether it will rain tomorrow
okay and the data set contains over
145,000
rows so the data set contains a date it
contains some numeric columns you can
see here these are numeric columns it
also seems to contain some categorical
columns you can see that the wind
direction is definitely a categorical
column you can see these are strings but
you can see that there are a limited
number of values that these take so it's
a good mix and our OB objective is to
create a model to predict the value in
the column rain tomorrow using all the
other columns maybe except the
date so let's check the data types and
see if there are any missing values in
these
columns so in total we have
145,50 rows of data the
date
is not so there are no not n there are
no null values for date there are no
null values for location that's great
because all of this information was
collected on a particular date at a
particular location but you will start
to see that there seemed to be quite a
few null values in the other columns and
that's perfectly fine maybe that data
was not available maybe that data was
not measured maybe it was not entered a
lot of things could have
happened but one issue here is that the
rain today and rain tomorrow columns
also seem to have quite a few null
values in fact you have 145,000 total
entries and here you have
142,000 values for rain today and rain
tomorrow so about 3,000 rows don't seem
to have information of whether it rain
tomorrow now that's a problem because we
want to train a model to predict whether
it will rain tomorrow so we can only use
data which contains information on
whether it rain tomorrow or not I mean
if your data itself contains null values
in the Target column that's not very
useful for the model to learn anything
because you not giving the model any
information so that's one issue so we
should probably remove the rows where
the target column is
empty now I want to go one step further
and say that and this is just a
hypothesis now uh that whether it rains
today should have a very strong bearing
on whether it rains tomorrow right so if
we have missing data on whether it rains
today we I think that a lot of important
information is missing here in that data
even though we have a bunch of other
information so what we going to do is we
are going to drop all the rows where
either rain today or rain tomorrow are
null okay where either the rain today
value or the rain tomorrow value are
empty and the second one it makes sense
because it's a Target column and we
should only have rows where we actually
have a value to predict for the Target
column but the first one rain today I'm
just taking a guess here saying that hey
if I don't know whether it rain rain
today it's going to be very hard to
predict if it's rain tomorrow okay so
I'm going to just run draw DF do dropna
rain today and rain tomorrow in place so
from RW DF we are going to drop this
information and now if you check R DF
dot info you should see that the number
of rows should have gone down it has
gone down to 140,000 but at the same
time we don't have any non-null values
anymore okay the rest of them we will
deal with them over time but these were
just two important ones that I felt in
this data set we have to take care and
this is something you will also have to
figure out on a Case by case basis are
there missing targets then maybe those
rows are not useful and are there any
critical columns that uh you shouldn't
uh you should not have null so maybe you
should drop those rows as well okay and
you can think about how you will deal
with missing values in the other columns
but we will come back to it as
well okay next up we have some explorat
data analysis and visualization so
before training a machine learning model
it's always a good idea to explore the
distributions of the various columns and
see how they are related to the Target
column and they will often give you a
lot of interesting insights about the
data they will give you ideas for
whether um you need to transform certain
features whether maybe there is some
invalid data that you need to fix
whether you can combine multiple
features to create new features whether
you can maybe do a log ithm of a certain
feature to get a better correlation etc
etc there are many many ideas that you
will get as you explore the data but
today because our focus is on logistic
regression we'll do a limited amount of
Eda so let's just install these
libraries these plotting libraries mat
plot lip cbon and plotly and first of
all I'm just going to look at the
location data I'm going to see what
different locations we have and how many
measurements we have across locations so
I believe we have a a around 29
locations if I'm not wrong let's check
that so rf.
nunique that will tell you how many
locations we
have rf. location. nunique will tell us
that okay we have 49 locations so these
are the 49 locations maybe there are a
few more but for these locations you can
see for each location we have about
3,000 values roughly speaking and that
makes sense 10 years of data so per
location 300 or 360 days of data Maybe
it's not 10 maybe it's 9 and 1 half
years so 300 rows of 360 days of data
per year multiplied by about 9 years or
9 and 1 half years should give us about
3,000 values but you will see that for
certain locations the number of
measurements is smaller maybe they did
not have weather stations earlier they
got weather stations recently or maybe
this data was not collected or was lost
or for certain days so that's what this
St tells us we we're getting a good
sense that we have mostly uniform
distribution of data across
locations I have also chosen color as
rain today so we have split These Bars
to show whether the value of rain today
is no or yes so if you roughly look at
this you can see that in Albury there
were
2300 rain
today 2300 measurements where there was
no rain on those days and there was 6 00
days where there was rain on those days
so 600 out of 30,000 out of 3,000 that's
about 20% of days and that seems to be
roughly the case that about 20% of days
in pretty much every city there was rain
and then for about 80 or 75% of days
there was no rain of course that's not
true everywhere for example here with
Uluru you can see that there are very
few days where there was rain and there
are
other like Hobart where in this case you
you can see that there are quite a few
days where uh there was rain or I guess
this is wall pole yeah on wall Poole
there are quite a few days where there
was rain almost 1,000 out of
2,500 okay so location definitely seems
to be a factor that decides how much
rain there is going to be so there is
some correlation here for
sure let's look at a few more and we'll
go through them very quickly let's look
at the temperature at 300 p.m. so we're
going to plot a histogram of what the
temperatures at 300 p.m. look like and
let's also break those histograms by
whether it has rained on the next day or
not so my guess is that if the
temperature at 300 p.m. today was low
then it's likely that it might rain
tomorrow and this histogram seems to
validate that like if you just look at
the overall histogram it seems to form a
gosan curve or a normal distribution but
you can see that the red indicates the
cases where it did rain tomorrow so you
can see that there are more cases of low
temperatures and rain tomorrow than
there are with high temperatures and
rain tomorrow so if the temperature is
lower it's more it seems more likely
that it would rain although there are
still a decent number of examples where
the temperature has been high and it has
still rained
right so this is how you can break down
histogram specifically for
classification problems you can use this
color argument in PL and I'm using
plotly here but you can or plotly
Express but you can use cbon and there
you have the Hue argument so you can use
the color argument to distinguish
between classes and here I'm just
getting a sense that when the
temperature is lower the chances of
rainfall might be
higher maybe let's also look at rain
today let's also look at the
distribution of rain
tomorrow in how many cases is rain
tomorrow said to yes in how many cases
is it said to no so it seems like out of
140,000 data points for about
10 10,000 data points it seems like it
did not rain and then for about the
remaining 30,000 data points it seems
like it did rain on the next day right
so this is called class imbalance you
have two classes no and yes and you do
not have an equal number of observations
in each class this is an important
factor we'll talk about later when we
build our models one other thing we have
done here is we have chosen rain today
as the color so what does that tell us
this tells us that there were 92,000
instances where rain today was no and
rain tomorrow was also
no and there were only 16,000 instances
where rain today was yes and rain
tomorrow was all was no so that means if
it did not rain today then there's a
pretty good chance that it will not rain
tomorrow on the other hand here you see
a mostly even split which means that if
it did rain today if rain today was was
yes it may or may not rain tomorrow and
if if rain today was no again it may or
may not rain tomorrow right so uh
predicting rain tomorrow yes is
difficult but predicting rain tomorrow
no is easier when rain today is no okay
so there are many ways to think about
and interpret this chart so spend spend
some time on each chart trying to
understand what it represents but as
such we can already tell that if it did
not rain today we can be confident that
it is not going to rain tomorrow of
course there are a lot of factors
involved as
well uh then here's a scatter plot of
maximum temperature and minimum
temperature so you can see on most days
this is what the distribution of maximum
temperature minimum temperature looks
like in fact between them there is a
linear correlation so you could probably
even try a linear regression model to
predict maximum temperature using
minimum temperature and you would have a
line like this but that's not what we're
doing here what we've done is we've
colored in these days or these points
using rain today and you will start to
see that the cases where the the minimum
temperature and the maximum temperatures
are very close right or where first of
all the minimum temperature is low and
second the maximum temperature is close
to the minimum temperature where there's
not a lot of variation in those
days rain today seems to be more common
so when it rains on a particular day
then the variation in temperature is
small and maybe that is also relevant
for whether it rains tomorrow or not
right so these are all different facets
that you can explore about weather
weather is infinitely complex and
weather has a lot of different uh
interesting things that you can learn
from and then here is a graph of
temperature today versus humidity today
and how that relates to whether it is
rains tomorrow so I'm guessing that if
the temperature today is low and the
humidity is high then there's a high
chance that there may be rain tomorrow
and that seems to be the case you can
see here that if all the red points are
in the low temperature high humidity
region and the blue points are in the
high temperature low humidity
region okay so try and make your own
interpretations from these charts and
try and visualize all the other Columns
of the data set and then study their
relation with rain today and rain
tomorrow as well but we will move ahead
so at this point let us just save our
work so from time to time you should be
saving your work and you can do this by
running by importing the Jovian python
library and running Jovian doc
commit and the reason you should do this
is because if you step away from the
Google collab notebook for 10 or 15
seconds then the notebook will shut down
and you can lose your work so when you
run jan.com it you will be asked to
provide an API key so this is not the
kaggle API key this is a jovian API key
because we want to take a snapshot of
this notebook and put it on Jovian so
you just open up
jan. and in the get started tab of your
profile you will be able to find this
API key so just click on API key come
back back here and paste it in and what
this will do now is this will capture a
snapshot of all the code execution that
we have done so far and take that
Jupiter notebook and put it on your
Jovian profile so as you can see here
this is my personal copy of the lesson
notebook that I've been working on so
far and any changes that you've made
will be preserved here uh and you can
always go back to jan. and you can find
it in the notebooks tab of your profile
as you can see here python SK learn
logistic regression I have a notebook
here just for this and if you want you
can go back and you can click run on
collab or run on binder to run this
notebook okay so to keep running jan.com
it from time to
time all right now there is one other
optional step that I would like to
suggest when you're working with massive
data sets where you have millions of
rows we don't have it right now we have
100,000 rows that's fairly small
relatively speaking but if you have
millions of rows or tens of of millions
of rows it's always a good idea to
initially work with a sample and by a
sample we mean a fraction a randomly
picked
fraction and this is so that you can
quickly set up your model training
notebook so that each line of code that
you execute runs quickly and you're able
to just try out many different ideas
very quickly so if you would like to
work with a sample in this notebook just
set use sample equals true so let's say
if we set use samples equal equals true
and then we pick a fraction of the data
that we want to work with then all we
are doing here is we are setting raw DF
the data frame that we have created to a
sample of the data frame so we are
setting raw DF to rdf do sample and we
have the fraction sample fraction do
copy so we are basically taking a 10%
fraction and instead of using 140,000
rows we would just be using 14,000 rows
and that will make our training or our
uh analysis much faster uh in this case
not by so much but if we had like 10
million rows then it would make a lot of
sense to maybe just work with 100 ,000
initially set up the notebook and then
come back and change use sample back to
false and if it's false then we won't
pick a sample and then rerun The
Notebook from top to bottom okay this
will save you a lot of time when you're
working with massive data sets so always
set up this these three lines of code
use sample sample fraction and uh this
if else condition which you can easily
switch between having a sample and
working with the entire
data so that's a quick trick there all
right so moving right
ahead before we train the model we have
to learn a few best practices so we are
going to learn a few best practices that
now you will start to see coming up over
and over again with every model we build
now while building real world machine
learning models it is quite common to
split a data set into three parts the
first part is the training set and the
training set is used to train the model
which means that we take the inputs from
the training set put them into the model
which is randomly initialized with some
random weights we then take the outputs
or the predictions of that model comp
compare them with the targets the actual
targets and compute a loss using a loss
function and then we put them through
the optimizer to change the model's
weights using an optimization technique
so that's machine learning that's a
machine learning training workflow the
training set is used to train the model
but remember that your model is not
going to be used on the training data
the training data in this case for
example is historical data but we want
to use the model on new data so
it will not be accurate to report the
model's performance on just the training
set and that is why we create two other
sets we create a validation set and a
test set now a validation set is used to
evaluate the model during training
because training is often not a one-step
process often you train a little bit and
then see if you got a good enough result
maybe train some more maybe you change
some parameters in the model maybe
instead of uh using a logistic
regression model uh you use a a
polinomial logistic regression model or
maybe you change the optimization
algorithm maybe you change from least
squares to gradient descent to bilinear
solver etc etc right so while you're
training the model you will want to
experiment with a lot of different
tweaks to the model structure itself and
to the optimization process itself or
maybe even to the loss function you can
even change the loss function so as you
want to tune all of these different ways
of training the model you should be
using what is called a validation set
which is simply a fraction of the uh
data
set and you shouldn't use it to train
the model but you should use it to
evaluate the model which means that once
you have trained the model using the
training set you then make some
predictions on the validation set and
simply check what the score on the
validation set is so instead of Now
using that score to once again train the
model or or improve the weights you
don't do that you use just a training
set for training and you use the
validation set simply for checking how
well the model is doing
while you are still experimenting with
the model and picking a good validation
set is an
essential a very essential probably the
most one of the most important parts of
a machine learning project U because you
want your model to generalize well and
you can learn more about it here I've
linked to a Blog about picking good
validation sets and then finally there
is a test set so then there's a third
set and this test set is used to compare
different models or compare different
approaches by different people for
example you have certain data sets um
which are public data sets that are used
by researchers around the world now with
these data sets if if everybody reports
their accuracies or their
performance on a different validation
set maybe somebody picks a first 10% of
data somebody picks the last 10% of data
somebody picks a middle 10% or a random
10% then those results will not be
comparable so that's why typically it's
a a common practice to standardize a
test set for a data set and you will
often see that you will get a training
data and then you will get a test data
so when you have training data you split
it into training and validation but the
test data is what is standardized and
you're not supposed to use it for
training you're not even supposed to use
it for validation you should only use it
at the end to report the model's final
accuracy and for many data sets test
sets are provided separately and then in
a lot of cases for example in k data
science competitions you are not given
the actual targets for the test set so
you are simply given the inputs for the
test set and you have to then make some
predictions for the test set create a
CSV file with your predictions submit it
to kaggle and then kaggle will compare
them with the actual data for the test
set and then give you the result or give
you the score so this is called a hidden
test set and a lot of companies tend to
do this as well as a data scientist when
you're given a project your um the you
will not be given the entire data so
you'll be given maybe 80% of the data
with labels and then you will be given
another 20% of the data with the labels
hidden from you so you will then once
you train all your models you will take
that 20% of data and you will make
predictions give it back to whoever is
given you the project and they will tell
you how well your model is doing in the
real world okay so this is a very
important piece of machine learning and
you will often see when you start out
with machine learning that the models
that you train perform really well in
training you get to like 98 99
100% accuracy but when you put them out
into the real world they get like 30 40%
accuracy and this phenomenon is called
overfitting where your model is
optimizing too much for the training set
so to give you an analogy to think about
the training validation and test set
think
about how School works or how high
school works so now in India we have uh
12 grades and in grade 12 what happens
is you have a textbook and you have
classes so you read the text textbook
and in the textbook for example for a
maths course in the textbook you have
some questions so now you solve the
questions in a textbook and you use that
to improve your understanding of
mathematics and one way to do it is to
actually learn the concepts but the
other way to do it is to Simply memorize
the answers right and your model because
you are simply trying to optimize for
the lowest possible lws your model over
time will start memorizing training
examples just like uh in a lot of school
systems people start memorizing answers
uh to questions so to avoid blind
memorization what people tend to do uh
is schools conduct exams so School
schools conduct a midterm School schools
conduct quizzes so they conduct exams at
various places during the school year
and you can think of that as the
validation set so that is where the
model or you face questions that you
have not already solved and obviously
your performance is a little bit worse
but more importantly you need to learn
the actual Concepts or the underlying
relationships rather than simply
memorizing answers right so that's a
validation set but then you have these
board exams or what you might call the
SATs which are used to compare the
performances of students across the
nation or across the world even so you
can think of that as the test set so
that is like at the end at the very end
of your school year you have to give
this one exam and everybody in the
country will be ranked based on that
exam so that's the training set
validation set and test set training set
is what you Ed to learn validation set
is what you use to improve yourself and
change your approach while you're still
uh building a model and the test set is
to report your final performance okay
and as a general rule of thumb this is
not this is not set in stone but as a
general rule of thumb you can use about
60% of the data for training you can use
about 20% data for validation and 20%
for test uh and this is typically good
enough if you're working with the let's
say tens of thousands of rows or
hundreds of thousands if you have more
data millions of rows then you can
shrink the size of your validation and
test sets and use more for training if
you have less data then you may have to
even keep a larger fraction but it
really depends on problem to
problem and if a separate test set is
already provided to you let's say you
are given a training set and a test set
separately then you can do a training
validation split which could be like a
75 25 or a 70 30
split so typically this pick or this
division of the validation and test set
is done randomly especially when the
data set does not have any inherent
order so if you have just random data
sets or random rows in the data it is
very common practice to just pick random
subset of rows for creating the test set
and the validation set and this can be
done using the train test split utility
from psyit learn so we import from psyit
learn. model selection train test split
and you give train test split the data
that you want to split so in this case
we want to split the raw DF the entire
data set that we have and we want to
extract out first 20% and set that aside
as the test DF so as the test data frame
so I'm just setting test size equals 20%
now which 20% do we want to extract so
we can specify a random number and we
don't have to um if we don't then it
will pick something automatically but we
can specify a ROM number so in this case
I'm just specifying the number 42 and
what this will do is this will
initialize a random number generator and
then using that random number generator
certain rows will be picked so a certain
fraction of 20% fraction of the data
will be put into test DF and the
remaining will be put into what I'm
calling train while DF okay now the
benefit of random state is that it gives
you the guarantee that every time you
pass 42 as the random State the same
fraction the same 20% fraction will get
picked as the test set so so the benefit
here is that each time you rerun The
Notebook your test and validation sets
will not change so we want a random
fraction which is picked randomly once
but we also want it to be fixed across
our runs because otherwise we will not
be able to compare with each run of our
notebook whether we're doing better or
not right so you want to pick a random
fraction but we want to fix it and
that's what random state is for okay so
now we've created a test data frame
which is 20% of data and then we have a
training validation data frame which is
the 80% of the data now out of the 80 I
once again want to do a u 20 60 split
which means 25% of the remaining data
becomes validation data and then 20% uh
80% 75% of the remaining data becomes
the training data so I'm using train
test split once again and this time I'm
setting the test set 2.25 and I can use
a different random state but that I if I
want but it's okay I'm just using 42
again here and that's going to give me a
training data frame and a validation
data frame so first we extracted a test
data frame then we extracted a
validation data frame and finally we
were left with the training data frame
so this is how we have created three
data frames and you can check their
sizes training data frame now contains
84,500 data points validation data frame
contains 28,000 test contains 28,000
okay so this is what you will do for
most data sets you will pick a random
sample as a validation set and a random
sample as a test set if you're given a
test set already this will go away maybe
you'll have a separate CSV file for test
so you'll simply do a 7525 split between
training and
validation okay now one other thing I
want to add here is when you're working
with dates which we are in this case
fortunately or unfortunately so when
you're working with dates there is an
additional consideration to keep in mind
because we want to take this model which
has been trained on historical data and
then we want to use it in the future
okay okay so that means that your model
ideally when it is making prediction on
a certain date it should not have seen
any data that came after that date right
um because you should not train your
model to learn from future data to
predict past data so whenever you're
working with this is called time series
data or whenever you're working with
dates it is often a better idea to
separate training validation and test
sets with time so what you want do is
maybe if we just check out the years in
the data so we have this is what the
distribution of the data looks like we
have these many we have a bunch of
values for 2007 a bunch of them for 2008
9 10 11 12 13 14 and we are presumably
going to use the the model to make
predictions in 2018 or 2019 so here is a
good way to divide the training and
validation and test sets how about we
take the data till 2014 as the training
set so we train the model using data
till 2014 then we use the data from 2015
as the validation set so now the model
will be evaluated on data from the
future data it has not already seen in
the past right uh so we use 2015 as the
validation set and then we use 2016 and
2017 as the test set so our final
accuracy of the model will
be reported by its performance on 2016
and 2017 while the model has been
trained and evaluated on data till 2014
and 2015 the benefit of this is that
because we're going to use the model in
2018 and 2019 so the test sets score is
going to very well reflect how the model
will perform in real life on the other
hand let's say if you pick 2011 as the
test set then it's possible that the
model may use some information from 2010
and 2012 to become a better predictable
better predictor for 2011 than it would
be for 2018 right because it has access
to data from the past as well as the
future so what I want want you to take
away from this is whenever you're
working with dates or with time series
data it's often a good idea to take the
last fraction as the test set and maybe
uh a fraction just before that as the
validation set okay so that's what I'm
going to do I have created this ear
column so I'm going to convert rf. date
to a date time uh series and then I'm
going to get the year out of it and for
the training data frame so I'm I'm going
to ignore what I created earlier all of
these data frames using random splitting
but for the training data frame I'm just
going to use the data before 2015 for
the validation data frame I'm going to
use data just from 2015 and from the
test data frame I'm going to use the
data after 2015 so 2016 and 17 are going
to be the test set validation is going
to be 2015 and training is going to be
Bel before 2015 and this is what the
split looks like like so it's not a
perfect 60202 split uh but we have still
ensured that the test validation uh that
the validation and test set both
contains both contain data for at least
12 months or entire calendar year which
means they see all the seasonality and
they occur in the future after the
training data so which will more
accurately reflect our model's
performance in the real world so the
whole purpose of test training
validation Etc is to create a
model whose performance can be reliably
measured on how it will perform in the
real world right we don't just want to
get a higher accuracy just for the sake
of reporting it we want to create models
that work well in the real world and
that's why we do all these
splits so that's your training set now
the first eight years of data uh the
first seven seven years of data then
validation set the next one year of data
and then the next year and a half of
data is the test set okay if you do not
have dates then pick a random 60 20 20
sample all right and I'm just going to
save my notebook once again and record
Another snapshot now some of what we
have done here may seem a little complex
may seem it's not something that you may
be able to grasp in the first glance but
do work through the notebook do go
through every line of code all of it is
uh explained and you can check out you
can separate out each line into a
separate cell and try and work through
it and see how it works
out
so next best practice or next step in a
machine
learning problem is to identify the
input and Target columns and often this
is something that people tend to mess up
as well just in the hurry to get to the
modeling process so not all columns in a
data set are useful for training a model
in fact in the current data set if we
look at Raw
DF you can see here that we have a date
column and the date column is different
different for each day in fact it only
contains dates from 2008 to 2017 now
presumably we're going to use the model
in 2020 or 20121 and onwards so the date
will never be something like this right
so the model will so there's no point
training the model on these dates or
dates which it has seen in the
past if it is going to be used in the
future right so date is not a useful
input to the
model on the other hand minimum
temperature definitely is because the
model is going to see temperatures in
the same ranges it may see it may not
see 13.4 but it may see 13.5 it may see
13.1 so this is a useful thing to have
maximum temperature is again a useful
thing to have so all of these rows apart
from date uh like location Min temp Max
temp Etc these are definitely useful for
uh prediction so we definitely want to
use these similarly sometimes you will
have ID columns for example in the last
example of insurance or medical charges
prediction there was certain IDs
sometimes you will have names of people
like you you may have names of a
customer or maybe have you may have
emails of customers or you may have like
a customer ID or some unique identifier
which is different for every row so
whenever you have these ID columns you
should completely ignore those because
those are just unique and that is not
useful information to use then there is
obviously also a Target column the
column that we want to predict we want
to take all of this information and we
want to use it to predict the rain
tomorrow column so we want to make sure
that we don't use the rain tomorrow
column as an input uh for sure right you
don't want to use uh whether it rain
tomorrow to predict whether it rain
tomorrow you don't the rain tomorrow is
a Target and that is why and it seems
like an obvious thing but in a lot of
cases you will see that you are training
a model and then you train the model and
you suddenly see 100% accuracy 100%
training accuracy 100% validation 100%
test accuracy and and you debug and
debug or maybe you just think you've won
but ultimately you will figure out that
you are actually using the target as an
input I do this all the time whenever
I'm training models so that's why one
thing you should try and do is very
clearly identify what are the inputs to
your model and what are the outputs and
what are the things you need to ignore
so I'm going to create two lists here
one is a list of input columns so here
I'm saying train DF do columns so from
the training data frame or from the raw
data frame doesn't matter they have the
same set of columns I'm going to pick
from column number one which means I'm
going to ignore the date and I'm going
to pick till the column number n n minus
2 so I'm going to skip the last column
which is the target so that's going to
give me all the columns starting from
location
to rain today
okay and then the target column that I
want to predict is rain tomorrow in this
case there is just one target column and
generally in classification there is
just one target column
but sometimes there might be multiple
Target columns as well so this could be
Target columns in certain
cases and another thing to keep in mind
is certain machine learning algorithms
expect you to always have a list of
Target columns for example linear
regression does expect that I think but
uh certain machine learning algorithms
are work fine with just a single value
so logistic regression in fact expects
you to have a single Target
column and that that's why we just
picking a single Target column here okay
so just be aware of that sometimes you
this may need to be a list sometimes
this may need to be just a string
sometimes it wouldn't matter uh but but
this is the idea we have input columns
and Target columns so these are the
input columns just very explicitly
printing it out it's always a good idea
to eyeball this and make sure okay I'm
not using rain tomorrow as the
Target and uh then we have the target
column as well which is rain tomorrow
now another special case of this is
sometimes you may have columns which are
derived from the target column for
example you may have rain tomorrow
and U rain rainfall tomorrow in um let's
say in millimeters so if you have a
column rain tomorrow and you have a
column rainfall tomorrow then you
probably don't want to use rainfall
tomorrow as an input because you want to
use a model with today's data so you
want to make sure that and rain tomorrow
is going rainfall tomorrow is going to
be a very strong indicator of rain
tomorrow but at the same time it is
derived information from rain tomorrow
and it is not something that you will
have in the real world so be mindful of
that sometimes some of these columns are
derived or very closely related to the
Target and are targets themselves so
make sure to ignore those right if you
want to use today's data you pick just
today's data so that's your input
columns and Target columns now once we
have that it's a good idea to just
create separate data frames so you have
train inputs here I'm simply picking uh
input columns from the training data
frame and I'm also just creating a copy
because now we start modifying this data
we'll start doing scaling and encoding
Etc so I'm just going to create a copy
so that the original data is not
Disturbed and then we have train Target
so here I'm just picking the target
column so here I'm picking columns so
train inputs is going to be a data frame
you can see here train
inputs it's a data frame containing just
the just the input columns and then
train targets picks single uh pick
single column so it's going to be a
panda series you can see that this is a
series and this series has just a bunch
of yeses and
NOS similarly we are creating validation
inputs and validation targets we are
creating test inputs and test targets
and we can see what they look like so
these will either mostly all the inputs
are going to be data frames or sometimes
numi arrays and then the targets could
be series or they could be data frames
and if you're ever in doubt you can
always just check what the type
is so this is a series but the general
rule of thumb is when you're picking
multiple columns or a list of columns
that's when you get a data frame when
you pick a single column you get a
series okay one other thing that will be
useful is to identify which columns are
numerical and which ones are categorical
this will be useful later because we
will need to convert categorical data
into numerical data for training a
logistic regression model or any machine
learning model so if we look here these
seem to be numeric and then this seems
to be categoric I don't know maybe this
is also numeric but then this is
definitely categorical this is
definitely categorical uh this is
definitely numeric so there's a
combination in fact location here is
definitely a categorical column and it
has a grand total of 49 categories and
obviously location is a big factor
because the weather or the climate of
each location is definitely different so
as long as we are predicting just for
these same locations location is an
important factor to look
at and by the way you should also Now
understand that because we you're using
location as an input your model can only
make predictions for locations that it
has already
seen now if you use this for you cannot
use this model for New York because your
model does not know what to do with New
York as an input it has only seen a
location as an input so if you want to
create something generic something that
is Works irrespective of location then
you will have to remove the location
column right so keep that in mind on and
on on a Case by case basis you'll have
to figure out whether to use it or not
for now we'll assume that we are going
to use the model for predicting these
same locations most of the time so we
will retain the location
column so here's a quick trick to come
up with numerical and uh categorical
columns so if you do if you take a data
frame and then call Select D types and
simply give it which type of columns to
include so here we have said include np.
number and then you can get the list of
columns so basically this selects just
those columns of data in the data frame
where they are numeric and do columns
give gives you the name of the numeric
columns and then
because and then we just converting them
to a list so I think we should remove
this as
well and that should give us the numeric
columns so let's see numeric calls so
these are all the numeric calls minimum
temperature maximum temperature rainfall
evaporation Sunshine Etc okay all I've
done is I've selected The Columns which
have a numeric type np. number and I've
taken the list of that columns and I've
converted it into a list and similarly
for categorical we have selected the
list of columns with data type object
and we've converted those to list now I
was able to do this because there are no
string columns in this data set but if
there were string columns then we would
have to do something more interesting or
maybe would we would have to manually
type out categorical columns and you can
by the way you can do that as well
that's completely fine there are just 23
columns so you can manually type out the
names of numeric and categorical columns
okay so that's numeric and categorical
columns uh here's numeric columns main
temp Max temp rainfall
Etc and as soon as you have numeric
columns you can also very quickly check
some statistics by calling do describe
so here we are just selecting the
numeric columns from the training inputs
and then we're calling dot describe just
to explore okay what does the ranges of
these values look like what's the
minimum what's the maximum what's the
standard deviation what's the median so
it seems like minimum temperature can go
up to minus8 and Max maximum temperature
can go up to so the minimum temperature
can go from - 8.5 to 33 and the maximum
temperature goes from -4 to 48 and this
is also a good opportunity for you to
see if there are any values that don't
make any sense at all in which case we
may have to maybe do some uh fix some
incorrect values in some way maybe draw
some more histograms Etc
okay yep but these values look fine to
me so I don't think there's a lot of
data cleaning required here at this
point so that's a numic data and let's
also check the categorical data for the
categorical data it's a good idea to
check how many unique categories there
are and this will also let you verify if
all these are actually categorical for
example location there are 49 values
that may seem like a lot but we are
dealing with 140,000 um rows of data
here so 50 is still I think I would
still call it categorical I would not
call it a string but if I had maybe a
5,000 or 10,000 different values then
maybe that's better suited as a string
column and not a c orical column then we
have wind direction there have 16 values
for those well that's just simple
directions and wind direction at 9:00
a.m. 3 p.m. and finally we have the rain
today column which is also a categorical
column yes and no and rain today I'm
sure is going to be very helpful in
predicting whether it's going to rain
the next day or not okay so that's just
identifying the input columns Target
columns and within the input columns the
numeric columns and categorical columns
and the reason we've done this is
because we'll now start doing some
processing with this data now machine
learning models cannot work with missing
data whenever you have a Nan and you try
to train a machine learning model it's
probably going to
crash so you need to fill these missing
values with some valid values and the
process of filling missing values is
called
imputation now there are several
techniques for imputation but we will
use the most basic technique here and
I'll let you check out some of the other
techniques and we will try try out some
other techniques over time but the M
most basic technique is to replace
missing values with the average value in
the
column and you can do this using the
simple inputter class from SK learn.
imput so what we want to do is we want
to replace this Nan with the average
value in this column and I think the
average in this column if we have just
three rows is 17 + 5 22x 2 11 so we have
11 here and the average in this column
is six so we have six here the average
in this column is just seven so we'll
just put seven here so this is just a
guess yes it's obviously may not be
correct but you have a choice here you
can either throw away those rows but if
you have a lot of Nan values in a
certain column and you throw away those
rows you may lose a lot of data so you
just take a guess there and you think
that okay maybe I replace it with the
average sometimes you may choose to
replace it with not not the average but
maybe a fixed value and it can do that
as well simper imputer has several
strategies sometimes you may replace it
by the mean if you by the median if you
think that there are outliers that may
affect the average for example if you
have a income column it's always a good
idea to replace it with with the median
rather than the mean because there will
be outliers that may affect the
average okay so many different
strategies we are going to use a simple
strategy of filling in Nan values with
the average value in that
column so how do we do it we import
simple imputer and then we create the
simple imputer object with some
parameters in this case which just a
strategy but you can check what other
parameters it supports simply by typing
simple
imputer and a question mark before that
so here you can see that this is the all
the help available for simple imputer
you will also see some
examples missing value you can also
specify what the missing value looks
like in this case it's np. Nan that's
automatic you can specify what strategy
you want to use and so on okay so we
create the imputer fine now we've
created ated an imputer object so first
before we perform any imputation let us
just check how many missing values we
have in each numeric column so that we
can verify later that those were filled
so if we just do on the raw DF which is
the entire data check get the numeric
columns and check is any which is
replace each value in the data frame
with a true or false whether or not it
is null and then take the sum so all of
this business is just to count the
number of missing values in each column
you can see that U Min Min temp Max temp
have a low number of missing values
evaporation sunshine have a fairly High
number evaporation it seems like almost
uh half of the data is missing on the
other hand we have for some of these
other things there is a reasonable
fraction of missing values okay and here
this is the entire data set but we could
also check these individually for the
training validation and test sets for
example here is the check for just train
inputs checking missing values just for
the train data and you will see a
similar pattern or similar fraction in
the validation and test set as well okay
so with that out of the way the first
step in imputation is to fit the imputer
to the data which means that we give it
the data that we want to fill and it's
going to look through the columns it's
going to look through all the columns so
it's going to look through the Min Min
temp Max temp rainfall column in the
data frame the data frame raw DF numeric
calls which
is just just the just the numeric
columns chosen from the raw data frame
so this and it's going to go through
each column and for each column it is
going to figure out the statistic that
you have asked it to figure out the
imputing statistic in this case we're
using the mean or the average so it's
going to compute the mean for Min temp
mean for Max temp mean for rainfall mean
for evaporation and so on okay so let's
call imput do fit so it's not yet
changed any of the data we've not filled
any anything in we've simply calculated
the statis statistics so if you now
check imputer do statistics
uncore so for the first row or the for
the First Column that we gave it and
remember these columns are simply the
numeric columns that we have picked so
for the Min temp column it has figured
out that the average is 12 for the max
temp column the average is 23 for the
rainfall the average is 2.5 evaporation
average is 5.4
Etc we have asked it to compute averages
it has computed averages now once these
averages have been computed Ed then they
need to be fit filled in into the test
set into the validation set and into the
training set so here's how we do it we
say imputer do
transform let's take it step by step so
let's look at train inputs. numeric
calls okay so this is just from my
training data which is the 60% data just
the numeric columns I've picked out in a
data frame and obviously there are a lot
of nans here then we call imputer the
imputer already knows the averages for
all of these columns Min temp Max temp
rainfall Etc and we call imputer do
transform and it's going to fill all the
nans with
averages and now that becomes a nipai
array so you can't really see here but
you but if you look at this numai array
you will see that it now contain it does
not contain any nans so it has looked at
all the nans and it has replaced those
nans with those average values now it's
not showing you a data frame because
imputer just just outputs an NP array
but what we can do is we can take this
output this nump array and we can put it
back into the data frame as the new
values for the numeric columns right so
we are overwriting the numeric columns
now in the original train inputs data
frame with the imputed data which means
with the Nance replaced with the
averages okay and we're doing that for
validation data we are transforming the
valid input numeric calls and overing
overwriting that into valent put numeric
calls and so on okay so all of this
business imputed or transform and then
storing the data back all of this is
simply to get to the point where if I
now check train inputs numeric calls you
will see that now there are no Nan
values now those Nan values have been
replaced with the average value which I
I guess in this case you can probably
tell 5.47 is probably the average value
for evaporation 7.6 is probably the
average value for Sunshine but only the
nans have been replaced not all the
values
okay
and now you can check for each of the
training validation and test sets that
there are no missing values at
all okay now that's the average
imputation technique but you can try
other imputation techniques like median
or sometimes you can also use other
columns to impute data so there are
several techniques just check them out
there's an entire module in psychic
learn that does this okay now we've
dealt with missing values another good
practice is to scale features to a small
range of values right now if you check
the numeric features or the numeric
Columns of data you will see that they
have a fairly wide range for example
mint temperature goes from - 8 to 33 on
the other hand wind speed goes
from um 6 to 135 I think this is min and
this is
Max let's
see yeah pressure at 3 P.M okay this
seems to go all the way up to 1039 and
the minimum seems to be
977 now what what's what happens is when
you put all these numbers into a machine
learning algorithm and you apply weights
to them and then you compute a loss
function ultimately the loss is a single
number right the cross entropy or root
means Square loss Etc ET the loss is a
single number and we say that higher the
loss worse the model but what happens is
if a certain feature has a very high
range of values maybe like rainfall
takes values that are in the thousands
but minimum and maximum temperature take
values that are in less than 10 and
maybe there are certain there's a
certain column where the values are
0.0 something which are basically in the
decimals so what happens is that the
values which have a very high magnitude
tend to dominate the loss because it's
ultimately all all these numbers getting
multiplied and added together so the
values that have a high magnitude the
features that have a high range tend to
dominate the loss but features that have
a lower absolute values and features
that have lower range of values
tend to not show up in the loss as much
so what happens is that if what
dominates the loss also dominates the
optimization process so that means the
values which have these high numbers are
going to their weights are going to
change a lot but the values which have
low numbers or smaller ranges their
value their weights are not going to
change that much during optimization so
just to give everybody a Level Playing
Field just because we measure rainfall
in a certain unit where it gets large
values but we measure temperature in a
certain uh unit where it gets lower
value so just to level the playing field
for all the features what we like to do
is we should scale all the features into
a same range of values so we're going to
scale the features we're going to scale
all the numeric features into the range
of values 0 to 1 and sometimes this is
also minus1 to 1 either one is fine it
depends on the circumstances but uh 0 to
1 is fine for classification problems
and and the way you do this is using a
min max scaler so from sklearn
preprocessing this is again another
module and we are in fact what we're
doing right now is called pre-processing
so from sklearn preprocessing import
minmax scaler and then you create a
minmax scaler and then you can give it
some options like you can give
it you can check here it it supports
like a feature range it supports whether
it should create a copy of the data etc
etc but the objective of the minmax
scaler is to identify for each column
what is the minimum and what is the
maximum and then scale the values in the
column so that they all lie in the range
0 to 1 so it's a two-step process just
like the imputer first we fit the scalar
to the data so we compute the range of
values for each numeric column so we say
scaler do fit raw DF numeric column so
what's happening here is it's going to
look at each column from raw DF the
entire data frame main temperature max
temperature rainfall evaporation Etc
it's going to look at each column and
it's going to find the minimum and
maximum of each column when we run
scaler do fit so now we have if you
check the minimum we can see that the
data minimum in you can see that for
these columns for the numeric columns
which
are main temp Max temp rainfall Etc the
minimum values are- 8.5 - 4.8 0 0 Etc
and then for the maximum values the
maximum values are 33 48 375 371 145 Etc
so now it knows the minimum and the
maximum and this this is stored in data
Main and data
Max now when we call scalar do transform
what it's going to do is it's going to
take this
column and instead of these being in the
range minimum to maximum it is going to
scale them in the range 0 to one so the
minimum value will become zero the
maximum value will become one and
everything else will be scaled
proportionately so let's do that it's a
pretty simple transformation ultimately
so let's now let's now check train
inputs I think we can just check this
here we can just call describe and you
can check for each of the columns now
for each of the numeric columns you will
see that the minimum becomes zero or
very close to zero you can see all of
these are very close to zero and the
maximum becomes one or very close to one
so in this case you can see that the
maximum is. 56
um 98 yeah it it either becomes one or
very close to one in some cases it may
not actually be one because of how
internally the imputer works but you can
also verify this by looking at the
actual data instead of just the
statistics that now all of these values
are nice and uh small all of these
values are between 0 to 1 okay all the
numerical columns for
sure okay so now we have all our numeric
data between the range 0 to one so none
of them will disproportionately affect
the loss and another thing is also that
optimization algorithms often use
calculus and calculus involves
derivatives and powers of functions and
polinomial so all of these optimization
algorithms also work really well when
all the numbers are small in the 0 to
one range and there are also issues with
numerical methods where uh they cross
floating
Point computation ranges so if numbers
get too large then decimal information
can be lost and there's a lot of bunch
of issues with large numbers especially
when you're working with these numerical
optimization methods so it's always a
good idea to get your numbers into a
small
range
okay this one is about categorical data
now we our numerical data is in good
shape missing values have been filled
and the data is in a good 0 to one range
because machine learning models can only
be trained with numeric data we also
need to convert categorical data to
numbers so a common technique is to use
the one hot encoding for categorical
column colums so you take a categorical
column like a column which has maybe
category a category B category C and
what you do is you get rid of this
column and you instead create a column
for each category so category a becomes
a column cat B becomes a column cat C
becomes a column and whichever row had
the value category uh a in this
categorical column we put a one there in
the c a column and we put zeros in all
the other column so that's why this is
called a one hot Vector so instead of
this category string or this category U
class we replace it with a vector which
contains a one for that particular
columns for that particular categories
column and Zer everywhere else similarly
we have category B this is also one hot
Vector now this becomes 0 1 0 and
category C becomes 01 now here there are
only three categories but you can have
any number of categories for example if
we check the number of unique categories
for location we have 49 categories for
wind gust direction we have 16 wind
direction 9 A.M we have 16 and for rain
today we have two categories so now if
we want to perform one hot encoding what
we are actually trying to say is that if
I just look at uh the location
data rf. location.
unique what we're actually trying to say
is that we want to create one column in
the data for albur B Craig Cobar Etc and
put ones and zeros in these columns so
we're going to introduce 49 columns for
a location now that may seem like a lot
but it's okay it's not a problem um
because most of these are just going to
be 01 and then most of the time they're
going to be zeros in fact so it's not
something to worry about too much and
our data frame can handle
it so how do we create these uh one hot
encoded columns the way to do that is
using a one hot encoder again from
sklearn preprocessing import one hot
encoder and and I hope I hope you're
starting to get the drill now for all of
these pre-processing steps you create
that object so we creating a one hot
encoder and we are giving it a bunch of
options we telling it that we want to
don't want to create a sparse Matrix we
want to actually create a proper numpy
array so sparse is just a optimization
technique and we are saying that if you
come across a category that is that you
haven't seen before just ignore it okay
then there are several other options
that it supports so we create the
encoder object then the encoder needs to
First understand the data so we call
encoder do fit and at this point it's
not creating any one hot encodings it's
simply identifying the categories in the
data so
we okay so I think this needs to be
fixed somehow I'm just going to check
where to fix
this okay so we call encoder do fit on
Raw DF and maybe there's a way to to
ignore Nan values let's see one hot
encoder pyit
learn ignore
Nan all right I'm going to just do a
quick fix here uh I think this is
something to do with the with the actual
version of psychic learn involved here
but I'm just going to
do raw
DF do categorical and pick the
categorical
calls and do fill any and I'm going to
just fill it with the word
unknown okay yeah and I'm just going to
call it raw
df2 yeah so these are some issues that
you will run into from time to time for
example this worked with the version of
psyit learn I had on my computer but did
not run on collab and it seems to be the
issue seems to be with Nan voles Nan
values so I'm just going to put in raw
df2 here which just contains which has
replaced Nan values with the word
unknown and that will just be treated as
another category all right so now we
have called one hot encoder fit on the
raw data frame so it has looked at all
the columns that we gave it and for each
of the columns it has identified the
categories that those columns contain so
if you check categorical
calls The Columns that we gave the
column of data that we gave to the
encoder so for location it has
identified these categories and then
similarly for wind gust Direction it has
identified these categories and then for
rain today it has identified these
categories no and yes so for each of the
columns uh for each of the columns
in the data
frame so columns location wind gust wind
direction 300 p.m and rain today it has
identified what the list of categories
are
then there is one additional step
involved here we can generate column
names for each individual category using
this get feature names function again
not something you need to remember
something that you you you need you can
look up so what we do is now we create a
list of category names so now now we've
instead of having just location we have
location Adelaide location Albany
location albur etc etc and similarly
going forward uh for each category we
have a category we have a column name
that we've generated like rain today no
rain today yes and we just suffix it
with the original columns name to avoid
any confusion or avoid duplicates in
column names okay so like wind direction
3 p.m. has wsw and similarly wind
direction 12 p.m. will also have
wsw or 9:00 a.m. will also have
wsw okay so now we have a list of column
names for and we just calling them
encoded calls uh and we have a list of
column names for these new one hot
columns that will be created finally to
actually create those one hot columns we
call encoder do transform and then we
give it the categorical Columns of data
so we are giving train inputs
categorical columns and that is going to
give us numpy arrays and we want to put
those numpy arrays into the pandas data
frame the train inputs data frame and
with these column names okay so I'll
just show you the output here
and okay I think I will need to fix this
as well so I'm just going to quickly
fix train inputs categorical columns do
fillna yeah I think we can just add
this yeah so we can just add this here
and this should fix it sorry about that
yeah all right so what's going to happen
here is it is going to transform all
those categorical columns and it is
going to convert them into these nump
arrays of one hot encoded vectors and
then it is going to add those as new
columns into the data frame so let's
view the test inputs for example what
that looks like and you will now see
that we have location Min temp Max temp
all of these but if you start scrolling
further you'll start to see all these
new categories all these new columns
location ad location Albany location
albur so like 49 location columns and
then you will see
these okay wind gust so there are eight
wind gust columns and there are eight
wind direction columns and there are two
rain today columns okay so we have added
all these one hot columns and you can
see that there are zeros in most of
these and ones every now and then every
here and there you will see a one like
you see uh what's this location albur so
you should see a one at albur yeah you
see location albur is set to
one okay so now we have done some
categorical data encoding as
well again it's a bunch of code But
ultimately it's something that you can
look up quite easily the more important
thing is to just grasp the concept that
we are doing this
encoding now once you've done all of
this pre-processing and before your
model is before you're ready to train
the model one thing that you should do
is you should save these intermediate
outputs to disk because we spent what a
couple of hours just creating all of
this data and if you're working with
really large data sets it may take even
longer because each step will take some
time to run a few seconds to maybe a few
minutes maybe even up to an hour for
some of these steps so now we have these
train inputs train targets while inputs
Val targets test inputs test targets for
the training and validation and test set
you can save these and you can save
these to CSV but there are more
efficient formats a very efficient
format that Panda's data frame support
is called the paret format so you can
save these to the up to the parket
format and for that you need the pi Aro
Library installed so that's why we have
this pip install here so I'm just going
to save train inputs to train inputs.
paret while inputs I'm going to save to
while inputs. paret and test inputs I'm
going to save to test inputs. parket
and similarly I'm also going to save
targets now this's just one additional
step here we need to convert them into
Data frames to actually save them
properly so I'm just going to save those
targets as well and now the benefit is
the next time you restart this notebook
or maybe start a new notebook maybe you
want to do pre-processing in one
notebook and then you want to do model
training in another notebook you don't
need to repeat all these pre-processing
steps you can simply read these files so
I'm just reading in train inputs while
inputs test inputs train targets well
targets test targets and that can give
me the same information so now what what
we've just done is we have taken this
these the training validation and test
sets after all the pre-processing and
saved them to the disk so that if you
shut down the jupyter notebook it will
still be there of course in cab the dis
also goes away so this is not completely
true so what you'll want to do is maybe
download all these sparket files or
maybe save them to their Google drive or
something but at the very least you want
to back up these files if you're working
on collab and then you can upload them
into a new collab notebook when you're
working on a new um when you're working
on the next project or when you want to
use this data and then you can simply
load it up on your computer you don't
need to do all that business it is
always saved on your file system so you
can write it and read these anytime okay
so that's just a quick tip that whenever
you have done a lot of pre-processing
just save the outputs after the
pre-processing and finally after all of
that we are finally ready to train the
logistic regression model Okay this may
seem like we've done a lot of work but
actually it's just been three or four
steps which is identifying the uh drop
uh identifying the inputs and the
targets and identifying numeric and
categorical columns converting filling
missing values in numerical columns
filling um um imputing yeah that was
through imputation then scaling numeric
columns to the 0 to one range then we
also replace the categorical columns
with one hot
vectors so these are just four or five
pre-processing steps that we've
performed and now we have our data in
the form where most of it is numeric
data like if you have if I check train
inputs yeah so we have we still have
these categorical columns which we'll
probably get rid of while actually
training the model but we have numeric
data for the numeric columns and then
the categorical columns have also be
converted into numeric data so now we're
ready to train the model and logistic
regression as I've already mentioned is
a common technique for solving binary
classification problems we take a linear
combination or a weighted Su of the
input features that's why we need them
all to be numeric and that's why we also
need them all to be in similar ranges so
that they don't mess up uh one feature
does not mess up the loss then we take
that weighted combination and we apply
the sigmoid function which ultimately
gives us a number between 0 to 1 for
each input so for each set of inputs for
for each specific row of data we get a
number as Z between 0 and one as the
output of the model the number
represents the probability of the input
being classified as yes so that's how we
interpret the number from the model then
we use the cross entropy laws to
evaluate how good the probability is
with respect to the results now
obviously intuitively what we want is if
the target is yes or one then we want
the probability to be high very close to
one if the target is no or zero then we
want the probability to be no and that's
what this formula captures this is
called cross entropy uh we won't get
into it but the idea is it penalizes bad
predictions okay
and then we train it using the normal
machine learning training process so
here's how we train a logistic
regression model the actual model
training part is so simple that you
simply import logistic regression from
sklearn linear model and then you train
logist IC regression now here if I hover
over it here you should be able to see
that there are a lot of different
arguments that we can pass the kind of
penalty there's something called a dual
something called a c something called a
tolerance fit intercept etc etc uh you
can even specify random State you can
provide weights for the different
classes uh you can specify the number of
iterations so these are all parameters
that you can change and remember I was
talking about the validation set so each
time you try a different kind of model
with a different set of parameters you
can use the valid set to judge whether
those parameters said led to a good
result or not okay now in my case I have
picked this solver called lib linear
because and you can check what kind of
solvers it supports you can just see
the you can see the options here yeah so
there is Newton CG there is lib linear
there is Sag SAA you can try out
different ones um the reason I picked
lib linear was because lb fgs did not
work for me it um sometimes they're
unable to solve the problem because
these are numerical methods sometimes
they just fail to solve the problem so
you try a different solver so I just
tried the lib linear solver and that
took just like half a second you can see
in total it took just about half a
second to perform this entire fit uh
well actually it is we have not yet
created the model so I'll take that back
so now now we've just created this model
we've just instantiated this model with
the lib linear solver with some other
options now to train the model we can
train the model using model.fit Okay so
let's run model.fit and this is going to
take a few seconds maybe okay it took
what 1.4 seconds on my computer it took
less than that and what did it just do
well it uses this exact machine learning
workflow uh and I hope you're starting
to get bored with this at uh with at
this point because that's what we want
you want to get this machine learning
workflow in your head internalized so we
initialize the model with some random
parameters so some random weights and
biases we pick random values for these
W's and B's for each of the
features that we have then we pass the
inputs the training data into the model
and we get some predictions we take the
predictions and then we take the outputs
from the model and then we run them
through a lost
function and then we use an optimization
technique to slightly reduce the loss
and improve the weights of the
model and in this case we're using the
lib linear optimization technique then
we repeat the steps 1 to 4 till the
predictions from the model are good
enough so if you see here if I see
logistic
regression you will see that there is
this Max iter this is the maximum number
of iterations that we want the model to
take so here what we telling the model
is that we want to repeat this process
of creating predictions comparing them
with the targets running some
optimization 100 times at most or we
want to stop at a point where the
tolerance or where the loss gets lower
than a particular value of 01 right so
all of these things you can configure if
you want the model to go on for longer
increase Max iterations and uh reduce
the value of Tolerance make the
tolerance lower and that way it will go
on for longer it will take more time but
maybe it will learn better so all of
those things are things you can
customize in the model okay but that's
it the model has now been fitted so now
for each of the individual
for each of the individual columns in
the data or for each of the numeric
columns that we have given it it is
going to now have a particular weight
and I just want to tell you one other
thing that I've done here I have not
given it the entire training
inputs
because train inputs contains some
categorical data as well remember we
have not removed the location column
although we have added those one hot
vectors so if I just put in train
inputs you can see that although we've
added one hot vectors at the end we have
not removed these categorical columns so
I've done this small trick here because
I know the names of the numeric columns
and I know the names of the encoded
columns so I've just picked the encoded
and numeric columns and given that as
the input to the model and then the in
terms of the targets we've simply given
the training targets which are simply
numbers uh actually training targets
are yeah training targets are not
numbers training targets are
yeah training targets are these yes and
no values and that's fine so psyit learn
specifically logistic regression can
work with numeric training targets it
cannot work with numeric categorical
data as inputs but it can work with
training targets what it'll do is the
first class that it encounters it is
it'll it'll automatically convert that
to one or to zero and the second class
that encounters it will convert to one
and so on okay so targets can be
category orical but inputs cannot be
categorical and this differs from model
to model library to library Etc in any
case we have now fit the model using the
training data just using the training
data yep and now all these weights have
been set so if we check the numeric plus
encoded columns and we have all of these
columns we can see what weight has been
assigned to each column in that formula
by checking the CF argument here or the
CF property so minimum temperature has
been assigned a weight of 89 so it seems
like minimum temperature has a weight of
089 and maximum temperature has a weight
ofus 2.8 so it seems like maximum
temperature has a negative impact on
whether it will rain tomorrow and that
makes sense if your maximum temperature
gets too high uh then it's unlikely to
rain tomorrow then rainfall has a high
positive coefficient uh and that again
makes sense that
yes you should give a high weightage on
what the amount of rainfall today is to
figure out if it will rain tomorrow
evaporation again has a positive
coefficient sunshine has a negative
coefficient so you can see that these
models are not just black boxes you can
actually interpret them what this model
has learned is that rainfall is a good
predictor and a strong indicator of
whether it will rain tomorrow the amount
of rainfall today on the other hand the
amount of sunshine today is a strong
predictor but in the opposite direction
uh if you have a high sunshine today
maybe it's not going to rain tomorrow
again wind speed if your wind speed is
very high then that seems to be a very
strong predictor if you have high if you
have really fast winds today then it's
probably going to rain tomorrow and then
let's keep going let's check
humidity so humidity it seems like
humidity is also predictor specifically
humidity at about 5:00 p.m. is a good
predictor and if you want to see these
sort of side by by side you can create a
data frame you can do PD do data frame
and let's just
create colum or let's call this
feature and here let's just give this
numeric columns plus encoded
columns and here let's put
weight and let's just put the list of
Weights here okay and we'll see it as a
nice table maybe
the let me just check this
okay yeah I think this I need need to
just pick zero here and this should be
fine yeah all right we finally have it
just sometimes you can see that this
coefficient list is actually a
two-dimensional array not a
onedimensional array that led to a
problem in any case you can now see the
different features and the weights for
each each
feature rainfall temperature evaporation
Sunshine Etc I think we can also
increase the number of columns that we
want to show here so if you want to show
all the 118 columns we can show that
information here too but roughly this is
how you interpret the model a higher the
weight for a particular feature the more
important it is for the prediction the
lower the weight the less important it
is the sign indicates whether it is a
positively correlated feature or
negatively correlated feature so your
logistic regression model is capturing
all of this information in the form of
weights and then of course there is that
last intercept or bias term that is
added at the end and there is simply a
correction for all values being zero so
that's sort of the zero correction
you may try more experiments and that is
something that may take more time you
may try different imputation techniques
you may try different kind of encodings
there are other encodings as
well does Max iter are the realizations
of the simulations well so max iter is
you can see here what we do is we
initialize a model put some inputs get
predictions We compare the predictions
with the targets using the loss function
we optimize the model using an optim
imization technique so one optimization
does not like one pass of optimization
does not fix the entire model all for
forever it simply makes a small changes
to the weights that will slightly reduce
the loss because all of these are
approximation methods so you need to
repeat this optimization many many times
to get a fairly optimal model so that is
what Max iteration indicates how many
times you repeat this
process do you visualize the feature
weights with bar H yes you could do that
that's a good idea I haven't done that
but yeah I could do that so let's say we
do let's call this weight
DF
and let's
do SNS do
barplot data equals weight
DF on the x-axis we can have the
weight and on the Y AIS we can have the
feature yeah and hopefully that should
give us a good okay I think we have a
lot of features so I should probably
set yeah something like this
should make it easy to
visualize yep so you can see the
different uh features here and their
weights visualized here so you can
clearly see that pressure at 3 p.m. is a
very important factor when gust speed is
a very important factor uh a low
pressure is seems to be a higher
indicator and humidity at 3 p.m. is a
very strong Factor you could probably
even sort these by the importance so
yeah that was a great suggestion
actually I should have added this uh
before so you can probably sort these by
importance and just pick the top 10
features so let's do something like this
sort
values by the feature uh weight and ass
sending equals false and just pick
the top 10 out of these and then we
won't need
this yeah so wind gust speed humidity at
3 p.m. pressure at 9:00 a.m. rainfall
temperature at 3 p.m. Cloud at 3: p.m.
minimum temperature this is the order in
which things are important seems like
wind is the most important factor in
predicting whether it will rain tomorrow
okay so moving
ahead next we want to make some
predictions and evaluate the model
now we've trained a model but we
ultimately want to use the model and
before we use the model we want to
evaluate it on the training set test set
and validation set so let's evaluate the
model uh because we want to use just
these numeric and encoded columns I've
created these three variables xtrain X
Val and X test which will contain just
the numeric data that we can pass
directly into the model so now I'm going
to call first make a prediction on the
training set get a bunch of predictions
and the way to do that is called model.
predict so when you call model. predict
you give it a set of inputs you don't
give it targets you simply give it some
inputs and it is going to give you a
list of predictions for those
inputs so so this is what our model has
predicted no no no no yes no no Etc and
you can check that there are a few yeses
here if I like if I do a list you will
see that there are actually some yeses
it's just that
because only about 20% of of the data
has rainfall so even your models
predictions only about 20% of them are
going to be
yes okay that's a long
list should probably
have limited this in some way anyway so
this is the predictions that our model
has
created this is the predictions that our
model has created no no yes yes Etc and
these are the actual targets so this is
what we expect to see from our model so
we have some predictions we have some
targets for each day the model is
predicted yes or no and we have the
actual Target yes or no the simplest way
to understand how well it is done is to
Simply look at the
accuracy and to look at the accuracy
accuracy simply means we compare
where we compute the percentage of
matching values in train PRS and train
targets you see train PRS here so train
PRS has a bunch of Nos and yeses train
targets has a bunch of Nos and yeses if
we compare we count these okay this is a
match one match two match three match
four match five match mismatch mismatch
so we count the number of matches divide
that by the total number of uh days
which is about
14455 to
so or less
so we can do that directly using this
accuracy score function so from SK
learn. Matrix we import accuracy score
we call accuracy score it's going to do
a one by one match between train targets
and train predictions it's going to
count the matches divide by the total
number of values and that gives us an
accuracy of
85.1% on the training set okay now apart
from giving you predictions the model
can also give you
probabilities If instead of calling
model. predict uh and this is only for
logistic regression if you call model.
predict prober which is predictor pra
and give it an input it is then going to
give you probabilities you can see that
now we get two values for each input
this is the probability of the class
no and you can check the classes using
model do classes so this is the
probability of the class no and this is
the probability of the class yes so this
is the no class and this is the yes
class and these probabilities add up to
one you will see for each model right so
it's 94% confident about a no in this
case it is 94% confident about a no in
this case it is 87% confident about a no
and so on
okay so you your model is giving you a
lot of information not only is it giving
a prediction it is also giving you a
probability of how confident it is about
the prediction so maybe you can also say
that there is a 94% chance that it will
not rain tomorrow and there is an 87%
chance that it will rain tomorrow and so
on okay so that's predicting using the
model model that is predicting
probabilities using the model and
finally getting accuracy score getting a
score accuracy score using the model now
the accuracy score is a good measure to
just get an overall idea of how well the
model did
but what you can also do is you can also
break down this into what's called a
confusion Matrix so you can create this
kind of a table where you have these
actual values right so you have there
are possibilities where uh there was no
rain the value in the actual Target was
no but your model predicted yes so if
the actual value was no and the model
predicted yes we call that a true uh
then on the model predicted no so if the
actual value was no and the model
predicted no we call that a true
negative which means it was able to
identify a negative correctly that it
will not rain correctly and similarly if
the actual value is yes and your model
predicted yes we call that a true
positive which means that it is going to
rain tomorrow and your model did did
predict that it is going to rain
tomorrow so we call that a true positive
so these are both cases in which your
model has succeeded these are both the
success scenarios then there are two
types of scenarios error scenarios and
they are called the type one error and
type two error or false positive and
false negative once we have false
positive so false positive is when it is
not going to rain tomorrow or the actual
value is no but your model has
predicted yes so model has predicted
that yes it is going to rain tomorrow
and then similarly here we have a false
negative when the where the actual value
is yes it is going to rain tomorrow but
your model has predicted no now
depending on the business case or what
you want to use the model for you may
want to very closely look at false
positives or false negatives for example
if you want to use this model to predict
whether a a baseball game should be
hosted tomorrow in the open then false
false negatives are a big problem you
may want to avoid false negatives where
it is going to rain tomorrow but your
model predicts that it is not going to
rain so if you have a high number of
false negatives that means you are in
for a surprise where you get 50,000
people and people are playing baseball
and starts to
rain that's why maybe you want to
optimize you want to reduce the false
negatives and you're not just interested
in the
accuracy on the other hand let's say
it's a different kind of model which is
predicting whether you may have breast
cancer then at that point you may want
to uh take a close look at false
positives before let's say recommending
I don't know chemotherapy to somebody
you want to make sure that your model
you want to make sure that it is not a
false positive and for that while
training the model you want to make sure
that the number of false positives is
low so in general depending on the kind
of problem you may want to optimize
either for false positives or for false
negatives and how to do that is
something that we will discuss in future
lessons but just keep this in mind that
this is called the confusion Matrix and
again SK learn gives you a single line
of code to create a confusion Matrix
like you just give it some targets and
some predictions and it is going to give
you confusion Matrix and it's also going
to convert them into percentages so here
what it tells you is among the actual
yeses which means the among the actual
NOS which means all the days where
rainfall was actually supposed to be no
it predicted no in 94% of the cases and
it it predicted
yes in 5% of the cases and then here it
tells you that among the cases where it
was actually going to rain it predicted
no it predicted that it won't rain in
47% of cases so that means your model is
actually pretty bad it has a lot of
false negatives and you should probably
not use it for deciding whether you
should hold a baseball uh game in the
open tomorrow um and it was 52% of the
time when it was going to rain it has
predicted right so just by looking at
this now 85% accuracy doesn't seem all
that good because it seems like if it is
going to rain tomorrow and really that's
what we all concerned about whether you
should carry your umbrella or not your
model's performance seems to be 50/50
more or less right it's a bit more
confident than a random guess it's about
0.52 um but it's not that great right so
if the model says that it's not going to
rain
tomorrow um I'm probably not that sure
if I can uh sorry if the model says that
yeah the model said that it's not going
to rain tomorrow I don't know because if
it is going to rain tomorrow there is
still a 47% chance that the model says
that it it's not going to rain tomorrow
right so look at these numbers spend
some time looking at this Matrix and you
can what you can do is you can convert
this Matrix into a nice heat
map this confusion Matrix can be
converted into a nice heat map and you
can then you can start to interpret this
heat map Dark values means especially in
these negative regions means that's good
and uh like like bright values here
indicate that this is probably a bad
area for the model right so yeah that's
a confusion Matrix and what we've done
is we've simply created this predict and
plot function which can uh take some
inputs and take some targets and it will
predict generate the predictions for
those targets using the model it will
compute the accuracy it will print the
accuracy it will create a confusion
Matrix and it will plot the confusion
Matrix okay so this is how you an ize
the results of a model so in this case
it has about 85% accuracy on the
training set let's validate this let's
check it on the validation set so now we
are running it with now we calling this
predict and plot function that we
created with the validation data and the
validation targets and on the validation
targets as well we got we get an
accuracy of
85.4% so that's good even on data that
the model has not seen before it is
about 85% accurate that's
good uh let's check the test set
now the test set remember is data from
the last two years or the last 1 and a
half year and on the test set you can
see that the the accuracy slightly low
it's about
84.2% all right so now you can start to
see that how the training and validation
and test sets are useful if the test set
accuracy was 30% that means the model is
very badly overfitted to the training
data but since it is quite close it's
about 84% and training is 85% you can
accurately just go back and report to
your boss or whoever um gave you the
project that hey my model is about 84%
accurate although it does have a lot of
false negatives so please don't use it
to decide if you should uh do something
in the open
tomorrow
okay
now one thing you might wonder is how
good is 84% accuracy and while this
depends on the nature of the problem and
on the business requirements a good way
to verify whether a model has actually
learn something useful is to compare its
result to a random or a dump model right
so for example let's create two models
we'll create a model called random guess
which takes some inputs like the
training inputs or validation inputs and
it completely ignores the inputs and it
randomly picks yes or no okay so that's
my random guest
model and then I'm going to create
another model called all no and this is
a model that just says that it's not
going to rain it it always says uh that
it's not going to rain
okay so now if I use random guess for
example on the validation set so if I
call random guess on X well which is the
data from the validation set you see
that it it half of them are Nos and half
of them are yeses and on the other hand
if I use all
no on the X you see that this always
return returns no okay so these are also
models these may not be very intelligent
models these may not have looked into
the the data but these are models and
one thing that you should always try and
do is take your brilliant machine
learning model that you've created after
all this pre-processing etc etc and
compare it to a baseline model like this
something like a random guesser all know
so let's do that let's compute the
accuracy for the test data or the test
set using the random guess model so we
give it the X test that gives us the
predictions for the random guess from
the random guess model and compare the
with targets ah so a random guess gives
us about a 50% accuracy and that makes
sense because you have a certain you
have two outcomes and if you just guess
randomly 50% you would
your like any given input you have a 50%
chance of getting it right roughly so to
speak but if you are more intelligent
and if you were to always get always say
no then what would you get then your
model would have a 77% accuracy and this
is because in the data set remember
there's a imbalance so on 77% of days
there was no rain and only on 23% of
days there was rain so just by
predicting that there was no rain your
model achieves an accuracy of
77% now thankfully the model that we
have created has an accuracy of 85 or
84% which is definitely better than 77%
but this is not always the case and you
will often find that once you train a
model and do all of this analysis and
create all these features and
normalization etc etc and after all that
you get a model that's worse than a dumb
model like this like it there there are
definitely ways in which we could have
created a logistic regression model that
was maybe 65% accurate so that means
that your model is worse than simply
predicting no always right so always
analyze your models against these dumb
or very simplistic baselines and make
sure that it makes sense and now you may
say okay if 77 is so easy to get then I
don't know if 84% is something that is
worth putting all this effort for right
another thing to do is maybe do a human
Baseline so what you could do is maybe
you could pick a thousand days of data
from the test set and ask a
meteorologist to to predict and check
their accuracy and then check your
models accuracy on those thousand uh
data points and this is called a human
Baseline and if your model is able to do
better than that particular
meteorologist then you have kind of
beaten a human and that is how we say
that the this AI is now better than a
human of course you don't want to just
beat one person ideally you want to beat
a panel of experts um all of them who
have independently made predictions and
you are beating maybe the average of
their predictions uh and if you're
comprehensively doing that then at that
point we can probably just tell all the
meteorologists to go home because
they're not able to do as well as our
model is able to do right and that
brings me to this last piece which is to
make predictions on actual single inputs
now once the model has been trained to a
satisfactory accur satisfactory
accuracy once we've analyzed it compared
it with meteorologists and we've decided
that okay we can fire them and just use
this model we now have to use this model
to make predictions on new data so
consider this uh dictionary containing
the data from the Katherine weather
Department today so 2021
619 uh this is the location this is the
minimum temperature maximum temperature
rainfall evaporation etc etc and whether
it rained today we have all the
information but obviously since tomorrow
hasn't happened we don't know if it's
going to rain tomorrow and we have to
send out a weather bulletin in a couple
of hours so now it is up to our model to
tell us if it is going to rain tomorrow
okay and as you run through this
notebook you can try changing some of
these param
so I'm just going to yeah I'm going to
create this dictionary and let's see how
we can use our model to make predictions
now obviously we cannot directly feed
this dictionary into our model our model
expects numbers and encoded categorical
data etc etc so the best way when you
want to make a prediction on a new input
is to try and mimic the original input
format as closely as possible so the
original input format was a pandas data
frame and this would ideally be a row
within a data frame so here's what we
can do we can take the new input which
is a dictionary and we can put this into
a list so now we get a list of
dictionaries and remember the panda data
frame Constructor can take a list of
dictionaries and it interprets each
dictionary as a row of data so we are
just going to create a pandas data frame
using this list of dictionaries which
the which contains just one dictionary
so that means the pandas data frame will
contain just one row of data
so we've taken this dictionary and
converted this into this pandis data
frame okay the objective for you is to
get the data
into the same kind of a structure that
was used to train the model so this was
a structure that was used to train the
model right a pandas data frame and here
we have just one data point so that's
why we have just one row but let's say
if you had this information about all
the locations all the different
locations you had collected 49 pieces of
information you could create a data
frame with 49 rows
okay in any case we now have this data
frame can we pass this into the model
not yet because we need to apply the
same pre-processing steps that we have
applied while training the model first
is imputation of the missing values and
this is where the imputer that we had
created earlier is going to be useful so
I'm just going to call imputer do
transform and remember it's going to use
the the main values that it had
calculated on the entire data set so we
can't just create a new imputer we need
to use that original imputer we need to
keep that imputer around and I'll tell
you how to keep it around when we talk
about saving models but we say imputer
do transform and then we give it new
input DF and just the numeric columns
right remember so we also need to keep a
list of the numeric columns and then we
need to grab the numeric columns out of
the new input DF and transform them and
that will fill any missing data so for
example there's one Nan here for
Sunshine that will get filled in then we
have we have scaling so numeric features
also have to be scaled remember these
values 23 22 all of these have to be
brought into the 0 to 1 range so we now
say scaler do transform and that's why
the scaler is useful and remember the
scaler has already been fitted on the
entire data set so it knows the ranges
so we can't create a new scaler so we
use scaler do transform and then we pass
in the numeric columns and that's going
to then give us um the new input DF now
with the numeric value scal and finally
we also want to encode the categorical
column so we take the categorical column
colums and remember we have an encoder
it already knows what all the different
categories are and what all the
different columns need to be created
are and it's going to create these
encoded columns and let's check new
input DF
now yeah so now you can see now it has
been converted into the format that will
be that is ready to be passed into the
model okay it's still one row of data so
now let's grab from new input DF
remember we only want to pass in numbers
into the model so we take numeric
columns we take encoded columns and we
get those from the new input DF and we
check X new input you can see that now
it just contains the numbers that can be
passed in directly and all the columns
are in exactly the same order that's
also very important right all the
columns are in exactly the same order
that they are in the input that's why
these pre-processing steps should be
applied exactly to every new input and
we can now make a prediction so we call
model. predict like if we just call
model. predict it's going to give us a
list of predictions one for each row of
data you can see that it's an array of
yes but obviously we just want the first
prediction because we just have one row
so that's why we just selecting zero
here so we say prediction and we check
prediction and it turns out the
prediction is yes so based on this
input Catherine mint temperature max
temperature Etc the model has predicted
that it will rain tomorrow
and what is the probability we can check
the probability as well we can get the
probability that the model thinks it
will rain tomorrow so the probability of
for no is zero the probability for yes
is 51% so it seems like the model is
just on the border it's not 100% sure on
whether it will rain tomorrow it's only
about 51% sure so maybe I don't know if
you should put this out in the weather
bulletin that it will rain tomorrow you
may want to say slight chances of rain
and leave that possibility open and
that's another interesting thing to look
at right so now one thing you can play
around with is try changing some of
these values like now that you know that
wind speed at 3 p.m. is very important
maybe try changing the wind speed maybe
let me change this wind speed to uh
zero okay and let me repeat these
steps and let's see if the prediction
changes so the prediction still says yes
let's see if the probabilities change
okay the model actually has become more
confident uh so I don't know maybe it's
not the 3pm wind speed I think but maybe
it is just the overall wind speed uh I
think this is the one actually so let me
just change this to 10 and let me keep
the three 3 pm wind speed at 20 let's
see if that creates a
change and this is how you want to okay
so now the prediction is no right so if
the you can see that the wind gust speed
has gone down by a lot from 50 to 2 to
10 you can see that now it is 89%
confident that it will not rain tomorrow
so this is how you should interpret your
model and this is how you should also
make sense of your model if these things
are sensible you should then sit with
the meteorologist or the domain expert
and show them hey if I put in this
number this is the output that it gives
and this is the probability that it
gives do you think it makes sense or and
then they can tell you from weather
research if these things actually make
sense or not and if some of these things
don't make sense then maybe you need to
go back and check these correlations and
sometimes you may have accidental
correlation sometimes you may have what
is called a data leak where maybe some
information from the target has been put
into one of these input columns somehow
and all of these things happen and
that's why models don't work well in
real life so you need to look into the
model and see why it is giving you a
certain result and again as always it
helps to create a helper function to
make these predictions so now we have
this helper function predict input and
then we can just make some modifications
into this new input
input and we can try uh and we can try
things out right for example here we for
this input I just change the location to
Los senton and it seems like now it is
more confident maybe if I pick Albury
let me see if the prediction is going to
change yeah so now it's even more it's
like 79% confident let me pick there was
a certain place Olu which had very
little rain so let me put Olu
here okay it's still confident it seems
like that this is this indicates a very
strong chance of rain for most places
right so that's how you analyze your
model you can try changing some of the
other parameters let me try rainfall
here let me try the rainfall for today
let me make it
two okay still says yes so do play
around with this do pick maybe pick some
random Row from the data and then try
and change a few things or maybe even
look this up look this information up
today live and put in this information
see how useful this model is 3 years
from being created and honestly climate
does not really change that much in just
3 years it's a multi- deade or multi-
Century phenomena so if you've trained a
model using data from 2007 2000 to 2010
to 2017 it should hold up pretty well
even uh today in 2021 so you could go on
Yahoo weather or somewhere or ACU
weather and get all this information and
then put this information into the model
and check if it actually RS to tomorrow
by by checking it right and that is what
machine learning is it is about taking
data and using data to make predictions
but how do you make predictions from
data you assume a certain relationship
between the inputs which is the weather
information for today and the output
which is whether it will rain tomorrow
and that relationship is called the
model and that model has some inherent
parameters called weights of the model
which are initially randomly initialized
and then you train the model which means
that you make predictions compare them
with the actual data and that's where
you need labeled historical data or
labeled data for whether it rain the
next day for the last 10 years and using
that comparison computer loss reduce the
loss using an optimization technique
make the model's parameters better and
as the model gets better then you
evaluate the model you interpret the
model and then you use the model in the
real world this is used for weather
prediction this is used for predicting
whether somebody will default on a loan
this can be used for predicting if a
certain tumor will cause cancer this can
be used for predicting let's
say well actually a similar technique is
used for predicting uh for recognizing
pictures of cats and dogs logistic
regression if you check out our other
course which is the data deep learning
with py toch 0 to Gans course there we
apply logistic regression on image data
so a very similar technique is applied
to just identify a separate pictures of
cats and dogs or even like identify
handwritten digits so it's a very
versatile technique logistic regression
by itself but machine learning in
general it can be applied to a whole
bunch of different kind of problems one
last thing I want to cover before we
close for the day is saving and training
uh saving and loading trained models
obviously we've spent a lot of time
training these models we've done a bunch
of pre-processing just as we have saved
pre-processed data we should also save
the trained models and what is the model
really well the model is two things the
model is what kind of model it is which
is the logistic regression model and how
it was initialized so all the parameters
that we are given in the initialization
like the kind of Optimizer the number of
iterations etc
etc and then it is the Learned weights
of the model which is what has come out
of model.fit
so we should save all of this so that we
can reuse this model without having to
train it without having to fit it on
this pre-processed data from scratch in
fact once the model is trained and we
know the coefficients we don't need to
look at the data anymore we can just
hand over the coefficients to a software
developer and they can set up a a simple
web page where um somebody inputs a
bunch of uh weather parameters and then
that input is sent to a web server where
we simply multiply those parameters with
the coefficients apply the sigmoid
function and then return a result and
that is going to just work as a
standalone web application without ever
looking at all the data so in some sense
the model the models parameters or the
models weights is
the is sort of a a condensed or a dense
representation of all the intelligence
that is present within the data right so
it is capturing all the patterns within
that large data set of
130,000 uh rows of data into just these
250 numbers 250 weights and biases and
that is really uh what makes machine
learning so powerful you are summarizing
millions of of data points into just
these hundreds of numbers sometimes
maybe a thousand numbers but still these
very dense representations which is the
sort of the intelligence of the data and
can be used to make predictions so how
do we save our model now we can save our
model using this Library called job lib
but we don't want to just save our model
we want to save our model we want to
save our imputs we want to save our
scalers we want to save our encoders we
want to save even the column names that
are important anything that will be
required while generating predictions
using the model should be saved so
anything that is used inside this
function for example should be saved so
here's what you can do jblb is a very
generic Library which can save any
python data so I would typically create
a dictionary like this so I'm calling
this OC rain the dictionary and I'm
giving it the model the imputer the
scaler the encoder input columns Etc so
I have the key model and I have the
value which is the actual machine
learning model that I've created I have
the key imputer and I have the value
which is the actual imputer that I've
created so here I have created this
dictionary and then I'm going to just
save this dictionary using jb. dump so
we say jb. dump give it the name of the
Python object this you can just save
your model if you want you can save them
as separate files but I just like to
keep them all together because they're
going to be used together anyway and you
can save it now shut down this notebook
and uh maybe create a new notebook and
upload this file. JBL by the way from
collab you will want to definitely
download this file if you want to keep a
copy around and create a new notebook
and upload this file. jobl and then just
do jb.
load and you can see that is now loaded
into this variable o r 2 and that will
have now all of these things like now we
can check
AI rain 2 model so this has been loaded
from
disk
and
yeah so this has been loaded from the
disk and you can see that we have got
back the Lo logistic regression model in
fact you can even check its coefficients
and make sure that these coefficients
are the coefficients that it had
learned I think it's called ccore yeah
so these seem to be the same
coefficients that we looked at 8.9 3.16
Etc Great so now we've been able to
retrieve our model we don't need to
retrain our model each time we can
probably hand over this
jobl file to a software developer and
maybe if we have time we will also look
at how to create a simple web
application using your machine learning
model but for now let's just make some
predictions using this model so test PRS
2 is going to um be the results of using
the ocy R 2 model to make predictions on
X test and then we are Computing the
accuracy score from test targets and
that gives the 84.2% result the exact
same result as we had before before and
it should of course because we've saved
whatever was there in the model to dis
and then loaded it
back so that's how you save and load
models now if you want to attach your
model with your Jovian notebook then
while running Jovian docit you can use
this outputs argument and give it a list
and in this list you have ocin do jblb
right so you just give it the name of
the output files you want to include and
when you run it and create a notebook on
Jian that notebook will now contain this
jblb file in the files tab as you can
see here
.j okay so you can always whenever you
want to download it you can always
download it very
easily okay and we've covered a lot of
ground in this tutorial we've covered a
lot of different concepts and you are
not expected
to become an expert in all of these or
even any of these immediately uh the
things that we've learned right now
being able to apply them effectively or
even just get them getting them to work
is something that will take weeks months
or even like a year or so uh for you to
really grasp right so the machine
learning course that we're doing right
now the Practical machine learning
course the objective is to expose you to
what machine learning is what real world
machine learning problems look like and
what the process of training a machine
learning model and using a machine
learning model looks like right and once
you get this high level picture then
over time you can slowly chip away at
small pieces and this you will do via
the assignments that we will have and
why the project that you will do but
even over time uh you can chip away all
of at all of these small pieces and
perfect each of these right this is not
a skill that will come immediately
unlike let's say data analysis with
pandas or uh just visualization with
plotly I I would say even those take
time but at least there are a fixed
number of things you can do there with
machine learning you have to apply a lot
of thought you have to apply a lot of
creativity you have to apply a lot of
insight there's a lot of experience that
comes in so don't be discouraged if you
are not able to train good models
initially um in fact most machine
learning models that you train initially
will be pretty bad but see that as an
opportunity for improvement now one good
way to improve yourself is by going to
kaggle data sets and then clicking on
the code tab so here for example this is
the rain in Australia data data set
clicking on the code Tab and then
filtering by most
ports and then you can check out some of
these notebooks people are very nice
they have created these um public
notebooks for people for you to check
out you can see that there is a
extensive analysis and there is an
extensive feature engineering and
splitting and scaling and training and
predictions and accuracy and scores and
confusion matrices and classification
metrics and a bunch of different things
so
this is a honestly it is a lifelong
Pursuit machine learning but I would
also say that it is worth it because the
kind of things that you can do with
machine learning models is just amazing
it's out of this world especially once
you start getting into deep learning as
well so yeah so don't feel overwhelmed
pick some data sets and try to create a
model that works and if you're unable to
create a model that works maybe read
through what people have done with that
data set pick up some ideas from here
and there maybe copy paste some code if
you need to maybe even just run through
this person's notebook look at each line
of code and that is how you learn uh the
the theory behind machine learning you
can probably watch a couple of videos
and get a decent idea but that is not
going to help you beyond a point what is
going to help you is to try these things
out of on your own on real data sets on
just like jumping into the pool without
knowing how to swim essentially and just
learning along the way right so that's
what you want to do and there are a lot
of great resources but you have to dig
them so you have to find grade data sets
and then you have to read through these
notebooks as I suggested one quick hack
is go to a data set click the code uh
Tab and select sort by hotness you can
even add some filters if you want but
like language Python and things like
that but sorry sort by most wordss uh
and just browse through the top three or
four notebooks and just like this you
will learn a lot about the different
machine learning techniques now one
other thing I want to add here is that
everything that we've done can be
covered in just each step can be covered
in no more than three or four lines of
code so it may seem intimidating the
concepts may seem int intimidating at
first but go through this notebook again
review this video and once you get the
concept realize that the work to be done
there is actually quite quite small
there may be some experimentation
required but the kind of the amount of
coding is quite small so here's what it
looks like the data pre-processing step
downloading the data set is three lines
of code you download using open data
sets you read it using raw DF and then
you drop it you drop Nas so I've just
dropped the rows which have rain today
or rain tomorrow set to false or set to
Nan then creating training and
validation data sets is two three lines
of code now we have used this um because
we have date a date column we have used
like years less than 2015 equal to 2015
and greater than 2015 but we could also
have used bra test split and that would
also be just one or two lines then we
created some inputs and targets by
creating the input columns the target
columns and then creating training
inputs training targets validation
inputs validation targets test inputs
test targets
Etc then we have created some numeric
and categorical columns just because we
are going to need that information for
the next steps then we imputed the
numeric values by creating an imputer
fitting it to the data and then
transforming the training validation and
test inputs imputing is simply missing
filling in missing values then we have
scaled the numeric features so creating
a scaler is again just one line of code
you create the scaler and then you fit
it to the data so it's going to figure
out the ranges there are other scalers
too there's something called a standard
scaler you can check out and then you
apply them to the training validation
and test sets again psyit learn has a
very nice API where everything that you
do in pre-processing you first
instantiate or create an object with
some options then you fit it to the data
and then you transform the data using
it one hot encoding works the same way
you create a one hot encoder then you
transform the data and of course when
you transform the data for each category
you're going to get a new column so you
also need to create a list of the new
columns and that's what this encoded
columns is for and then you apply that
for the training validation and test set
then you save the pre-processed data to
disk this is an optional step but this
is useful when you working with large
data sets so that you don't have to keep
rerunning the notebook over and over and
over some people also like to have a
pre-processing notebook U model training
notebook and a prediction notebook and
they would often put all those three
notebooks in the same folder and they
would share these files across the three
notebooks so each time you improve
something in pre-processing you save it
to the parket file you read it in the um
prediction not in the training notebook
and then you save the model weights to
uh disk and then you read the model
weights in the prediction notebook okay
and this is how you load the
data now what you should try and do is
just try and explain each line of code
above and really there's about 15 lines
for you to explain because most of this
is just repeated U code so if you can
explain these 10 to 15 lines right so
you're just 10 lines away from
understanding how to build machine
learning models think of it that way and
try to just work through understanding
these 10 or 15 lines and you will
understand the pre-processing then you
have model training and evaluation so
here we import logistic regression now
very interesting with uh the interesting
thing with psychic learn is that a lot
of different models will have the exact
same API so instead of logistic
regression you could say a random Forest
classifier you could say an svm
classifier you could say a knife based
classifier and they would work exactly
the same way you would have to change
almost nothing except maybe just this
one line so here we are creating the
model we are instantiating the model
using logistic uh regression the in the
Constructor then we fit the model always
is the next step fitting is where we go
through this process of generating
predictions Computing loss improving the
weights and biases then again generating
predictions and keep repeating that
process once we have fit the model it's
always a good idea to just check the
accuracy or the score or whatever loss
or whatever we are interested in however
we want to evaluate the model on the
training data on the validation data on
the test data and whenever you're happy
with the results you should save the
model and addly when you're saving them
you may also want to maybe just add like
a small note here on what date you're
saving it on just some kind of
information in the file name so that you
have multiple values now the difficulty
is then you run into these issues of
like final one final V1 V2 etc etc so
what we recommend is that when you run
jan.com if you just attach the saved
model with your Jovian notebook so with
every version you can have a different
version of your saved model that you can
refer to okay again try to explain each
line of code in your own words and if
you can understand this you understand
how to train a model you can even just
try this out very quickly just change
this to like x a random forest
classifier and just replace this with
random forest classifier and see if you
get a better result the logistic
regression is the simplest possible
model for classification essentially
there are we are going to talk about
decision trees and random Forest next
week which are again a very interesting
approach to the same kind of problem and
you'll see how they're able to get a
better
result then finally your model is going
to be used for prediction so you need to
have a way to very easily uh test your
model and always try and create this
predict input function which can take an
input in the Raw format or in a very
human friendly format and return the
prediction and the probabilities in case
of classification or in case of
regression it's just a prediction right
this allows you to experiment with the
interact with the model oneon-one
because if you're saying this is an AI
um a piece of artificial intelligence
then you should be able to interact with
it in the same way you interact with a
human which is by giving it some input
and getting some output out of it and
then interpreting it and comparing it
with what a human would give you right
and the closer it gets to the stateof
thee art or the closer it gets to the
truth uh the better the more intelligent
this uh model has become okay so playing
with and and experimenting with
individual inputs will give you a lot of
insight into why the model is working or
not working now you can see here that
fitting the model is a very
straightforward step right so there's
not much you can change here maybe there
are some parameters you can change here
and even calculating the predictions and
accuracies is again a fairly
straightforward step you just run a
couple of functions but what will really
give you Insight in how to improve your
model is by looking at the misclassified
examples which means the examples it was
not able to predict correctly or looking
at the examples which it was UNF unsure
about and then finally just playing with
individual inputs the kind of insight
that this gives you is far more than any
single accuracy score or any single any
single number can give you right so
definitely play with your model and it's
also very interesting to see because
once you've done all this work and
trained this model to see how it behaves
to see how it um performs to see what it
thinks essentially right the model's
brain is those weights that is a very
very important piece of understanding
what the model is doing I can go on for
a long time about machine learning this
is my favorite topic and probably going
to spend um a long time just working on
machine learning that's why I feel very
excited about it but do try and I hope I
was able to con convey that same
excitement to you or the same power of
machine learning to you if not the exact
details but be patient with it don't
expect all of it to come immediately but
when it does you will be able to do some
amazing things
and people will not believe the kind of
things that you'll be able to do so
stick with it that is what I'll say with
machine learning okay so here's a quick
summary of what we've done downloading
the data set exploring data set uh
splitting it into training validation
and test imputing missing values scaling
numeric features encoding categorical
columns training a logistic regression
model evaluating a model using a
validation set in a test set and saving
a model to disk and loading it back
there are even more steps U that are are
involved in machine learning which we
will talk about in in future lessons and
we will look at other types of machine
learning models as well and here are
some more resources if you want to look
at the theoretical aspects of linear
regression logistic regression you can
watch these you can watch these um
lessons I I think they're part of the
machine learning course by Andrew in
that's a great course which gives you a
good theoretical foundation for machine
learning probably a good complement with
this course so it's on corsera machine
learning Stanford anding you probably
know the course already
then here are some tutorials that I
found useful while working on this
notebook especially this one the
extensive analysis Eda modeling I have
borrowed a lot of things from this
notebook so do check it out every time I
read a kaggle notebook I learn something
even after doing machine learning for
several years and if you want to try
your hand at training your own logistic
regression model just spin up a new
notebook and repeat each of these steps
with one of these data sets breast
cancer detection this one should be
relatively easy Lo repayment prediction
this is a very hard and handwritten
digit recognition this is going to be
intermediate but you will have to figure
out how to work with image data
fortunately all of these are hosted on
kaggle and you
can go and check the code Tab and on the
code tab you can always look at the most
VES so you can try something and then
you can let's see you can even search
here I'm just looking for logistic
regression
yeah so you can see that there is this
applied machine learning notebook and
this contains
a logistic regression example
somewhere supervised machine learning
there's probably a logistic regression
example somewhere there logistic
regression there you go right so this is
the logistic regression on another data
set the topic for today is decision
trees and random forests this is
something different from what we've
covered so far which is is the linear
models like linear and logistic
regression and random Forest especially
are a very powerful and widely used
machine learning
technique it's most likely that in your
professional work you will be building
decision trees and random forests most
of the time and one of the primary
reasons for that is interpretability of
these models so we will also talk about
why these models learn the things that
they do and why they give the results or
predictions that they
do so here's what we're going to cover
today we will download a real world data
set just as we've been doing for the
previous lessons we will prepare a data
set for training a machine learning
model then we will train and interpret
some decision trees and then we will
move on to training and interpreting
random forests we will talk about
overfitting hyperparameter tuning and
regularization these are some of the
central problems in machine learning and
and this is where you will spend a lot
of your time when you are improving your
models and finally we will talk about
how to make predictions on single inputs
as
well now I'm running this notebook on
collab but you can also run it locally
but things may be a little bit slower
depending on what your configuration is
if you have a good CPU and a high Ram
you should be able to run this locally
as well just as we've been doing in the
previous lessons we will take a
practical and coding focused approach we
will learn how to use decision trees and
random Forest to solve a real world
problem from kaggle and we going to use
the same data set that we used the last
time and this will also give you a
chance to
contrast decision trees versus linear
regression logistic regression models so
we will use the rain in Australia data
set which contains about 10 years of
daily weather observations from numerous
Australian weather stations and here is
a small sample from the data set set so
on several dates you have information
captured from several locations and this
information includes minimum temperature
maximum temperature rainfall evaporation
Etc and the last two columns are the
most interesting one is whether it
rained on that day and the second is
whether it rained on the next day now of
course we have rain tomorrow because we
are looking at historical data and as a
data scientist at the Bureau of
meteorology you are tasked with creating
a fully automated system that can use
today's weather data for a given
location to predict whether it will rain
at a location tomorrow so you want to
create an automated system which can
essentially
predict the likelihood of rainfall all
over
Australia so let's see how far we can
get
there before we begin we'll just install
and import some of the required
libraries that we've been using
throughout open data sets for
downloading a data set pandas
for loading data sets and working
working with data frames numpy for some
mathematical work mathematical
Computing SK learn contains all the
machine learning models that we train
and Jovian for saving snapshots of your
notebook so let's import all the
libraries as well open data sets as OD
matplot li. pyplot as
PLT cbon is SNS pandas as PD nump as NP
matte plot Li Jovian and we will also
use the OS module a bit so these are
standard conventions that you should
follow in all your Jupiter notebooks and
if you don't follow these you will find
that people get confused uh of course
you can call pandas anything you want
but uh prefer calling it PD because
that's how you will see it all over the
Internet finally we also setting some
options for display here so that the
graphs are a little bigger and we can
see more information within our pandas
data
frames all right so the first step is to
download the data set as we had done the
last time we will download this data set
using the open data sets Library
directly from
kaggle within Jupiter so we just run od.
download and when we Run od. download we
will be prompted for an API key a kaggle
username and an API key here's what that
looks
like okay let me just run
this yeah so we will be prompted for a
kaggle we'll be prompted for a kaggle
username and an API key here's what that
looks like now this is one way to
provide the information your kaggle
username and your kaggle API key but one
other thing you can do is just click on
this file explorer and find the upload
button and upload your kaggle do Json
file and if you place your kaggle Json
file next to your notebook then open
data sets will automatically find the
credentials
and download the data set as you can see
here this was a 3M data set that was
downloaded
automatically and of course if you don't
have your kagle Json file go to
kaggle.com which is where we're
downloading the data set from click on
account scroll down to create new API
token and that will download the kaggle
Json file for you okay so you can either
provide your kagle username and ID uh
and key directly or you can upload the
kagle Json file to Google
collab or just place it next to the
notebook if you're running it
locally so the data set is now
downloaded and extracted into this
folder wether data set rattle package
and we can check that using os.
list now I'm just going to click edit
clear all outputs here so that we can
see we can run all the code fresh and we
do not have any stale outputs in our
notebook
all right so the file weather a.csv
contains the data you can see here
weather a.csv
so let's load it into a pandas data
frame I'm going to run pd. read
CSV and that loads the data frame up and
here's the data frame so here's the data
we looked at it the last time as well we
have date location minimum temperature a
bunch of weather parameters and finally
we have rain today and rain tomorrow our
OB objective is to take all of this
information maybe not the date because
everything is on a different date but
everything except the date and use that
to predict whether it will rain on the
next day and hopefully we can then use
it on some future data as
well so let's check the column types of
the data set if we just do rf. info it
tells us that there are a total of
145,000 entries
and you can see the types of each column
so you have object which is mostly
strings or categorical data and then you
have float 64 and then you have okay no
in 64 but floats and inss are numeric
data the others are mostly categorical
data and some and sometimes these can be
string data as
well and you will notice that some of
these columns have null values too so we
need to deal with them as well now one
of the things I'm going to do is remove
any rows where the value of the target
column is null because we want to train
a model that can predict whether or not
it will rain tomorrow so to give the
model any data where we don't know
information about whether it rains
tomorrow will not be useful to train the
model right so we will remove any rows
where the target column is empty so I'm
just going to remove the subset rain
tomorrow and here's an exercise for you
try and perform some exploratory data
analysis on this data set if you have
hav already and study the relationships
of the other columns with the rain
tomorrow column see if you can figure
out before we build this model which
columns are the most important in
determining whether it will rain
tomorrow and I'm just going to save my
notebook as well so I'm running jan.
commit
here and I am asked to enter my API key
which I can find from my Jo profile by
going to jan. just click on this that
will copy the API key and I can paste it
here and this will save a snapshot of
the notebook to my profile so that I can
come back and continue where I've left
off in my next session the collab
notebook of course will shut down after
some
time all right so now we've done most of
this before so let's go over this
quickly we will perform some steps to
prepare the data set for training the
the first step is to create a training
test and validation split remember it's
common practice to set
aside only about 60% of the data for
training the model and then we use 10
20% of the data for validation which is
to evaluate different versions of the
model as we try out different uh
parameters to train the model and
finally to report the final accuracy we
use the test set now it's common
practice to do a random split but in
this case because the data is ordered by
date and because the model that we are
going to create using this data is going
to be used in the future we can simulate
that which is using the model trained on
the past to the to predict values in the
future by picking the last couple of
years for the test
set and we can maybe pick one year
before that for the validation set and
then all of this data can be used for
the training set so this is the
distribution of the number of rows per
and we've done that using a simple count
plot using
cbon so here's what we'll do we will
create a train data frame which is a
fraction of the rows of the raw data
frame which we just loaded up where the
year is less than 2015 and here is how
we've converted the year we have taken
the date column raw DF DOD and we have
passed it as a date time field each
value in the column and from that date
time field we have extracted the year so
this is basic pandas date operations
that you should check out if you're not
familiar with this
already so before the year 2015 which is
up to 2014 we use the data for training
and then the validation data is the year
2015 and then the test data frame is the
year 2016 and
2017 uh again this we doing this only
because we have this chronologically
ordered data and this is how your model
will be used in the real world if you do
not have chronologically ordered data
then you use a random split and there is
a method in psyit learn called train
test split which you can use to do
that all right so now we have about
98,000 measurements 98,000 observations
or 98,000 samples for training we have
about 177,000 samples for validation so
as we try different kinds of models and
we'll try quite a few today we can use
the validation data frame to evaluate
how well those models are performing and
finally we have a test data frame this
is where we will report the final
accuracy of our
model now here's an exercise for you if
you want to build on top of this you can
try and scrape the climate data for the
recent years from this website this is
the official website of the Bureau of
meteorology in Australia you can try and
scrape the data from 2017 to 2021 and
try training a model with the n enlarged
data set in fact this is how this data
set was created in the first place by
scraping data so web scraping is a great
way to create new data sets for machine
learning we have created the training
and validation data set split and then
the next step is to identify the input
and Target columns because not all the
columns will be useful for machine
learning and it's also very important to
separate out the input and the target
data one common mistake people make
initially is to accidentally use the
target column to predict the target
column in which case your machine
learning model isn't really doing
anything it is taking the value of the
target column and simply returning it so
always make sure to carefully check The
Columns of your data frame and separate
out the input and output columns so if I
check the raw data frame or maybe if I
just check the train data frame which is
just a subset of the rows you can see
that we don't want to use the first row
date and and we don't want to use the
last
row tomorrow as an input why not date
because we are going to use the model in
the future so a date will not be a
useful thing and rain tomorrow is not
useful because this is the value that we
want to predict so the input to the
model should be the rest of the
columns and the prediction of the model
should be compared with the target
column which is rain
tomorrow so here's how we setting that
up we are set up train DF colum s we've
converted that into a list and we're
excluding the first and the last value
from that
list and now we can take just the input
columns from the training data frame and
create training inputs so I'm just
creating a copy here because we are
going to make some modifications in the
few in the next few steps and we can
also separate
out Target columns or we can also
separate out the target column so now
the target column is just a single
column so when we select train DF Target
call that is is going to return a panda
series not a data frame uh so just keep
that in mind so here's what that looks
like train
inputs so this contains location to rain
today and train
Targets this contains just the value of
rain
tomorrow okay always a good idea to just
check out what information you have
within your data frames before
you move forward similarly here we are
creating the validation inputs
validation targets and we're creating
the test inputs and test
targets next up let's also identify the
numeric and categorical columns within
the data because we will need to deal
with them separately
so here's one trick well one simple
thing you could do is you could just do
train DF and then you could manage ually
look through and make a list okay main
temp is numeric Max temp is numeric
rainfall is numeric etc
etc but what you should ideally be doing
is detecting these automatically so
here's how you can do that if you just
do
this train inputs or any data frame do
select D types so only select the
columns which have these matching D
types and for the matching D types if
you just provide np. number which
encompasses flow
and int and all the numeric data
types so now you will get just a data
frame containing all the numeric columns
and then you can simply access the
columns
here and that gives you a list of all
the numeric columns and finally we can
convert that into a list using two
list so here now we get back a list of
all the numeric columns now to get the
list of categorical columns all you need
to do is change this to
categorical oh sorry not categorical to
get the list of categorical columns all
you need to do is change this to
object so when you change this to
object you get back the list of
categorical columns now how did I find
this out well I simply looked it up
online how do you find numeric and
categorical columns in a data frame and
once I found it I just have it written
in my notebook so that I can use it
anytime so these are the numeric and
categorical
columns now one thing you might want to
do at this point is decide if you really
need all the columns because every
column introduces new data which may
potentially slow down your training in
this case we have a small enough data
set so we may not we do not need to
worry about it but you can do some
analysis and you can figure out how
closely The Columns are correlated with
the Target and maybe just select a
subset of the columns instead of all the
columns and observe how it affects the
results does it lead to a large decrease
in the output or is this a very
insignificant decrease and if it is then
it's probably okay to drop a few columns
and just use the ones that are more most
important okay so try it out observe it
and try to get a feel for when it makes
sense to drop some columns uh for now we
are going to move ahead with all the
columns and the next important step is
to impute
missing numeric values which means we
want to take all the missing values
because machine learning algorithms
can't work with missing values they will
throw errors at you and we want to
replace them with some other values so
how do you check the missing values well
you can go train inputs and then from
train input it inputs pick the numeric
columns so just the data from the
numeric columns this is what that looks
like and here we can check is any which
is going to to replace each value with a
true or a false depending on whether it
is Nan so this will become a true and
this will be a false and then I'm going
to do a do
sum so chaining Panda's commands is a
useful skill to learn
so always think about what you want to
get to and what is the incremental
process that will take you there and
maybe I might even do this I may also do
a sort values
here in this
series and maybe set ascending equals
false all right so it seems like
sunshine has the highest number of
missing values followed by evaporation
followed by cloud 3pm cloud 9 name
pressure n name and so on so all these
numeric columns have some missing values
and we are going to replace them using a
simple strategy which is
the which is basically replacing them
with the average of that column so for
this we can import simple imputer from
pyit learn and we create an imputer
object and we specify the strategy that
we want to use strategy is mean and
after creating the imputer object we can
also call do fit and give it the data
the numeric column data which is all the
data from all the numeric columns in our
data
frame and imputer is going to then
figure out what is the average for each
of those columns now once you have
fitted the imputer which means once it
has found the averages or the statistic
that we want to use for each to fill
each column we can actually fill the
columns by calling imputer do transform
so we call imputed or transform on train
inputs numeric columns that is going to
fill information into all the empty data
in in the numeric Columns of the train
inputs and return a new numpy array we
can take that new result and put it back
into the original data frame train
inputs and replace the original numeric
columns okay okay so the net effect of
all of
this is that you have no missing data in
any of the numeric columns we filled it
with the mean value now the mean is not
the only imputation strategy there are
several other imputation strategies that
are available in pyet learn so an
exercise for you would be to try a
different imputation strategy and see
how it affects the final result and this
is all what practical machine learning
is you try different things and maybe
sometimes you try different strategies
for different columns by doing some
exploratory analysis and figure out the
strategies that work best for the
problem at
hand okay next up we are going to scale
the numeric features scaling simply
means we want to take the ranges of each
of the numeric features which is the Min
and the Max and we want to bring them
down into a 0 to one range as you can
see here in the validation training or
test data set each numeric feature has a
different range Min temp is - 8 to + 31
and wind speed is 7 to 135 whereas
certain values like pressure can be like
988 to
139 so because there are a lot of
numerical computations that happen
inside a machine learning algorithm and
ultimately a single loss value is
optimized we don't want the data to have
any we don't want any specific featur to
dominate the training process we want to
give every feature a Level Playing Field
to participate in the training of the
model and that is why we scale all of
these feature values to the range 0 to 1
and we do that using minmax scaler so
here we are creating a minmax scaler and
then we call on minmax scaler fit uh and
we give it the numerical columns uh the
data from all the numerical columns so
it is going to figure out for each
column what is the minimum and the
maximum value and then we can call
scaler do transform give it all the data
from the numeric columns and it is going
to scale them into the 0 to one
range and then we can take that output
and put it back into
our training validation and test data
frames so the net result of all of this
is that the inputs are going to change
from are going to change from a variety
of different ranges to the 0 to one
range
now the 0 to one range is not the only
scaling strategy there are several other
scaling strategies as well so you should
try out a different scaling strategy
specifically standard scaler is
something worth checking out and observe
how that affects the
results next next we're going to encode
the categorical data
machine learning algorithms can only
work with numbers and in our data frames
we have some categorical data if I just
check train DF you can see here you have
location which is categorical then you
have wind gust Direction which is also
categorical and then you have a bunch of
other categorical data as well things
like rain
tomorrow in fact that's what we've
listed in categorical
calls location wind gust Direction wind
direction wind 3 p.m. and rain today so
what we're going to do is perform one
hot encoding for the categorical
columns okay and for the categorical
columns we do need to First fix the nans
so I'm just going to fill nans wherever
we have nans in the categorical column
so I'm just going to
do train DF categorical
calls do fill
any and I'm going to fill all all Nas
with the value
unknown I'm going to do that for the
validation I'm I'm going to do that for
the test data frame as well so we did
fill out missing values in the numerical
columns but we did not do that for the
categorical columns and you can see here
if I just pick the categorical
columns you can see that some of them
have some Nan values most of them
actually so we just going to fill
wherever we have Nan values we are going
to fill it with the string unknown U
just so that one hot encoder doesn't
complain and let's just do that in
place
let's try that
again all right let me just fix
this I believe this is an issue because
of the version of I could learn so this
was something that worked on my computer
but did not work is not working on
Google collab and whenever you face such
issues where something works in a
certain place but does not work in
another place that is probably
because of that is probably because of
uh psychic learn because of version
differences okay let's do this one last
time and this should fix it so watch out
for version differences between
libraries and if you ever want to check
the version of a particular Library the
way to do it is just run pip list and
that will show you a list of all the
libraries that are
installed and you can check their
version so you can check the version on
your computer you can check the version
on collab or wherever you're running and
identify the discrepancy and the way to
install a specific version is to go pip
install
ssy kit learn for example and then
specify the version you want to install
but after an equal to equal to like
0.1.3 okay so with that out of the way
we can now one hot encode our
columns we can now one hot encode our
columns so by one H encoding what we
want to do is we want to take all the
categorical columns and take the values
in those categ orical columns and create
a create a separate column for each
category and those category columns will
simply contain ones or zeros depending
on whether a particular row belongs to
that category again something that we've
discussed in detail in the previous
sessions so I will just run this code
here which is to First create a one hot
encoder and then fit it to the inputs
that we have then create a list of new
feature names or new category names and
you can see what these category names
are create the list of new category
names so for each categorical column and
for each category combined we have one
new category
name and then we can transform the data
from the categorical columns into one
hot vectors and put them back into our
data frame so the net effect of this is
that for every categorical column for
example location
here we have a bunch of separate columns
like location rain today location
adelade location Albany location Alber
Etc where we have zeros and ones and we
have one for the specific location that
this represents for example one for
albur because this location is albur and
zero
elsewhere now categorical one hot
encoding is not the only encoding
strategy there are some other encoding
strategies as well so I encourage you to
try them out and observe how they affect
the results and as a final step let us
drop the textual categorical columns
from our inputs so I'm just creating
these new xtrain xw and X test variables
which contains simply the numeric
columns which have been imputed and
which have been scaled to the 0 to one
range and the encoded categorical
columns so we are removing the actual
string categorical columns and just
keeping keep the encoded ones here and
these this is the input that we will use
to train or evaluate our model of course
we have the targets as well we
have train targets Val targets and test
targets as
well so here's what the input to our
model looks
like Okay so let's save our work before
continuing this is something that we did
the last time as well so it's
so this all this is something that we've
done the last time as well so this
should be fairly com fairly standard
should start to feel fairly standard and
boring by now because these are the
steps that you will take for pretty much
every machine learning
problem let's talk about training and
visualizing decision trees a decision
Tree in general parans represents a
hierarchical set of binary decisions for
example here is a kind of decision tree
that that you may set up to decide
whether or not you accept a job offer
maybe if the salary is between $50,000
to
$80,000 then you then you consider the
offer if it is not between $50 to
$80,000 maybe you decline the offer if
it is between $50 to
$80,000 then maybe you check if the
office is close to your home if it is
not then you decline the offer otherwise
you check if the office if the company
provides a cap facility and if it if it
doesn't then maybe you decline the offer
otherwise you accept the offer so this
kind of a strategy is how we make a lot
of decisions in the real world in fact
this is how a lot of processes are set
up and if you think carefully this is
how programs are also set up or where
where we write a lot of if else if else
statements to come to a certain
decision now a decision Tree in machine
Learning Works exactly the same way
except that we let the computer figure
out the optimal structure and hierarchy
of decisions instead of coming up with
the criteria manually so applying it to
our problem about whether or not it will
rain tomorrow first we'll set we'll let
the computer figure out what is the most
important criteria to decide whether or
not it will rain tomorrow and maybe
after checking the value of that
criteria let's say maybe it's whether it
rained today or not there is a different
Tree on whe based on whether it rained
today and a different tree or based on
whether it did not rain today so if it
did if it did rain today then maybe we
simply look at the pressure and if it
did not rain today maybe we look at the
wind speed at 3:00 p.m. and so on right
so you can have multiple trees on either
side and we will see how these trees
come up but the important point is we
are not creating those trees we are
letting the machine learning model
figure out what the right criteria and
the right decision points are going to
be to best fit the model
okay and to train a decision tree we
simply import the decision tree
classifier model from psyit learn. tree
to train a decision tree now why
decision tree classifier because this is
a classification problem remember there
are two types of problems classification
and regression in regression you're
trying to predict a continuous value
which is for example the medical charges
for an insurance applicant but in
classification you're trying to classify
the input into one of two categories for
instance here we trying to classify the
measurements given today based to
whether or not it will rain tomorrow so
yes or no um so that's why we using a
decision tree classifier if it was a
regression problem we can use a decision
tree
regressor so from SK learn. tree we
import decision tree
classifier and then we create the
decision tree model
so we create the decision tree model by
simply creating an object of the class
decision tree
classifier and there is some Randomness
involved in how decision trees work so
if you want to get the same output each
time you run this code uh just provide a
value for random State So Random State
42 so this is initializing the random
number generator inside the decision
tree so each time you run this code you
will get the same kind of randomiz ation
and H the same kind of outputs um now if
you do not want to have the same kind of
output each time you run this code then
you can remove this random state but it
is generally recommended to have a
random State and you can pick this to be
any number you want but it's is
generally recommended to have a random
state for your decision tree classifier
so that you can replicate your results
otherwise your results will not be
replicable all right so now we've
created the model and the next step is
to fit the model so we give the model
the training data which is all the
numerical columns which have been
imputed and which have been scaled to
the range 0 to one and we give it the
targets which is simply the yes
no value for whether it will rain
tomorrow for each of the input
columns and we run that and it takes
maybe a second maybe a couple of seconds
so it took 2.8 seconds and our decision
tree classifier has been
trained okay okay so what just happened
let's try and use this classifier and
let's see how it works and then we'll
try and visualize it as
well so the first thing after training
any model is to try and make some
predictions using the model and evaluate
how well it is doing so here's how you
can make predictions using the
model if we call model. predict and we
give it a set of inputs to make
predictions on it will give us the
predictions that we can look at so I'm
going to call model. predict on
xtrain and this is what xtrain looks
like so we are giving the model all this
data all of these are numbers and all of
these have been missing values have been
filled in categorical columns have been
converted to one
H and the model gives me some
predictions what do those predictions
look like well the predictions are
either no or yes how does the model know
that it needs to predict no or yes
because we called model. fit with our
targets and our targets also have these
yes no
values so when the model was training
when it was learning from the data it
identified that it needs to predict a
yes or no value now internally of course
the model represents this yes no target
value as a zero or one but um to show us
the output it it is showing us it is
going to show us it is going to to
return strings yes or no all right so
now we have some predictions from our
model we called model. predict on our
input data the training data itself and
we got some predictions and these are
the predictions and we it seems like
there are a lot of NOS here but just to
make sure that we also have some yeses
I'm going to run pd. value counts and
pd. value count simply takes a list and
it's going to tell you the counts of the
unique values so it seems like there are
about 76,000 Nos and about 22,000 yeses
in the predictions so the model is based
on some whatever logic it has learned
the model is actually predicting
different things it's not just
predicting no every time so the model
has seems to have learned something now
how well has it learned something well
that is something that we can evaluate
by Computing an accuracy score so we
have training
predictions and we have training targets
which is the actual
values and the simple thing we can do is
compare each value so we compare the
first value and they match we compare
the second value and they match and we
compare the third value and they match
and we count the percentage of values
that match so I'm just going to
run accuracy score and accuracy score is
imported from SK learn. Matrix and that
is simply going to count the number of
matches I'm going to run accuracy
score on train PRS and train
targets so let's see how well the model
has done on the training set okay so it
seems like the accuracy of the model on
the training set on which it has been
trained is
99.99% so practically 100% this could
just be a floating Point error so the
accuracy is now is close to 100% And The
decision tree also returns probabilities
for each production for each prediction
so we can also check the probabilities
so let's check the probabilities and to
get probabilities you can simply call
model. predict proper P ba and give it
the same input and let's check the
probabilities and it looks like the
model is very confident about its
predictions as well so we have an
accuracy of 99% and we have a
probability of one for all the for most
of the predictions and you can verify I
if this is actually true throughout or
not so it seems like we've learned
everything there is to learn from this
data or is that so the training set
accuracy is close to 100% but we can't
rely solely on the training set accuracy
because your model will not be used in
the real world on the same training data
in the real world your model will see
data that it has not seen
before and so far it hasn't seen the
validation set so we must evaluate the
model on the valid validation set so now
we need to make predictions on the
validation set by calling model. predict
and then we can compare the validation
set predictions which are obtained from
the validation inputs with the
validation targets using the score
accuracy score
function but because this is such a
common operation pych learn models
already have a DOT score method so in
the case of decision trees if you call
model do score give it the input so in
this case the validation inputs and give
it the targets then it will make a
prediction on the it will make
predictions on the validation inputs and
it will then compare those predictions
with the targets and it will give you
the accuracy here and it turns out that
the accuracy on the validation set is
just
79.2% so you can see that the accuracy
on the training set was
100% as we saw here 99.99% and the
accuracy on the validation set is just
about
79% and in fact 79% is only marginally
only marginally better than always
predicting no for example if we look at
the validation data and we see the
percentage of values that are no which
is by getting the value counts and then
dividing that by the length of the
validation data set so it turns out that
78.8% of the
data is has the Target no and 21% of the
data has the target yes which means if
we had a model that simply predicted no
all the time that would be 78.8%
accurate and our fancy decision tree
that we've trained which is 100%
accurate on the training set is only
marginally better just less than 1%
better just only half a perc better than
our dump model which always predicts no
so what's going on here what's going on
how is the model 100% accurate about the
training data but completely missing or
learning anything but completely failing
to learn anything important anything
useful about the validation data so
here's what has happened it appears that
the model has learned the training
examples perfectly which means it has
basically memorized all the training
examples it's like if you memorize the
answers to all the questions in your
textbook for an exam and then you go to
the exam and none of the questions come
up with exactly the same values so you
are likely to score a very low Mark in
the exam in the same way the model has
learned all the training examples but it
does not generalize very well to
previously unseen examples this
phenomenon is called overfitting and
reducing overfitting is one of the most
important parts of any machine learning
project especially when you're dealing
with tree based models like decision
trees so we'll see how to improve we'll
see how to reduce overfitting and the
first step in understanding what's going
on is to visualize the decision tree
that has been learned from the training
data
um now I told you in the beginning that
decision tree is a hierarchical tree of
binary decisions um something like
this something like this so our model
actually builds a decision tree which is
pretty close to what we saw above and we
can visualize this tree using the plot
tree function from SK learn. tree so I'm
just going to import plot tree from SK
learn. tree and plot tree uses matte
plot lip under the hood so I'm just
setting I'm just increasing the figure
size here so that this is a big image
that we can look at and we call plot Tre
with the model and plot Tre can also
takes the name of the features or the
name of the columns so we can provide to
plot
Tre the names of these columns so that
it can actually tell us which columns
the model is looking
at and then we provide a maximum depth
because this tree is a very deep tree
it's going to have a depth of about 40
or 50 which cannot be printed very
easily so we're just going to look at
two levels of the tree and we just this
is just some some information about
color so we're just filling up we'll
just fill some nodes of the tree with
some backgrounds so let's run this and
let's see what this looks
like so here's what our models
predictions look
like the model first
checks the humidity at 3 p.m. and it
checks if the humidity at 300 p.m. is
less than 715 then it goes into this
direction and then it checks if the
rainfall
at after checking whe if the humidity at
3 p.m. is less than 715 it checks
whether the rainfall is less than
0.004 if that is so it then checks if
Sunshine is less than 0.25 525 and then
it has multiple checks and so on so this
is how the model proceeds each time it
makes a decision based on this value
based on checking the humidity either
goes left or right now if it is gone
right then here there is another check
on humidity and once again based on that
it goes left or right and then based on
this condition it checks left or right
and then it keeps going now we've only
plotted till the depth of two but you
can plot till any depth
here so you can see here here you can
plot to any depth now there seems to be
a problem here typically this image you
will see that it is connected so in this
image you will see that there are lines
connecting these uh but you can see the
tree that's building up here so this is
the first decision and based on this
decision this may be the second decision
based on this this may be the third
decision and so on and that keeps going
till it finds a final Leaf node where
there are no more decisions to be made
and at that leaf node it contains
information about which class should be
returned as the
output
okay so I hope you can see how a model
classifies a given input as a series of
decisions positions now of course the
tree is truncated here but following any
path from the root node to a leaf will
result in a yes or a
no and I hope now you can also start to
see how a decision tree differs from a
logistic regression model now one
important difference that I can
immediately tell
you is that instead of having a standard
weightage for every instead of having a
fixed weight for every column
as you go left and right the the kind of
conditions and the kind of Weights can
change for example based on whether the
humidity is less than 7 or more than 7
the conditions that are applied to wind
gust speed may change and that makes
sense like if it has rained today maybe
the factors I should look at are
different compared to whether it has not
rained today and that nonlinear
relationship can be captured better in a
decision tree and it's a bit harder to
capture in a linear model so whenever
you have these nonlinear relationships
then it's always better to try out a
decision tree and see if that performs
better than a logistic regression model
okay
now you may wonder how this decision Tre
is created how exactly does the model
figure out what is the first decision to
be made and what's the second decision
and so on and this is where you
should pay attention to this Genie value
so in each box you will see this Genie
score now every machine learning model
has something called a loss function or
a cost function and the objective of the
model is to minimize the cost so the way
the model does this is the decision tree
does this is by using a Genny score the
Genny score represents how good a
certain split is so a Genny score a
lower Genny score means a lower cost
which means a good split so a perfect
split let's say by just looking at
humidity 3 p.m.
you could perfectly classify things as
will not rain tomorrow versus rain
tomorrow in that case the jinny score
will be zero so a perfect split has the
Genny score zero and as as a split gets
worse and worse so if if your split is
completely useless which means that even
after splitting there are 50% yeses and
50% NOS on this side and 50% yeses and
50% NOS on this side then you will have
a high gen score maybe close to 0.5 or I
think yeah somewhere around the range of
0.5 all right so a low Genie score means
a good split a high geni score means a
bad split so what do what is our
decision tree model
do conceptually speaking while training
the model evaluates all possible splits
across all possible columns so right now
we are looking at this one split
humidity 3 p.m. but conceptually
speaking what the model has done is it
has looked at all the different columns
and then for each column it has looked
at all the possible split points so it
has basically sorted all the values in
those columns in increasing order and
then it has taken each value as a split
point and then for each split point it
has performed the split and based on the
split it has calculated the Genny score
now good splits will have a low Genie
score and bad splits will have a high
Genie score out of all the all the
columns all the splits it has selected
the best
column with the best split which leads
to a lowest possible Genny score now of
course with just one split you cannot
really get to a gen score of zero
because you can't just look at one
feature and one split and perfectly make
predictions about whether or not it will
rain tomorrow but among all the possible
splits it turns out that humidity at 300
p.m. whether that's less than7 or more
than 7 is the most important factor it
it it leads to the lowest gen score okay
so that's how the decision Tre figures
out what should be the top level root
level
node now once it is figured out what the
root level node is which is the best
split among all the columns and all the
possible
splits it performs the split using that
data so certain data points fall into
this region all the training data which
has humidity less than 7 falls into this
region all the data which has humidity
greater than 7 falls into this
region and this is where now the process
is repeated now for this entire data
which has humidity less than 7 it tries
all the columns all the possible splits
and figure out and figures out the best
splits now turns out that if humidity is
already less than 7 rainfall less than
04 is the best split and if humidity is
greater than 7 then humidity whether
that's humidity less than equal to 0825
is the best split okay so that's what is
happening
here so the iterative approach of
machine learning
in the case of a decision tree involves
growing a tree layer by layer so what we
do first is input all the training
data and
we essentially look at all possible
splits and we take all those possible
splits and then we compute the jny score
for all the possible splits across all
the possible columns based on the Genny
score we pick the best possible
split then we split the data into BAS on
the split that was decided and then we
repeat the process recursively for each
split for the left split and for the
right split right so we are recursively
growing the tree we have the level one
decision and then we make level two
decisions with the split data then we
make level three decisions with the
split data then we make level four
decisions with the split data and so on
and for how long does this go on well
this goes on forever till the point that
you end up with just a single value now
right now you can and in fact that is
the number that you can see here at the
very top top you have 98,9
188 rows of data and this split send
76,000 rows into the left and 22,000
rows into the right now similarly this
particular split has 82,000 rows of
data and this split sends 70,000 this
way and 11,000 this way right so that's
roughly how it works it it it divides
the data into multiple parts and it
keeps dividing till it gets to single
leaf node so you where you just have a
single row of data and then for that row
of data since you already have the
target so that the target for that row
is used as the value of that leaf right
so every leaf ultimately contains just
one sample and that sample already has a
target of yes or no so essentially what
we're saying is we want to follow this
decision Tre down to a specific example
from our training set and just look at
the label of that training example and
return the same label okay so I hope now
you understand why the training accuracy
is 100% because the decision tree has
literally learned or literally memorized
the entire training set in the form of
this tree based
structure
okay and you can verify how deep this
tree is by checking the maximum depth of
the tree so you just call model. tree.
max depth and it turns out that this
tree is 48 layers deep so there it's
possible that within 48 decisions you
will get to a leaf node and on that leaf
node you will have a label corresponding
to that specific training example which
lies in that leaf node
okay so this is one way to visualize a
decision tree what the model
learns and as I said you will see arrows
here normally I don't I'm not sure why
they don't they're not showing up here
but normally you do see
arrows one other way to display player
decision tree which can be easier to
follow is as text so you can call Export
text and you can pass in the model you
can again specify a maximum depth up to
which you want to show things because
again this can get pretty large as well
and you provide a list of feature names
here too so here's what the textual
representation looks like so here we are
checking if the humidity is less than uh
72 and if the humidity is less than 72
we go down this path otherwise we go
down the other path which is well I
think we've not shown it here we've just
shown a few lines because the tree
itself even with
10 layers of depth is very high uh but
yeah if you first you check humidity
then you check rainfall then you check
Sunshine then you check pressure then
you check wind gust speed then you check
humidity again then you check wind uh
Direction then you check the location
now if you're looking at West wet Sonia
then we check the cloud cover at 9:00
a.m. and then we check the wind speed at
300 p.m. and then we check the pressure
so if all of these checks succeed then
we return Yes that yes it will rain
tomorrow if the pressure check fails if
the pressure is not less than equal to
47 then we return
no and if the wind speed check fails if
the wind speed is not less than equal to
07 if it is greater than 7 then we check
the minimum temperature and then there
is another branch of decisions that is
to be made and similarly you have this
if the cloud cover is is greater than 83
then we check the cloud cover at 3 p.m.
and then we return Yes otherwise we
return true otherwise we return uh
otherwise well we check the temperature
and then we return Yes otherwise there
is another decision tree here okay so
the idea is this is the same as the
decision tree that we saw above and the
idea is that we make these hierarchical
decisions and the model has learned
which decision to make first by
analyzing all possible
decisions now one small note I want to
give you here is this is how you should
think about it conceptually the model
actually has not really analyzed all
possible decisions because that is going
to be very inefficient so there are
certain techniques or certain what are
called heuristics that are applied so
which is basically strategies to figure
out good decisions good enough decisions
if not the best decisions and there is
some randomization involved in there as
well right so just as an optimization
there is some randomization and some
strategies to pick if not the best but
at least a good enough decision all
right right so that's the internals of
decision trees which we don't really
need to worry
about so based on this discussion now
can you explain why the training
accuracy is 100% whereas the validation
accuracy is lower and you can think
about it it's because the model has
literally learned every training
example and when it sees an example
which does not fit exactly with training
it tries to categorize it into one of
the existing training examples by
following One path of the decision tree
and that may or may not end up really
well
because it's going to ultimately Bo boil
down to a specific training example and
this is what is called overfitting where
your model has learned or memorized
specific training examples and does not
generalize well to examples that it has
not seen before okay okay let's keep
going now based on the Genny index
computation a decision tree assigns an
importance value to each feature
again there is a certain calculation
involved here on figuring out how the
importance is assigned
but these values can be used to
interpret the results given by a
decision tree so if you just check
inside any decision tree model do
feature uncore
importances that will give you a list of
numbers so here's what that list looks
like and this is the importance for
every feature now remember the input to
our model
xtrain this had about 119 columns so you
will see 119 values here in fact if I
just check the
columns and in fact if I just check the
columns xtrain do columns you can see
here
that there are 119 columns so this is
the importance for minimum temperature
and this is the importance for maximum
temperature and this is the importance
for rainfall and this is the importance
for evapor and so
on so let's create a data frame out of
it so I'm just creating a pandas data
frame where we have one column called
feature or the name of the column in the
original data frame xtrain and one
column called importance which is the
importance of that feature and then
we're going to sort those values by
importance in the descending order and
let's look at the let's look at the 10
most important values the 10 most
important columns so we have humidity at
3 p.m. which seems to be the most
important column here 26 then we have
pressure at 3 p.m. which seems to be the
next most important then we have
rainfall which seems to be the next most
important and so on and you will find
that these importances line up with the
decision tree itself you can see here
you have humidity and then you have
rainfall and then you have a wind gust
speed a pressure does show up sunshine
doesn't show up but pressure doesn't
show show up yet but if you maybe went
one level deeper you would also see
pressure so these are the importances
humidity pressure rainfall wind gust
speed Sunshine Etc and we can also plot
these as a bar plot so I'm just using
SNS do barplot to create a horizontal
bar plot and we are looking at the 10
most important features here so it turns
out that humidity at 3 p.m. has a
feature importance of higher than 26
higher than 025 whereas the next most
important feature seems to be pressure
at 3:00 p.m. followed by rainfall wind
gas speed
Etc and these values should be
interpreted in relative order so mostly
you just want to use this to figure out
which one
is more important than other columns or
than than other
features so that's how you interpret a
decision tree you can see the actual
decision- making process of a decision
tree given an example you can actually
just draw the tree and work through it
and see why a decision tree arrived at a
certain answer and you can also see the
importance of the different factors and
this is where now you can check if
humidity has a lot of missing values and
maybe we filled a lot of missing values
into humidity maybe we are misleading
the model by filling all those missing
values maybe we should remove the
humidity column or maybe we should try
and fill those missing values and so on
right so you need to go back and forth
you need to go back and check if your
data makes sense given that this is the
feature importance that you're working
with so that's how you train a decision
tree you import the decision tree
classifier from SK learn. tree and then
you fit it to the input data and then
you can analyze it you can evaluate it
using the validation data set and we saw
that the decision tree classifier that
we trained memorized all the training
examples lead to a 100% training
accuracy while the validation accuracy
was only marginally better than a dum
Baseline model so at this point our
decision tree is basically useless
because it has just memorized all the
training examples and this phenomenon is
called overfitting and in this section
we will look at some strategies for
reducing
overfitting so you will hear a lot of
these terms now there will be four or
five terms that you'll hear right now
and often in machine learning
overfitting simply means that you're
doing very well on the training data but
you're doing very poorly on the
validation data and we'll Define it a
bit more rigidly a bit more concretely
in in a short while and the process of
reducing overfitting is known as
regularization so whenever you see
regularization or regular regularization
techniques regularization coefficient
regularization uh component etc etc all
of that is concerned with with reducing
overfitting which means trying to
increase the validation accuracy or get
it closer to the training accuracy and
sometimes we may be okay to give up some
training accuracy to get a better
validation accuracy because the
validation accuracy is what we
ultimately care
about now how do we reduce overfitting
in a decision tree classifier now the
decision tree classifier when we created
it we gave it a couple of arguments we
set some random state uh we give it just
one argument which was the random State
and apart from that it also accepts
several other arguments which can be
used to reduce overfitting so if you
just check the help which is by typing a
question mark um for decision tree
classifier you will see that you can
specify a Criterion which can be gen or
entropy and this is simply the loss
function so there are two loss functions
one is Genny and one is
entropy you can specify a splitter so
this is the strategy that is used to
split at each node and by default it
picks the best strategy which just picks
the best possible split of course with
some randomization or you can also uh
specify a completely random split with
without actually looking at the without
actually evaluating different splits but
here's something interesting so you have
a max depth parameter and you can
specify the maximum depth of the
tree so let's see that
there is a max depth parameter and
typically these arguments in the context
of machine learning that you set right
when you are creating your machine
learning model are called hyper
parameters uh because the term parameter
is generally reserved for the parameters
or the numbers inside a machine learning
model for example in logistic regression
the weights of the different features
are known as parameters in a decision
tree which column is the root node and
what point we are splitting at and then
what do the splits look like those are
known as parameters anything that the
model learns or figures out on its own
is called a parameter so just to
separate things that model figures out
versus things that we have to set up
front we call some of these things hyper
parameters so we call max depth which is
something that we specify at the very
beginning when we are creating the
classifier we call it a hyper parameter
because it's not something the model
figures out it's something that we are
specifying
so what is maximum depth well if you saw
the tree the tree went
down to about 40 42 levels deep and we
could check that using so the previous
model that we had the model that we
trained earlier if you just check the
tree inside it so we we can call model.
tree uncore and then we can check max
depth so the model that we had trained
earlier the decision tree went 48 levels
deep and that was one of the reasons for
overfitting because it was learning
every training example so what if we did
not go 48 levels deep what if we only
went three levels deep let's try and see
what that will give us so if we only go
three levels deep so now we have put in
a restriction that we do not want our
decision tree to go more than three
levels deep and then we call model. fit
with the same training input data and
the same training targets so now the
model has been trained again it just
takes a second or two and then we try to
compute the accuracy of the model on the
training and validation data sets so so
we call model do score on X Trin and we
call model do score on xw and while
targets and now it turns out that the
model is only 82% or 83% accurate on the
training
data and this makes sense because the
model can no longer learn every training
example it can only go three layers deep
so it just has to make the best it can
out of three layers but this has the
unintended consequence that the model is
no longer overfitting the model now
performs better on the validation set
than it did before so this may seem
counterintuitive that a three level deep
tree performs better in the real world
on real world data compared to a 48
level deep tree and that's because the
48 level deep tree is learning specific
training examples whereas the 3 level
deep tree is picking up General Trends
and in machine learning you want models
to pick up General trends and not
memorized training examples
okay so that's the model the model's
accuracy has gone up to 83% from 79%
that's a good Improvement and even
though this has gone down ultimately
what we care about is the validation
accuracy and let's visualize the model
now so we can visualize the model using
plot tree once
again so here's what our entire decision
tree model looks like first we check
humidity at 300 p.m. if the humidity at
300 p.m. is less than
715 then we go
left now here we check the rainfall if
the rainfall is less than 04 then we go
left then we check Sunshine if the
sunshine is less than 0525 we go left
and finally If U if we reach this point
we return the class no so whenever you
reach a leaf node you return the class
of that leaf
node similarly now you check humidity
rainfall fall humidity J and you get to
this point you return no so it seems
like a lot of these have no and so in a
lot of cases as you go along this
decision tree you will end up at no but
there are certain cases where you will
end up at yes so you go to humidity uh
humidity 3 p.m. rainfall so if the
rainfor if the humidity at 3 p.m. is
less than
0.825 and then the wind speed wind gust
speed is less than
0.279 then the jny
score in is
0.471 all right so it's your humidity is
greater than point the humidity is
greater than 7 but less than 8 and the
wind speed is less than 27 so here the
class is yes so here is what here you
return that there will be rain
tomorrow and if the humidity is greater
than 7 and greater than 08 well it turns
out that in all these cases you end up
at yes right and of course these trees
got truncated these trees could not be
built Beyond three layers deep so that's
why you see a bunch of yeses here it's
possible that if you had allowed more
layers then maybe some of these yeses
would then split once again into NOS but
because we are ending the tree at three
layers it's going to return no in all
these conditions and it's going to
return Yes in all these conditions
okay so this is what you want to study
carefully because at this point we
already know that we can predict with
83% accuracy simply by looking at
humidity rainfall Sunshine wind gust
speed and that's it right so just four
out of the 23 plus columns can be used
to predict to get a prediction of
83%
accuracy and once again we can also look
at it as a textual tree so here you can
see the same thing humidity less than 72
and humidity greater than 72 and then
you check the rainfall and based on the
rainfall value you either check sunshine
or you check humidity once again and
returns yes and no
okay so one thing you may want wonder is
what is the right maximum depth to use
should we use a maximum depth of zero
obviously not because if you used a
maximum depth of zero then your model
would not learn anything that means it
would always just predict no and while
that would be 79% accurate and while
that would be
regularized um that would not be very
useful because you've not given enough
power to your model
but on the other hand if you allow your
model to go 40 layers deep or 50 layers
deep then your model can memorize every
single training example and since it is
trying to optimize for the lowest Genie
score it is basically memorizing all the
training data and that's bad because
then your model will not generalized so
the best value for the
maximum depth of the tree is going to be
somewhere between 0 and 40 so let's try
and explore that let's try and figure
out what the best value for maximum
depth is going to be so here's what I'm
defining I'm defining a function called
max depth error which takes a sample max
depth value which we can give as an
input and then we create a decision tree
classifier for that particular max depth
with the random State 42 and we get this
model then we fit this model to the
training data for that given max depth
we create the model fit it to the
training data then we calculate the
accuracy on the training set and we
calculate the accuracy on the validation
set
and we Define let's call this
error and we Define the training error
as one minus the training accuracy and
let's call and we Define the validation
error as one minus the validation
accuracy so if accuracy is how what
percentage it got right error is the
percentage that it got wrong and then we
simply return this dictionary and you'll
see in a moment why I'm doing this now
we take this max depth error function
which takes a max depth and then figures
out for that max depth what is the
training error and the validation error
and we run that through
this list comprehension so we try all
the max we try all possible values of
max depth from 1 to
21 and that's why it's taking a while
because we are building a decision tree
for every max depth value from 1 to 21
and we are Computing the training error
and the validation error for each of
these max depth value models and then
we're putting all those results into a
data frame so let's yeah so let's give
that a minute and then here you go so
this is what we get when you have a max
depth of one the training error is18
which means just
by which means just by selecting a max
depth of one just by making one
decision you get to a training accuracy
of about
81% and a validation accuracy of about
82% that's what it looks like and but as
you as you increase the max depth the
error goes down which means the accuracy
improves you can see here the training
error keeps increasing 187 the training
error keeps decreasing the accuracy
keeps improving so 18 17 16 15 14 13 and
it goes down all the way up to 0.09 03
so at this point we are at 99 point
Sorry at this point we are at 97%
training accuracy at a Max of 20 and of
course if we increase the max dep
further the model will be so to speak
learn or memorize more training examples
and it will get better at the training
data but notice what's happening with
the validation error so the validation
error is at17 and it goes down and it
goes down and it goes down to 0.15 and
then it starts to increase again so you
can see here from 0.15 starts to go to16
0.17.1
8.19 and if you plot this so here's
here's what it will look like if I plot
it
so here I've simply plotted the training
versus validation error the blue line is
the training error which is one minus
accuracy and the orange line is the
validation error so what's happening
here here you see both the training and
the validation laws decreasing so what's
happening here is you are making your
model progressively more
powerful which means you allowing it to
make uh one decision right now and here
you're allowing this model the model at
where max depth 2 you allow it to make
two layers of decisions and this model
with Max step four you allow it to make
four layers of decisions and so on so up
to a certain point it helps to add more
complexity or help helps to add more
power within your model right it helps
to make your model bigger but after a
certain point when once your model's
capacity gets large enough it starts to
just focus on memorizing the training
data and it stops generalizing so at
this point you see it gets better and
better at the training data and it gets
worse and worse at the validation data
and this is the scenario that is known
as overfitting okay so here is the graph
that you will see over and over and over
again in pretty much every
problem as you increase the complexity
or the size of your model as you
increase the size of your
model or the power of your model or the
capacity of your model so many different
ways of looking at it ultimately it's a
question of how many parameters are
there inside the model so as you
increase the complexity or size or power
or parameters of your model you will
notice that both the training error and
the test or validation error will go
down up to a certain point because the
model is
getting the model has more capacity so
it can learn more and it can actually
capture some information about the
inputs and the targets and how they
related but after a certain point it
will start memorizing training examples
and that is a point where your test or
your validation error will start to
increase that is a point where your
validation accuracy will start to drop
and this scenario is known as
overfitting where your training error is
is going down but your validation error
is going up if you train your model a
little more if you increase the
complexity of your model a little more
if you add one more layer to your
decision tree then the training error
goes down but the validation error
actually gets worse and this is where
you should stop training your model so
you want to stop training your model at
the point where or this is where you
want to pick the complexity of your
model so you want to pick the complexity
of your model at the point where the
validation loss is just about to
increase so here by plotting this graph
we have been able to figure out that at
at a max depth of seven we get as good
as this decision tree can
get on the validation error for the
given data set so the max depth of seven
is actually the
best depth for a decision tree so this
is how you figure out this is how you
regularize a decision tree so you
regularize a decision tree which means
to reduce overfitting by tuning some
hyper parameters so this is called a
hyper parameter max depth and just
changing its value is called tuning the
hyper parameter and by tuning this hyper
parameter we have regularized the model
a little bit we have now reduced the
amount of overfitting that it has so you
can now see that the validation score
and maybe also let me also print out the
training score
here the training score and validation
score or training accuracy and
validation accuracy both are about 84.5
84.6% so that seems like the best we can
do by modifying the max depth of the
decision tree
okay so we just looked at one hyper
parameter which is Max tree
depth and we also looked at how that
hyper parameter can be used to can we
use to regularize the
model let's look at another hyper
parameter this one is is called Max Leaf
nodes so this is another way to control
the size of the complexity of a decision
tree another way to control the
complexity of a decision tree and which
is to limit the number of leaf nodes now
whenever you have a decision tree there
are as you can see
here there are a certain number of
decision nodes and then there are a
certain number of leaf nodes now the way
we have limited the size of the decision
tree or the and the complexity or the
parameters of the decision Tree in this
case is by specifying how deep it can
get but that may not be the best way
maybe you want to allow it to go a few
layers deep here maybe you want to allow
it to go five layers deep here and you
want to allow it to just stay two layers
deep here so that's where you can
actually specify the maximum number of
leaf notes that your decision tree can
have so here's how I'm going to do that
I'm going to specify that for my
decision tree that the maximum number of
leaf not it can have is
128 and roughly speaking if you have one
one node at the top that splits into two
nodes below it that splits into four
nodes below it what we might think is
that the decision tree actually goes
layer by layer where it goes builds
layer one and then it builds layer two
and then it builds layer three but
actually what happens is it always tries
to make the best possible split so if it
is created a layer one maybe let's look
at it here so if a decision tree has
created a layer one uh it is created a
split here and then based on the split
you now have two splits left and right
now it looks at both of these and it
sees which is the better to split if
this is going to if splitting this is
going to result in a lower gen
coefficient then it splits this into two
parts by creating a split condition here
and now it's going to analyze among all
of these Leaf nodes which is the best
split to make so if it determines that
this is the best split to make then it's
going to make this split first and now
now maybe at this point it's going to
look at all these Leafs nodes and
determine which is the best split to
make so maybe at this point the next
best split to make is is this and maybe
after this the next best split to make
is this and so on so your decision tree
doesn't really go layer by layer where
it first does this and then it does
this rather it goes it looks at all the
leaf nodes and it figures out which is
the best Leaf node to split at the
moment and it splits
it now how does that tie down tie back
to Max leaf notes now here what we're
saying is we want Max Leaf nodes to be
128 and 128 I believe is 2 to the power
of
seven so if you had a decision tree
which was seven layers deep at its
lowest point it would have 128 nodes now
let's try and give the max Leaf nodes of
128 and let's see if the decision tree
actually has a depth of
seven so here we create this decision
tree we call decision tree classifier
and then we call model. fit so now we're
training and the only restriction we've
specified is that the number of leaf
nodes so number of these nodes which
have not been
split should not go higher than 128 and
that limits a certain number of
splits so now we fed the data on the
training we fed the model on the
training data and it turns out that the
training accuracy is only 84.8% and not
100% because of the same reason it
cannot go down and memorize every
training example is only a limited
number of nodes it can
create and let's check the model's
accuracy on the validation data set so
on the validation data set this time the
accuracy is
84.4% and let's check the tre's depth as
well so the depth of the tree is
12 so let's compare this 84 with what we
had the previous
time yeah with a model here we had a
model that could go to maximum depth of
and that had
84.5% validation accuracy in this case
we have
84.4% maybe if you change this a little
bit maybe if you change this to 1 130 or
140 you may find that it may actually
cross but the important thing is that
these two are different and the reason
these two accuracies are different is
because the strategy by which we are
limiting the size of the tree is
different in one case we are saying that
max depth can be seven in the other case
we saying that the maximum number of
leaf node can be 128 and the tree
actually does go down to a depth of 12
in certain places so that means certain
paths go down to a depth of 12 but
certain parts maybe are shorter certain
parts are maybe just three or four
levels deep and we can try and verify
this we can convert this model we can
get the textual representation of the
model and maybe look at just the first
few lines of that textual representation
the entire thing will get pretty long so
I've just printed the first 3,000
characters or
so so here you you can see that this is
a fairly long
path uh but then this path definitely
shorter you can see that this path is
shorter than this path this is about 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 so there are 12
checks here on the other hand here there
are maybe less than 10 checks and here
there's even fewer checks and maybe once
we go further maybe if I print more of
this you will see that there are shorter
and shorter
paths
yeah so this is this is definitely a
shorter path you can see that this is
maybe 1 2 3 4 five levels deep on the
other hand this is 6 7 8 9 9 levels deep
so sometimes you have five levels deep
sometimes you have nine levels deep and
that depends on the best split that the
decision tree was able to find so here's
an exercise for you find the combination
of max depth and Max Leaf nodes that
results in the highest validation
accuracy
okay then another exercise for you is to
experiment with the other arguments of
decision
tree psychic learn has excellent
documentation very extensive and very
helpful very easy to read as well so
just check out the documentation of
decision Tree classifier on Psychic
learn SK learn. tree. decision tree
classifier look at all of these and go
through all of these now in a lot of
these cases it will tell you exactly
what each parameter does maybe try a
different Criterion maybe try the random
split see if that help maybe try the
random um try changing the max depth we
did do some experiments but how does max
depth matter if you're working with a
random split Etc is worth figuring
out look
at there are some other par parameters
hyper parameters here that you can look
at so try and experiment with all of
these and you can see that there are
detailed explanations for each of these
and in fact in certain cases you will
find that there are links to other
resources and as I said a lot of these
are implementations of some of the best
papers in machine learning so a lot of
the best practices are given to us a lot
of the best techniques are given to us
we just have to try them out with psyit
loan another exercise for you uh is to
try out a more advanced technique for
reducing overfitting this is called cost
complexity pruning so just as we have
limited the number of loads by depth and
we have limited the number of nodes
by the number of leaf nodes there is a
way to limit the number of nodes by the
kind of split that a node performs so we
perform a split only if it satisfies
certain criteria and this is called cost
complexity pruning so you can learn more
about it here it's not a very commonly
used technique because decision trees by
themselves are almost never used in
isolation so I will not cover it here
but it's something that you can check
out psyched learn has good documentation
on it and in fact it has a example
implementation and also the link to the
paper so you can uh check this out and
try and follow the code from this
tutorial and try to implement cost
complexity pruning and see if you can
improve the validation accuracy further
okay machine learning is all about
trying different hyperparameters trying
different techniques and getting that
additional boost in the models
performance okay all right so that was a
quick introduction to decision trees now
of course we've skipped over some parts
especially the more Ma mathematical
Parts about the Gen index and the
importance calculation and things like
that but I hope you were able to get a
basic intuition of on how these splits
are created we look at all possible
features all possible splits find the
best split and the best evaluation is
done using the Genny index then we
divide the data into these two parts or
these two portions and then we identify
which is the next best split to be made
based on the leaf notes that we have and
then we make that split and then we keep
going till we either hit Leaf nodes in
which case we essentially memorize the
entire training data set or till we hit
some limits that have been artificially
imposed via some hyper parameters for
the purpose of regularization and in
general you don't want to have an
unbounded decision tree you want it to
be somewhat generalized so that's why
you want to limit its depth and you want
to maybe limit some of the other hyper
parameters as
well now while tuning the hyper
parameters of a single decision tree may
lead to some improvements a much more
effective strategy is to combine the
results of several decision trees that
are trained with slightly different
parameters and and we'll talk about
these slightly different parameters
slowly but just assume that we training
maybe a bunch of different decision
trees with a slightly different max
depth slightly different Max nodes
slightly uh different some other
parameters and then you combine the
results of several decision trees that
you've trained on the same data set that
is called a random Forest as the name
suggests a forest is simply a collection
of trees and random Forest because there
is some amount of randomization involved
here on how this Forest is created now
if you created a forest with the exact
same data set then each decision tree
would be identical so we use
randomization to make sure that all the
all the trees in the forest are slightly
different to each other and why we doing
this why are we combining the results of
several trees well the key idea here is
that each decision tree in the forest
because of all this randomization will
make different kinds of errors and upon
averaging many of those errors will
cancel out so it's a very interesting
idea and sometimes seems
counterintuitive but we let's look at a
common world real life example of this
and the real life example is commonly
known as the wisdom of the crowd now
let's say if you if if you want to
estimate
the weight of this cow here the way we
would do it one way we could do it is we
could actually measure and that would
give us the weight of the cow one other
way we could do is we could actually ask
a lot of people now it turns out that
the more people you ask the better or
the closer you get to the actual result
so if you just ask one person that one
person could be way off because they may
not be exposed to livestock at all they
may not know what um a cow is but if you
ask enough people over time you'll find
some people who are underestimating some
people who are overestimating some
people who actually know what the
information is and the average of 800
guesses this is a real experiment that
was conducted turns out to be very close
to the and this is an ox sorry so turns
out to be very close to the actual
weight of the ox right so this is an
idea that intuitively makes sense that
if you ask enough people you can get
closer to
the real answer of course that's not
100% true in all cases because humans
have biases as well but in general this
is the idea and this is the kind of the
strategy here that when we take
decisions from several decision trees
that have been trained with some amount
of randomization then the kind of errors
that they make will cancel out upon
averaging and the result that we will
get will be better than the result from
any individual decision tree okay so
let's check it
out so here's how a random Forest works
it simply takes the results of multiple
decision trees and then it averages or
combines them for example here you have
tree 1 tree 2 tree three or tree and
entries entries have been trained and
then you
take and let's say these are classifiers
so then you take all these
entries and you get the output out of
each of these entries and you simply do
a basic voting you figure out which
class is the most commonly occurring
class among these entries and you return
that as the output of the random Forest
so the random Forest is simply a
collection of all these trees that have
been trained independently and slightly
differently and the outcome of the
random Forest is simply by getting the
outcomes of all the trees and then
combining them now because we doing
classification the way you combine them
is by voting which means by picking the
most common class if it was regression
the way you would combine them is by
average
which means if each decision Tre was
predicting a continuous number you could
add them all up and get the average and
return that as the
output so to train a random Forest
classifier as you might be able to guess
by now is really easy you just import
the random Forest classifier class from
Psychic learn. emble so this is called
an ensembling technique which is the
more general term whenever you take
multiple models and they don't have to
be decision trees they don't even have
to be the same kind of model whenever
you take take multiple models and you
take the results of all those models and
combine them together to get the result
of this combined model this is called an
ensemble so let's import the random
forest classifier and let's set up a
random Forest classifier now there are a
couple of things I'm passing through the
random Forest classifier one is the nend
jobs and remember random Forest
classifier is going to have a bunch of
trees inside it and we would want to
train the trees in parall because each
tree will be trained independently uh so
when you specify n jobs equals minus1
then the random Forest classifier can
pick
up you can use different workers or
different CPU threads to train decision
trees in parallel and that just makes it
faster and you can try removing n jobs
equals minus1 and see the difference and
I'm also specifying a random state of 42
this random state will be used inside
the decision tree so this will be passed
to each decision tree to control the
randomization
there again the reason for passing a
random state is so that each time I run
this line of code or each time I try to
fit this model I get the exact same
result so we've just created the random
Forest classifier object and let's fit
it so this is where n jobs becomes
useful if you had nend jobs unspecified
it would just use one thread but right
now it is using all possible threads or
all possible workers okay so I recommend
you try out change ing removing end jobs
and running model.fit once
again all right so it took about 16
seconds to train the model and what
exactly happened here well it just
trained a whole bunch of decision
trees and now once we've trained the
model the next thing is to just score
the model so see how well it does on the
training data by calling model do score
XTR so once again it is 99 99% accurate
on the training data and that makes
sense because we have not specified any
limitations on the decision trees each
decision tree will train completely to
perfectly learn the training data set
but here's where it starts to get
interesting if you now check the
validation accuracy so if you score the
model on the validation set you get an
accuracy of
85.6% remember the first time or the
first decision tree that we trained had
a training accuracy of 99.9% and a
validation accuracy of 79 which was
barely greater than a very dumb model
which always predicted no rain but in
this case we've gotten to 85.5% accuracy
that's even higher than our
fine-tuned model so here the model that
we had created with a certain maximum
depth Etc only got to about 84.5 so
we've seen a 1%
increase simply by taking a bunch of
decision trees and averaging their
results how does that even work how does
that make sense because each decision
tree is worse than their combination
right and this is where you see the
power of
embling so this is a general technique
of combining the general technique of
combining the results of many models
this is called ensembling and the reason
it works is because errors of individual
models can cancel out when we average
the result
so visually here's what it looks like
let's say you want to create a
separation between let's say you have
two features feature one and feature two
and then you have a Target which is
shown
here as a shape so we have three Target
or three classes one is a triangle one
is a square and one is a circle now one
thing you could do is you could try and
train a tree a decision Tree on the
entire data but here's this other
approach that that has been taken so
we've taken like a 30% or 40% sample of
the data trained one decision Tree on it
then we've taken another 30 40% sample
of the data trained another decision
Tree on it and we trained another we
took another 30 40% sample of the data
and trained another decision Tree on it
and each of these decision trees is
imperfect you can see that this line
kind of cuts through it is it is missing
this triangle for example and it is
missing this all these circles and then
this one this one is
also kind of imperfect because it is
missing a few I guess it is missing
definitely a few squares and circles
here and then this one is also imperfect
so what happens is if you take if you
average out all these decision
boundaries and this is what happens you
combine all these decision
boundaries put together the Ensemble
decision boundary can be a lot more well
defined or can can be a lot more um
accurate than any individual decision
boundary
okay so that's the idea here and this is
something you have to think about for
some time and see if that intuition
makes sense to you if not let us know
and maybe we'll talk more about it over
in the next lessons or so but the idea
is that the errors cancel out and The
Ensemble or the wisdom of the crowd is
greater than the prediction of any
particular
tree and that's why we get this
validation accuracy of
85.5% now a random Forest also gives you
probabilities for the predictions the
classify in the classification case so
if we can also call model. predict proba
with X Trin and check the training
probabilities and here's what they look
like 0.9.1 9703 so now they're no longer
just ones and zeros they are actual
numbers between 0 and 1 and how does
this probability get calculated well the
probability of a class like the
probability of the class no for the
first example is simply the fraction of
the trees which predicted the given
class
no so it turns out that among all the
trees that were trained in the random
Forest 90% of the trees predicted no for
the first example the first input and
only one only 10% of the trees predicted
yes for the first example and that is
why the probability assigned to the
first example for the class no is zero
is 0.9 and that's why the
result of the random forest or the
prediction of the random forest for the
first example the first input in
xtrain is
no okay you can see here this is this is
xra so this is the first input that
we're looking at the first row of data
when that is passed
into the model we get a probability of
0.9 for no and you can verify this with
the
predictions you can see that the
prediction of the model is a no and that
is because the value is 0.9 okay so
that's how probability calcul ated in a
decision Tree in a random Forest simply
by taking the fraction that predict a
certain class all right so we said that
there are a bunch of decision trees
being trained where are those trees so
those trees can be found within within
model. estimators so if you just check
the length of model do
estimators you will see that there are
100 decision trees by default and this
is something that we can configure and
we'll talk about in a second and if you
check the first estimator estimat
underscore um so this now you can see is
a decision tree classifier great and we
can now actually plot a couple of these
trees and let's just plot them to a
depth of two so I'm plotting decision
tree number zero and I'm plotting
decision tree number
20 and it turns out that maybe let's let
me pick a different one so that I can
illustrate the difference
better okay so in decision tree number
number zero it turns out rain today is
the most important factor we looking at
rain today less than equal to.5 and then
we're looking at Cloud at 9:00 a.m. and
pressure at 3:00 p.m. but on the other
hand we have this decision tree decision
tree number 15 in this case we're
looking at sunshine and humidity and
we're also looking at rain today but
sunshine and humidity are definitely
more important which don't show up here
at all maybe humidity does but in a
different format so definitely there is
some randomization going on here not all
the decision trees are the same and we
will learn more about this as we explore
the hyper parameters of a random
Forest now one exercise for you is to
verify that none of the individual
decision trees have a better validation
accuracy than the random forest and this
is really the thing that you want to get
out of this that the combination of all
of these is better than any individual
decision tree and once you get that you
get the power of on assemble
methods now just like decision trees
random forests also assign an importance
to each feature and this is done by
combining the importance values from
Individual trees again there are
certain mathematics involved in how that
computation is done but the important
thing is that random forest skarn does
that for you and skarn gives you that
model. feature importance so you can
just check model. feature uncore
importances uncore and let's just put
that into a pandas data frame and it
looks like we have the same things
showing up here more or less so we have
humidity Sunshine pressure
Etc right so you can see the the similar
features show up here as they did in a
decision tree especially if you compare
it with the unbounded decision tree or
the decision tree with uh seven or eight
maximum depth you will see a similar set
of things here one thing that you will
notice is that the skew is a lot less
because now we are depending on a
combination of all the different trees
so we able to look at every feature and
every feature gets some importance
because it it is important in some
decision tree so you'll see a less of a
skew
here and that's how you train a random
forest and that's how you make that's
how you train and evaluate a random
Forest now you can make predictions
using a random Forest you just give it a
set of inputs and it is it'll give you a
set of outputs you can get the
probabilities and you can get the
feature importances so again this is a
model feature importance not to do with
any specific input but the model in
general values the humidity a lot and
then the sunshine and
pressure so let's talk about how to
improve random forest and this is where
random forests and decision trees are
more powerful or more versatile I would
say than some of the linear models like
logistic regression and linear
regression because in a random Forest
you can actually increase the capacity
even in a decision tree you can increase
the number of layers that you have in
the tree or you can increase the number
of trees that you have within a random
forest and we'll see some other examples
as well so based on the data that you
have based on the kind of overfitting
that you're running into the kind of
problems you're running into you can
tune your random Forest really well so
just like decision trees random forests
also have several hyperparameters in
fact many of these hyper parameters are
simply passed down to the underlying
decision trees and we look at some of
them not all of them and you can learn
more about them again on the pyit learn
documentation site excellent
documentation really well explained
really approachable so these are all
the parameters or hyper parameters that
you can set for your random forest model
and then there's a detailed description
about each
parameter and you can also check it
anytime simply by using the question
mark
here so let's create a base model which
we can compare with the tuned hyper
parameters before we tune any hyper
parameters let's just create a base
random Forest classifier let's give it
the random state of 42 and N jobs minus
one so this is something that we will
keep fixed throughout so that we know
that the results we are getting the
changes we're getting are not because of
Randomness but because of actual
hyperparameters so let's set random
state to 42 n jobs equals minus1 and
let's fit that to our training data here
and that gives us the base model and
based on that let us calculate the base
training the training accuracy and the
validation accuracy of the base model so
we've not done anything yet this is just
a Bas line that we are setting up for
ourselves for our
comparison so in the base model as we
already saw earlier we have 99.9%
training accuracy and we have 85.5 n%
validation
accuracy now the first thing we look at
is n estimators this is the first hyper
parameter that we look at and this
argument controls the number of decision
trees in the random Forest now we know
that if you have just one decision tree
that's just going to overfit to the data
very badly and this is one of those
parameters where as you increase the
number of estimators you increase the
randomness within the data and just a
general rule for you to keep in mind is
Randomness
increases Randomness helps reduce
overfitting the more Randomness you
the more Randomness you bring in into
your
model the less overfitting you will
have so the default value is 100 and one
thing that you can try is you can simply
experiment with other values for example
here is an estimate with here is a model
with
10 estimators or 10 decision trees so 10
decision trees obviously train a bit
faster but here with train decision
trees it turns out that you get to a
training accuracy of 98.7% not really
99.99 and you get to a validation
accuracy of
84.4% so that's not too far from 99.99
and
8559 although I think this this is a
little bit low so it seems like you do
need to increase your number of
estimators to a certain value a small
number of estimators will not will
probably not give you a very good result
so here we have 500 estimators we've
gone from 100 which is a default to 500
and that's going to take a minute or so
to train because it's five times as many
estimators or decision trees okay maybe
I should have tried a smaller
number but the general rule about number
of estimators
is as as a general rule try to have as
few estimators as needed so if you can
do the job with 100 and if going from
100 to 200 is not really helping it's
not really increasing your um accuracy
or whatever your loss is whatever your
metric is
meaningfully then stay with 100 if you
think that going from 100 to 200 is
giving you a reasonable increase then go
to 200 and a good way to try estimators
is by just doubling them so the default
is 100 one thing you can quickly try out
is changing that to 200 and see if that
helps and then try changing that to 400
see if that still helps try changing
that to 800 see if that still helps at
some point the benefit that you get by
doubling is going to be too small and
the cost of how long it takes to train
the model is going to be too high like
with 500 so it's it turns out that when
I do 500 I get to
85.7% so that's a 2% increase or 857 so
there a 2% increase in accuracy from
85.5 n well that's less than 02 that's
about
.13 now do I care enough about. 1%
accuracy improvements if I do then and
in some cases you might in some cases
that may mean something for example if
it is some kind of a financial model um
then maybe that .1% can make you more
money or it can improve your estimation
of the risk so in that case you should
maybe get it and if you also have the
hardware to spare you don't mind
training 500 estimators do it but if you
don't really care if you're more
concerned about 85 versus 90 then I
wouldn't bother with it too much if I'm
just getting
A.1 3% increase by using five times more
decision trees so there's uh sort of a
diminishing returns here for the number
of estimators okay but one thing I'll
tell you is when you have really large
data sets data sets with millions of
rows of data then you will have to go
with 100 sometimes maybe a th000
estimators that's not very
uncommon
the default in psychic learn used to be
10 estimators and that was recently
bumped a few years ago to 100 estimators
because the data sets have started to
get much
larger so here's an exercise for you
vary the value of N estimators and the
way you can vary It Is by simply
doubling it each time and plot the graph
between training error and validation
error and try to figure out what the
optimal value of n estimators is now n
estimators is unique in the sense that
it does not really add complexity to the
model because it's bringing more
Randomness and ultimately you're
averaging results from each decision
tree so a tree by itself is not getting
bigger so complexity is not really
increasing but at the same time it is
bringing some Randomness so you can keep
increasing n estimators to a fairly
large
value without worrying about overfitting
on the data unlike some other hyper
parameters like max depth and Max Leaf
nodes so you have max depth a Max depth
is passed directly to the decision tree
similarly Max Leaf nodes is passed
directly to the decision tree so we've
seen both of these in context of the
decision trees already now when you pass
max depth or Max Leaf nodes to a random
Forest that is going to get applied to
every single decision tree it is
training now by default no maximum depth
is specified which is why every tree has
a training accuracy of close to 100% on
the training data
and you can specify Max step through
reduce overfitting so if you feel that
your or if You observe that your random
forest model is overfitting which means
that the training error is going down
but the test error is going up then
specifying a max depth may be a way to
limit the complexity of the model and
get to a better position so let's try
that out so what we want to do is we
want to try out a random forest with a
certain max depth and maybe we want to
try two or three values now because this
is getting a bit repetitive what I've
done is I've written a simple function
called test params which takes a bunch
of
params and it simply passes those
parameters to a random forest and then
it fits that random Forest on the
training data and then it Returns the
score here uh it Returns the score of
the model on the training data and the
validation data okay what's the star
star well when you call test params you
can call it like this you can call max
depth equal to 5 and Max Leaf
nodes equals 1024 and maybe you can also
specify n
estimators equals 1,000 so when you call
test params with multiple arguments it's
going to take all of these arguments so
star star params is going to capture all
of these
arguments and then it's going to pass
all of these arguments with those same
names to the random Forest classifier so
it's going to pass max depth equals 5 to
random Forest classifier Max Leaf equals
Max Leaf notes equals uh 1024 to um the
random Forest classifier n estimator is
equals th000 to the random Forest
classifier okay so this is some special
python syntax if you want to look it up
this is called star star quarks so you
can just search python
function
quarks to learn more about it okay but
all of this business is simply to just
simplify
testing so if I call test params with
max depth 5 that's going to train a
random Forest that's going to set up a
random forest classifier with random
State 42 n jobs minus one and max depth
5 and fit that to the training data and
give us the training and validation laws
so let's test max depth 5 and the
default remember is no max depth so
unbounded max depth so at a max depth
five we have severely limited the
capacity of the model and that's why it
falls down to about 82%
accuracy but on the other hand when we
set a max depth of 26 and let's just
give that a second to run you will see
that our accuracy has actually increased
to 85.7% so if you see the base accuracy
that we had here the base accuracy was
85.
59 and that has increased to
85.7 so there that's a significant
increase that's a 0.1% increase and all
we've done is we've reduced the depth of
the tree so it actually takes less time
to for the tree to
train all right and similarly here are
some experiments with Max Leaf nodes
with the max Leaf nodes here I've set it
to 2 to the^ of 5 which means 32 so if
we have a maximum of 32 Leaf nodes we
can only get to about 83.2% accuracy but
if we have a if we allow 2 to the^ of 20
which means that's I believe that is
2048 oh no that 2 to ^ of 20 is a lot of
nodes that's about uh a million nodes I
guess y a leaf nodes
but in any case the tree itself is not
going to ever get that large so we
shouldn't worry about it because the
tree only goes to a depth of about 40 or
45 so anyway when you have unbounded Max
Leaf notes you get to about
85.6% I guess there is still a bound
here
probably and here you have the base so
this is without any of the hyper
parameters you see there are certain
differences here you have 85.5 n% here
you have 85.6 5% here you have
85.7% and maybe there is a combination
of max depth and Max Leaf
nodes that can give you a good result so
it's worth figuring out right so it's
worth trying out different values of Max
Leaf nodes and Max depth and the thing
to remember is that the optimal value is
somewhere in between if it's too low
then your model is not powerful enough
if it is too high then the model is too
powerful and it has me it started to
memorize and overfit on the training
data so it's somewhere in between and
your job as the machine learning
practitioner is to figure out what that
sweet spot is and the way to do that is
by trying multiple values one thing you
could do is you could try maybe
increments of five increments of 10 or
maybe increments of just doubling uh the
max depth and Max size okay as we did
above for the decision tree you can do
the exact same you can you can vary the
value of max depth plot the graph
between training error and validation
error and figure out the optimal value
of max depth that way and then do the
same for Max leave and then try to
combine the two and see if that helps
you in any
way next up we have Max features now
instead of picking all the features for
every split
so instead of using and we have a bunch
of features right we have let's call X
train and let's check the
columns so we have 119 columns now
instead of using all 119 columns for
every single
split we can specify that only a
fraction of the features should be
chosen randomly to figure out a split so
here's what I mean by
that you have your data set here
with a bunch of features so this is your
data set let's let's say this is your
data frame and in your data frame you
have a bunch of
columns now typically when a decision
tree is
created you look at all the columns so
you check this column find the best
split you check this column this column
this column this column this you check
every column and for each column you
check all possible splits you check this
split this split this split this split
this split all of these and you pick the
best split and that's how you decide
now the trouble with random Forest is if
you are training two decision trees and
you're using this exact same logic of
checking all the columns and then
checking all possible splits then this
split let's say this is a greater than 7
and this split are going to be the same
now if the two splits are the same then
it's likely that these next splits are
also going to be the same and then it's
likely that the next splits are also
going to be the same so you're not
really training multiple decision trees
you're just training 100 copies of the
same decision tree so you're not really
gaining from that Randomness and
averaging out of Errors so what you do
instead is you specify that for my first
decision or for the first split that is
being done I randomly pick a fraction of
the columns so I pick a fraction now
this fraction is going to be maybe I
pick this column I pick this column I
pick this column and I pick this column
so I pick a random selection of columns
and then for those columns I try all the
different splits and maybe after trying
those splits I figure out that maybe
this column is the best so if this
column is the best then here I'm
checking for C and the next time I do a
split I random I randomly pick a certain
fraction of columns maybe I pick this
pick this and pick this and based on
that perform a split and then similarly
there's another decision tree being
trained in parallel in another thread
now here also you're picking a random
column so you're you're picking random
selection of column maybe you're picking
this this and this so what this does is
each split whether it is in the same
tree or across different trees each
split is randomized because it uses only
a certain fraction of
columns
now this is again a bit counterintuitive
that using a fraction of the columns
doing randomized splits is better than
doing single splits uh better better
than doing perfect splits where you look
at all possible columns and all possible
splits because your objective is not to
fit and memorize the training set your
objective is to generalize so your
objective is to learn General Trends and
the way you learn General Trends is by
dropping random information here and
there while training right you're
skipping some of the columns and that
helps you that forces you to learn some
general Trends rather than specific
relationships or specific values within
specific
columns so here are the values that you
can specify for Max features you can
specify Auto sqrt log 2
or you can specify an integer or you can
specify a float now the interesting
thing is by default the value is Auto
and what does Auto do so when you
specify Auto or you don't specify
anything in a random Forest by default
it picks the square root of the number
of features so how many features do we
have here we have 119 features the
square root of that is around 11 so
every decision tree or every split only
looks at 11 features every split does
not look at 19 features by default and
that is how each decision tree in the
forest is different so remember we
mentioned there is some Randomness so
this is that
Randomness each decision tree in the
forest is different and while it may
seem counterintuitive choosing all
features for every split of every tree
will just lead to identical trees so
this will overfit badly to the training
set the entire random Forest will
basically become just copies of the same
tree and will not generalize well so if
you don't want to go so aggressive as
square root you can probably you can
specify an actual number let's say you
want to pick
exactly 10 features or you want to pick
exactly 20 features each time or you can
specify a fraction let's say you want to
pick maybe 30% of the features for each
split or you can also specify a
logarithm a log to the base two which is
also another way to just these are all
different ways of just specifying what
fraction of features to pick now
remember the overfitting
curve this comes in here as as well if
you picked two few features then your
model will not be powerful enough
because it is really let's say if you
just allow it to pick one feature
randomly then it's not really learning
it's just having to pick a pick a
feature and make a split on that feature
so you are going to end up in this space
but if you allow it to pick all the
features then you're going to end up in
this space so somewhere in between is a
sweet spot and through practice again
this this must be the result of some
paper which is looked at all possible
splits and through in practice they may
have found that square root is a
good percentage of features to pick not
to mean that this is the best for every
data set but in general it's a good
percentage of features to pick as a
default but you should experiment with
this because for your data set it may be
different so here I'm just going to call
test parameters with Max features log
two so this is going to take log to the
base two of 112 119 which is
about
seven I believe so it will take seven
features and then I'm also manually
testing three features six features and
maybe I can even try something like 3 so
if I specify an integer it's going to
pick exactly that many features I
specify a fraction between 0 and 1 it's
going to pick that percentage of
features and remember by features we
mean
columns so we looking at six columns for
every split randomly picked six columns
and here we looking at three columns for
every split and here we have the base
accuracy which is
I believe this was
8559 okay so turns out with the base
accuracy we're looking at about 11
features so it turns out among these the
base accuracy is the best but now what
you can try is maybe try 20 here and see
if 20 gives you a better accuracy than
the base accuracy so I hope 20 should
probably give us something better but I
don't know I don't know and that's why
there's no real way of telling other
than by actually looking at the data
whether the default is good enough or
whether you need to be left or right of
the
default so once again find the optimal
values of Max features on this data set
by varying it and you can varying it you
can vary it in steps maybe you can
double it 2 4 8 16
32 yeah so it does H so it does work
when you increase Max features to 20
from square root of 119 which is about
11 so if we say that we look at 20
features each time we get to 85.7 5%
accuracy rather than 85.5 N I think 0.15
is a reasonable increase uh seems like I
don't think we're going to get to 90
anytime soon so seems like yeah it's a
reasonable increase to
have all right let's look at a few more
and then we will wrap up here but I I
hope you're starting to see the trend
here you want to understand what each
hyperparameter does and then you want to
understand how it fits on the
overfitting curve and then you want to
experiment and figure out the right
piece where that hyper perameter needs
to be used at okay so I'm going to test
a couple more one is called the Min
sample split and the other is called the
Min samples Leaf so by default the
unless you have other parameters like
max depth Etc the decision tree
classifier tries to split every node
that has two or
more rows of data inside it so for
example here we have the entire data set
and when we do a split maybe 30% of rows
go here and maybe 70% of rows go here
and then we do a split again so some
percentage of rows some like n rows go
here and N Prime rows go here and so on
but as you keep
going by default the decision tree will
keep splitting till we get to Leaf nodes
with just a single row of data inside it
and maybe this must be two okay or if it
is three then this will get to two and
then this will get to one and one so
you'll by default it goes to that step
what you can do to regularize the tree
to reduce the complexity of the tree
again this is another way of going about
it is to say that a node should be split
only if it has greater than seven rows
so if a node has less than seven rows
don't split it that's one thing uh we
can say the other thing you can say is
that when a node is
split then two leaves are created right
now if these leaves are one and six you
can specify a minimum Leaf size you can
say that the minimum Leaf size is three
so a leaf will get created only or this
division will this split will be
performed only when the leaves have a
size greater than three okay so that's
why these are two very connected things
this is one is the size to minimum size
for splitting a node that even a split
will be considered and second the
minimum size for a leaf node that is
created when you split a node both of
these you can specify so by default you
split a
node which has two or more rows of data
and by default the default the minimum
Leaf size is one so that's just going
out maximum overfitting as much as
possible but let's change that let's
maybe change the minimum samples split
to three and the minimum samples leave
to two so a node will be split only if
there are at least
three only if there are at least well
that doesn't really make sense let me
make that five so the node will be split
only if there are five rows of data
inside it and a leaf a node will be
split only if the leaves created have at
least two no two rows of data each so
here it turns out that using a sample
split of 5A 2 gives you
85.5% accuracy 8556 so that's a
reduction and if you increase the size
if you increase the main sample size
that means you're saying saying that
nodes must be larger and larger so you
are reducing the power of the tree
because what you're essentially saying
is that I'm not allowed to have a node
of size two I'm not allowed to have a
node of size three not allowed to have a
no node of size five I must have a node
of size 100 so here I've set the Min
sample split to 100 so nodes will not be
split if they have less than 100 rows
and here I've said the mean sample
leaves to 60 nodes will not be split if
the leaves that they create are not of
size 60 so that definitely reduces the
power of the model and because of
that we could end up in this situation
here right so now what happens is a very
high value for the node size or the
split size is going to put you in the
low power space the low complexity space
a very low value or a zero value or the
default values put you in this space so
somewhere in between maybe around let's
say a split size of 10 and a no size of
three or something like that is the best
fit so that is again something that you
have to
explore
okay so that's about Min sample split
and Min Min samples
leave next up just a couple
more and then we're done one is the Min
impurity decrease so here's yet another
way of controlling the split
now consider a point in the
decision tree so you have a point in the
decision tree here and this has a
certain geni value right based on the
most optimal split let's say this has a
geni value of
7 and then when you split it you get two
nodes and those nodes have geni values
of 68 and
69 so there's not really been a
significant reduction in the geni value
right because this was 7 and this is 68
and 69 if the most optimal split only
leads to a negligible reduction in geni
value then maybe this split is
completely useless it's just adding more
complexity to the model it just causing
overfitting so what you can specify is
that nodes should be split only when the
decrease in the impurity is higher than
a certain value so I can specify that a
node should be split only when the
decrease in the Gen value which means
from 0.9 to 68 is higher than 0.1 now
0.1 is a very high value I should
probably use something much lower but
just to give you an example so this node
will be split only when the geni value
goes from 7 to 6 or lower for each
node right so that's
the that's the value that's the purpose
of Min impurity decrees and once again
by default it is zero so by default
whatever minimum or even zero reduction
in the Gen value will allow creating
multiple nodes will allow
splitting but if you you want to control
it then we pass some a value like
this okay now once again where does this
lie on the overfitting curve everywhere
you see hyper parameters you should
start thinking about the overfitting
curve geni value U minimum threshold of
zero which means that we can split
without having to worry about how much
reduction in error in in the genie index
there was that is maximum complexity on
the other hand a very high value for the
threshold that if you say that point one
a geni value of a gen deduction of 0.1
is required for a split that makes
splits very hard so that puts you in the
low complexity zone so somewhere in
between you have the value of uh which
is the optimal for getting the maximum
validation accuracy right remember
that's our goal maximum validation
accuracy now here I recommend trying out
powers of 10 10 Theus 7 10 the- 6 10us 5
and so on and I found here for example
we went I think I found with 10- 6 or
something I found uh the best
reduction yeah with 10- 6 was where I
saw the best uh value so somewhere
between 0 and 1 or 0 and 0.1 as you go
with powers of 10 you will find the best
Min impurity decrease where you have the
maximum increase in the valid where you
have the maximum validation accuracy
yeah you can see here when we set the
Min impurity decrease to one e- 6 so
that's
85.6% validation accuracy versus 80 85.5
9 all right last two one is called this
one is called bootstrap and Max samples
so one trick that I told you about
random forest is by picking a random
selection of
features that's good but one and that
picks just a random selection of columns
another trick that random forests apply
is not to use the entire data set for
training each decision tree instead it
applies a technique called
bootstrapping and here's how
bootstrapping
Works let's say you have a training data
set so here we have a data set with a
whole bunch of
rows Row one row two Row three row four
row five row six typically to train a
decision
tree and there are columns as well so
typically to train a decision tree you
would take this entire data set and you
would feed it into the decision tree
algorithm and that would figure out the
optimal split etc etc bootstrapping
Works in a slightly different way now
let's say you have what's this let's say
you have 10
rows the way bootstrapping works is you
randomly pick one of the 10 rows let's
say you pick this and then you copy it
here of course it's only a conceptual
copy I'm not saying that an actual copy
is created then you forget that you
picked this row and then once again you
randomly pick a row and maybe this time
you got this and then you copy it
here then you forget that you picked
these two rows and then you randomly
pick one another row and you get another
row fine then you again you forget that
you picked any rows and then you
randomly pick and it turns out maybe you
pick this one again and that's fine so
this
row this row will now come up here again
so now you'll have two copies of this
Row in this is called a bootstrap so
this is called random picking with
replacement so you pick a row but then
you don't keep track of the fact that
you've picked it already and you allow
yourself to pick it again what this does
is a couple of
things why now you can see by the end of
this process that by the time that I
have 10 rows maybe two of these rows got
got picked twice and then some of these
rows got picked once and then some of
these row did not get
picked and then this is going to you be
used to train a decision tree so one
bootstrap is used to train one decision
tree and what this does is different
bootstraps will drop different rows so
each decision tree will only be trained
with on a particular fraction of the
data rather than the entire data because
even though we are picking 10 rows we
are picking with replacement so we are
missing certain rows po potentially and
second we also randomly assign like a
double weight or a triple weight to rows
when they get a pig twice right any like
initially every row has equal weightage
but what we saying is for certain
decision trees we are assigning a higher
weight to certain rows because we are
picking them twice or Thrice in the data
set right and again this is happening
randomly and this is happening for 100
or hundreds of decision trees and that's
where all this Randomness actually helps
again this is one of these techniques
that has been tested empirically and has
been shown to work well papers have been
written on it and the authors of psychic
learn have very kindly made that the
default with within random forests so by
default bootstrap is set to true and if
you set bootstrap to false what will
happen is every decision tree will be
trained using the entire data set with
just one copy of each row now I'll let
you decide which has better Randomness
and I'll let you decide which will
generalize better
okay so that's
your
bootstrap and this entire system of
picking a bootstrap training a decision
tree picking another bootstrap training
another decision tree picking another
bootstrap training decision tree this is
called a bag of bootstraps so this is
also sometimes called bagging and one
thing that you can also do is you can
also control the size of each bootstrap
now here what I said was you have 10
rows of data and you keep picking
randomly with replacement till you get
10 rows even if they may have copies but
you can actually decide that maybe you
just want to pick seven rows with random
replacement so that's called the bag of
midle bootstraps where you don't use the
entire data set but you
train a decision tree or maybe you you
just want to pick a 20% uh fraction so
you train using bootstrapping and you
train uh and you only pick samples of a
certain
size so for example and here by the way
without bootstrapping you can see that
the accuracy is about the same in this
case it did not make a big difference
but maybe in certain other data sets you
will see it's different but what you can
do is you can pick you can specify when
bootstrapping is set to true that you
want to pick only a certain number of
samples or only a certain fraction of
samples so instead of picking a
bootstrap of size 98,000 which is the
size of the uh training set maybe you
want to pick a bootstrap of just 90% of
the rows right so you you pick just I
don't know about 89 80 89 or 90,000 rows
not 98,000 and you pick them with
replacement using the bootstrapping
technique and again that will help you
that will that will help you by reducing
overfitting if each decision tree is
being trained on a smaller fraction then
there is more randomization across trees
so then there is more uh gen then there
is more
generalization and you can see here we
got to 85.6 5 from 85.5 n so that's a
small increase once again on the
overfitting curve if Max samples is set
to one uh which means you're picking as
many as possible then you are on the
high complexity side uh then you in the
overfitting side if Max samples is set
to 0 or 0.01 or something like that
where you're only putting picking one%
of the rows for each decision tree then
each decision tree is very weak very
less powerful so that's going to be on
the low power side so somewhere in
between is where you'll have the optimal
value
okay the last one and this is slightly
tangential but the last one is class
weight now one of the things we have in
our data set especially is this
particular data set especially if you
look at the
targets and you check the value
counts let's call that train
targets and you check the value counts
you have
76,000 Nos and just 22,000
yeses and that's bad and if you if you
divide this by the length so length
of train
targets so 77% or 7
77.8% Nos and only 22% yeses so there
there aren't many yeses here and maybe
you want to give higher weight higher
weightage to the rows which have yes
right simply because you have a very low
number of rows with that particular
weight so you want to give that weight
you want to with that particular class
so you want to give give rows with that
class A Higher weightage you want your
decision tree to consider them twice as
important or three times as important or
four times as
important in your calculation so you can
do that and the way you do that is by
specifying a class weight when you
create the random Forest so when you
create the random Forest you specify a
class weight and you can either give
like a proper class weight to each one
so you can say for the no class we set a
weight of one so each row of the no
class will have a weight of one and each
row of the yes class will have a weight
of two and that is going to be used
somehow in the Genny calculation and
somehow in the splitting but the the
underlying concept is that more
weightage will be given to uh the class
yes so you can specify that and you can
compare that with the base which is to
give equal weightage to every class or
equal weightage to every row no matter
what or you can also specify a term like
this balanced so if you specify balanced
and you can check out the documentation
here psychic learn will automatically
figure out that okay you have four times
as many NOS than you have yeses so maybe
I'm or three times as many so maybe I'm
going to apply a weight of three so the
inverse ratio is going to get applied as
the weight of that particular class so
yes is going to get a weight of three or
3.5 and no is going to have a weight of
one right uh that may not be ideal you
may not want to give so so high a weight
uh so probably something in this range
might work best for you where you
manually give a slightly higher weight
to the class which which is under
represented and you can see here we go
from 85.5 n to 85.6 5 simply by applying
a class weight to yes
okay and once again with class weights
there is an optimal value somewhere it's
not 1 one is not optimal and 14 is not
optimal you can see that this actually
led to a reduction maybe somewhere
around 1 12 is optimal for this
particular balance and this is the
central theme in machine learning you
will have high hyper parameters one end
of the hyper parameter will lead to a
very bad result for training and
validation because it just is going to
reduce the power of the
model and the other end of the hyper
parameter is going to lead to a very low
training loss or training error but a
very high validation error because it's
going to overfit it's going to be really
powerful okay and your job will always
be to kind of find the central find the
middle path find the optimal fit for the
data so that the model learns enough but
it does not overfit to the training data
and normally you will be modifying all
of these things together so you would
set up something like this you would set
up a model here you have a random forest
classifier and you would set up maybe
the number of estimators the number of
features the depth the class the weight
you will try some experiments and you
will figure out which direction you need
to go in if you change and there's no
single way to just look at the number
and tell whether you should increase or
decrease this what you should be looking
at is what happens when you increase
this and what happens when you decrease
this and that will help you decide
whether you are in this region so if we
look at the overfitting chart remember
this is how the training loss goes and
this is how the validation loss goes so
you want to figure out whether you in
this region or you're in this region now
if you're in this region then you can
increase the complexity of the model to
get to the optimal fit because there's
still a possible reduction in the
validation loss and if you're in this
region then you need to reduce the
complexity of the
model because your validation loss can
actually be lower by with a less complex
model because your model is overfitting
okay so let's try an example here and
then you can play around with this so
apply this exactly this technique have
the overfitting curve in your head as
you work through this and let's see if
after applying all of these random
forest all of these hyper parameters do
we actually get anything useful out of
it okay now I have picked here 500
estimators and seven features a maximum
seven features maybe I should change
that to 20 a maximum depth of 30 and
class weights of 1 comma
1.5 so this is in this is bringing some
regularization for sure this is also
this is probably increasing the power
because Max features by default is log n
and this is again probably bringing some
regularization uh well I guess this is
increasing the power of the model as
well so you have to now think about
which lies in which uh area right and
one exercise for you is to try and
modify all of these and see what is the
best accuracy that you can get to so
play around with these
hyperparameters let's give that a second
I think this gets to about an
85.7% accuracy
finally yeah just scoring the data
now
okay 85.6 one I guess in my previous run
with certain changes in hyper parameters
I got to about 85.7% accuracy maybe I'm
just going to run this
again but we increased the accuracy from
84.5% with a single decision Tree Fine
tuned to 85.7% with a well tuned random
Forest now depending on the kind of data
set and the kind of problem you may or
may not find this valuable and you may
or may not find the significant or you
may not or you may or may not even see a
significant improvement with your
hyperparameter
tuning so uh it's not that if you tune
the right hyper parameters you will get
100% accuracy 100% validation accuracy
that's almost never going to
happen and this could be due to one of
the following reasons and this is the
order in which you should try to explain
what's happening when your model is not
improving the first thing is simp simply
that you may not have found the right
mix of hyper parameters maybe some of
your hyper parameters are still on the
low complexity side and some of your
hyper parameters are on the high
complexity side uh some are overfitting
some are underfitting which is the
opposite of overfitting so you need to
bring all hyper parameters into the
right range and so you need to maybe
keep trying to improve the
model that's one possible region that's
one possible uh reason why your
validation loss is not increasing the
second possible reason is that you you
may have reached the limits of the
modeling technique that you're currently
using which is random Forest it's just
as logistic regression has a limitation
that any any nonlinear relationships it
will not be able to
capture similarly random Forest also
have certain limitations
primarily because we are using decision
trees and we are using uh averaging
between decision trees it's possible
that certain types of relationships
cannot get captured for example
um in a decision tree you're always
making a binary decision so if let's say
you have a very simple model where the
target is simply a
linear multiple of one of the features
your decision tree will have to create a
huge we'll have to create a huge tree
because your decision tree cannot
capture these proportional relationships
which is Target is 10 times of a certain
feature that that kind of relation does
not get captured so modeling random
Forest may not work well in such a case
okay so when you have linearity linear
models work well
and and tree based models may not work
well and when you do not have linearity
then tree based models are likely to
work
well here's so we're kind of peeling
back so the the most immediate problem
may be hyper parameters but when you've
tried and tried and figured out the
hyper parameters are not the problem
then maybe the next most immediate
problem is a modeling technique and
maybe then you should try a a different
modeling technique and then it's
possible that maybe you've simply
reached some limits of what you can
predict using the given amount of data
and we may need more data to improve the
model so think about it we have data for
10 years if we had data for 1 years
would your model be better or worse I
think it would be worse because we have
less data and if we had data for 20
years or 100 years would your model be
better or worse I think it would be
better so whenever you get more data
it's possible to train better and better
models so at some point you're going to
reach the limits of what you can predict
using the given amount of
data that's one
possibility but beyond that another
possibility is let's say you've gathered
as much data as possible and you're
still not seeing an improvement then you
may have reached the limit of how well
we can predict whether it will rain
tomorrow given just the using just the
given weather measurements like we have
only 20 columns there are and these 20
columns are arbitrary measure weather
measurements that we have invented there
is no physical law that states that the
rain tomorrow depends on just these 20
columns and can be predicted accurately
so maybe we need more features maybe we
need to take more measurements maybe we
need to take more accurate measurements
to further improve the model maybe we
need to take the rain not just in the
particular region but maybe we need to
consider rain within a larger radius
maybe we need to consider winds within a
larger radius maybe we need to consider
ocean temperature etc etc so in many
cases adding new features or adding new
columns to the model definitely helps
with modeling and in a lot of cases we
can also generate new features using
existing features this is called feature
engineering and we will look at feature
engineering briefly the next time so
adding new features can help and finally
it's possible that rain tomorrow may be
an inherently random or chaotic
phenomenon which simply cannot be
predicted Beyond a certain accuracy it's
possible that that maybe you cannot
predict whether it will rain
tomorrow given any amount of data for
any number of other measurements with
any modeling technique Beyond 90%
accuracy it's just not possible and
that's why we have our validation sets
and our test sets to remind us of the
reality that um it's not all about just
a training data you have to make
predictions in the real world and your
models will fail after a certain point
right so what you want to take away from
this is that ultim Ely all models are
wrong but some models are useful if you
can rely on a Model that we created
today to make a travel decision for
tomorrow or maybe if Airline Airlines
can rely on this model to decide on
whether or not they should fly tomorrow
or how many flights they should schedule
tomorrow and if that saves them money
then the model is useful even if the
even if sometimes it may be wrong even
if one out of 10 times it is wrong on
the other hand if you cannot Rel on in
this model then it's practically useless
right so ultimately all models come down
to their practical utility so whenever
you ask what is a good accuracy or what
is a good model or what is is this good
enough the question is you should be
asking what is the purpose we are
looking to use it for and in its current
state is this model good enough to be
used okay so that's just something for
you to think about uh just more
generally as a bigger picture of machine
learning okay so that's all we have for
today and finally one last thing you
should do is you should also compute the
accuracy of the model on the test set
and now you'll see what I'm talking
about when I say train validation and
test set split remember on the
validation set we got to
85.6% well what's happened is that we
have been manually testing so many
different models and we may have
overfitted our choice of
hyperparameters to the validation set
right so think of yourself as a machine
learning algorithm that's picking the
right hyper parameters and you are now
overfitted to the validation set so the
test set is there to give you the human
the reality check that maybe you
shouldn't be trying to optim over
optimize the validation set maybe you
should just do a more principle thinking
about what Will generalize a model
better and just choose that okay so
that's why you have a test set at the
very end which you should just use at
the very end to report the final
accuracy of your model okay and then
just like last time you can make
predictions on the model so you can do
that that here's an input and then you
can we've written a helper function here
to generate a prediction on the and we
get like a 77% probability that it's
going to rain tomorrow given these
inputs okay and you can save and load
the model so you can take the model and
the imputer and the scaler and the input
columns Target columns Etc save it into
a joob file load it back and it should
work exactly the same
way so that's all we have for today we
looked at how to download a real world
data set we looked at how to prepare a
data set for training we looked at how
to train and interpret decision trees we
looked at how to interpret random
forests we and train them we looked at
overfitting hyperparameter tuning and
regularization one of the most Central
problems in machine learning that you
will spend most of your time breaking
your head over making predictions on
single inputs is something that we
looked at the last time and this time as
well it's pretty straightforward you
just set up a function to do that and
then we also introduced a bunch of
different terms so you should start
becoming familiar with these terms
because you will see them in tutorials
that you see online you will see you
will probably get asked these terms in
interviews and try to get a good
intuitive understanding and maybe come
up with your own on line description
here and that's more important than any
description than we can give you so
definitely try and write a on line
description for these and if you want to
check out some of these resources you
can check these out decision trees and
random Forest can be used not just for
classification but also for regression
problems for example predicting the
price of a house so here are some
examples that you can check
out the topic for today is how to
approach machine learning projects and
we are going to look at a stepbystep
process that you can apply for
approaching ml problems all the way from
conceptualizing and identifying a
problem to performing data cleaning
preparation then building some baseline
models doing some model training an
evaluation then maybe regularizing your
models and Performing some ensembling
and finally interpreting and presenting
your results so this is roughly what the
process looks
like and here are the steps in a little
more detail so the first step is to
understand the business requirements
because machine learning models are
always used to serve some business
requirement and understand the nature of
available
data which tells you how how good your
model can possibly be or whether it is
possible to even build a model at all
the second is to then classify the
problem as a supervised learning problem
or an unsupervised learning problem and
so far we've only been looking at
supervised
learning but we will talk about a couple
of examples of unsupervised learning as
well and if it is supervised then
whether it is a regression problem or a
classification
problem next you need to download Clean
EXP exp the data and possibly create new
features that may improve models so this
process is called feature engineering
where the data may not be in a format
that makes it very easy for the model to
learn from it so we will look at some
ways of doing feature
engineering next you create a training
test validation split and prepare the
data for training machine learning
models so this covers things like
imputing missing
data scaling the data and encoding
categorical data the next step is to
create a quick and easy Baseline model
to evaluate and Benchmark future models
uh this is a very important step in any
large machine learning project you want
to know what the Baseline is so that you
don't waste your time on models that are
not any better than a very simple
approach that you can take
somewhere next you pick a certain
modeling strategy train a model tune
hyperparameters and try to achieve the
optimal fit for that modeling strategy
and then you repeat that with the
different strategies so this way you can
try a bunch of different modeling
strategies and figure out which one
works best for the
problem next you experiment and combine
results from multiple strategies if
possible to get a better result you may
also have to do some
regularization some hyperparameter
tuning and finally you need to interpret
the model study individual predictions
and present your
[Music]
findings and that's the most important
piece because ultimately your model is
going to be used for making individual
predictions
and you will have to explain why your
model gives the result that it gives and
you will have to present all of this to
non technical stakeholders so we'll talk
a little bit about that too okay now we
are running this code on Google collab
but you can also run it on your computer
locally just follow these
instructions so first let's install the
required libraries and import them as
well so we are using numpy for numerical
Computing pandas for working with data
frames mat plotti plotly and cbon for
visualization and we have the Jovian
library for recording snapshots of this
notebook then we have the open data sets
library for downloading data and psyit
learn contains all our machine learning
algorithms and let's import all of them
too and we are also setting certain
styles for the graph so that our graphs
look
nicer now let's talk about step
one the first step is to understand
business requirements and study the
nature of the data most machine learning
models are trained to serve a real world
use case so it's very important that you
understand why you're building a model
what the objectives are and the nature
of the data you have available before
you start building a machine learning
model and the best way to do this is by
asking questions so you want to start
out by understanding the big picture
about why a company cares about a
machine learning problem or why
somebody's asking you to build a machine
learning
model and figure out if if an ml model
is even required in the first place or
maybe you can do something simpler and
more effective
okay so typically you either given some
data along with some documentation and
maybe a problem statement or you have to
talk to somebody so you have to discuss
something with stakeholders and figure
things out in either case whether you
have written descriptions and written
requirements or whether you have whether
you're talking to somebody you should
try and ask some of these questions for
example
what is the business problem that you're
trying to solve using machine
learning and we look at a few examples
here but uh we look at a couple of data
sets and we'll ask the questions in that
context but for example it could be
increase sales of a particular product
that could be a business problem it
could be to reduce churn so reduce the
number of people leaving your service or
your subscription service it could be to
increase conversion of some kind so the
number of of people who come on a page
you want them to more of them to buy a
certain
thing it could be forecasting of some
kind where you're trying to forecast a
value in the future for example whether
or not it will rain tomorrow or what the
sales in a particular location of your
business are going are going to be so
you need to ask what the business
problem that you're trying to solve is
and if you if you don't know what that
problem is then you may not be aligned
and you may not really be able to create
the best model for the problem and the
next question is to understand why we're
interested in solving this problem and
what impact it will have on the business
now typically there are two or three
reasons why people look to machine
learning one is to automate some manual
tasks so there are certain manual tasks
or where it either requires a lot of
people or it requires some special
expertise and so it is expensive and
that that is one reason why people want
to automate manual
tasks another case is if they want to
predict the future and there is no easy
way to do that except by looking at all
the data we have so it's sort of an
extension of a statistician but you want
to automate that system so instead of a
statistician having to make forecasts
make a lot of different forecast you can
just set up a model and the model can
give you forecasts and typically there
is some kind of a revenue impact on the
business if not Revenue then maybe there
is uh some impact related to customers
some impact related to some other
stakeholders like Partners so you need
to understand
what the reason for solving the problem
is and what impact it will have on the
business and all all of this will inform
the kind of models you train all of this
will inform the level of
interpretability that you will require
and the level of complexity that you can
use in your models next thing you want
to know is how is this problem solved
currently without any machine learning
tools and in a lot of cases if you just
study this you will figure out that
maybe there is a better way to just
improve the process that is used to
solve the problem uh and maybe you don't
really need a machine learning tool
right maybe you don't really need a
machine learning model you can also
study the cost of building a machine
learning model which is in terms of time
and in terms of the people involved and
the potential impact the machine
learning model will have on the business
now obviously if the cost of building a
machine learning model is higher than
the potential savings or uh earnings
that it can create then maybe it's not
that useful to create a machine learning
model right maybe at a smaller stage
it's better to solve the problem using
manual processes or some kind of an
intelligent
estimate next you need to understand who
will use the results of the model and
how will it fit into other business
processes your model will not be used in
isolation it will be part of some other
system so you need to understand how
they're going to use it and this is the
kind of issue where sometimes
the other team is going to use your
model more as a yes
no decision Point U and in that case you
should create a classification model but
if they're going to look at the exact
number then in that case maybe you
should create a regression model so the
kind of model that you train depends on
how it is going to be used so this is
all about the problem like why are we
doing this what what problem are we
looking at next we talk about how much
historical data do we have and how was
it collected so it's important to
understand the scale of the data and the
nature of collection now if it was
entered manually if there was some
manual digitization involved then maybe
there might be errors if it was
collected through some sensors then what
are the calibration issues Those sensors
might have if it was collected from the
internet do we have the rights to use
this data etc
etc and these are all also places where
you might want to think about bias and
uh think about whether it is ethical to
use certain kind of data for example is
it ethical to use race
to decide whether somebody should be
given a loan or not
right next you talk about what uh
features does the historical data
contain so you get a list of columns you
try to understand if those features will
help
you make the kind of model that you want
to create
and very importantly you need to
understand if you have historical data
for the values you're trying to predict
so far in all our models we've seen that
we need the target column in our
training data set so if you do not have
the values that you're trying to predict
then the data is not useful for machine
learning so the first thing then you
will need to do is you will need to add
labels or add um the targets into the
model before you can create a model then
understand the known issues with the
data if there are any data entry errors
or if there's any Miss missing data
sometimes what happens is missing data
is just replaced with a zero or a minus
one if the if the data was limited
intentionally at between a certain range
etc etc if there are different units
maybe one person was reporting in
kilometers one person was reporting in
Miles all of these are issues that you
have to anticipate nobody will tell you
in advance I mean some people will but
in general you will have to ask people
questions and figure them out and then
look at some sample rows from the data
set so if you're in a discussion with
someone you just just ask them to show
you some sample rows from the data set
and then once you can actually see the
data on your screen you can ask a lot of
questions about the data and you want to
figure out how representative the sample
is of the entire data set right so you
need to be very curious about data and
before you even get into modeling and
before you get into Ed Etc you need to
be curious about the business problem
and you need to ask as many questions as
possible as you can think of right and
the last thing is to figure out where
the data is stored and how will you get
access to it so data can be stored in
multiple places sometimes you may have
to combine data from multiple sources
sometimes those data access to that data
is split across multiple teams so you it
is your job as a data scientist as a
data science professional to figure out
to make sure that you have access to the
right data right so that's some
questions that you should ask when
working on a machine learning problem uh
to get you started but there are many
more that you can ask right
and if you have any other questions you
think which should show up in this list
please feel free to add them in the
chat the main idea is to gather as much
information about the problem as
possible so that you have a clear
understanding of the objective and the
feasibility of the project right in a
lot of cases machine learning projects
are simply infeasible because
of a very ambitious problem statement
like you're trying to do something that
is really difficult to do or because the
data isn't good enough or the data set
isn't large enough right so before you
even build a project you need to
understand the feasibility of the
project um and that is something that
you can do once you ask a lot of these
questions and of course you're not
working in a professional setting right
now so how do you apply the same
strategy apply the same process to your
projects so whenever possible try to
work with real world data sets that
means try to work with data obtained
from real businesses and kaggle is a
great source of real world data sets if
you just go to kaggle.com sets and we've
talked about how to get data search data
on kagle all you do is you select you go
down here you select some filters like
if you're looking for tabular data
select CSV if you're looking for a large
data set put in a number like 100 MB and
uh apply this these filters and then
maybe search
for let's say Finance if you are
interested in some kind of financial
data and then sort this by the most
votes okay so now we are searching for
finance data sets greater than 100 MB in
CSV
format and now you have historical data
for Bitcoin now that is real world data
or here
is again stock histories for MX
NYSC NASDAQ that is real world data you
have parking tickets data that's real
world
data
so kagle is a great place to find real
world data sets and another thing you
should check out on kaggle is kaggle
competitions now kaggle competitions are
also held on real world data so for
example if you look at op realized
volatility
this competition that's currently
ongoing so the data for this competition
is given by a company called oper and
they have established a objective that
you need need to meet by building a
machine learning model and if you're
able to do that and if you're among the
top three then you can earn tens of
thousands of dollars now on kagle you're
probably not going
to you're probably not going to take
part in competitions for the sake of
earning because it's really difficult
and it's very unlikely as
well uh it's a bit unpredictable but
it's a great learning process so what we
will do is we will pick
an older competition on kaggle so we'll
go through this kaggle competition the
Rosman store sales prediction
competition and we'll try and answer all
of these questions here and then we'll
try and build a machine learning model
so here's the Rosman store sales
competition and the objective here is
stated very clearly forecast sales using
store promotion and competitor data so
it's about sales forecasting you have
certain
stores or Rosman has has a bunch of
stores across uh I believe a bunch of
European countries okay let's let's just
read this Rosman stores Rosman operates
over 3,000 drug stores in seven European
countries and currently Rosman store
managers are tasked with predicting
their daily sales for up to 6 weeks in
advance so you can see here there is a
human elevant involved here somebody has
to predict their sales and based on
their predictions maybe they can order
inventory Etc and not only is human
element involved here it's a manual
process but it's also an error prone
process because what is the formula
they're applying to make these
predictions right so everybody has their
own approach so you want to Rosman wants
to standardize this and they know that
sales store store sales are influenced
by many factors for example whether
there's a promotion running whether
there's some kind of a competition
running between stores whether it's a
holiday uh the seasonality and the
locality so with thousands of individual
man managers predicting sales the
accuracy of the results can be quite
varied right so now we understand now we
can start to answer some of these
questions now we can start to answer
some of these questions what's the
business problem we want to predict
sales why are we interested because we
have thousands of stores everybody tries
to make predictions in a different way
if we could standardize it then we could
save a lot of money because then we
would not have too little inventory or
too much inventory our Revenue predic
will be more accurate and based on that
maybe our cost allocations can be more
accurate how is this problem solved
currently without machine learning tools
well
by these managers individually so now
this point you could ask how can you
improve this without using machine
learning so one simple thing that you
can try and do is maybe create some kind
of a formula maybe just do some
statistical analysis and create a
formula that all managers can put a
bunch of VAR Ables into
and uh get a result out of it right now
how do you create that formula one way
to create that formula is to train a
machine learning model ultimately a
machine learning model is a Formula
that's just a little more complicated
but the other way is to maybe just do
some analysis over the historical data
and come up with something manually and
that's perfectly fine in a lot of cases
it works just fine how much historical
data do we have and how was it collected
okay let's see so now let's go to the
data Tab and in the data tab it says
that there are there's a historical
sales data for 1,150 Rosman
stores and then there are these files so
there is train. CSV test.csv sample
submissions uh store. CSV so apparently
this is the historical data on which we
need to train our model and then we need
to make some predictions on this test uh
file and the way it works on on kaggle
is that the predictions or the target
values for the test set are hidden from
you so you need to train your model on
the training data where you have both
the inputs and the targets and then you
need to make predictions on the test
data where you only have the inputs then
you go here and you make a submission
when the competition is active you can
make a submission but even if the
competition is ended you can just try it
out so you make a submission where you
make a prediction for each row in the
test set and then kaggle through an
automated system is going to compare
them with the real test targets which
are hidden from you and give you a score
and that's how they create a leaderboard
and that's how they create competition
and we'll see that process by the end of
this uh
tutorial and uh this is what the
submission file looks like so there is a
submission file format that you need to
follow and then finally it seems like
there is some supplemental information
about the different stores that are
present and this this is all the columns
that you have and if you go down here
here maybe if you check train. CSV you
can see a few rows of data this is what
it looks like so seems like we have nine
columns day of week date sales so I I
think sales is what we want to predict U
yeah sales is what we want to predict
and there seems to be also a number of
customers not sure if we can use this or
not because we don't know how many
customers are going to come to a store
in the next month so good way to check
what the targets are is to compare the
training data with the test data if you
check the test data here you have store
day of week date whether the store is
open whether it was running a promotion
on that day whether that day was a state
holiday and a school holiday and it
seems like we have neither customers nor
sales so we can't really use customers
the customers data as inputs to our
model we would have to use some of the
other things and sales is what we're
trying to predict okay so now we are
getting a clearer understanding how much
data do we we have well I think
somewhere here in the column section we
should be able to
find let's see it seems like we have
1.02 million so we have over 1 million
rows of data here so across a th000
stores or 15,000 Rosman stores we have 1
million rows of data that means we have
1,000 days of data for every store
roughly speaking that means we have
about because each row represents the
data for one day so that means we have
about 3 years of data roughly speaking
right and you want to get all of these
things in your head before you start um
just working on the data because now you
know that okay now we have three years
of data and for we have this data for
thousand stores uh I think that should
be sufficient amount of information to
build out a sales prediction model for
the next 2 months okay U so yeah that
seems like a reasonable size of data and
uh known issues ETC those are described
here so you can read the description and
learn about known issues and this is
something that you should make your own
notes about if you think that there are
certain issues missing data Etc we just
saw some sample rows and next in this
case the data is stored on kagle but in
some other cases maybe the data will be
sent to you over a CSV file or maybe it
is in a SQL data set maybe you have to
get data from multiple sources maybe
train. CSV or the this historical data
is in some SQL database but the store
data is in a Json format somewhere and
you have to read it and combine them
okay so those are some things that you
will have to do that is the preparation
that goes in and typically you can take
a few days to maybe a week couple of
weeks just
to understand all of this make sure that
you're happy with the initial data that
you're getting make sure that it's clear
to you what the objective is and you
feel at least somewhat confident about
approaching the problem
okay all right so that was step one okay
so step one was all of this preparation
understanding the problem
Etc the second step is now when things
enter back into the data science
domain so now we are slowly translating
the business requirements into a
specification for a project for a data
science and machine learning project so
we need to now start to classify the
problem as an supervised learning
problem or an unsupervised unsupervised
learning problem and if it is supervised
as a regression problem or a
classification problem okay and we'll
talk about this we've talked about these
before but here's roughly the landscape
of machine learning and where machine
learning lies in the Entire Computer
Science ecosystem now of course computer
science is a vast field and one piece of
computer science is artificial
intelligence which is systems that take
seemingly Intelligent Decisions now
artificial intelligence is a very broad
term it includes machine learning but it
can also include hand-coded systems for
example if you look at
uh uh I mean if you look at Amazon Alexa
for example Alexa answers a lot of
questions
so in the background actually a lot of
questions have been hardcoded so what
they look for is once they see certain
keywords based on those keywords they
trigger specific activities for example
if any sentence you say has the word
alarm then alarm then the alarm is going
to be set for you or if any sentence you
say has the word play music then it's
going to play some music for you so
that's not too much machine learning I
mean there is some machine learning in
just converting your voice to text but
ultimately once your instruction is
available as text it's simply a rule
based system where you check for a
presence of a certain word and then you
react in a certain way right so
artificial intelligence systems can can
be rule based where they are coded by
somebody manually rule by rule or they
can be machine learning systems or
machine learning models which is what we
are building here where we simply give
the data to a model and it learns the
relationship between uh what we want to
use and what we want to predict now in
machine learning you have unsupervised
learning and supervised learning
supervised learning is where you know
what you want to predict for example we
want to predict the sales at Rosman or
we want to predict whether a tumor is
cancerous or not so that's supervised
learning unsupervised learning is where
we don't have any Targets where we are
primar just interested in learning the
structure of the data let's say you have
a lot
of activity of customers on your website
and you want to just figure out which
customers
are less frequent visitors and which
customers are power users and which
customers lie somewhere in between so
that becomes a clustering problem where
you don't really know know already
beforehand for each customer but you
want to group customers into similar
clusters and then study those clusters
so that's unsupervised learning that we
will touch on briefly towards the end of
the
course and within supervised learning
where we have categorized or numerical
Target data we have two kinds of
problems we have classification and we
have regression now classification is
when we want to predict a category for
example we want to take information
about a breast tumor and predict whether
it is cancerous or not that is a
classification problem and then a
regression problem is where we want to
predict a number so here for the Rosman
store sales prediction you want to
predict a dollar value a continuous
value that is called a regression
problem and then within unsupervised
learning you have again many different
types of problems like clustering where
you just want to split up the data into
a bunch of similar clusters and maybe
then study those clusters then you have
something called dimensional ity
reduction where you want to take data
that has a lot of columns maybe hundreds
of columns and reduce it down to 5 10 15
columns without losing the essence of
the
data and then you have uh another class
of problems like Association which is
more of like a similarity search or a
recommendation so for example if you've
watched
um for example recommending which movie
you should watch next based on the
movies you've watched and the movies
watched by people who have also watched
all of the movies that you have watched
right so people like you or people who
have a similar Taste of taste as you you
can pick up a song a movie that they
have watched and you haven't watched and
recommend it to you right so that's
Association or recommendations or
U yeah similarity search essentially
right so those are the two areas and
today we are just looking at regression
and classification
now here's the question for you what
type of problem is store sales
prediction as we just discussed because
we're trying to predict a single number
it is a regression problem and what type
of problem is best breast cancer
identification well as we just discussed
that is a classification problem here's
a third example you have this data set
for Mall customer segmentation so you
have a bunch of information about
customers who visited a certain shopping
mall so you have information like the
customer ID which I believe is unique so
not very useful for modeling but then
you have a gender you have an age you
have an annual income and you have some
kind of a spending score so there's
nothing we want to predict here um all
we want to do is we want to figure out
what are the big clusters of customers
we have maybe we have some low Spenders
maybe we have some high Spenders or
maybe we have some Millennials who spend
a high amount maybe we have some older
people who spend a a lower amount we
don't know and that's where we use a
tool or a machine learning algorithm
called clustering which automatically
splits our data into a bunch of
different clusters and we can decide how
many clusters we want to create and then
we can study those clusters to figure
out what makes them a cluster or what is
the common property between them
right all right so once you've
identified the type of problem you are
solving you next need to pick an appro
rate evaluation
metric also depending on the kind of
model that you will end up training your
model will also use a loss function or a
cost function that it will optimize
during the training process for example
if you're trying to
predict whether
a tumor is cancerous or not then the way
you will evaluate the results of your
model is probably by looking at the
accuracy which means if you give it 100
inputs you will want to maybe look at
how many of them did it predict
correctly based on the historical data
or maybe you might be interested in
things like precision and recall so you
may you may want that there shouldn't be
too many false negatives where somebody
who has cancer should not we should not
tell them that they do not have cancer
or maybe you want there not to be too
many false positives where somebody who
doesn't have cancer you don't want to
tell them that they have
cancer right right so based on the exact
scenario you may have to use you may
have to figure out what evaluation
metric you're going to use uh so the
evaluation metric the important thing
here is that they are used by humans to
evaluate the model and in fact this is
something that you will discuss with the
other stakeholders with the business
team and figure out an arrive on an
evaluation metric you will promise them
that I will I will try to deliver a
model that matches this evaluation
metric and they will agree that okay
once you deliver a model model that
matches a certain evaluation metric or
meets a certain threshold for an
evaluation metric that is pred decided
then we will try out the model in our
system all right so evaluation metrics
are for humans but evaluation metrics
like accuracy precision recall are not
understood by Machine learning models
they typically need different kinds of
evaluation metrics because the
requirements for machine learning models
are around differentiability and
continuous functions and things like
that so that's where loss functions come
into picture machine learning models use
loss functions for example for the
breast cancer example a machine learning
model was would use a loss function
called cross
entropy and this that's a common loss
function for classification problems and
it will try to optimize the cross
entropy by changing its internal
parameters all right so that's something
to keep in mind and here is a link that
you can check out this is a survey of
the common loss functions and evaluation
metrics so there are 11 evaluation
metrics and then
some loss functions as
well so this talks about the difference
between evaluation Matrix and loss
functions and typically for regression
tasks for example predicting sales a
continuous value the most common
evaluation matrics are root mean squared
error or root means squared logarithmic
error or mean absolute error which is a
variation of root means squared error
where you don't take squares or square
roots you just look at absolute values
and the r squ
score and then you have evaluation
metrics for classification tasks where
you have accuracy error rate Precision
recall F1 score you have something
called the MCC balanced accuracy log
loss and then you have something called
Au Roc so you can check out all of these
what these mean and the good thing is
for all of these you have functions
inbuilt into psychic learn so whenever
you have some predictions and you have
some targets you simply put them both
both together into the function and that
is going to give you the uh value of the
evaluation metric okay so do check out
this tutorial on evaluation metrics and
loss
functions now what is the appropriate
loss function and evaluation metric for
store sales
prediction this is a regression problem
and with regression problems typically
the loss function in most machine
learning models
is either root means squar error rmse or
R squ so one of these two but it really
depends on the kind of model that you're
training so we'll probably just say that
we'll we'll use root means squared error
as our evaluation metric as well because
it is something simple enough to
understand it simply says that on
average your model is off by a certain
amount and if you have too many outliers
and you don't want to give too much
weightage to outliers then you can also
consider mean abs absolute error okay so
that's another thing worth considering
again you will have to discuss the
evaluation metric with the business with
the other stakeholders and figure out do
you care about outliers are outliers
really uh something that we should try
and solve for then yes then you use root
mean squared error otherwise maybe you
can just use mean absolute error if you
don't worry too much about outliers and
that would be a good evaluation metric
okay then what are the appropriate loss
function and evaluation metric for
breast cancer identification so for
breast cancer identification the loss
function typically in most
classification models is cross entropy
or in tree based models it is typically
the
J the jny score uh at every
stage and the evaluation metric is
generally either accuracy or Precision
or recall or it is going to be the F1
score again something that you would
have to discuss with the other
stakeholders okay now if we actually
check the
the Rosman store sales here you will see
here that there is this
evaluation mentioned here and it turns
out that the submissions that you make
to this competition are evaluated using
the root mean Square percentage
error so that's very interesting now
it's no longer root means squared error
it's R
MSP and this is how it's calculated so
in root me square error we take the
prediction and we take the
target
so we take the Target and the prediction
we take the difference between them we
take the square and then we take the
average of that and take a root but in
this case we are interested in the
percentage error and we are not
interested in the actual error right so
this is something that we'll have to
maybe try and figure out maybe while we
evaluating our models we will also
Define a root mean Square percentage
error function okay so just keep an eye
out for this because it seems like
they're interested not in the absolute
absolute value that you're off by
they're more interested in what is the
percentage that you're off by are you
off by 5% or 10% or 20% and that's what
they really care about okay on
average so yeah so that was step two
identifying what kind of problem you're
solving supervised unsupervised
regression classification and then
identifying the evaluation metric that
the business cares about and agreeing on
that evaluation metric with the business
one thing that you should also then try
and find out is what is a good value of
the evaluation metric that um the other
stakeholders would be happy with for
example for Rosman if you are getting a
root mean Square percentage error
of 10% or lower is that good enough or
do they want something that is 5% or
lower or do they want something that is
1% or lower what is the exact amount
that they need and this is something
that the business will then calculate
maybe they'll go back historically and
see how how much the estimates were off
by maybe the estimates by store managers
were off by 30% on average so if you can
build a system that gets that is off by
20% then it's better than all the store
managers and it does not require them to
spend that time so maybe 20% is good
enough right so it depends case to case
obviously for breast cancer prediction
we wouldn't want maybe uh 60 or 70%
accuracy we want we maybe would want
closer to 98 99 person accuracy to avoid
misclassification because it's a
question of life and death there right
so that's the kind of decisions so
that's the kind of tradeoffs that you
have to discuss and encounter in real
machine learning
projects okay so now we are getting into
the territory that you're familiar with
which is about downloading cleaning
exploring data and creating new features
but you can see that there's a lot that
goes in before you get to this step and
let's move forward let's now get into
more familiar territory here so next we
get to downloading cleaning and
exploring the data and creating new
features right um and this is something
that we've done multiple times so we
will not go very deep here we will just
roughly see the process the and you can
explore the code whenever you're free
but we want to get through this process
and get to the uh next steps which is
all
about trying different kinds of models
so I'm just going edit clear all output
so that I can run all the code from
scratch
now the first thing is to download the
data set and for kagle competitions
there is a special step that you have to
takech you need to go to the kaggle
competition page go to the rules page
and click accept rules here unless you
accept the rules of the competition and
you can read the competition rules
unless you accept the rules of the
competition you will not be able to
download the data so always make sure
that if you're on a competition page and
you can see that there is a slash C in
the URL that's a competition page so if
you're on a competition page go to the
rules Tab and then accept the rules and
an easy way to download the data set
from kaggle is using the open data sets
Library so you just run od.
download and that will then ask you for
your kagle credentials which by now I'm
sure you should be familiar you can go
into your kaggle account
and your kagle account and here on your
account you can click create new API
token to get your API key so I'm just
going to grab my API
key from my desktop
here and I'm going to put in the
username and key here so my username is
this and then I'm going to put in my key
here there we go and that's going to
download the data set for us so it was
about a 7 MB data set let us check out
the folder that was created Rosman store
sales it contains test.csv train.csv
samplesubmission.csv and store. CSV
great and you can check the same thing
here on the side you have Rosman store
sales next
up you
check you load up the data using pandas
so we're just doing pd. read CSV and
this is what the data frame looks like
so it seems like we have this
information store day of week date sales
customers whether the store was open or
not that's one or zero whether the store
was running a promotion or not that's
one or zero the whether it was a state
holiday or not that's a big factor and
whether it was a school holiday or not
that's another
Factor but apart from the training data
train. CSV there is also the store. CSV
file so maybe let's check out this file
store.
CSV so store. CSV contains Store the
store ID but it also contains a store
type and I'm guessing this might be
important because if you have different
types of stores maybe one is just a
kiosk in in a bigger store and one is an
actual large store then perhaps that is
going to be an important factor in
determining sales so maybe we should add
store type here
somewhere then let's look at the
assortment maybe the again here it seems
like there are a bunch of values so this
seems like a categorical column maybe we
should add that here
too and then we have competition
distance okay and then we have
competition since month and competition
since year so I'm not too sure what
these represent maybe this would be a
good time to go back and check the
description or maybe ask a question with
whoever gave you the data what these
represent and for now maybe I'm not
going to use these very extensively so
I'm not going to do dig deeper into
these but this is an exercise for you
what this represents but here we have
promo two again it tells you whether the
store was promot running a promotion or
not and then it has some information
about what week what year and what
interval the promo was running
for so there seems to be some
information about for how long uh stores
have been running certain promotion so
all of this information could be useful
and this is given store wise so for
every store you have this fixed
information now we want to get some of
this information into the training set
what we want to do is here we have store
one so for store one what we want to do
is just put in the data for store one
and then there are a bunch of rows for
store one this is not the only row
because here you see you have 100 you
have over 1 million rows of data so
store one shows up multiple times in
fact about a th times uh over 3 years
but here you have just one row for store
one so so we want to take all of these
and then replicate it for each of those
rows each of the Thousand rows and to do
this we can use the
merge method of the data frame so we say
Ross DF which contains the training data
so which contains all this information
about a single store sales on a single
day and we merge into Ross DF store DF
and how do we do it we want to do a
left outer joint so which means that we
want to make sure that we retain all the
data from rosf and maybe some stores
don't show up in the Rosman data set uh
in the training data set then we ignore
those stores so that's why we have left
and we want to merge on the store column
so once we run that you can see that we
now have store day of week date sales
customers open promo state holiday
school holiday Etc and then we have the
store type assortment competition
distance so this data got replicated for
each row where the store number was one
okay so that's pandas data frame merge
if you are not familiar with this or not
comfortable with this just look up
merging data frames on pandas it is also
part of the 0o to pandas course uh that
we have but now we have a much better
data set right and this is something
that you will have to do you will have
you will get maybe three or four rows of
data three or four Columns of data but
then you look up a certain other
database and then maybe you can expand a
certain column uh and get more
attributes about uh that column and you
generally will have to then try and
combine data there was a question about
weather so you can actually get weather
data now so based on the date you can
probably get some weather data you can
probably get some financial data as well
if you think that the
overall like the stock market index is
going to have an effect on the kind of
sales uh then you can probably get that
information as well and put that in here
like just the rosmus or maybe the Rosman
stock price or things like that so get
get in as much data as you feel might be
relevant into your training data
set so now we have 1 million rows and 18
columns and this data set also contains
a test set so there is a test. CSV file
now let's just see what that test set
looks like before we add store data into
it as well now in the test set you will
see that you have an ID so this is some
kind of an ID for each row of testing uh
but then you have the store you have the
day of the week and then you have the
date and you have whether the store was
open whether it was running a promotion
whether it was a school state holiday
school holiday so no information about
customers no information about sales and
you have to generate predictions for the
sales here okay and I'm just also going
to merge in into the test data frame the
things that we merged in into the
training data frame so here we have
state holiday store type assortment
competition distance Etc okay so the
only difference between the training and
testing data at this point is that you
don't have
the columns customer and sales and sales
is what we want to
predict okay the next step is to do some
data cleaning so we check some data
types and then we check if there are any
null values in this case it turns out
yes there are some null values in some
of the columns so we may have to figure
out how to deal with these null values
if they are
one thing we could do is we could simply
not use those columns or if we think
they're important maybe we may want to
fill those null values because machine
learning models cannot be trained with
null values or we can maybe do some kind
of one Hort encoding for categorical
features and the null values will just
become all zeros so that's the kind of
thing that you have to then look at each
column carefully and typically just this
step may require some back and forth
communication where you
talk to the business and figure out if
it
is how important they think it is to
track the certain input and what they
can give you maybe they can give you the
data maybe they have that data sitting
elsewhere or if you have to then guess
what should you be putting in there
should you be putting in the average or
should you be putting in the median and
you can guess that by studying the
distribution as well if it's a normal
distribution the average should be fine
if it is an exponential distribution the
median should be good or should you be
putting in some kind of a an like an
unknown value for a category so on a
Case by case basis you need to argue and
figure out what you need to do
here uh this is wrong there are null
values I think yeah and then you should
also look at the ranges of data
especially the minimum and maximum
ranges just to get a sense of whether
the data is valid or not for example in
this case it seems like the data is all
all the ranges seem pretty reasonable in
the sense that uh nothing seems to off
there are no negative values here so no
negative sales if you did have negative
sales then you would have to go back and
figure figure out why there are negative
sales
reported maybe on that day the returns
for certain products were higher than uh
the actual sales so maybe there was a
huge recall of a particular kind of
product that you were selling because
there was some issue or some side effect
it was happening so everybody came to
the store on that day and just returned
a certain product uh and no other sales
could be made so maybe then you might
want to exclude that because that is not
representative of what happens on on the
general day-to-day so again you you need
to use your Insight as a data science
practitioner your your skills are as a
data science practitioner but have to
combine that with the actual knowledge
of the business to get the right insight
about how to deal with these situations
then here we have maximum value so it
seems like the maximum sales were about
$40,000 so that already gives you that
okay you're trying to make predictions
in the range of 0 to 40,000 now Zer is
an interesting value why were there zero
sales on uh certain days it could be
because the store was not open on those
days uh so that's something we will have
to try and deal with when the store is
not open yeah the the sales are zero do
we want to handle that in our machine
learning model or do we want to handle
that as a special case because it seems
like a waste of all that modeling power
and time when we know really that if
open is set to zero then sales should be
zero so that's the kind of thing that
you have to think about as you go
through these ranges look for invalid
values look for anything that stands out
and then go back and have a discussion
about
it and also check for duplicate row
again depending on how the data was
collected there may be duplicate data so
you always need to make sure and if you
do find duplicate rows you need to go
back and discuss and figure out whether
these duplicate rows are actually
duplicates that should be removed or
they are valid data that we should keep
around and that really depends on the
context you
can't reject or you can't reject or keep
duplicate data as a rule okay and then
whatever you have dates you want to pass
dates out so here we are just passing
dates into the date time format using PD
do2 date time and once you have these
dates you can also check the minimum and
maximum so it seems like in the training
data the training data combined with the
store data it starts out around
2013 January and it ends at
2015 July
31st and then you're trying to make
predic itions
for what's this this is August of
2015 and then it goes up to you want to
make predictions so this is a test set
so you want to make predictions for
August to Mid September so about a month
and a
half okay
now this is the objective that has been
set out for you and this is the test
data you have and here's already
something that you should think about
now because your test data simply
contains data from August to September
now you train your model and then you
generate some predictions on the test
set and then you get a certain
score do you expect your model to have
the same kind of performance if you put
it out into the world and then it is
used on data for October and November or
November and December or December and
January I would say probably not I would
say that your model would Faire a little
worse because here you are only testing
your model for August and September now
in this competition that's what they're
looking for so that's what we'll try and
solve for but at this point you may want
to go back to the business and go back
to whoever you are working with on the
business side and tell them that hey you
are only or the test data that we've
agreed on is only for a month and a half
August and September that may not be a
good predictor of the models performance
in the real world maybe we should have
one full year of test data and then they
may tell you no no we don't have that we
we only have three years of data if
you're using one full year for testing
then that reduces the amount of data we
use for training etc etc so then you
have to negotiate and figure out what is
going to be the right split because if
the model has to be used year round it's
ideal to have test data year round or
maybe you may AG uh you may come to a
compromise and say how about we just
build it for the next month and a half
right now
and maybe what we'll do is a month and a
half later we can then build it for the
next month and a half and like this for
about a year we just predict the next
month of data and then once we are once
we' made once we've gotten through uh
one year and we have we training models
every two months we can then use that
last previous years of data to make
predictions right so you have to figure
out exactly how you will do this a
project isn't just done and finished at
once so you will keep keep improving
your model over time and if it's
possible to train your model every 2
months then maybe it's fine to make uh
use a test set which is just looking uh
back by 2 months or something
okay all right so now we have the data
set ready to go and the next step is to
do some exploratory data analysis and
visualization and by this time you
should know the objectives of the
exploratory analysis first you want to
study the distributions of of the
individual columns uniform whether
they're uniform whether they're normal
whether they're exponential um based on
this you may decide how to fill missing
values uh based on this you may decide
if you want to apply some
Transformations for example if you see
one column which is exponential uh and
its correlation with the target column
seems like an exponential curve maybe
you can take the logarithm of that
column and that will give you a better
result then you want to detect some
analysis uh anomalies or errors in the
data if you see any missing values any
incorrect values any values that don't
make sense um by drawing the charts you
can fix those then you want to study the
relationship of the target column with
other columns you want to see if there
is a linear relationship a nonlinear
relationship Etc and then you need to
gather insights about the problem and
about the data set and you need to then
come up with ideas for pre-processing
and feature engineering so in a lot of
cases you will see that maybe if you
combine two columns you may get a good
result or you may get a better result
with the same kind of model for example
if you have if you're trying to predict
the price of a house and you have the
overall width and length of the house
and let's say it's rectangular the the
entire
plot then maybe using area as a column
might be a better idea than using width
just width and height as separate
columns because
area has a direct linear relationship
with cost of the house but weight and
height may have a a different kind of
relationship so these are the kind of
things that you have to think about and
this is called feature engineering
combining features or transforming
features to create new features that
make more sense right remember that your
models are limited by how they are
defined or how they how the training
happens so if you're training a linear
Model A linear model can never learn a
quadratic relationship that a width
multiplied by length has some linear
relationship with cost on the other hand
if you introduce a third column which is
area then your linear model can suddenly
start learning much richer relationships
U because now there's a linear
relationship between area and uh the
cost okay so most of the time is
actually spent in feature engineering
and then once you have good set of
features figured out then model training
becomes quite easy
so let's study the distribution of the
sales
column here's what the distribution of
the sales column looks like this is the
Target and already you can see that
there is this huge chunk of zeros here
about 175,000 of these so
about I would say 1 in seven and that
should give you a hint it's probably
that these are Sundays maybe the store
is closed on
Sundays and that's why the store sales
on those days are zero now this kind of
a distribution is going to be very hard
for a machine learning model to predict
especially linear models maybe tree
based models will figure it out because
uh they'll be able to see that okay when
the store is not open then you simply
return a zero otherwise you do General
tree based modeling Etc but for linear
models it's going to be really hard and
this is this seems like a very clear
thing that we should just maybe just
handle up from front right why even put
all this complexity into our uh machine
learning models so let's just check this
once let's check the number of Val let's
check the value counts for zero so it
seems like there are
172,000 rows where the value of open is
zero and there
are what is this this is about
172,000 so it seems roughly that all the
days when the store was closed the value
was Zero so how about we remove all
those rows of data where the store was
closed because there were no sales on
that data so uh there were no sales on
that day so rather than trying to train
a model to predict learn to predict zero
we know that we can just look at the
value of open and return zero right so
I'm just going to remove from the merge
data frame or exclude from the merge
data frame all the dates where the store
was closed and then later on when we
making predictions we can handle it as a
special case so here we just checking if
merged open equals 1 and we just keeping
that section of the data so we are only
going to use the data where the store
was open and this is something that you
can tell them in advance hey I'm
creating a model for the days where the
store was open to keep things simple so
don't use it to predict sales for days
where the store is closed where it's
closed you just predict zero okay so now
it looks much nicer now it looks much
more manageable I think we could then
now um yeah so now it looks much more
smooth and we've handled that special
case right and that's why it's important
to do this exploratory data
analysis otherwise you might miss things
like this and your models would perform
really badly like just by removing the
zeros you will see that there is a huge
difference in the
models and I encourage you to try it out
with the zero as well and see if
that makes a big
difference let's let's check out some
other columns let's check out maybe uh
stores sales versus customers and this
is where you will see a strong
correlation where that you as you have
more customers you have more sales of
course not necessarily true because
sometimes some customers spend more so
this is a scatter plot each dot
represents one row or one day of data
for a particular store and they are
colored by date so roughly you can also
probably see
that the spending probably increases
over time with customers so here you can
see that uh you have a lot of 2013's
here where the sales are less but the
customers are higher and you have a lot
of 2014's and 15s here where the sales
are high and the number of customers is
low right so this gives you a sense of
the trend but unfortunately we cannot
use the customers column so too bad
because we don't know know how many
customers are going to come to the store
a few days later right in fact that
could be another thing that we can try
and predict uh that could be a good
exercise for you try and predict how
many customers will visit the score uh
visit the
store next up we
have okay next up we have this uh figure
between the store and the sales so you
have stores about 1,000 or you have
about 1,200 stores and for each store
we've simply just plotted what the
spends or what the sales on particular
days look like and it's very noisy
because there are thousands of stores
but each vertical line will represent a
store like this represents a store and
you can see that this particular store
had very low sales on a certain day had
a very high sale on a certain day while
most stores have sales between 5 to 10
$15,000 I would say uh it seems like or
$5 to $12,000 and there are some stores
which kind of stand out here so it might
be worth looking into why are some
stores uh sometimes getting a very high
sale and why are some stores mostly
getting sales in a standard
range okay then here's a trend of the
day of the week compared to the sales
let's take a look at that and we'll also
see how promotions affect
sales yeah so this is how it looks like
on the different days of the
week you have 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 oh all right
so we I think the store is probably
opened the stores are probably open 7
days a week and the holidays are
on uh well maybe there's a fixed set of
holidays every year for or the fixed set
of days when the store is closed but it
looks like overall that the spending is
highest on I believe this is Monday so
the spending is highest on Monday and
lowest or highest on Sunday and Monday
and lowest on Saturdays and then it's
somewhere in between during the week so
that's something useful to look at the
day of the week is an important thing
here we are looking at the average sale
based on promotion so if you do not have
a promotion at the St store the average
sale is about $6,000 if you have a
promotion running at the store the
average sale is about $8,000 so
promotion definitely seems to be an
important factor
and that's the kind of analysis that you
will do and sometimes you will find some
interesting things that you will need to
deal with like we dealt with the the
zero values for sales and you can also
look at correlations you can look at how
the target column correlate is
correlated with the other columns so it
seems like it's highly correlated with
the number of customers but we can't use
that as an input then promo seems to be
an important thing promote since week
whether it's a store holiday seems to be
an important thing uh the store well
this is not really a useful correlation
because store is being treated here as a
numerical value but it's more of a
categorical value strictly
speaking so yeah you don't see you don't
see much correlation with store here but
store should have a big impact on the
sales right so just a correlation may
not actually tell you the real picture
because the store depending on which
store we looking at you should have like
a good idea of what the sales for that
store should be
but still useful thing to look at all
the correlations especially with the
numeric continuous
data and here's an exercise for you
analyze and visualize all the other
columns and figure out how they are
related to the Target
column you have to know the data inside
out and exploratory data analysis is the
way you do that so just look at all the
columns there shouldn't be any colums
that you ignore that you're putting into
the data set into the uh
model
all right so next we will talk about
feature engineering which is the process
of creating new features by transforming
combining transforming or combining
existing features or by incorporating
data from external sources for example
we have a date column if we just
check merg TF so we have a date column
here but I'm guessing there is probably
some sort of a monthly trend so maybe we
should extract out month from the date
column and I'm also guessing that maybe
there is an yearly Trend so maybe we
should also extract out Year from the
date column maybe we could also extract
out information like whether it's a
weekend or not maybe we could extract
out information like whether it's the
first day of the month or last day of
the month maybe we could extract out
information like is it the first day of
the quarter or the last day of the
quarter and
maybe the day in the month so all that
sort of thing
and that's feature engineering for you
essentially so here we'll try and figure
out the day month and year very simple
and we can do this by simply using the
DT property of the date column and there
are many ways to do this in pandas if
you just try and figure out given a
datetime column how to get the day month
or year uh you will find some resources
online so what we'll do is we will just
add these three columns day month and
year into the training and the test
set
and we can then plot and see if there's
actually some sort of a correlation here
so we are plotting the year wise sales
and then we plotting the month-wise
sales average
sales yeah so here are the year wise
sales and you can see that there is a
slight increase you can see that 2013 is
a slightly lower than 2014 slightly
higher lower than
2015 and we also have month-wise sales
here month-wise sales seems to show a
clear Trend the average daily sale
month-wise seems to be quite high in
December
and then there's another Peak around May
or June so I think it was a good idea to
extract out the month and the year
columns maybe we should also look at the
day column and as I said you can do
things like we whether the day is a
weekend or not whether it's a start of a
month end of a month Etc
that you can
create now you can also create new
columns by getting information from
external sources so you could try and
get the weather on each day you can
probably just check whether it rained or
not on that day you can check the
temperature for that day and if you
would probably need the locations of the
stores
so if with this maybe you can go back to
whoever is working with you on the
business side and tell them that can you
also give me the locations of each store
and then you can use the date and the
location to figure out the weather on
those days and if you can figure out the
weather on those days then you can use
that information to make a prediction
and to make predictions about the future
maybe you can use the predicted weather
so there is again a an additional
uncertainty that gets added there but it
could potentially lead to better
results so that's something that you you
can try and add you can try and add
whether that date was a public holiday
so you can just look up information for
Germany or for Europe and fill in the
information on whether it's a public
holiday I think in this case it's
already included but in in case it isn't
that is something you may want to
add it we already have whether the store
was running a promotion on that day but
suppose that was not available then then
you could just get a list of promotions
that have been run across the Rosman
stores and figure out if a particular
store was running a promotion on that
particular day or not in this case it's
given to us but that may not always be
the case Okay so try coming up with new
ideas and try adding more columns one
thing that you can also do to get a
sense
of what kind of ideas people apply to
feature engineering is to Simply
check is to Simply check
the notebooks that people have shared so
let me just find
Rosman yeah Rosman store
sales so if you go to the competition
page and on the competition page go to
the code section and in the code section
just sort by
votes and then search feature
engineering yep so you will see some
examples of feature engineering here
like Rosman data cleaning and feature
engineering and then you can open up
this notebook and on this notebook you
can then see what kind of features
people have
created let's see so it seems like
they're creating they grouping stores
based on the sales level I think this
was something that we were talking about
where we could probably look at the
average sales and if the when we can say
that this is a low low performing store
or high performing store or low sales
store or high sales store uh we don't
have things like
the area of a store but uh we can use
the sales as an approximation to
calculate the area
right or to to find find a value that is
proportional to the area then here are
some features created using dates here
are some features created by taking
logarithms so taking logarithms of the
sales U and taking standard deviations
and means and so on so probably one
feature worth adding is take all the
historical sales of a store and then add
the average of that as a feature for the
store and then there is a bunch of
feature engineer ing related to
Promotions there's a bunch of feature
engineering related to competitions so
we've not really looked at the
competition information that has been
stored that has been shared with us so
that is something worth
exploring yep so those are some examples
of feature engineering and a lot of your
time should be spent coming up with good
features not initially but once you
train a first model and then you feel
like you want to improve your model then
you spend some more time working on uh
coming up with new interesting
features and here's some exercise for
you where you can look at some of the
existing features and then try to
improve their
representation
okay all right so we're done with the
data cleaning and visualization next
part is data
preparation so the first step here is to
perform a training test and validation
so the first thing we'll do here is
create a training test and validation
split for the data now we already have a
test set given to us so that contains a
month and a half of data after the end
of the training set so we can create
apply a similar strategy to create the
validation set maybe we'll just use the
last 25% of rows for the validation set
after ordering by date so here's what
I'm going to do I'm just checking the
length of the data frame after removing
the holidays we are left with 850,000
rows
approximately so 75% of that is 633
th000 rows and the rest will go into our
training our validation
set so these are just some basic
calculations on what the size of the
training set needs to be now here's what
I'm going to do I'm going to take the
data frame sort it by date so now we
have all
the observations by a single ordered by
date and then from the data frame I'm
going to just select the last few rows
or the last 25% of rows for the
validation data set and I'm going to
select the first 75% of rows for the
training data set so now we will have
the training data frame which contains
633 th000 rows and a validation data
frame which contains 200,000 rows okay
now I'll let you figure out how we
achieved this in this uh line of code uh
you can probably create a new cell and
try to sort out try to work out each
piece here but what we're doing is we're
sorting by date selecting the first 75%
of data for training and rest for
validation and here's what the data
frame looks like now so this is our
training data frame it contains store
day of week date etc etc all of that and
validation data set will look exactly
the same what will be different is the
date range that you have for the
training and validation set so the
training set it starts from 2013 January
to
2014 December it looks like and the
validation set starts from 2014 December
and goes on till
2015 July and the test set starts right
after that okay why are we doing this
time based split because we Now
understand that our model is going to be
used in the future so we want to show
our model data that it hasn't seen in
the past or or data that that comes into
the future of the data that it has been
trained on right right so that's why you
have the train that's why you have the
test set which comes after the training
period Then you have the validation set
which also comes after the training
period so it is a better reflection of
the test set if you pick the validation
set randomly that might still work that
might still give you a good result but
the results or the metrics that you get
on the validation set may not be a good
reflection of the metrics that you get
on the test set or the metrics that you
get in the real world so you want to
make your validation set as close
to the real world data that your model
will face as possible okay now of course
if we did not have dates you could just
pick a random segment of the data for
validation so these are the date ranges
you can see that the test set comes
after the validation set and remember we
already have a test set given to us
separately all right so now we have our
training test and and validation data
frames and all of them have all these
columns now we know the drill here we
need to get we need to identify the
input and Target columns so I'm just
going to create a list of input columns
and I'm not going to use all the columns
for your initial
model for your initial model when you're
just figuring out what kind of modeling
approach you should use or what would
the rough accuracy or the rough Baseline
performance of your model look like it's
not worth spending too much time on just
engineering and understanding every
single column for your initial model you
can just pick a few columns and then
just try things out so I'm just going to
pick about 4 + 5 nine columns here for
my initial model and I am going to put
them into a list called input columns
and the target column is sales one thing
I should be very careful of is to make
sure that sales or the customers column
does not come up in input columns
because that would be an error there is
not something we have in the test
set let's also separate out numeric and
categorical columns now this is where it
gets a little tricky here because stores
ideally should be treated as categorical
columns 115 stores all of them have a
different property so there's no natural
order to stores it's not that a store
with a higher ID is going to have higher
sales or a store with a lower ID is
going to have higher sales uh it's
completely random the numbering and the
sales so technically it is a categorical
column but the difficulty is creating
115 treating it as a categorical column
and then creating
1,115 Columns of data is going to
severely increase the size of the data
set and also it's going to make the
models a bit harder to train because of
something called The Curse of
dimensionality which means means that if
you have a lot of different features
which all are very closely correlated
then that makes it a lot easier for your
models to overfit uh essentially right
because
now because now it has a lot more
parameters to play with so it can very
easily overfit to the training data and
those models generally do not generalize
very well so that's it's not the exact
definition of the curse of
dimensionality but that's the idea the
more features or the especially when you
get into thousands of columns or
thousands of features you are going to
start facing issues so we are going to
treat store as a numerical column and
that is probably a problem probably
there's an issue there but we'll just
see what happens right and that's why
you can do some kind of feature
engineering where maybe you can reorder
the stores maybe you can compute the
average sale per store the average sale
value and and based on that give a new
numbering to the stores and that
numbering could be reflective of the
average sales so that a higher number a
higher store number would mean a higher
average sale a lower store number would
mean a lower average sale right so
that's something worth trying out but we
just going to use it as a numerical
column linear models will struggle
decision Tre Tre based models might be
able to figure this
out then we have day of the week this
this is also this is categorical I think
we can keep it categorical uh we have
day month so these are technically
categorical 2
so again with month again with day maybe
you don't want to add 31
days you don't want to add 31 new
columns so we might leave this numeric
or maybe we might even leave month
numeric and maybe decision trees should
be able to figure out figure it out they
can have decision boundaries like if the
month is less than five but greater than
three then do this otherwise do
something else so so I'm hoping you get
the idea here linear models will suffer
when you have categorical data treated
as numerical data but decision trees
generally should be able to sort it out
okay so I am just going to create a list
of numeric and categorical columns here
numeric columns is Store Day month month
and year so this is a store I'm going to
treat that as a number day I'm going to
treat that as a number as well month as
a number and year as a number as well
okay and you can try making them
categorical and try things out but the
rest of these things I will keep them as
categorical
things so store numeric columns are
store date month and year categorical
columns are day of week promotion state
holiday store type and
assortment anything that contains
strings has to be categorical or uh
yeah especially if it has a limited
number of values if it is a unique
string like some notes or something or
like a description of the store that we
may simply just have to drop or use that
to create new categorical or numeric
columns okay so what one other thing
that we're doing here is we're just
creating this train inputs and train
targets so these new data frames which
only contain the input columns and the
target column respectively so this is
something that you should success
successively keep doing you should keep
eliminating the things that you no
longer need so that your inputs and your
targets just contain the information
that you need so now if if you see train
train
inputs you you will see that it only
contains these seven or eight columns
that we are interested in and also does
not contain the Target and then train
Target only contains the target value
that we're trying to predict okay
similarly we have validation inputs and
validation targets and similarly we have
test inputs but we have no test targets
because our test data does not have
targets we have to make those
predictions and submit to
kaggle all right so now we've identified
numeric columns categorical columns
there is some scope for debate here but
this is just something I went with and
maybe I can revise that
later now we get to the imputation SC uh
scaling and encoding the first thing
we'll do is we will imput missing values
in the numerical columns so I'm just
going to use a simple imputer here I'm
going to use the strategy of mean but as
I said what you should ideally do is
look at the distributions of the
different columns and figure out the
columns that are that have a normal
distribution maybe use a mean there The
Columns that have some kind of an
exponential distribution maybe a median
will make more sense here and there are
also more complex imputation strategies
that you can check out so the imputer
then takes all the numeric columns
computes the average for each column
when we call fit and then here we are
using it to trans form the training data
validation data and test inputs all of
these uh so we just fill in all the
missing values wherever there are
missing values now in this particular
data set maybe that was not necessary
because there were no null values in the
numeric columns but in general yeah
there might be null values so you will
have to deal with
them and as I have already said you can
apply different imputation strategy to
different columns depending on their
distributions so that was
imputation which is just filling missing
values then we have scaling so we just
want to get all our numbers in the 0 to
one range once again here with scaling
maybe you might try a standard scaler
which creates a minus one to one range
roughly or assumes a normal distribution
and creates a minus one to one one range
of mean and standard deviation mean zero
and standard deviation one that's one
other way to scale or the min max scaler
creates a 0 to one
range you can try different scaling of
approaches here um and to begin with you
can just pick one and uh just go with
it okay and then we have categorical
columns encoding as one hot vectors
again we've seen this a few times so
this should be straightforward enough
where we are taking all the categorical
data and we are putting it into one hot
encoded vectors so here's what happens
if I just check train
inputs you will see here that we have
for day of the week since it is treated
as categorical we have day of the week
one day of the week 2 day of the week 3
4 5 6 7 so the benefit of this is that
if sales are very high on Sunday for
example then a weight a certain weight
or a certain decision can be made on
just the column day of the week 7 and it
will not have to it it will not apply to
any of the other days so I hope you see
the benefit of having these one hot
encoded columns and of course if you had
strings here then you would have to
convert them into numbers using one hot
encoding right now at this point because
we have added new categorical columns
for each of the a new one hot columns
for each of the categorical columns so
we can probably just extract out all the
numeric data all the numbers that can be
fed into a model so that includes the
numeric
columns which we have imputed and scaled
and that should also include the encoded
columns so for we can drop the original
categorical columns and just keep The
Columns that we have created for each
category the one hot columns all right
and now we have this x Trin x w and X
test so X and Y generally refer to
inputs and outputs in psyit learn so
these are the actual inputs that will go
into the model and these are all numbers
and these are all
properly scaled and
imputed all right so that is the data
pre-processing steps we need to take and
I'm just going to save my notebook here
so do save your notebook from time to
time and you can just grab your API key
from Jovian to save your notebook so you
just go to jan. a click copy API key
paste it here and when you do that a
copy of this notebook will be saved to
your Jovian
profile okay so here's my copy of how to
approach ml okay so now before you get
to machine learning one thing you should
try and do is just create some quick and
easy Baseline models to Benchmark your
machine learning models what do we mean
by Baseline models well suppose you
didn't know about anything about machine
learning suppose you just had to somehow
come up with some
approximation on how to make these
predictions and they can be as and you
can come come up with as simple or as
basic an approximation as possible what
would that
be
and then we come we think of s such
approximations or such strategies and
then we Implement those strategies and
see what the result from those
strategies looks like so here's an
example of what I'm talking about let us
Define a model our so-called model
because this a this doesn't really do
anything let's define our model which
always returns the mean value of the
sales as prediction so we have the sales
column if you check train
targets okay this is the train targets
and if I just take the mean mean of the
sales data it's about
6873 and let's say my model simply
always predicts that the sale for any
store on any day is $
6873 okay that's a
very dumb model in some sense it doesn't
really do much but let's just see what
what we get out of it okay so now we
have this model we defining or this
function we defining simply called
return mean which given a given a bunch
of inputs simply Returns the mean over
and over for every input so if I pass it
pass into it X train which is the
training data and I get back some
predictions and of course all the
predictions are simply predicting the
mean right the average sale on a
particular store on a
across the entire data set in a store in
a in a single
day and here is how this becomes useful
now what we can do is we can now check
this against our evaluation metric so
remember we decided that the evaluation
metric should be the root means squared
error or actually in the competition it
is the root means Square percentage
error and I'll leave it as an exercise
for you to figure out how to implement
the RM psse or rmsp but we are just
going to to use the rmsse score here
because there's an inbuilt function for
it but yeah but do replace this with
rmsp so I'm importing the mean squared
error function here and then I call mean
squared error on the predictions which
is all fixed predictions and the targets
so which are the actual targets that we
want to
predict train
targets yep so this is what we need to
predict and this is what our model
actually predicted a fixed value and
let's just compare how bad this is so if
you compare the mean squared error of
train predictions with train targets it
turn and and we set squared equals false
so that will give us the root mean
squared error so it turns out that the
mean squared error is
3082 okay now why is this important well
first thing you should try and see is
how does this compare to the actual
values so it seems like the actual
values can be in the range 2,000 to
15,000 roughly 15 or 177,000 3,000 to
177,000 and this mean squ error of about
3082 is off by how much so 2,000 to or
3,000 to 15 17,000 how much is that 17 -
3 is 14 so if you're off by 3,000 out of
a range of 14,000 then roughly if you
just predict the average
all the time you are only off by about
20% very roughly speaking and you can do
the r uh root mean percentage square
error and figure
out so if your sales
predictions from all these stores from
all these sales managers is off by more
than 20% then that means the work that
they're doing is actually
counterproductive the predictions that
they're making are actually causing
actively causing a loss if you s simply
just use the average value as the
prediction you will probably have a
better forecast right so that's one
thing that you understand the second
thing you understand is that now any
model we train any fancy uh machine
learning model we train should ideally
have a lower loss than just predicting
the average right because here we're
simply just predicting the average
there's no intelligence here so this
gives us that's why we call this a
baseline this tells us that our model
any model that we train should be at
least this good it should be at least
the rmsc should at least be less than
3,000 if the RMS is greater than 3,000
then our model is completely useless and
maybe there is something we need to fix
about it fundamentally
okay all right so that out of the way we
can also check this for the validation
set so we generate predictions for the
validation set where we just return the
mean and then we compare it with the
validation targets and we get about 316
68 so the model is off the so-called
model is off by about 3,000 on
average let's try another model this
time we are going to make a random guess
between the lowest and the highest sale
so the lowest sale I believe is
about $3,000 since we have removed all
the zeros okay it's we still have a
bunch of zeros here so if it just
guesses randomly between the lowest and
the highest
sale and the highest is 41,000 that
seems like a large number so maybe you
can change the range here maybe you can
put a range of 3,000 to
15,000 but yeah here we are doing a
random guess so now if you pass the
training inputs into this guess random
model you will get random training
predictions all of these are completely
random we've not looked at the data at
all and let's check the mean squ error
and this time we off by about
18,000 you can see here we are off in
both cases by about 18,000 I am I'm
quite curious what happens if I just put
this here if I just put here maybe 3,000
and maybe
18,000 instead of Min and
Max so then we would be off by just
about 6,000 right so a random guess is
off by about 6,000 maybe if we played
around with the ranges a little bit
maybe we might get it down to four 5,000
or 4,000 and then a fixed guess is off
by about 3,000 so our model should be
off by less than both of these
values here's one other thing you can
try a quick hand coded
strategy where and this is where you
maybe you might be able to satisfy the
requirement without even building a
machine learning model so write a
function that implements this strategy
if the store is closed return zero so
when you get an input it checks whether
if the store is closed it returns zero
and if the store is open then simply
return the average sales of the store
for the current month in the previous
year okay so what we're saying is if
you're checking for store number 1,000
or store number 1 2 3 4 and you want the
sale you want the prediction for the
sale in on 15th of July
2015 then just look at the average daily
sales
in 2014 for the same store and return
that and this is something that you can
pre-compute and keep for every store you
can keep uh store comma month and the
average sale and you can just look up
that table and return the
answer and I believe that it should be
better than uh this model which is where
we always return the mean so maybe here
we are looking at the average we're
looking at the same store and we're
looking at the same month in the
previous year and maybe you can have a
rule that maybe maybe you increase it by
10% uh to account for inflation let's
say or increase in prices or increase in
traffic whatever and just use that those
three rules and try and figure out and
Implement that strategy and find the
validation score for that
strategy and you may be surprised that
this hand-coded strategy may actually
perform a lot better than many of the
machine learning models that we are
about to train okay so don't always
think that a machine learning model will
perform better sometimes human Insight
especially when the signal in the data
is weak U sometimes human Insight can
give you a much better strategy okay so
do try out a hand code strategy and if
sat if it satisfies the requirement that
have come from the business then that's
it uh end of project you don't have to
uh train a machine learning model and
that's a good thing because you
understand a hand coded strategy it is
very clearly explainable because you
have coded it
okay
then after trying all of these things
that is when you should maybe try a
baseline machine learning model so maybe
just pick the simplest possible model
for regression problems linear
regression is the simplest model for
classification problems logistic
regression is the simplest model and
often these models themselves will be
good enough and you can just end the
project there you don't have to even do
any hyperparameter tuning Etc maybe just
a little bit of feature engineering uh
so let's see
here we're importing the linear
regression model and uh we just creating
this model here instantiating it then we
are calling fit so when we call fit what
happens is the linear regression model
assumes a linear relationship between
the inputs and the targets so the target
which is sale is assumed to be some
weight multiplied by the store number
plus some weight multiplied by day of
week plus some weight multiplied by
there was a promotion or not plus some
weight multiplied by whether it was a
public holiday or not etc
etc so there are about eight features it
will apply a weight to each of those
Eight Features I think there are 18
after one H encoding so it will apply a
weight to each of the 18 features and it
will start out with random weights but
it will slowly improve the weights by
this kind of a workflow where it will
put some inputs through the model get
some predictions compare the predictions
with the targets using a loss function
so linear regression in psyit learn
actually uses the r squ loss function
which is a Vari of the rmsc loss
function and it then applies an
optimization method uh in this case it's
called Ordinary lease squares to improve
the weights of the model so the so the
random guesses are slowly improved step
by step
iteratively till the model gets good
enough okay so that's what happens when
we run linreg do fit now once the model
has been fitted which means once good
weights have been identified for each
feature in the input we can then use the
model to make predictions now keep in
mind that the parameters or the weights
inside the model will not be updated
during prediction so if you see the
model now
linreg this is a linear regression model
inside it you will find a bunch of
coefficients that have been that will be
applied to each
feature yeah and these coefficients
correspond directly to the columns in X
train so remember xtrain so 1.04 will be
applied to store number minus one will
be applied to day 6.5 49 will be
multiplied with month 1.47 will be
multiplied by year and all of these
multip uh all of these weights will be
applied and then that will be added
together and that will give you the
predicted sale okay so it's a very
simple linear assumption we know that it
is already very weak because store
number has no direct correlation with
sale at least not a linear relationship
so here are some predictions so now we
put in into linear regression we put in
xra so now we're just predicting now
we're no longer fitting the weights of
the model are fixed so we are just
taking the inputs applying the weights
and getting some predictions out okay
now we're not training the model anymore
and now we get these predictions out for
the training set and let's compare the
predictions with the train targets and
let's get the root mean squared error
and it turns out that the root mean
squared error is 27 41 so our linear
regression model gives a root me squ of
is off by 27 or almost
$2,800 and
our Baseline average model the one which
always predicts the average is off by
$3,000 so clearly linear regression is
not doing too well here I mean we were
off by 3,000 earlier now we off by 24
2700 it's clearly a bad uh model but now
you know now you know that it's actually
a pretty bad model because you can
compare it with the Baseline and now I
hopefully you can see the value of a
baseline in fact for the validation set
the error is even worse 2817 that's
almost the same as always guessing the
mean okay and we understand why because
the relationships are definitely not
linear sale is not a
direct like
linear combination of the store number
and the day of the week and things like
that it's it's nonlinear the relation
the relationships here okay but anyway
that was just a baseline model with
machine learning now we get to the
interesting part which is where we now
train interesting models and we tune
hyper
parameters
okay and this is where we have to then
systematically explore a bunch of
different modeling
strategies now psyched learn on its
website side offers this cheat sheet
that you should check out to help you
figure out which kind of models to
use and this doesn't include all the
different models but it roughly gives
you an idea that psychic learn is split
into a bunch of classification models a
bunch of regression models a bunch of
clustering models and a bunch of like
dimensionality reduction models so
that's all psychic learn contains and
then there are some other non- modeling
related modules as
well and here is where uh they say that
you start and you check if you have more
than 5050 samples and if you have less
than 50 samples then just get more data
no amount of modeling is going to help
you in this case fortunately we have
over half a million so next we ask the
question are we trying to predict a
category or are we trying to predict a
quantity so if you are predicting a
category then we check if we have
labeled data so for the breast cancer
example this is the direction that we
would head into so we have we do have
labeled data so that means this is a
classification problem we already know
whether tumors are malignant or benign
cancerous or non-cancerous so we can now
use a classification
algorithm and these are some of the
classification algorithms you have this
SGD classifier you have this K neighbors
classifier then you have this uh
Ensemble you obviously have random
Forest classifiers uh you have decision
tree classifiers those are not listed
here but they're part of this so these
are some of the these are all the models
that are applicable to that particular
problem right almost all classification
models will be applicable to that
problem not all of them may perform well
but all of them will
work on the other hand if you're
predicting a quantity like in this case
then we just check here if we have less
than 100,000 samples then we should
probably just use SGD regressor or one
of those other regress regression
algorithms otherwise if U we know that
some features should be important so
here they have this check if you think
that some features are going to be more
important than other features use lasso
and elastic net so the difference
between SGD regressor which is basically
just linear with the gradient descent
optimization technique so it's just a
different optimization technique it
works well for large uh data sets so the
difference between SGD regressor and
elastic net and lasso and all these is
somewhere within the loss function uh
somewhere to prevent overfitting some
things like
that and then yeah there are a couple of
other um options so the here what
they're trying to tell you is try the
simplest model possible and if the
simplest model does not
work then you can try maybe these
Ensemble regressors which is random
forest and then they should have put in
decision trees here as well somewhere so
if linear models work out fine that's
great if you're not satisfied with
linear models then maybe you try some of
these Ensemble regressors right so
that's the rough idea there you start
out with simpler models and go with go
to increasingly more complex
models so here's a general strategy find
out which models are applicable to the
problem you're solving now obviously us
uh K near neighbors classifier is not
going to be applicable to sales
prediction because it's a classification
model but all of these would be
applicable train a basic version for
each type of model that's applicable
even if you know that the the linear
relationships are weak still makes sense
to just train a a linear model just to
see uh what result it gives you you may
be surprised don't assume
anything so you train a basic version
for each type of model then identify the
modeling approaches that work well and
tune their hyper parameters so once you
try a basic version of all of these
models then you will get a sense of
which one is working well and then you
can start tuning some of the hyper
parameters and as you do this use a
spreadsheet to keep track of your
experiment results so here is one
spreadsheet that we've put together for
you it's a simple format that you can
follow and this spreadsheet
contains this spreadsheet contains two
sheets if you see at the bottom here you
have an idea sheet and you have an
experiment sheet
so what you should do is you should list
out all the ideas you want to try maybe
I want to try a linear
regression and uh a potential impact or
uh potential
outcome whatever ideas you have about
the potential outcome I think this is
going to be pretty
bad something that we've already seen
then maybe you want to try out uh Ridge
regression and you can read about Ridge
regression and then lasso
regression and maybe you can try out
polinomial
regression so Ridge and lasso regression
simply make some changes to the loss
function of linear regression polinomial
regression means you're taking some
you're taking squares and cubes of
certain features which you think might
be useful then maybe you want to try out
a decision
tree and maybe you want to try out
random forests and maybe you also want
to try out uh gradient boosting maybe
you want toy try out something called
support Vector
machines yeah so just list out all the
ideas you have and it's a good idea to
just list out what you think the outcome
might be so this you think should be
better than linear
regression because it contains
regularization in internally decision
tree well
okay should offer good
interpretation
and things like that right so whatever
outcome you're going you're looking for
from each model it's it's a good idea to
just project uh try and predict which
model might work well and then once you
actually train that model you can list
out your learnings here and you can see
if your prediction about whether a model
will work well matches your actual
learnings after training that model and
that is how you train your mind to think
about picking the right machine learning
model there is no good answer there is
no series of rules that you can follow
it's just that you have to work through
a bunch of different data sets and try
different kinds of models and in for
each kind of model if you can just take
a second to predict what outcome you
want to see from that
model and learn from the actual outcome
that you see you will start course
correcting so in some sense you are
doing you're running a machine learning
algorithm on your brain and you will get
better at picking machine learning
algorithms all right so this is one
thing that you should have this is the
idea sheet then you have this experiment
sheet so in this experiment sheet you
should put all the experiments that
you've put in uh all the experiments
that you're conducting I think you
should have hyper parameters here as
well yeah so I'll tell you what I mean
by this in just a
second
yep okay so here's what we're going to
do we are going to define a function
called Tri model which takes a model so
you instantiate a linear regression
model and give this
model and let's say here's one potential
model that can go into this
function okay so you give it a model and
it's going to first fit the model to the
training data so you have you have X
train and you have train targets so it's
going to fit the model then once the
model has been fitted once the weights
inside the model have been finalized it
is going to generate some predictions
inside the model so it's going to say
model. predict xtrain get predictions
for the training set model. predict xal
get predictions for the validation set
then because we already have the targets
for the training and validation set we
are going to compute the mean squared
error training targets training
predictions squared fals validation
targets validation predictions squared
fals and it's going to return the train
RMS and Val RMC and why am I defining
this function here so that I can try
different types of models out like I can
call try model with a linear regression
model I can call try model with a random
Forest I can call try model with
something else that's the benefit of
psychic learn it has a standardized API
that we can use to write these nice
functions so first I'm going to try some
linear models and you can read more
about them here and this is like linear
regression Ridge lasso elastic net and
SGD now you can see I'm creating a
linear regression model and I'm just
directly passing it into Tri model so
this is the same as doing model equals
linear regression and then Tri model
model OKAY instead of that I'm just
writing it in a single
sentence and we've already trained a
linear regression model and we know that
the linear regression model has a
training RMS of 2741 and it has a
validation RMS of
2817 so now this is an experiment we've
conducted this is a certain model we
model we've trained with certain default
hyper parameter
so I'm just going to put in this
experiment here I'm just going to say
that
on linear regression is one experiment I
conducted and I'm just going to insert
the current time here by just typing
now and then the hyper parameters well I
didn't tune any hyper parameters so I'm
just going to put none
here oops this does not really work
anyway let me just put in today's date
July
3 and then I'm going to record the
training score so the training score is
1.5 and then the validation score is 28
17.7 so I'm just going to put that in
here as
well we don't have the test score yet
but we can put it in later I am probably
at this point I would also maybe just
commit the notebook and save the link to
the
notebook but I'm just going to to put
this link
here yeah and then any other details we
want to incorporate about the model we
can put it in here okay so that's our
linear regression model then let's do
Ridge regression so with Ridge
regression it seems like we are getting
a very similar result not too different
27 41.5 and 28
17.7 let's try lasso
regression this seems to be taking
slightly longer let's try some other as
well lasso elastic net n and
SGD lasso gives us a worse result in
both places and elastic net gives us a
worse result even worse so it seems like
all linear models are pretty bad and
2972 is almost as bad as the mean
prediction right so then you would just
put in here okay you tried elastic net
and you tried
Ridge and you
tried and you tried lasso
um and you write SGD
regressor and just put in all the
information here right and if you think
that a experiment was completely useless
you can even skip it but the idea is you
want to build out this this table of
your experimentation so that when you
need to look back after having conducted
100 or 150 experiments you can pick the
right model out of this otherwise it
gets really messy okay and here's an
exercise for you try changing some of
the parameters in the above models for
example elastic net has a couple of
parameters you can see it has this let's
see it has an alpha and then it has L1
ratio and a bunch and an L L2 Ratio or
something so you can try passing an
alpha maybe try Alpha
equals 6 and read about it in the
documentation okay so changing the alpha
changes the result so maybe here you may
want to note down that you put
Alpha equal
6 and that led to a certain score and
maybe add another row and put in the
alpha equals something else and that led
to a certain score this is how you
organize your work and it's very
important as a data science practitioner
as a data scientist to keep your work
organized okay next up let's look at
some tree models and from this point
I'll assume that we are putting in all
the results into that
spreadsheet but uh here's a tree model
I'm just importing decision tree
regressor and just trying a basic tree
model so I'm just calling decision tree
regressor with the random state of 42
and calling try
model and it takes a while but you can
already see that the training loss is
zero and this is something that we
already know about decision trees that
they overfit to the training data badly
so we may just want to experiment with
some hyper parameters but even with
overfitting the validation loss is 155 9
that is far far
lower than 28 what was this 28 28 yes
that's far far lower than 2828 this was
as good as just predicting the mean this
is half right so we've reduced we've cut
the error from the Baseline to half so
now that I think is a pretty good model
and but we would still have to go and
figure out a talk to business and figure
out if this is good enough or if we need
to do even better and then you can also
plot this decision tree so at this point
now you can plot this tree and you can
then send this information out saying
that hey it seems like promo is the most
important thing if we have promo then we
um check which day of the week if we do
not have a promotion we check the day of
the week if we do have a promotion we
check the store type and this is how we
arrive at a certain value okay and then
you can do the analysis of the decision
tree how deep it goes how many which are
the most important features etc etc but
let's also quickly try a random Forest
let's see what happens when we go from a
decision tree to a forest of 100 trees
again the default configuration not
changing any hyperparameters
here and the random Forest obviously
takes a lot more time and in fact that
is something that you can put in here as
well you can also maybe put in the
amount of training time so just feel
free to add more columns here uh so
we've just done decision Tre and that
gave us something like one about 1,500
was it the training score was Zero um
and the
let's just call it loss so that it's
clear the training loss was zero and the
validation loss
was uh 1500 which is both much better
than our linear
models and it's taking a while so let's
let that work it
out and then an exercise for you is
going to be to just tune the hyper
parameters of the Deion trees and the
random Forest to get better results and
at this point you may want to then
consider how much better a random Forest
is compared to a single decision tree
because a single decision tree offers
100% interpretability you can see
exactly how each decision is taken
because you can plot this out but a
random Forest performs the average of
100 trees so if you think that the
business requires a very clear
demonstration of how you arrived at a
certain result then maybe you're willing
to sacrifice some of the accuracy for
interpretability of the model but if not
then feel free to maybe train a bigger
random Forest because random Forest also
offers some sort of a feature importance
and
stuff okay I may have to just pause this
at this point but I believe uh from my
previous run I can recall that random
forest was around 1,300 so that was
again a decent reduction from a decision
tree and then there are several other
supervised learning models that you can
try out now if you just go to pyit
learn.org and look at supervised models
you have a whole bunch of linear models
we've not covered all of
them and of course not all of these are
regression models so some of these are
for regression some of these are for
classification and you can just check
the
documentation then you have these kernel
Ridge regression seems interesting you
have something called support Vector
machines these were pretty popular back
in the early 20 thousands but now
they're not very widely used uh but you
can check them out
nevertheless then you have stochastic
gradient descent this is just a
variation of the linear models which
uses the gradient descent algorithm you
have something called the nearest
neighbors model the idea here is given a
data point you find the closest four or
five data points to it in the training
set and then just take the average of
those so you have nearest Neighbors
regression classification Etc you have
uh knife Bay you have decision trees
that we just looking at you have
Ensemble methods which includes random
Forest gradient boosting Etc gradient
boosting is something we will talk about
the next
time and yeah that and then you also
have neural networks which is just
another area which is just goes into a
topic called Deep learning but yeah you
have a lot of these that you can check
out okay this is still running so this
there's probably some issue
here let's just do n
estimators equals 20 and let's see if
that runs
faster
okay now uh an exercise for you is to
just try out some of these other models
and see if you can get a better result
than a random Forest I believe a random
Forest gets you to about 1,300 if I'm
not uh
mistaken and then you can tune the hyper
parameters as
well and then certain cases when it's
not a supervised learning problem you
can then apply some unsupervised
learning approaches that we will touch
on briefly towards the very end so here
you have clustering you have co-variance
estimation density estimation and
dimensionality reduction a bunch of
these uh
topics okay so now the random Forest has
run
with 20
estimators and I wonder what the output
is like so we'll see the output the next
time but now we come to the next and
probably one of the most important steps
once you have a good Baseline once you
are doing this whole once you're doing
this whole process of trying out
different models is to perform
regularization so you pick the model
that is working well and then you tune
its hyper
parameters and then you also try and
combine results from different models
all of which seem
promising so in general these are some
strategies that you can use to improve
the performance of your model so now you
have a model it's beating the Baseline
you want to make it better the best way
to improve the performance of the model
is to gather more data if you can get
your hands on more data just get more
data and that is going to uh capture
more relationships between the data
between the inputs and the targets it's
going to help you regularize and
generalize the model better as well try
and include more features the more
relevant features for predicting the
target you can get the better the model
gets so this could be by getting
additional data this could be by feature
engineering by carefully thinking about
which form of a certain feature is very
useful for example going from date to
day month and year is a huge leap that
is not something that a model can figure
out on its own a models are actually
pretty limited by the by the way in
which they are constructed so we need to
give them the right
features then tuning the hyper
parameters of the model can help so
remember hyper parameter tuning this is
how it works as you you change the a
certain hyperparameter the model's
complexity in a particular Dimension
goes from low to high as you increase
the complexity of the model initially
the model gets more powerful so it
starts to learn more about the data and
still keeps generalizing well but after
a certain time it starts to memorize
specific training examples and that's
the thing that you want to avoid right
so you need to find that best fit so
that's where you need to tune hyper
parameters so that they're not
underfitted but at the same time they're
also not overfitted because that
increases your test error uh and for
more information about this just go back
and review the decision trees and random
Forest lecture where we saw an example
of how wearing the max depth leads to
this kind of a curve between the
training loss and the validation
law
okay all right so this model has run now
so with 20 decision trees you can see
that we got it down to about
1396 uh so definitely a random Forest
regressor seems seems to be working
quite well for this particular problem
and this is a number that we can share
with business and then try to figure out
if this is a reasonable
value for prediction or
not okay so tuning hyper parameters is
another thing you can try one other
thing you should try is if you've tried
everything else uh You' you've been
tuning hyper parameters for a long long
time and you've know and you've tried
whatever feature engineering you could
come up with the next thing is to just
look at specific examples of where the
model is making incorrect or bad
predictions so you can make all the
predictions from the model and then you
can look at individual predictions side
by side with the targets and maybe just
compute what the difference is or um
whether the prediction matched or did
not match and find the ones where the
predictions were bad and use that to get
some insight look at those training data
points and maybe you'll figure out that
the model is missing a certain thing or
maybe you should give a certain weight
to a certain class or things like that
so looking at specific examples one by
one is always is a exceptionally good
strategy
because um it's okay to look at numbers
and numbers can just the metric just
goes up and down U you can't really get
a learn a lot from it but when you look
at specific examples you can apply your
insight into the domain into the problem
and figure out how to improve the model
then you can also do things like grid
search for hyperparameter optimization
if you're tired of tuning parameters on
your own you can set up a mechanism to
for this to happen automatically and
there's also another technique called
kfold cross validation which we will
cover in more detail the next time and
finally one other thing you can do is
you can combine the results from
different types of models or train
another model using the results of a
bunch of different models so this
technique is called ensembling and the
spe specific version of it is called
stacking so these are all more advanced
areas of machine learning now with
hyperparameter
optimization when you want to do it in
an automated fashion typically what you
do is you identify that these three or
four hyper parameters are the ones that
you want to tune and you identify the
ranges for those hyper parameters that
you want to test out and you can then
put this into a grid search
algorithm which is then going to create
models for each given set of hyper
parameters and then it's going to return
the result to you and you can pick the
best model out of them so I've pointed
to a tutorial here that you can try and
follow and we will apply hyperparameter
tuning to one of the models we train in
the
future next we have this technique
called kfold cross validation and this
is what kfold cross validation looks
like uh visually so we have some
training data and we have some test data
now instead of just picking taking one
portion of the training data as the
validation data what we can do is we can
split the training data into five folds
or five I mean you think of it like a
piece of paper and you fold it five
times so five equal portions and
then you train five different models for
the first model you use fold one as the
validation set and fold 2 3 4 5 as the
training set for the second model you
use fold two as the validation set and
fold 1 3 4 5 as the training set
for the third model you use fold three
as a validation set and you get the idea
so you're training five different models
on 80% of the data but each time it's a
different
80% and then what you can do is you can
make predictions using all five of those
models and simply average those
predictions out now the benefit of this
is instead of setting aside a single
validation set you
have used all of the training data while
still doing validation right so you
still have a validation score that you
can look at that you can use for tuning
hyper parameters but you are training on
the entire data that you have available
okay now this is going to be this is
going to perform a little poorly for
time series data or data ordered by time
because ideally we want to keep the
validation
data at the very end of the time period
but you could still try it it doesn't
hurt uh it's just it's giving the model
more data to train with so it's not bad
all right so cross validation again
something that you can do using psyit
learn and I have pointed to a tutorial
here as well and something that we will
apply uh the next
time next you have this technique called
ensembling and stacking and by the way
but for both of these for grid search it
may seem like a difficult thing to do
but it's because of the utilities that
you have in psychic learn it's actually
quite simple it's just like three or
four lines of code and you can always
look it up too similarly with kfold
cross validation it may seem ult okay
how am I going to split the data set
into five different pieces and then will
I need some for loops and will I have to
write some functions etc etc well all of
that is generally taken care for you you
you have this cfold class that you can
in include from Psychic learn and it is
just going to be three four lines of
code to perform all of
this it's actually easier to implement
than to um
explain next you have ensembling and
stack
so ensembling simply refers to combining
the results of multiple models and here
is what ensembling looks like visually
speaking you have the data you train
five different models and these could be
different kinds of models one could be a
linear regression model one could be a
svm one could be a random forest and one
could be a gradient boosting
machine and then you take predictions
from all of these models now depending
on classification or regression you
could do two different things things so
with classification then you just pick
the majority and with regression you
just take the average so in a way
ensembling and this something that we've
already covered is uh an extension of
random forests in random Forest we look
at 10 100 or 500 different decision
trees and then average their results but
in ensembling when you're doing a manual
ensembling we take five or six different
models and then we average their results
and all of these models are diverse so
some are linear models some
are some are tree based models some can
be like svm kernel based models and the
idea is each model can pick up some sort
of a diverse or some sort of a unique
way of relating the inputs to the
targets so when we average out their
predictions we the results that we get
may be better than what we may get from
any individual model that's not always
the case but that is the objective and
and if you do it well if you do it right
this works quite well one other thing
you can do is you can also give
weightages to each model maybe you know
that this model works is works well most
of the time so give it like an 80%
weightage and give these 5 10 and 5 10
and
10% uh 5 10 and 5% so then you would the
actual result for regression would be8 *
the result of this plus1 * the result of
this plus 05 * the result of this plus
05 * the result of this right so you can
give weights to the different
predictions and to the different models
so as an exercise just try and Ensemble
the result of a random forest with a
ridge regressor you there's nothing you
have to do you train a random Forest get
the predictions from the random Forest
train a ridge regressor get the
predictions from The Ridge regressor
then just average the two predictions
which means that add them together and
divide by two or if you want to apply
weights then maybe apply a weight of 08
to the random Forest and0 2 to the ridge
regression at add the predictions
together and see if you can get a better
score than either of the two models
individually okay and if you can do that
then you have uh then think about why
that is how is it possible that two
models when combined give a better score
than a single model and how the errors
average out and things like
that then there's something called
stacking which is a more advanced
version of ensembling where we train
another model using the results from
multiple model models now if you
remember I mentioned here we need we can
give weights to the different models
here model one can get a weight of
8.10 5.05 well how do you decide the
weights um you want to pick the weights
in such a way that the validation loss
is minimized or the validation uh
accuracy is
maximized so how about we just train a
linear regression model on top of
these ensembled results and figure out
the optimal weights so we can train a
linear regression model which takes the
outputs of each of
these models and figures out the best
weights to apply to them to minimize the
validation loss and this is called
stacking it's a natural extension of
ensembling again not very difficult to
implement it just um when you think
about it and think about how you might
implement it it might seem like a lot of
code but there are utilities to help you
do this and we will see uh
stacking in one of the models we train
to okay and this is now getting into
really Advanced territory but you will
see this done a lot in kaggle
competitions because if you see kaggle
competitions if you see the leaderboard
here this is the score that different
people have you can see that the
differences in score are very small you
can see 10999 and
988 so people are fighting for that
third fourth or fifth decimal place and
that's where all of these Advanced
Techniques help in production typically
you don't want to run all of these
models at once because it can get pretty
slow it can also get pretty resource
intensive so typically you only Ensemble
maybe two or three methods or two or
three models not more than that and
stacking also can go to multiple layers
you can have layers upon layers of
stacking but typically just one layer of
stacking is what you see in the industry
okay uh so yeah this is more of a survey
of some of these Advanced Techniques but
I encourage you to try it out
and once you've done all this hyper
parameter optimization ensembling
stacking Etc so now you will sort of
realize what is the best you can do with
the data that you have and the kind of
models that you have like you will hit a
wall at some point you will not get to
100% validation accuracy unfortunately
because that signal May simply not be
there in the input to uh give you the
Target right
but that's where you stop and you can
almost clearly see that point like we
saw here that we got to 1,300 with
random Forest maybe we try gradient
boosting maybe we get to 1250 or
something but I think it's going to be
very difficult to go beyond uh 1 1200
let's say or uh 1150 maybe we do a lot
of feature engineering and maybe we may
push it down to 1,000 but somewhere
there we are going to hit the limit now
at this point is where we start
interpreting the model and we prepare to
present our findings so what are we
going to do then well we have to first
explain why our model returns a certain
value so we have to explain why the
model returns a particular result and
most psychic learn models offer some
kind of a feature importance score for
linear models it is a coefficient for
decision trees it is this feature
importance
score so if you check the columns of the
training data frame you have these
columns and if you check inside a random
Forest the feature importances
underscore property you will see an
importance of each property like you
have store day month and you have the
importance of each of those features
here and then you can put that into a
data frame here so now we just putting
that into a data frame and you can now
see these are the different features and
these this is their importance and then
you can plot it so this is the kind of
thing that you want to ultimately show
in your presentation you in the
presentation you want to say that hey
the store is the biggest factor in
determining what the sales are going to
be like and then it seems like the
promotion is the next most important
factor and then it seems like the day
the month and the day of the week are
important factors too and then the store
type Etc have some bearing on that too
okay so maybe you may want to then get
more features that describe a store
maybe the area of the store is is an
important thing maybe the location of
the store is an important thing maybe
the number of people working at the
store is an important thing because all
of these could be indicators of how much
business the store does and all of this
information is available today so if you
can grab that information add those new
features then you will start making a
better prediction and that is how
machine learning projects work you don't
just train a model and report a a number
and a metric or loss and be done with it
you have to interpret and figure out
what more information we need how can we
make it better and it's an iterative
process that you have to keep improving
over and over okay and this is the kind
of chart that you will present to
non-technical stakeholders to explain
how the model arrives at uh its result
and if you wanted even greater
explainability then you can just use a
single decision tree maybe the decision
trees prediction is a little worse it's
off it's maybe instead of 1,300 it's at
14400 but the interpretability that you
get out of it maybe that might be more
useful to one convince people that your
model is working and second make a case
that they should gather some other
information like let's say if they want
to uh get the information about how many
people work at every store or what is a
footfall at every store that's there
well but like the area of every store
Etc they would have to put some
resources into it and that's where you
have to make a case as a data scientist
because everything costs something right
so everything has a
cost and now one other thing you should
do is you should start showing some
individual predictions so you should do
it yourself and you should also show it
in your presentation in your
presentation the number the training
curve is not going to be impactful what
is going to be impactful is some
specific examples so here I've defined
this predict input function and inside
this predict input function you can see
that I've encoded some logic that if I
get a single input and that input is
going to be a dictionary now if the
store is not open I simply return zero
if it is on if it is open then we create
a data frame just like the training data
frame or the test data frame we compute
the day we add all the pre-processing
steps that we've done for a training and
test data which is to convert date to a
datetime column extract the day month
year remember your model needs all this
information so any new data that comes
in has to go through the same
pre-processing steps then we impute uh
missing values using the imputer that we
have already trained so we shouldn't
lose track of that imputer we should
keep that same imputer around and
similarly we shouldn't lose track of the
scaler because we need to scale to the
same ratio that we have used for the
training set and then the encoder as
well you need to keep the encoder around
and the name of encoded columns around
and after this all of this
pre-processing you get this x input
which is just the single data frame with
all the imputed encoded scaled data as
numbers that can be passed into the
model for getting a prediction and you
pass this one row of this data frame
containing just one row of data into the
model and you get back a prediction from
the model okay and here's a sample input
and you can try playing around with the
sample input you can try changing the
date here and uh then you can just make
a prediction with the sample input and
show what this looks like so it seems
like the prediction here is
4107 now this is the kind of thing that
you want to showcase or maybe even build
a simple tool for people to play with
like if you have uh somebody on the
business side who wants to just play
with your model you can maybe set up a s
simple web page for them using tools
like the flask web framework and in that
page they could just make and they could
just enter all of these things so they
could just fill all this information
into a form
and they would click submit and that
that information would then be sent into
a machine learning model and then you
will return the value
41076 5 out and somebody who has and
maybe this could be shared with store
managers as well and what store managers
can now do is put in these values and
check if the value that comes out makes
sense to them makes sense for their
store and if a lot of store managers
come back and say that no this value
seems wrong to me then maybe there is
some problem maybe you're getting a good
loss maybe you're getting a uh maybe
you're getting a good value for the
evaluation metric because that's what
you optimized for but in the real world
the model isn't really performing well
right so don't underestimate the
importance of these qualitative
checks one other thing that you'll
gather out of this is if you notice that
a certain parameter as you moving it up
and down is affecting the output more
than it should then maybe your model has
picked up
some unintended correlation which it
shouldn't have uh so that's where you
can then go back and decide do I really
want to have this column or not U
because this column seems to be causing
some correlation with the output but I
know from basic common sense or human
Insight or business Insight that this
shouldn't have a correlation that's
where you need to work with business and
you need to give them these tools to
play with your model and interpret this
model in their own uh head
okay so look at various examples from
the training validation and test sets to
decide if you're happy with the result
of your model and then you need to
present your results you need to present
what you've done whether it is a weekly
presentation that you give or it is a
monthly presentation or maybe once at
the end of the um of the entire project
but ideally you should be communicating
as frequently as possible so you will
need to then create a presentation for
non-technical stakeholders and you need
to understand your audience figure out
what they care about most probably what
they care about most is how much maybe
the metric is something that they care
about but they probably also want to
understand how it works so don't uh
ignore that maybe first time you just
want to present a decision tree get
their confidence that the decision tree
works well and then tell them that maybe
100 decision trees all of which are
slightly different combined is are going
to give a better result and that's why
you should be using a random forest and
then avoid showing any code or any
technical jargon you definitely don't
want to show code you definitely also
don't want to show Too Much technical
jargon you can mention that this is a
technique we're using just for
mentioning it but don't talk about it
for too long the more important thing is
to show visualizations and deliver
insights in simple words you should be
able to if you understand your model
well enough you should be able to
explain in simple words why you have
chosen the kind of model that you've
chosen why you've engineered the kind of
features that you've engineered and what
the results of your model are I mean if
you're saying that my model's cross
entropy is
23 that's not conveying anything useful
and that probably indicates that you
have not understood how to interpret
that value but if you're saying on the
other hand
that most of the time the model is
correct like 98% of the time the model
is
correct but it has a slightly high false
positive ratio and that is something
that may maybe we may want to discuss
and then you can if they don't know what
false positive is you can go into that
and have more detailed conversations
around that and maybe show them a
visualization maybe show them a heat map
a heat map is much easier to understand
compared to numbers like if you're
presenting correlations or if you're
presenting feature
importances the numbers themselves don't
really make sense but when you present
it as a bar chart then anybody can make
out that ah this is more important
important than
that and focus on the metrics that are
relevant for the business don't use loss
functions uh use the metrics that have
been agreed upon the metrics that they
care about talk about feature importance
talk about how to interpret the results
explain the strengths of the model and
the limitations of the model this is
where you can draw out specific examples
and say that hey this is the kind of
example that it goes wrong with and
somebody might then come to you and say
okay this is there's a easy fix for this
how about you simply I can get you some
more data for this particular case will
you be able to fix it Etc or you may
then decide with some discussion that
this is a special case and we don't want
to deal with this special case right now
or maybe we want to train a different
model all that all of that will come out
of discussion and finally also want to
explain how the model can be improved
over time whether you need more data
whether you should be retraining the
model uh every 2 months and this is one
of the limitations of the model that we
just trained right I can be confident
that for the months of August and
September it's probably going to work
pretty well but for other months
especially the the Christmas season I
don't think the model is going to work
really well because you didn't give me
that test data or I I couldn't use that
data for
validation so those are the kind of
things that you have to convey uh so
that you are not setting the wrong
expectations and it seems like obvious
things but most machine learning models
and you can look this up like 80 or 90%
of machine learning models that get
deployed fail and they fail Miss
miserably because of either uh not
having a clear communication about the
requirements or the data scientist not
picking a good validation set which is
reflective of the kind of data that the
model will see in the real world or just
optimizing the wrong metric optimizing
just the loss while they should have
been optimizing a certain business
metric right so those are the kind of
things that you have to keep in mind and
uh that is what makes a good data
scientist okay so one last thing I want
to tell you is how to make a submission
on
kaggle Now quickly to recap from kaggle
we went to the data Tab and from here we
downloaded the data you can download it
directly here or you can also download
it using uh the open data sets tool then
we loaded up train.csv and we loaded up
store. CSV we added the data from
store we added the data from store to
train so we added a bunch of new columns
we also loaded up test. CSV test did not
have um the sales or the customer
information and we've not yet looked at
sample
submission so here's what we're going to
do we are going to first look at these
look at the test data so that that is X
test we have been doing all the
pre-processing on it even though we've
not used it yet and let's pass the test
data into predict So Random forest.
predict test predictions and this gives
us the predictions on the test set okay
looking good then let us load up this
submission DF uh this submission. CSV
file so kagle gives you always gives you
this sample submission.csv file and
let's take a look at this
file so it seems like there is an ID
column and then there is a sales column
and we need to fill out the sales column
okay and how are we going to do that
well here's one thing I could
do we could just do submission DF Sales
equals test sprads right because if you
see test uh if you see the test
DF it has these IDs 1 2 3 4 5 and these
IDs are in the same order and we have
not changed the IDS so from the test DF
we have performed some pre-processing
and then we have picked out X test and X
test does not contain the ID column but
it does not change the order of rows so
the outputs that we are getting from X
test which is the test sprads all of
these outputs apply to all of these IDs
in the exact same order so I have loaded
up the submission DF which contains all
the IDS and in the sales column it
currently says zero wherever it says
zero I am simply going to put in the
value of test PRS okay that seems fine
to me and I can check submission DF now
so you now see that there is a
prediction for each one of these but one
other thing that I should be doing
is filling in the values of
wherever wherever the store is closed
remember our model doesn't know how to
handle that so wherever the store is
closed we need to fill in a zero there
right so here's what I'm going to do we
have test
DF and in test DF we have
open okay so open is either one or zero
you can you can check this value
counts so open is either one or
zero um so I'm just going to convert
this to an integer as type
int okay there seem to
be some n Nan values I'm just going to
wherever open is Nan so I'm just going
to do fill na one so just assume it's
open and as
type
int so now this is a one or a zero
column okay and if I multiply this with
test sprads what will happen is wherever
we have a prediction that will just get
the prediction test spread and wherever
we have a zero or sorry wherever we have
a one that will just take the value from
test sprads and wherever we have a zero
that will just fill in a zero so in this
way we are just filling in
zeros into the places
where the store is not
open so we're completely ignoring the
models prediction when the store is not
open and just filling in a zero okay so
that's how we fill in this information
so now I can just put that directly into
the submission data frame so we take the
test predictions and we multiply it with
whether the store is open or not if the
store is open it's a one so we will get
the actual value predicted from the
model if the store is closed then test
DF open will be zero and we will get
the value zero which is correct because
when the store is closed
the sales are going to be zero okay all
right so with that what we've done is
we've loaded up the submission file make
test predictions added this added these
predictions back into the subm sub
Mission file the last thing we need to
do is
now write it back to a CSV file so I'm
just going to do submission DF do2 CSV
submission.
CSV and I'm also setting index equals
none the reason for this is uh if I
don't set this let me just open the file
and show you first so here's submission.
CSV the file we just created this file
contains an ID and this file contains a
sales and if you don't pass index equals
none if you don't pass index equals none
then a third column this this new column
will get added to so just to avoid that
third column I've put index equals n and
you can see what happens when you do it
without but yeah here is the submission.
CSV file it contains ID and sales this
is the prediction on the test set and we
can then download this file so one way
to download it is from here we have the
download option another way to download
is to generate a file
link this this is just a IPython useful
IPython tool where you can generate a
file link and then you can just download
that file okay that doesn't seem to work
in on Google collab um in any case I'm
just going to download it from
here yep now we have the file I'm just
going to save it on my
desktop so we made predictions for the
test set and now we have this file
downloaded and I'm just going
to take this file
now
submission.csv and you can take a look
at it here this is the submission.csv
file all the test predictions I am going
to go back to the kaggle competition
page click on late submission because
this competition is already closed
otherwise we this should just say
submission and then there's an upload
button here I'm going to click the
upload
button and I am going to click
submission.csv and where is this
submission coming from if you see this
comes
from uh RF so this is my random Forest
so I'm just going to add a note here
random forest with 20
estimators and the file is uploaded I
click make a submission so now what
kagle is doing is comparing the
predictions from my
file yeah I think that's done so KAG is
comparing the predictions from my file
to the actual data that they have for
the test set which was not shared from
shared with us so it was actually hidden
from us and now you can actually see
where you are on the leaderboard now
because this competition is ended you
will not actually feature on the
leaderboard but if this competition was
live then you would show up on the
leaderboard somewhere so let's see this
number here1
14431 let's go on the leaderboard and uh
there are two leaderboards interestingly
there's a public leaderboard and a
private leaderboard so here's what
happens just to make it even harder for
you when you make when you upload your
uh CSV file you are shown your rank on
the public leaderboard which is only
calculated using 33% of the test
data and then when the competition ends
they will then show you the private
leaderboard which is calculated on the
remaining 67% of the test
data and you see how much the the
extents to which they are going to
prevent overfitting because they do not
want you to overfit to the public
leaderboard they want your model to
generalize and overfitting is the
central problem in machine learning so
you make predictions on the test set and
then you make a uh you upload your
predictions based on that you get your
public leaderboard score every day you
can make four or five predictions so you
try to optimize your public leaderboard
score but you shouldn't overfit to the
public leaderboard so you should make
sure that your model General izes well
enough and at the end of the competition
the models that were best generalized
and also the most powerful or well
trained show up at the top and you will
often see a discrepancy you see
sdnt they had the highest score on the
they're the best score on the public
leaderboard but on the private
leaderboard where are they they fell six
positions so they overfitted to the
public leaderboard essentially and this
person G moved up and in fact neami
moved up 10 places so it's a very
interesting thing to just observe with
every competition in any case our score
was1
14431 let's see where that comes in and
there are about 3,500 okay
3,298 participants in this
challenge let's see. 144
31 now remember we've not really
optimized our model so you can see that
it's expected to be pretty bad but here
we are 14 yeah 143 somewhere around this
much right so we
are at the position 300 2,000 out of
3,200
that's not that good but that's not too
bad either in general with the kaggle
competition if you can be in the top
half that means you've trained a useful
model because the competition at the top
is very intense and people are just
fighting for the last decimal points but
if you're in the top half then you've
trained the useful model and if if
you're in the top 10% which means if
you're in the top
300 then you've trained a really good
model so here's the challenge for you
replicate this notebook and try and get
within the top 10% which means try and
get within uh 329 right so or even try
top 20% try and get within the top 500
if you can actually get within the top
500 with all of these techniques and all
of these resources then you are training
pretty good machine learning
models nobody can deny you
that and that's what we have for today
and you can make multiple submissions so
you can see a history of your
submissions here you can see these are
some submissions that I've made and uh
it seems like I was able to get to 1.43
with a 100 estimate
and there's a lot more hyper parameter
tuning that can be done and then you can
take some of this score and you can
probably just then put it on this
experiments and maybe just put the test
score here so this is how you work
through a kaggle competition you have a
list of ideas that you want to try out
and then you predict what those ideas
will do you also note down the learnings
once you actually try out those ideas
and lot of times your learnings will be
different from your predictions and then
you keep track of your hyper parameters
systematically one last thing that
people tend to do is at the very end of
a kaggle competition when the deadline
is about to close they will pick their
five best models and then they will
Ensemble which means they will average
out the predictions or maybe they will
stack which means they will train
another model on top of those
predictions and that's how they will
then get to the
top and the good thing about kaggle
competitions is you can see what the
winners have coded so if you just go to
the discussion section on for the code
section you can see what feature
engineering they've done you can see
what how they've trained models you can
see how they've applied cross validation
you can see how they've
applied um what imputation techniques
they've used and there is no better way
to learn than to learn from winners of
kaggle competitions so get into the
habit of reading code if you can start
reading and understanding code and a lot
of these have pretty good documentation
around it as well but if you can get
into habit of reading code then there is
so much you can learn learn and this
information isn't there anywhere else in
the world or in no textbook no course is
going to have this information the what
you want to do is go to kaggle
competitions go through the codes first
attempt it yourself go through the
discussions go through the code section
see what people have tried read their
code copy paste their code modify it try
a few things on top of it and that is
how you're going to become an effective
machine learning practitioner right and
whatever you need to learn along the way
you can learn the theory as well so an
exercise for you to is to repeat the
steps from this notebook on the breast
cancer identification data set that is
not a competition that is just a data
set but still worth repeating all these
steps and you can just pick out some
other kaggle competitions and try to
work through them look for competitions
where people have trained random forest
or decision trees and you should be fine
one last piece we've not covered here is
that you need to then hand over the
model to the software developer once
you're happy with the model once once
everybody's on board who can then put
the model into production as a part of
an existing Software System and then you
need to monitor the results and then
make improvements from time to time like
every 2 3 months you can train this
model U this is something that you
here's another tutorial that you can
check out this requires knowledge of the
flask framework and the Heroku platform
so not something that data scientists
typically have to do because this is
handed over to software developers but
still a good thing to just learn and try
out okay so that's how you work on a
machine learning project you understand
the business requirements and the nature
of the available data you classify the
problem as a supervised or unsupervised
learning problem and with regression or
classification you perform some data
cleaning you clean explore visualize the
data and you create new features you
perform some data preparation where you
create training test validation sets you
perform imputation categorical encoding
Etc you come up with some quick quick
Baseline models just to evaluate your
future models then you train a bunch of
different models that are applicable to
your problem and pursue the ideas that
are working well you apply
regularization hyperparameter tuning
ensembling stacking kfold cross
validation and finally you then
interpret and present these
models to the other
stakeholders and work with them
iteratively and this is not a linear
process you can you may have to go back
and forth sometimes you may have to
refine the business requirements
sometimes you may have to change the
type of problem you can say that I can't
predict exactly but I can give you a few
categories is that good enough for you
sometimes you may want to perform some
additional cleaning sometimes you may
want to get more features in so you go
back and forth but this is how you
should set up a notebook and then you
should have this spreadsheet on the side
in the spreadsheet list out all your
ideas put your ideas into AC ction into
the notebook and then keep recording the
results of your experiments and you will
be an effective data
scientist the topic for today is
gradient boosting machines or gbms with
XG boost and here's what we're going to
cover today we're going to download a
real world data set from a kaggle
competition we are going to perform
feature engineering and prepare the data
set for
training we're going to train and
interpret a gradient boosting model
using the XG boost
Library we're going to
train with kfold cross validation so
it's a different kind of validation
technique and we will also Ensemble the
results once we do the kfold cross
validation we'll also look at how to
configure the gradient boosting model
and how to tune its hyper
parameters gradient boosting is a very
powerful technique it's probably one of
the most powerful classical machine
learning algorithms so pretty much any
problem concerning with tabular data you
may find it useful to try out gradient
boosting and it's based on a very simple
but elegant idea which we will discuss
as we come to the model
training so let's begin by installing
the required
libraries now here I'm installing numai
Panda matte plot lip seon Jovian open
data sets XG boost this is the library
we're using today and graph wi this is
required to visualize the trees that are
created within XG poost um and light GBM
as well if you want to use light
GBM and one issue you may face from time
to time is when a certain notebook runs
on your computer but does not run on
collab or if it runs on collab but does
not run on your computer whenever you
face such issues where the same code
does not run in two different
environments or maybe leads to an error
in two different environments you want
to make sure that the version of the
libraries that you have in installed in
the two environments are the same so
what I mean by that is if you do pip
list
and run it you should be able to see the
versions of all the libraries you have
installed um and there is another tool
called GP so you can after pip list you
can just type this pipe character type
GP and let's say type XG
boost and that will just show you the
version of XG boost that you have
installed which in this case is 1.4.2 if
you do not have this grap it's just
going to show you a whole bunch of
libraries all of the libraries that you
have installed which may become too much
so that's why it's useful especially on
collab to just add a grap here and check
the version now there are other ways to
check versions too but this is one that
is standard across all packages
installed because it uses the PIP
package manager so we are using XG boost
1.4.2 okay so we are going to take a
practice practical and coding focused
approach here so we will learn gradient
boosting by applying it to a real world
data set and we are going to pick the
data set from a kaggle competition this
kaggle competition is called the Rosman
store
sales
competition and here is some description
about
it Rosman is a company that operates
over 3,000 drug stores in 7 European
countries this is a real company and
this is all real data and currently
Rosman store managers are tasked with
predicting their daily sales for up to 6
weeks in
advance now store sales are influenced
by many factors for example if there is
a promotion running at the store or if
the entire company is running a
promotion if there is a competing store
nearby um the school and state holidays
because that affects people's behavior
seasonality and
locality now with thousands of
individual managers predicting sales
based on their unique circumstances the
accuracy of of the results can be quite
varied so you are provided the
historical data for
1,115 Rosman stores and the task is to
forecast the sales column for the test
set and your task is to forecast the
sales column for the test set so we will
just look at the training set and the
test set but this is what we want to
predict we have data of 1,115 stores and
we want to predict the sales on every
single day okay
and we are going to download the data
from the Gaggle competition now we just
go to the data Tab and this is where we
can see some description about the data
so it turns out that there are four
files train. CSV test.csv sample
submission CSV and store. CSV and we can
look at the files here so if you're
unable to see this table here just go to
rules and click I accept the rules
otherwise you will not be able to see
the data
and here in the data tab you can see
train.csv so train.csv the file contains
nine columns it's shown in a tabular
format where you have some kind of a
store ID store IDs go from 1 to
1,115 you have a date this is the date
and they've conveniently also provided
which day of the week it is 1 to 7
Monday to Sunday I would imagine uh then
they have given you the sales and
dollars on that particular date uh
they've also G given you the number of
customers who came to the store on that
particular date they mentioned whether
the store is open whether the store is
running a promotion whether it was a
state holiday and whether it was a
school holiday so all of this is
important information that can determine
the
sales and let's check the test.csv file
and let's see what's different
here so test.csv file also contains
stores 1 to 1,115 apart from that there
seems also for each row they seem to
have added an ID presumably this is for
evaluation of your submissions because
you have to make predictions on the test
set and submit it to this Gaggle
competition then you have the day of the
week and date as before one thing you
will notice is that the dates in the
test
set occur after the training set and
that's just to reflect how the model
will be used in real life you train on
data from the past and you make
predictions on data from the future
and then it has open promo state holiday
and School holiday the things that it
does not have is the number of customers
and the sales
now this means that you cannot use
customers as the input to predict sales
but you can
use all the other things you can use
things like the store the day of the
week date you will have to figure out
what to do with it because all these
dates occur in the future so they don't
exactly occur on the training set maybe
we'll have to modify find some way but
you can use all of these things too so
this is a typical machine learning
problem you have a training file you
have a test file but you have one more
other file here store. CSV and this
contains metadata about the 1,115 stores
now if I go back to train you can see
that we have several uh rows of data for
every store it's not that if you check
the total number of rows you will see
that the total number of rows is about
1.2 million so for every store we have
data for the entire date range which is
from 1st January 2013 to 31st July 2015
on the other hand if you check stores we
simply have 1,115 rows and we have some
metadata for each store we have
information like the store type we have
information like the the assortment so
this conveys something about what the
store offers we have information about
uh competition distance so I think this
is how far away a compet a a competitor
is a nearby competitor is yeah and you
can check the description here you have
something called competition distance
which is distance in meters to the
nearest competitor store then we have
this competition open since and open
since month and open sense year so
competition open sense month gives you
the approximate year and month of the
time the nearest competitor was
open yep so for example this competitor
this competitor is open since 2008
and September of 2008 was when this
competitor opened then there is also the
second promotion that is running here so
this second promotion promo indicates
whether a store was uh so promo
indicates whether a store was running a
promo in that day this is part of the
training set but there is promo 2 and
promo 2 is a part of the store. CSV file
so promo 2 is a companywide
promotion it is a continuing and
consecutive promotion for some stores so
if stores participate in this
companywide promotion promo 2 has the
value zero otherwise promo two have the
has the value one and this is not
dependent on the date um this is just a
store- wise
configuration and then there are a
couple of other columns called promo to
since week and promo to since year so
this means stores start participating in
this companywide
promotion from a certain date and year
so you're given the you're given the
certain you're given the year and you're
giving the week number in the year when
a particular store started participating
in this companywide
promotion there also seems to be another
thing called promo interval which
describes the conse consecutive
intervals promo 2 is started so it seems
like with promo 2
you start this promotion several times
in a year let's say maybe this is some
kind of a competition that you're
running or some kind of a raffle or
something so it seems like there is a
certain promotion that you are starting
multiple times so promotion is started a
new and here when you have Feb May
August and November this means that each
round of this promotion to this
companywide promotion is executed by
that store in February May August
November okay so there's a lot of
information here this and this is
something that you would have to read
carefully and try to understand U but
this is storewide information and we
will have to figure out how to use this
information on a day-to-day uh in the
day-to-day data which is a train.csv
data
okay so that's a quick overview of the
data set and finally what we need to do
here is make this file Sam submission.
CSV file and the submission.csv file
should have IDs and this ID should
reflect the ID from the test set and the
sales here should be filled in with the
predicted sales that your
model comes up with after training on
the training data for the test set okay
so the ID would be the ID from the test
set like this and the predicted sale
would come here and then you create a
submission. CSV file and then you can
make these submissions so you given some
training data you have to train a model
using the training data and then you
have to make some predictions on the
test data and then you submit these
predictions and once you submit these
predictions
on the leaderboard you will be able to
see where your predictions rank okay now
this competition has already ended but
you can still make submissions and you
can still track where you land on the
leaderboard okay so that's the data set
and we can download the data set from
kaggle directly within Jupiter using the
open data sets library now one option is
to download this data from this tab here
onto your computer and upload it to
collab but the easier way is to just use
the open data sets library and make sure
to accept the competition rules before
you try to download the data so just go
to the data tab uh sorry go to the rules
Tab and click I accept the competition
rules and review them as
well now once you have done that then we
just going to import open data sets as
OD and then I'm going to run od.
download and to od. download we simply
give the link link of the competition
which is just this part kaggle.com c/
Rosman store sales now we give the link
of link of the competition here and you
are then asked for your kagle
username and then you will also have to
supply your kaggle API key which you can
get by going into your account on kagle
so just click your user your avatar
click on account and go down and click
create new API to token and that's going
to save the file kaggle Json to your
computer and once I open it up I will be
able to see my kaggle credentials here
so I'm just going to copy this now this
is a secret so you should not be
entering it don't save it in a variable
within a jupyter
notebook okay let me try that
again
all right so let me open my kaggle key
and here I have my
username and I'm entering my kagle API
key and that downloads the data set for
me okay and you can verify that the data
set is downloaded here in the file
browser
all right so let's check the files that
have been
downloaded so as expected it is the
exact same files sample submission train
test and store. CSV the first thing
we'll do is load them into pandas data
frames so I'm going to load train. CSV
into this data frame called Ross DF or
Rossman DF I am going to load store test
and submission data frames as well and
let's take a look at each of
these so this this is Rosman DF and this
contains exactly the information that we
saw earlier store the date the day of
week for that date the sales on that
date customers open promo state holiday
and School holiday and there are over 1
million rows of data so that's a lot of
data to train on then we have the test
data frame here we
have here we have an ID store date day
of week open promo state holiday and
School holiday as before no customers
and no sales
then we have the submission data frame
this is the data frame we have to
generate these are IDs from the test.csv
file and this is where we need to put in
our sales to generate our submission
file and finally we have the store data
frame where for all the 1,115 stores we
have a bunch of
information now the first thing I would
do in such a situation is to Simply
merge the information from store DF into
train DF and test DF because it would be
a lot more useful if this information
was part of this train of Ross DF so
along with all of this if we also had
the information like the assortment at
at the store the category of the store
etc
etc so that's what I'm going to do I am
going to merge I'm going to call Ross DF
which is the train. CSV file merge store
DF which is the information about the
store and we are going to do a left
outer join which means that we want to
retain all the days of data from the
training set we don't want to miss any
days and for each day we want to add the
information for that appropriate store
so we're joining on the store column and
a similar join we are doing on the test
set as well so this is what the merge
data frame looks like now you have the
store the day of the week the date the
sales the customers uh whether it's a
state holiday Etc and then you have
store type assortment competition
distance etc etc okay and of course
these details will get repeated several
times each time we have a row where the
store number is one all of these details
will get repeated
okay now this is the point where we
would do some exploratory data analysis
and this is something that I will leave
as an exercise for you so study the
distribution of values in each column
and study their relationship or their
correlation with the target column
sales okay so with that we have
downloaded our data set and I'm just
going to save my work here so on Google
ABB when you run jan. commit to save a
snapshot of your notebook you will be
asked for an API key so just go to your
Jovian profile click on copy API key
come back and paste the API key here so
just open Jovian and in the get started
tab you should see this button and once
you paste it here this notebook is now
saved and a snapshot of this notebook
has been captured and save to your
Jovian profile so this is the snapshot
of The Notebook on your profile that you
can run anytime okay and you can always
access this by going back to jan. and
checking the notebooks tab you can see
here all right so let's talk about
pre-processing
and a new and very important topic
feature
engineering so let's take a look at the
available columns and see if we can
create any new columns or apply any
useful
Transformations now one thing I'm
already seeing here is that we have a
date column and just the date value by
itself may not be very useful because
all the information from the date in the
training set belongs to the past
but all the dates in the test set occur
after the dates in the training set but
what will be more more useful from the
date is maybe extracting some parts out
of the date things like the year the
month
the day of the month Maybe because a lot
of stores have monthly Cycles so they
may have higher sales or lower sales
towards the end or beginning of the
month people get their salaries at the
beginning of the month so they may spend
more during the first couple of weeks so
the day of the month might be useful the
week of the year might also be useful
whether it is the first week of the year
A lot of people are making new purchases
or the last week of the year when it's a
holiday season versus maybe somewhere in
between where it's not as
busy
so date is something that we may want
want to First convert it into a date
time object right now it is just object
and second we may want to pass out
information from the date so that's what
we are going to do we are going to
extract different parts of the date and
because we have to do this both on the
training set and on the test set and
later we will also have to do it when we
try to make predictions on single inputs
so this is where we defining a split
date function so the split date function
takes a data frame and first it converts
the date column into the date time
column here using pd. two date time then
it extracts out the year the month the
day and the week of the
year and now we can call split date on
merge TF and merge test TF both of these
so merg TF is simply the train.csv
combined with the store. CSV file and
merge test DF is simply the test.csv
now we have a merge data frame as you
can verify here and in this merge data
frame you will now see these things year
month day and week of year note that we
already have day of week so we don't
need to extract that so we already know
whether it's a Monday Tuesday Wednesday
Thursday Friday or Saturday or Sunday
and this is essentially what feature
engineering is a model may not be able
to make a lot of sense out of a string
to 2015 0731 or even if you convert it
to a number of some kind but once you
put it in this format you are now
helping your model a model will be able
to figure out a lot more more because
now it can pick up monthly patterns now
it can pick up patterns that happen
through the month so the daily patterns
now it can pick up the weekly patterns
over the year and it can also pick up
the pattern during the week okay so all
of these patterns will can now be picked
up from our model so that was one useful
thing to do the next thing to notice is
that there is
this there is this column called open
this tells you whether the store is open
on a certain date and if the store is
not open on a certain date it's quite
likely that there will not be any sales
so let's maybe verify that if we just
check from merge DF just extract those
rows where merg DF do open is zero which
means where the store is closed and
check the sales on those dates and see
what all different values sales takes uh
on those dates so it turns out that the
only value in the cases where the store
is closed is zero so there are
172,000 rows of data out of the million
where the store is closed and on all
those days the sales are zero and you
can verify this if you remove value
counts you'll see that all these all
these sales are zero and that's what
we've done here just by putting in value
counts as well
okay so now instead of trying to model
this relationship using a machine
learning model it would be a lot easier
to just hard Cod this in our predictions
I mean it's our model has a limited
capacity or a limited power whatever
kind of model we're training
and the fact that it has to figure out
that when open is zero then the sales
are zero that is just some additional
work which we can save the model we can
do a very simple hard coding here we can
just hardcode this relationship in our
predictions so that whenever we are
making any predictions on the test set
for example we can simp simply set the
sales to zero if the store is closed so
that's what we can do for the test set
what do we do in the training set so in
the training set I would argue that the
best thing we can do right now is simply
remove all these rows and just train a
model which works
on data for when the store is open okay
so we are only building this model for
the days where the store is open and
that will make it easier for the model
to learn some of these um other
relationships which are not as easy to
guess so here's what we're doing we say
merg tf. openen equals equals 1 this is
going to select all the days where the
store is open and we select all those
rows of data and uh so now for all the
stores all the days when stores are open
are selected here and we're just
creating a copy here so that we can make
some modifications to this data frame
without affecting the old data frame
okay so now we've removed from the
training set all the days and all all
the days or all the entries where the
particular store was which that row was
referring
to we are not going to remove any rows
from the test set because remember we
have to actually generate predictions
for all the rows in the test set so we
can't ignore any rows we just ignoring
from training because we don't want to
train on data when the store was
closed okay so let's get get into a
little more advanced feature engineering
here now there is this competition open
or there is this competition open since
month SL year column if I just check
merge
DF you can see here there is a
competition distance this tells you what
is the distance in meters to a competing
store from maybe a different company and
competition open since so this tells you
when this store was opened so this was
this store opened in September of 2008
and what day are we looking at here we
are looking at
25731 right for this particular store
maybe let me pick a sample so that we
can see some variety
here okay so let's let's see this one
for example we looking at the data for
store number 925 on 2015 March 7 so it's
March 7 2015 and it turns out that there
is a competing store at 470 M away and
that store has been open since
2007 March all right now we we can pass
this information into the model which is
how when the store opened and which
month the store opened in the competing
store but something that will be a lot
more useful for the model is if we
simply one if we can simply
indicate whether there is a compet store
and if there is a competing store for
how long has it been open okay and how
long how do we quantify that we can
simply maybe count the number of months
that the store has been open
for so for example if you're looking at
2015 here so 2015 minus 2007 that is
about 8 years and March 2015 uh March
2007 to March 2015 so that's about yeah
that's about exactly 8 years and zero
months so this particular store has been
open for 8 * 12 96 months so I would
argue that instead of telling the model
that the competition has been open
since since March of 2007 it would be a
lot for a lot more useful for us to tell
the model that the competing store has
been open for 96 months okay on the
particular day for which we are trying
to model this relationship right so this
is what we're going to do for every day
or for every row we are going to pick
out the current day and using the
current day and using the information in
the competition open since month and
competition open since year we are going
to calculate a new column called
competition open and competition open is
simply going to be the number of months
that the competing store has been open
and the general idea here is the longer
a competing store has been open uh the
more impact it will have on this store
sales because
that's just a that's just a hypothesis
and that's what that's something we're
going to try out okay and you may have
different ways of looking at this but
this is just one approach that uh we
just going to try out and see if it
helps the
model so we're defining this comp
months function which takes a data frame
and first it
checks how many years the competition
has been open since compared to the
current year remember we've already
extracted out year so so we can do 2015
minus 2007 and then we also add to it
how many additional months there are so
if the current date is July of 2015 the
the date in the particular row and the
competition has been open since March of
2007 so we go 2015 - 2007 * 12 so that's
128 96 and then we go
July which is actually stored as a
number 7 minus March which is 3 so 7 - 3
is 4 so we had four more months so this
will say that the competition has has
been open for 100 months and of course
we are doing that row by Row for every
row okay now the only difficulty is
sometimes it's possible that maybe a
competing store opened in 2014 or in
so we don't want to put in information
about the future into any row so we
don't want to put in for example if we
have information about store number one
we're looking at January 1st 13 at that
point there is no competing store so at
that point we should probably just put
in zero U for competition
open or maybe put in some other number
like
na so that's one thing to to take care
of that we don't want to put information
about the future into the past so that's
why there is this additional line and
I'll let you figure out how exactly this
works but this additional line simply
replaces the negative values with zero
so wherever the competition open has a
negative value which means that there is
no competing store yet but it will open
up sometime in the future then there we
replace it with zero
okay so after doing all of
this the result is this so if I just
pick out the competition related columns
you can see here we have and I'm just
picking a random sample here we have
this is this is one row from the
training set so we have this date 2013
518 then we have the distance of the
competing store 250 M then we have the
compet competitions open since year and
competition open since month and we have
here calculated how many months the
competition has been open for okay and
this is far more useful for our model
than this or this okay and this has been
calculated using the date using the
competition opens since year and
competition opens since month all right
and in the cases where there is no
competing store nearby the value is zero
in the cases where a competing store
will open in the future in that case
also the value will be zero I can't find
a good example here but yeah in so let's
suppose the date here is 2013 and the
competition open since is
2014 then this value would also be zero
okay so that's just some feature
engineering
that people try and do to make
information to present information in a
form that can be most useful for the
model
all right now there is
another
other column set of columns which is to
do with promo 2 so if you recall promo 2
is basically
representing a companywide promotion
that stores participate in and it's a
recurring promotion so if a store
participates in promo 2 then you will
see the number one here otherwise you
will see the number zero and then there
is certain date at which every store has
signed up for this companywide promotion
at different dates so you can see those
dates here once again we have year and
we have week so using this maybe we can
just identify for how long this store
has been running a certain promotion so
we can just compute how many months the
store has been running a certain
promotion for and then this promotion is
something that is kicked off multiple
times every year so that that's where we
have this promo interval and here this
tells you that this promotion 2 was
kicked off at that store every Jan April
July and October
since sometime in 2010 okay so one thing
we can do is combine these two to just
compute for how long the promo 2 has
been running at a particular store and
the second thing we can do is we can
identify if at the current
date at the current date in the current
month is a new promotion starting right
so we can just check that as well and
that might be useful information because
this by itself is not something that we
can pass into the model but if we can
use this information combine it with the
current month compare it with the
current month and create a new column
telling us
whether a promotion is getting kicked
off in the current month that might be a
more useful piece of information to the
model okay so that is what we're going
to do here and there are a couple of
functions that perform this so this I
will leave as an exercise for you this
is is primarily just some pandas data
frame manipulations and the end result
of all of
this once this is
done so the end result of all of this is
that we are going to add a promo to open
column this tells you months since promo
to was open at this at the store and we
are going to add a is promo to month
which tells you if the promotion was
started in the current month and you can
see that here here we have this promo to
open this tells you number of months
since the promotion started and you can
verify here you have 2014 week 40 which
means somewhere towards the end of 2014
and here we are looking at March of 2015
so for about 5 months this promo has
been running and this promo runs in
January April July and October so that's
why you see Zero here but if you had the
matching month then you would see a one
here for example here you can see that
this date is February so here we have
yeah so here we have February listed in
the promo promo interval as well so here
we have a one okay so now we don't need
this column because we have this column
is promo to month and now we don't need
this column uh these two columns because
we have this column promo to open and
putting the
specific computations aside the idea
here is that we did a join we took some
storewide information and then we use
that storewide information in
combination with the day-to-day or in
combination with the present date for
each column in the training for each row
in the training set in combination with
the present date to compute this new
column which gave us richer information
about the
data and this is probably 70 or 80% of
uh machine learning which is cleaning
the data getting the data into right
into the right shape combining different
data sources engineering new features
based on Insight based on insights like
this that maybe we should keep track of
how long a competitor has been open or
maybe we should keep track of how long a
promotion has been open etc etc okay so
this is not very easy to come up with
this is I I I've just pulled it out of
some of the best notebooks that I saw on
the kagle competition but and these are
not possibly not certainly even the best
features so you may have to think about
what other features you can create but
this is what is feature engineering
combining multiple columns combining
data frames and transforming things like
breaking out date into things like year
month Etc okay so with that we have now
completed most of our feature
engineering
work so if you now check merge DF we
should have a lot more columns we have
about 25 columns some competition
related columns some promo related
columns and some date related columns as
well okay so let's move on
on now once we've done this feature
engineering once we've done this
exploration and again there is sort of
an interplay here it's not that you do
feature engineering once and you're done
you do the feature engineering then you
do some more Eda and then you using that
Eda maybe you do some more feature
engineering maybe you reject some of the
features you created maybe you um
combine some of the features to get new
features till you start seeing some kind
of a pattern or some kind of a
correlation and it's not that it's once
done and finished you train a model
model and if you see that the model is
not good enough maybe you need to go
back and do more feature engineering so
although we are following the linear
process that is not how it will be
typically and this
this problem that we are solving over
the course of 3 hours is actually
something that people have actually
spent 2 to 3 months solving for the
duration of the kaggle competition right
so there's a lot of back and forth and
nothing is ever just done or finished um
but that said moving on from feature
engineering let us now select the call
colums that we want to use for
training so here we are going to select
these are all the columns that we have
now either used from either picked up
from the data set or created and out of
these let's see which ones we are going
to use as inputs the store should be an
input we can keep that because the store
numbers in the training set and the test
set are the same we are making
predictions for the same stores if we
wanted to create a model which could
work on a new store which is not seen in
the training set then we cannot use the
store number so keep that in
mind but in this case it's the same
1,115 stores so we can use the store
number then we have day of week that is
going to be useful for sure we have date
um we can drop date because we have
extracted all important parts out of it
we have
sales um this is something that should
be the target column so that this is
what we've put in the Target call we
have number of customers this is not
something that we can use because this
information is not available in the test
set and of course when you deploy the
model you want to make predictions for
the next 6 weeks you will not have the
number of customers now one thing you
could do is you could train maybe a
customer number of customer prediction
model a model that predicts number of
customers and then use the prediction of
that model as an input to prediction of
this model etc etc but let's not go
there yet right now we are simply going
to drop number of customers as an input
column
open is again something that that we're
not using we've already gathered
information from it which is to drop all
the stores which were all the days all
the rows of data where the particular
store was not open and we are training a
model only for the days where the store
is open so open is useless column it it
just contains the values one now promo
will be useful whether the store is
running a promotion or not is going to
have an impact on the sales the state
holiday school holiday both of these are
useful so we going to keep those within
the input input columns as well the
store type assortment again seems like a
very useful thing so we should keep them
around and by the way these are
categorical and you can verify this by
just looking at the unique values for
these columns the competition distance
yes this is useful how far away a
competing store is competition open now
remember these two we have combined into
competition open which simply tells you
how many months the competing store has
been open for so let's keep that
then the date has been decomposed into
day month and year so we have those then
we have a week of year we
have promo
2 both of these are useful which week
are we currently in and whether the
store participates in promo 2 for how
long the store has been participating in
promo two so this is the number of
months and if promo two a new round of
promo two kicks off in the current month
so all of this is useful information
that we'll keep the things that we have
now engineered away we can remove like
date open sense month open sense year
promo to S week Etc and the target is
sales so once again I'm just going to
get the input columns out here from the
merch data frame and create this data
frame called inputs and I'm just going
to get the target column out so now it's
a single column and create a merge data
create a single Series so targets will
be a series and inputs will be a data
frame and I'm also creating copies here
because this is a very small data set I
don't have to worry too much about uh
creating multiple copies but if you're
working with a really large data set
maybe you shouldn't create a copy and
you just have to modify the original
data so you can now check this is inputs
this contains just the input columns and
one thing that you should note here is
uh there seems to be an A so this seems
to be a categorical column state holiday
where it has not just zero one but there
are several types of holidays that it
tracks a b c and d and then store type
assortment these are also categorical
columns with text so I'm sure we'll have
to handle them separately and the rest
of them look numeric although one could
argue that maybe we should treat day of
week as categorical because sales
generally are not linearly correlated
with the day of the week like Monday to
Sunday there isn't a linear increase so
we should probably treat them as
categorical one could argue the same for
day month and year as
well but yeah and this is where you will
have to choose which of these do you
want to treat numerically and which of
these do you want to treat categorically
now the good thing again is if you're
using decision trees decision trees can
typically work with both types because
decision trees can create these
decisions like is
store is day of the week less than one
so to pick the day of the week zero and
the rest of the days of the week will go
in another Direction so decision trees
can actually pick out using binary
decisions the the days like if Friday
Saturday Monday are specific branches
that decision trees can create even if
you don't create separate columns for
each of uh these days okay so yeah but
that's a that's that's still a decision
that you have to come up with should we
treat some of these as categorical or
some of these as
numerical U so that's inputs and let's
take a look at targets as
well and that's targets here so these
are the things that we're trying to
predict this is the
sales and we're also going to generate
test inputs simply from merge test DF we
going to get the input columns and then
create a copy so now this will contain
just all the test
inputs and at this point hopefully the
test inputs and train inputs should have
the same number of columns if they don't
then obviously you're not going to be
able to train a model which can make
predictions on the test set so when you
get to this point where you have
selected some input and a test column
input columns make sure that the test
inputs and train inputs have the same
number of columns which in this case is
16 okay then here is the uh here is the
somewhat subjective exercise of picking
the numeric and categorical columns um
now there are some binary columns which
have 01 values we don't really need to
one hot encode them they're already one
hot enod coded as 01 so I'm put them
into numeric just to keep things simple
to avoid this one hot
encoding and introducing new columns now
with some of these things like month and
day these could be made categorical but
I chose to just keep them numeric and
see what happens you can try and convert
them into categorical columns if you
want and see if that has an
effect so the only things that I'm
keeping categorical right now are the
day of the week because there are only
seven of them this whether it's a state
holiday so there are these values a b c
it's definitely not numeric store type
and assortment and both of these are
also not numeric okay so these whatever
are are the textual columns I am making
them categorical and specifically one
exception I've made here is day of
week and but you can try and experiment
with this and see if you get a different
see if you get a better
result okay so let's now impute the the
missing numerical data and instead of
doing an imputer let's maybe just check
where the numerical missing numerical
data is so it turns out that the only
place
where numeric data is missing is
competition
distance and this is possibly because
for certain stores there is no nearby
competing store so in such cases and the
same is true for the test inputs as well
and there are no other columns where
there are any missing data so let's
think about this for moment we need to
put in a number here for competition
distance otherwise some of our models
may not train
and a missing value here for competition
distance indicates that there is no
competing store near this
store now if we put the value zero here
or or if we put a very small value here
then that would be the opposite that
would mean the opposite that means the
competition is right next door so we
should probably not put the value zero
here what we might instead want to do is
maybe just put a very large value here
like if let's say just instead of saying
that there is no competition nearby
let's say that there's a comp
competition is 100 km away or something
like that uh just to sort
of retain the meaning of the value that
is inserted here zero would mean that
the competition is next door that's not
what we want to suggest we want to
suggest that there is no competition
nearby the closest thing to that is to
suggest that the competition is really
far away
so here's the trick that I'm going to
use I am going to
fill these empty values with the highest
value for the competition distance
column so let's check max
distance so max distance is 75860 that
means about 75 km away uh so that seems
reasonable 75 km maybe if if I want I
can even double that number and make
that 150 km away so I'm just going to
fill in that wherever competition
distance has the value none or Nan I'm
going to fill the value 75 75860 * 2 so
I'm just going to say that the
competition is 150 km away
which basically has the same meaning as
this store not having any competition
okay so this is again something that you
will have to do very carefully when you
are filling in missing values it's not
simply a matter of just using an imputer
and putting in the averages or putting
in the means uh or median sometimes you
have to think about what it means to
fill a certain value to fill the mean
would to fill the mean would change the
meaning because then you would say that
the competition is maybe like a few
hundred meters away but rather what we
want to put in here is to say that
competition is really far away or does
not
exist okay so although we have seen
these standard strategies for Computing
values and scaling values you will have
to apply some thought to it when you
apply it to real world problems the
standard strategies are fine when you
want to just quickly get to a machine
learning model but when you really want
to improve the model these are all
things that you have to think carefully
about okay let's then scale numeric
values I don't see any problem here I
think we can just scale them all to the
0 to one range that should be fine so we
are using a minmax scaler to do that and
then let's encode some categorical
columns as well now note that for
categorical columns we've mostly picked
out columns which have Text data so what
will happen is we will take each of
these unique categories and create a
column for each of these categories and
just put in the values 1 and zero
depending on whether the row contains
the category for that column okay so
that's what we do using one hot encoder
again
imputation scaling and encoding one hot
encoding is something that we've covered
probably four times now and hopefully
starting to sound boring and
repetitive um and and routine
essentially so just go through the
previous tutorials if you want to
understand how these
work um now one thing I want to point
out is we have not created a validation
set yet and this is because we are going
to use a different validation technique
called kfold cross validation so we'll
see that in just a moment but that's all
the data preparation that we need to do
and I encourage you to look through
notebooks created by participants in the
kaggle
competition you can look through
notebooks by going to this link this is
basically the date the code tab of the
competition and on the code tab just
select most votes to sort by the most
popular notebooks and just go through
some of these notebooks and see what
other kinds of feature engineering
people have done and even the
visualization exploratory analysis Etc
will help you learn a lot because a lot
of these people people are professional
data scientists and they are putting in
the same amount of care and the same
insights that they apply to their
day-to-day work at their job into this
competition so there's a lot you can
learn and this kind of information is
not available anywhere in any book or
any course uh so in fact this entire
notebook has been created just by
looking at a bunch of different
notebooks from the code tab of this
competition right so do check that
out let's do a quick recap before we
move forward just to revise what we did
for future
engineering so we downloaded the data
set we downloaded uh we downloaded we
downloaded the data set and that gave us
a training CSV file a test CSV file and
a store. CSV file with some metadata
about stores all right so we have we
have a training set and then we have a
test set the test set contains about
40,000 rows of data and then we have the
store data set which we merge merged
into the training and test sets so
that's one thing that you will have to
do often merge data from multiple
sources or perform some kind of joints
to augment the training data then we
looked at the dates and we extracted
information like the year month day and
week of Year from the
date and that gave us a merged data
frame with these additional columns then
we looked at whether the store was open
or closed and realize that when the
store is closed the sales are zero and
we decided that this is not something we
want to model this is something we will
hard code into our predictions so we
removed all the rows where the s store
was closed and the sales were
zero next we added some columns for the
competition so instead of having the
month and year since the competition
competing store opened we just have the
number of
months since the competing store opened
a single value which will be more useful
to the model similarly we added a couple
of columns one called promo to open and
is promo to month promo to open
indicates for how long the store has
been participating in promo 2 a
companywide promotion and promo to month
to keep track of whether the current
row has a
month when the promotion starts at the
current
store then we identified the input and
Target
columns and then we created inputs and
targets to data
frames then we identified the numeric
and C orical columns as well and then we
imputed the numeric columns and this
time we had to take a specific decision
to put in a very large value for
competition
distance then we scaled the numeric
values to the 0 to one range and encoded
the categorical columns which were
strategically chosen so that some of the
categorical columns which have numbers
we've kept them as numeric columns so we
don't want to change
them and finally we've put together
these two variables X which contains our
training plus validation set essentially
so which contains just the numeric data
from the numeric columns and the encoded
categorical columns right so that is
what x is it contains all the data that
can be directly fed into a model it is
all numeric it has no empty values and
similarly we have X test which is just
all the inputs that will be used to make
predictions for the test set so that's
our x and x Tex and X and Y are common
used to refer common used to refer to
inputs and Targets in machine learning
that's why we using uppercase X and
uppercase X
test all right so we're finally ready to
start training our gradient boosting
model and here is how a GBM model Works
a GBM is short for gradient boosting
machine so
first we're trying to predict the sale
at every store the first thing that the
gradient boosting model does is to
predict simply the average value of the
target column compute the average value
of the target column and use that as an
initial prediction for every input so
the model completely ignores all the
training data that it is given it simply
looks at the predictions or the uh the
target values and it simply takes an
average of the target values and it uses
that as a prediction now obviously
that's not a good prediction
so whatever error function you're using
let's say mean squared error or whatever
the prediction is going to be pretty bad
but here is where it gets interesting
now once you have predicted you once
youve made one set of predictions which
is the averages then we go back into
each row of training data and we
calculate the difference of the
predictions with
the actual targets so just to convey
that let's maybe work through an example
here let's say we have uh
three things we have
month let's say we have month and then
we have uh day day of month and we have
uh competition distance let's call that
CD competition distance and then we have
store number
here and then we have the sale okay so
we have a bunch of stores so there is
some information here for this store and
then the sale here let's say the sale
was 700 then there is some information
for a second store at a second date and
let's say the sale on this for this
training Row the sale was 800 and we
have another one and let's say the sale
here was uh 970 etc etc and like let's
say 850
here so these are some rows from the
training data so the first prediction
that our model is going to make is
simply the average of these numbers
average of 700 800 900 and 850 I believe
this would be let's say this is around
820 so it just predicts 820 for all of
them
okay so it just predicts 820 for all of
them uh now that's a bad bad prediction
so let's call this p 0 or prediction Z
Now using these p 0 it is going to
compute the residuals now what is the
residual it is simply the difference
between
the prediction and the actual sale sorry
the sale yeah difference between the
actual sale and the prediction so in
this case the residual should be
minus 80 oh sorry minus
uh not minus
80 the residual should be 700 - 820 so -
120 in this case the residual should be
800 -
20 800 - 20 that's - 20 in this case the
residual is 970 minus 820 that is 150
and in this case the residual is 850
minus 820 excuse the poor handwriting
and that's 30 okay so now this is what
we know that in our current set of
predictions we are off by this much for
each row so here is what happens next
now the model takes this input so it
takes all these
inputs and instead of trying to predict
the sale price it builds a decision tree
to predict this value
okay and then it takes uh this input and
uh using this input it tries to predict
this value and so on okay so a decision
tree is created so now we create a
decision tree let's use this to just uh
represent a decision tree and it's not
an unbounded decision tree typically
this is bounded in terms of depth so we
create a decision tree and using this
decision tree we now try to predict how
much we were off by when we made the
first prediction so when we made the
first prediction we were off by 120 and
now suppose our decision predicts here -
80 it predicts here minus 30 it predicts
here that we were off by that we were
off by 70 and it predicts here that we
were off by 40 okay so this is what our
first decision tree
predicted Now using the first decision
tree uh yeah so now we have we have the
this decision
tree let's just call this D so this is
the prediction of the decision tree
which which was an attempt to predict
the residual but of course this is
itself not that perfect so what do we do
next we compute the next set of
residuales so the next set of residuales
would be let me just write that here so
the next set of residuales would
be wanted to predict minus 120 but I
predicted 80 so I I still have I'm still
off by -40 I wanted to predict -2 but I
predicted -3 so that means I'm off by +
10 I wanted to predict 150 but I I
predicted 70 so I'm off by 80 and I I'm
off by minus 10 right so this way we
continue we keep getting residuales so
this is what this picture is
representing here first we use the
average and that's obviously very bad so
the error is very high then we train a
decision tree to compute the residuals
or the the errors that we com that
we incurred when we were predicting the
average so that is these errors we
trained the decision tree to do that
once again we don't do a perfect job but
it is better right if you see if if I
simply add up the prediction from the
original model
plus - 80 so the overall prediction from
the model becomes the first prediction
plus the prediction of the first
decision tree so 820 minus 80 becom
740 so 740 is now a lot closer to 700
similarly 820 minus 30 is
790 so 790 is a lot closer to 800 than
820 similarly 820 plus the prediction of
the first decision Tre 70 is about 890
so 890 is a lot closer to 970 than 820
alone so almost all the predictions now
become better because we have trained a
decision tree to compute the residuals
okay so as soon as we as soon as we
create one decision tree all our
predictions become better and how do we
make the predictions we simply add the
original prediction plus the prediction
the the predicted residual by the
decision
tree but of course we still not perfect
um we still will not have a perfect
model so then we train another decision
tree to compute the residuales that were
obtained after taking the result of the
original guess and the first decision
tree so that second decision tree is
trying to correct the errors made by the
second decision tree U made by the first
decision tree and that reduces the error
further then we take train another
decision tree and that attempts to
correct the errors made by the third
decision tree okay so that's how
gradient boosting works and let's just
go over this step by step and try to
understand this again so the average
value of the target column is used as
the initial prediction for every input
that's the starting point then we
compute the residuals of the predictions
with the targets so we we now identify
how much we are off by what the error in
our prediction is then we create a
limited depth a decision tree of limited
depth to just predict the residuals for
each input now we're not trying to
predict the entire sales and in some
sense it's a smaller more contained
problem right we're just trying to
correct the errors of our initial
guess
then here is a step that is an
additional step which is called which is
called The Learning rate we take the
predictions from the decision tree and
then we scale them using a parameter
called The Learning rate so we don't
directly add the prediction of the
decision tree to the original prediction
we just scale it a little bit and I'll
talk about that in a
second then those scaled predictions
from the decision tree are added to the
previous predictions to obtain the new
and improved predictions by for that
particular
row and then steps 2 to five are
repeated to create new decision trees
Each of which is trained to predict just
the residuals from the previous
prediction okay so that's how GBM works
and let me talk about scaling
now so coming back here we
had we had this data so we had this uh
input
columns and the Target that we trying to
predict was what was it Target was
700 and we predicted we predicted the
average the average was 820 so this was
our initial prediction p 0
then we trained the decision TR uh then
we computed the residual so let's call
that r0 and the residual is minus 80 and
then we do it for all of these columns
we compute the residual then we train a
decision tree D and D is trying to
predict these residuals so D is trying
to use the inputs to predict the
residuals and again D is going to be off
by a little bit so what is the number we
used here let's say the D predicted
minus 40 now what we do is we actually
have a training
a learning rate parameter and this is
called Alpha and let's say Alpha is set
to 0.5 so instead of predicting 820 plus
Point plusus 40 as the prediction from
our model after creating one tree we
actually predict
plus Alpha * or 0.5
* uh -
40 right which is a prediction so the
actual prediction that we are now making
and this pred prediction is the
prediction from the original average
plus the alpha the learning rate times
the prediction from the decision tree so
820 plus alpha alpha is .5 multiplied 40
so - 20 820 + -20 that is 800 okay so
this is the prediction and this
prediction is coming from P1 comes from
our average plus our first decision tree
okay that's how P1 comes in then once we
have P1 we compute the residual R1 which
is how far away the first prediction is
from the actual value that we're trying
to predict it is still off by Min
-20 and then we compute that for all of
them then we train a decision tree to
use the inputs to compute this residual
so now we have D2 and let's say it's
predicts minus 10 here uh the residual
it's still not perfect because it's not
a full decision Tre then once again we
multiply this by Alpha so we
go5 uh so so we go the initial average a
plus Alpha * the decision from decision
tree 1 plus Alpha * the decision from
decision tree 2 so once again we
multiply this by 0.5 so that means now
we get to
805 as our P2 and then we compare 805
and we're still far away from p 0 we're
still far away from the target so then
we compute the next residual R2 so R2
becomes 5 and that's how it proceeds
okay so ultimately the prediction of the
model
the prediction of the model P for a
particular input is the average a plus
Alpha times the prediction of decision
tree 1 and what was decision tree 1
trained on it was trained to predict P
minus a essentially the residual from
the original average plus Alpha time
decision tree
2 and what was decision tree 2 trained
to do the decision Tre 2 was trained to
predict the difference between this and
the actual Target that we have right and
then we have Alpha 3 and Alpha 3 will
have decision three and then so on okay
so you can configure Alpha this is
called The Learning rate and you can
configure the number of iterations or
the number of decision trees that you
create and that is called the number of
iterations or the number of estimators
okay and that's all it is that's all a
decision Tre is successive that's all a
gradient boosting model is successively
changing successively improving our
predictions by training these small
decision trees to correct the errors of
the model that we have so far now why do
we have this Alpha in place why don't we
simply add the predictions from the from
the previously trained decision tree so
it turns out that Alpha prevents
overfitting if we apply that scaling
factor to the decision tree that was
just trained to predict the residuals uh
so we are intentionally creating some
error there which can be then filled in
by the next decision tree and so on and
that helps prevent overfitting to the
training set so that's one thing and
then second why is this called gradient
boosting it is called boosting
because because boosting is the name of
the general technique where you train a
new model to correct the errors of a or
to improve an existing model so whenever
you have this kind of a system as
opposed to bagging which is what random
Forest do remember with random Forest
each decision Tre tries to make the
entire prediction that is called bagging
bootstrapping bagging Etc but boosting
means you are correcting or you're
improving an existing model so the
second decision tree depends on how the
first decision tree was created the
third decision tree depends on how the
second decision tree was created and its
predictions and so on so that's boosting
now why is it called gradient boosting
well in some sense this is similar to
the gradient descent algorithm and the
objective here is to minim minimize the
loss so we have a certain loss like mean
squared error or some kind of a loss
function and the objective is to create
new decision trees to minimize that loss
right so in some sense we are doing a
iterative gradient descent so that's the
mathematical term for it and that's why
it's called gradient so gradient
boosting machine is simply a boosting
technique which tries to minimize the
error by creating new estimators or new
decision trees each time
and that's what it is
okay so try and describe in your own
words how a gradient boosting model uh
machine differs from a random forest and
do check out if you want to check out
the mathematical explanation for this do
check that out as well but I will warn
you that when you look at the
mathematical explanation it is pretty
hairy there's a lot of equations so
unless you are comfortable with the math
I would not recommend it and the there
are some graphs as well but it doesn't
really
help but yeah do check it out if you are
interested in checking it out but really
the most intuitive explanation that I
have found is just the fact that
gradient boosting machines correct add
more decision trees to correct the
errors of the decisions we've made so
far okay I also like this uh tutorial
series on this YouTube channel called
stat Quest that you can check out this
is a five-part series I believe gradient
boosting
yeah they have four or five parts uh
this also gets into the mathematics but
this also has a bunch of uh visual
explanations so you can use that to get
a good sense of it uh but as long as
you're getting the basic idea that we
are training more trees to correct
errors from our previous trees you
should be
fine we always using the all the input
features now to train a GBM we can use
the
xgb the xgb regressor class from XG
boost there is also a gradient boosting
Ma machine in pyit loan but XT boost is
far more efficient and far more
versatile so from XT boost we're just
going to import xgb
regressor and let's check out what that
looks like here you can see all the
parameters that it accepts and you can
now see that there is this number of
estimators which tells you how many
trees you are going to create
and you can now experiment with this you
can try setting number of estimators to
one and see uh how that changes see how
many trees get created and try changing
it to two three four and see how many
trees are
created and then there is
this max depth so you can configure how
deep each tree goes why do we need a max
depth well think about it coming back
here if we trained an unbounded decision
tree then that unbounded decision tree
would essentially exactly fit the
residual so it would completely overfit
to the training set
to predict the residual and once again
that would be a problem so all of these
are regularizations because if it
overfits through the training set then
it's going to perform poorly on the
validation side so typically these trees
are not very deep then you have this
learning rate and this learning rate is
basically just the alpha or it's called
ITA I believe in XG boost it is simply
the factor that is applied the scaling
down the damping factor that is applied
to the residual prediction from each
decision tree once again this is used to
avoid overfit otherwise you may overfit
to the training
data and then you have a bunch of other
parameters so I'm simply going to create
an xtb regressor here and once again
setting some random State and end jobs
random state is simply to ensure that
the
randomization is using this number 42 as
a seed so that each time we run
model.fit or each time we run this piece
of code we get the same results uh
that's what random state is for and if
you change this number you will get
different results but but each time you
will get the same result when you put
the number seven for
example then you have end jobs this is
simply to configure the number of
threads that it should use in the
background when you put in minus one
here it will use all the threads that
are available on the machine that we're
connected to then here is the number of
estimators or the number of decision
trees that we will create so we start
with the average train one decision tree
to correct the errors train a second
decision tree to correct the errors of
the first two combined and so on we'll
create 20 decision trees and each
decision tree will have a maximum depth
of four so let's call model. fit now and
this takes not too long to fit because
it's a what 20 decision trees each with
a maximum depth of four shouldn't take
more than a few seconds so it took about
8 seconds and you can see some of the
other parameters here as well and you
can look up the documentation to learn
more and right now I'm just fitting it
on the entire training set we will talk
about validation shortly but right now
I'm just I've just fit it on the entire
training data that we had using the
inputs X and the targets and now here's
an exercise for you can you now describe
in your own words how a gradient
boosting model fits this machine
learning training workflow we take some
inputs put them into the model it makes
a first guess which is just the averages
we compute the loss we compute the
residuals and then we train a decision
tree to predict the residuals now we put
in the inputs once again now we get now
we get the output as the average
prediction plus the prediction of the
decision tree scaled down then we
compute the residuals again using the
targets and then we optimize uh by
training another decision tree and so on
okay and we can now make predictions
using the model so right now since we
just have the training set we've not
created a validation set so I'm just
going to call model. predict
X and these are the predictions of the
model
okay and then we can evaluate this just
in the same way we've been evaluating
all our models so I'm going to use the
root means squared error so I've just
defined this rmse function we give it
the predictions and we give it the
targets and it turns out that the
training error or the loss on the the
error or the loss on the training set is
2377 okay um and I just want to point
out here you can create a validation set
if you want it's not that gradient
boosting will not work with validation
sets it's just that we are using a
separate a different strategy for
validation that's why not created a
validation set yet okay but there's no
fundamental limitation in creating
validation sets for gradient boosting
you can and we
will so that now so now we get an rmsse
of
2377 and going back if you just think
about the average sales let me just go
merg DF do sales.
men
and Max I guess guess Min is zero in a
lot of cases
but so the maximum sales is around
$41,000 the Min is around U Min is zero
and you can also look at the histogram
but if you're off by
2,300 I would say that's not too bad you
know what maybe just let's also look at
a histogram let's do PLT
doist merged
DF do sales
I'm just going to pick a sample of maybe
10,000 rows just to get a
sense yeah so this is what the
distribution primarily looks like it
seems like most of the sales are around
1,000 around $5,000 to
$10,000 and seems like we are off by
2377 right the RMS is 2377 so that means
our predictions are off by
$2,300 and that's not too bad it's not
like our predictions are in the range
5,000 to 10,000 and we are off by full
10,000 which means our predictions are
completely meaningless we off by 2,000
or so which is probably not that great
but it's not too bad as well so already
we can see that our decision our
gradient hting model gives us a fairly
good result and what I would encourage
you to do at this point is maybe compare
it with a baseline model maybe just
build a very dumb model which always uh
maybe predicts the average or the
average of the same store for the last
month or something like
that and compare it with a linear
regression model compare it with a
compare it with a decision Tree in a
random forest and see how see if Gren
boosting is any
better and the reason it is better
better in a lot of cases is simply
because of this residual trick because
each time for each tree we are reducing
what it needs to learn rather than
random Forest where each tree has to
learn the entire relationship now in
this case each tree just tries to fix
the errors of the previous
tree so that's how you evaluate uh make
predictions and evaluate just as you do
with any other psychic learn model you
can also visualize individual trees
using the plot tree function from XG
boost uh this also requires the graph
Wiz library to be installed so you will
have to install that but here's what it
looks like we say plot tree and then we
pass in the model and the model of
course contains many trees and then we
pass in this num trees argument and this
num trees is improperly named it should
be called the tree number or something
so here you are just passing the tree
that you want to plot you want to plot
tree number zero the first decision tree
that was created or tree number one the
second decision tree that was created or
so on so let me just plot it and I can
plot it left to right which is nice
convenient to look at so here's the
first decision tree that was created
promo less
than5 that's what we're checking so it
seems like whether there's a promotion
running or not seems to be the biggest
Factor then if there was no promotion
running then it depends on the day of
the
week and again with the day of the week
we're checking day of the week less than
0.5 which or sorry day of the week one
which means whether it was a
Monday um so if it is not a Monday then
we check the month if it is if it is a
Monday then we check something else so
this is what the first decision tree
looks like and I will draw your
attention to these values you see here
23091 1823 and maybe you'll also
see yeah so all of these are not
predictions for the actual sales this is
simply the deviation from the average
that we predicting here and if I show
you the next tree num tree is equals
1 this is going to try and correct
the issues that have been created by the
first tree or the residuals that that
are that remain after adding the first
tree so here are the leaf notes and you
can see that these numbers are getting
smaller these are no longer that large
these are definitely smaller and if I go
to tree number
19 which is the final tree that we've
trained which is trying to correct the
errors of the sum of all the first 18
trees and the average you can see that
here you have numbers like - 19-
234 three so it's making very small
adjustments right so even though these
trees are all very small each tree can
correct the previous Tree in a
meaningful
way and contribute to an improvement in
the result
okay so now notice how the trees only
compute residuals and not the actual
Target
values and we can also
visualize we can also visualize these
trees in a textual format so if you just
run model. getet booster this is the
underlying structure that XG boost
creates and called do get dump that
gives us a list of trees uh tree objects
and text and there are 20 trees not
surprisingly and here is the first tree
in textual format so you can see what
how it makes its
decisions and just like decision trees
in random Forest XT boost also provides
a way of provides a way to understand
how important each feature is so the
feature importance
score and you can look into how this is
calculated but there are a couple of
ways one is called the gain uh which has
to do with how much
each feature has contributed to
reduction and loss over all the trees
and second is called the weight which
counts how many times a particular
feature was used to create a split okay
so one is the number of splits which is
called weight how many times a
particular feature was used to create a
split across all the trees and second is
the gain which is how much it has
contributed to reduction and loss so you
can see reduction in loss is called gain
right so it it that's how the word is
derived so here is the importance data
frame so we just pick model. feature
importances and we put that into a data
frame where we also putting the columns
from the X or the data we passed used to
train the model so here we have features
and here we have
importance and we can now plot that and
see that as well and this is what it
looks like as expected promo has a big
effect and then store type seems to have
a big effect too day of the week whether
it is one I'm guessing that may I don't
know if day of the week 1 represents
Sunday or Monday but that's something
that I would check but it seems like
that has a big effect promo 2 seems to
have an important effect as well so it's
good that we added a bunch of columns
related to promo 2 competition
distance as one might expect assortment
then month store and day interesting
that adding month and adding the day may
have significantly improved our model so
what I would encourage you to do at this
point is maybe turn off some of the
features and try to retrain the model
and see if you still get a good enough
result and it's possible that you may
it's possible that you may not so this
is how you figure out if the features
that you've cre created are working or
not you look at their importance you
look at the before and after and you
have to keep all of this information
organized in some fashion in some sort
of a spreadsheet where you note down
each experiment you've tried and the
result that you got for that experiment
and potentially also keep track of that
specific version of The Notebook so that
you can replicate the experiment if
required
okay now notice that we didn't create a
validation set before training our XT
boost model this is because we want to
use a different validation strategy this
time this is called kfold cross
validation so in kfold Cross validation
we take our training data which is
separate from the test data the test
data is supposed to be used only at the
very end but we take a training data and
we split that into many parts so when
you say k fold K can be configured let's
say k is five so we split it into five
folds or five parts it's like taking a
piece of paper and folding it five times
and then each time we train five
different models and for each model we
use a different fold as the validation
set so we take split one and we train a
model on split one and here we use the
first 20% as a validation set for split
two we use the second 20% as the
validation set for split three we use
the third 20% as validation set and so
on and we use that
for hyperparameter tuning we use that
for just experimenting between different
modeling strategies and the the benefit
of this is that we are not sacrificing
on any of the data we are for training
we are using all the data for training
but at the same time we still have a way
to analyze how these models are doing by
looking at the validation score for each
of the splits okay so that's what we'll
Implement and kfold is quite useful for
small data sets it's not very useful for
the really large data sets like this one
where we have millions of rows a million
rows actually and the other thing to
keep in mind also is that K4
is that key fold may not be the optimal
strategy here because our validation set
should ideally
reflect what kind of data the model will
see in real life should ideally be
closer to the test set and the test set
occurs in the future after the training
set so ideally the validation set should
be in the future of the training set so
we are breaking that uh so we are
breaking that uh requirement here or so
so potentially the validation score that
we get will not be as
useful as we might get if we simply use
the last one right so those are some
things to consider and we are doing it
here primarily to demonstrate how to use
kold cross validation but that
definitely keep that in mind when you
have time order data maybe you just want
to do just like split five which is just
take the last 20% by date and use that
as a validation set regardless here we
go with kfold cross validation we say SK
learn. model ction import kfold so we
have this kfold utility that we're going
to use this is going to give us all
these splits to try out and how do we
use it well we use it like this we
create the kfold object we pass in the
number of splits
and then we can use we can say kold dos
split and give it the data that we want
to split in this case we want to split
the training
input and remember the training input is
a data
frame so what this will give you is
indexes of rows for the training set and
indexes of rows for the validation set
for each split so you as you call it in
a for Loop it will give you five splits
so each time you will get a list of
indexes of training rows a list of
indexes of validation rows so we can
then take X and from it extract out the
training indexes so let's say it gives
us these indexes 0 1 2 3 4 uh etc etc
20% of them will fall into Val ID EXs
and 80% of them will fall into train ID
XS so we grab those rows from the
training uh from the input X and that
gives us the X Trin and then we grab
those rows and we using I log here to
grab those specific rows given the
indexes and that gives us the training
targets from so we grab them from
targets and that gives us training
targets similarly the Val validation ID
EXs this contains all the rows the row
indexes for the validation set we grab
those rows from the data frame frame to
give us X Val and we grab those rows
from the targets to get Val
targets okay so now we have X train
train targets X Val Val targets now we
need to actually train and evaluate the
model so I've written a simple function
here train and evaluate which takes the
X train takes the train targets xw while
targets it takes a bunch of parameters
like we passing max depth 4 now estimat
is 4 20 Etc and this is defined here so
with those parameters which you can see
are captured like a variable number of
parameters are typically captured using
star star params and then those params
are passed directly into a XG boost
regressor so this is just some python
syntax you can look look up this is
called quars or keyword arguments uh but
yeah we take all those parameters that
were passed in we create an X boost
regressor so for each split we're
creating a new model and then we fit
that model to the split data to whatever
is there in the current fold so then the
first iteration we are going to use this
as training this is validation and
create our first model then we compute
the we make predictions on the train set
so we make predictions on this data the
training set we calculate the loss we
prediction we make predictions on this
Set uh this validation set we compute
the loss so this was used for training
and this was used just for evaluation so
we compute the training loss and the
validation loss rmsse root means squared
error and we return all three we return
the model we return the training
loss and the validation
loss and we capture that model training
and validation loss and we are just
printing out the training and validation
laws for each split and we are going to
then append the
model we are going to just append the
model to a list of models so because we
training five models we are going to
need all of those five models to make
predictions later uh but that's the
whole idea here you split the data five
ways and then you use a different 20%
portion each time for validation then
you train the model for each of those
you train a separate model for each of
those splits and you can see here for
the first split the train rmsc was 2352
and the valid rmsc was 2424 the second
split the train rmsc was 2406 while RMS
was 2451 and so on okay so this way when
you have a really small data set
especially like maybe a few hundred rows
you may want to just use cross
validation and then average the results
from all the models so here is a
function I'm defining called predict
average it it takes the list of models
it takes a bunch of inputs it is going
to call model. predict inputs for each
of the models and then it is going to
take the average okay that's exactly
what's Happening Here we say for model
and models so we get each model one by
one and we call model. predict inputs so
we give the inputs to that specific each
model get the predictions and then we
take the averages of all the predictions
along XIs
Z
so here's what that looks
like this is the average prediction
obtained on the training data by taking
the averages of the predictions of all
the models okay and you can do that you
if you want you can now break that down
you can say model
zero do
predict
X and you can say model plus model
one do predict
X Plus model 2. predict X and so on and
when you want to average them you can
simply just divide by the number of
models you have and that's basically
what we're doing
with yeah so that's basically what we're
doing with uh our yeah that's models so
that's basically what we're doing with
predict average okay so that's kfold
cross validation you use the
kfold class to create some splits and
and you can also do randomization let's
say you want to First Shuffle the rows
before creating a split then you can
also specify Shuffle equals true might
be worth a try you can just do Shuffle
equals true here and then you get you
put it in a for Loop you get the train
indexes Val indexes for each split you
com you get the actual data for each
split the training and validation you
train a model you evaluate the model uh
you can view the actual results here and
then you can also keep track of all the
models and then use all those models
together to make
predictions definitely a more advanced
technique not something that you will
have to use for data sets that are large
enough but still a good thing to know
okay all right so
that's how we use we perform kfold cross
validation next let's talk about
hyperparameter tuning and
regularization now just like any other
machine learning model there are several
hyperparameters that we can adjust to
change the capacity of the model and to
reduce overfitting
and this is the typical model complexity
versus error curve when your model is
very weak let's say you're just training
one decision
tree then obviously you're going to be
you're going to have a very high error
but as you start increasing the capacity
of your
model your training error starts to
decrease and it continues to decrease
because your model looks at the training
data it has more parameters to learn
information about the training data so
that continues to decrease over time but
at some point your test error will start
to increase and this is where you have
to manage the different hyper parameters
and adjust them in such a way that you
get to the best best fit you get to the
minimum possible test error and any
further you go the test error should
start to increase so that should be your
goal with all the different hyper
parameters that you train okay and XG
boost has quite a few hyper parameters
you can check out the documentation here
and there's a detailed explanation about
each of the hyper parameters so once you
have that intuitive picture in place is
average followed by a decision tree to
correct the residuals followed by
another decision tree to correct the
residuals and how you how you make
predictions is simply adding up all the
predictions but with a learning rate
applied then you can check out all of
these different parameters here this is
the learning rate this is called the Min
split loss max depth mild etc etc okay
everything to do with
trees so you could experiment with the
hyper parameters with kfold cross
validation which means that every
different hyper parameter you try you
could perform kfold cross validation for
it and look at the result and here is a
helper function to help you do that but
because we don't have that kind of time
we want to do
quick experiments so we will just fix a
validation set for our hyperparameter
tuning and this is something this is a
choice that you'll have to make from
time to time so I'm just going to to fix
a random 10% split of the data as the
validation set so here I'm importing
train test split and then I'm calling
train test split with the inputs with
the targets and setting the test size to
0.1 so that should give me a training
set with 90% of the data and a
validation set with 10% of the data and
I guess for a million rows uh 100,000
rows is enough to accurately verify the
model and ideally again what I should be
doing is maybe picking something from
the very end so that the validation set
is closer to the TR test set u but
that's okay right now I'm just going to
go with a random selection and see what
happens maybe I'll come back and replace
this with actually selecting the last
few months of
data but now we have a fixed training
set we have a fixed validation set and
then we have this test params function
so you just give it some parameters and
it is going to create a regressor and
then it is going to fit it through the
training data it is going to to
calculate the training loss validation
loss and it's going to print it out
that's all so now let's test different
number of estimators n estimators is the
first hyper parameter probably the most
important one how many decision trees
are you going to train the more you
train the lower the loss will
get so here right now we are looking at
10 estimators and with 10 estimators we
get to just with 10 decision trees we
get to 2 334 validation loss and you can
see that the model isn't quite
overfitted yet because you can see that
the train RMS is
2340 whereas the validation RMS is 2334
so it's actually lower the validation uh
loss here again we go to 30 estimators
and things have started to get better we
are now only off by $1,000 or
$1,800 again not bad at all considering
the values that we're trying to predict
are in the range of $5,000 to $10,000 so
this is not bad at
all I believe this is going to take some
time so maybe we'll let this one run and
we will just cancel this execution but
you will see this kind of a trend here
at some point you will see the best fit
and then training error will continue to
decrease but the test error will start
to increase
potentially so as an exercise do
experiment with different values of N
estimators and then plot a graph try and
plot this kind of a graph of the
training loss and the validation loss
for the different
strategies that you've
tried yeah for the different strategies
that you tried and see where you get the
best fit and it's not just about the
best fit some sometimes it's also about
what is the additional benefit that
you're getting let's say by moving to
200 to 240 estimators the validation RMC
reduces from 1209 to 1190 that's not a
big increase and the amount of time it
takes to take train 240 estimators is
more than double the amount of time it
takes to train 100 estimators so that's
where you will have to decide is it
worth the time to add the additional
estimators now if it's not then maybe
you stop at 100 150 wherever you see
that the change in validation rmsc is
started to flatten out so you can stop
somewhere here as well that's not a
problem in a lot of cases it's not like
it starts to increase immediately but
starts to continue to decrease very
slightly for a very long time and at
this point it just doesn't make sense
because you're creating this huge model
which is only slightly better than this
much smaller model right so start out
small increase the capacity of your
model and whenever the it stops making
sense to just increase the capacity
further either in terms of the time or
because of overfitting you can
stop now similarly here we have max
depth so as you increase the maximum
depth of each tree the capacity of the
tree increases and it can capture more
information let me maybe stop this right
now so that let me do this with a
smaller number of estimators so that we
can see the
effect let's say estimators
10 yeah so max depth is simply the depth
of each tree the trees that we create to
correct the residuals what is the
maximum depth you want to allow them to
have and you can see as we increase the
max depth initially the loss definitely
goes down
once again experiment with different
values of max depth now we can see that
these are not
overfitting just
yet we can see that these uh these
models are not overfitting right now so
you can probably still push the model
you can probably still keep increasing
the max step till the point that you
start to see some overfitting happening
which means the training error continues
to
decrease but the test error actually
starts to increase so the kind of trend
that you'll notice is let's say around
max depth of
15 uh the test error flattens out and
then maybe around max depth of 18 the
training error is still going down but
the test error has started to increase
and at max depth of 20 the Texs the test
error actually starts to or the
validation error actually starts to go
up by a significant amount right so when
you whenever you notice this trend maybe
you come back and find the lowest
point and also just to clarify
overfitting is not a situation where the
training error has to be zero that's not
the case overfitting specifically is
described by this scenario where the
training error is increasing is
decreasing as you increase the model
complexity but at the same time the test
error is increasing so the model is
getting worse even though it is getting
better at the training
data okay next up we have the learning
rate the learning rate is the alpha that
is applied to the predictions so this is
the alpha remember we take the initial
average then we apply an alpha to and
this factor to scale the prediction of
the decision tree and then we apply that
to all further decision trees so we set
the learning rate to 0.01 that means
it's going to give very less weightage
to this prediction it's going to hardly
collect the residual Maybe by 1% so that
makes it very hard uh for the model to
even get good at the training set so you
will need a large number of
estimators so a very low learning rate
something like 0.1 will lead
to underfitting and a very high learning
rate like 99 may lead to overfitting
it's not that it will but it may lead to
overfitting because you have other
hyperparameters as well right so one
hyper parameter alone cannot cause
overfitting but because some other there
may be other regularizing parameters but
this is the direction roughly that it
looks like low learning rate low power
because you're really not giving your
decision trees that much weight uh in
their predictions you're giving a much
higher weight to the initial prediction
High Learning rate you're giving the
decision trees a lot of power so it's
likely that they may start overfitting
through the training set while the test
set starts to get worse or the test
error or validation error starts to get
worse
so here's you can see here when the
learning rate is 0.01 the validation
rmsc is
$5,000 that's way off that's like we
trying to predict values in the range
5,000 to 10,000 and if you're off by
5,000 that's pretty bad and hopefully if
we get somewhere here it start to get
better I don't think it's going to
overfit just yet because we are just at
50 estimators but let's say we had 500
estimators or 1,000 estimators and we
had given them each a max depth of of
maybe uh 10 or something then you would
definitely see that maybe Beyond 7 or so
the models would start to overfit but
right now it's just because the number
of estimators is so low that there's not
enough power even if you set the
learning rate to one it may not
overfit there is a question can hyper
parameter optimization be done while
combining multiple hyper parameters yes
absolutely like if I've put in N
estimators 50 here I could put in N
estimators
20 and I could put in
max
depth of 10 and I could put in whatever
I want here right so ultimately what
test params is doing is creating a
random forest and that random Forest is
then going to be trained on the data and
then we're going to evaluate it using
the by making predictions on the
training and validation sets Computing
the rmsc so you can modify multiple
hyper parameters at a time but it's
generally a good strategy to start with
the most
effective or the the hyper parameters
that is going to have the biggest effect
let's say the number of estimators I
would think that initially would have
the highest effect and find a good value
for the number of estimators like I
would probably try try multiples of two
I would go 50 100 200 400 and at some
point I would start to realize that
maybe the benefit is not there of
doubling again or maybe it has started
to overfit so maybe I'll just again
between maybe find something between 2
200 and 400 that works best uh maybe try
and plot a graph and figure out so pick
the biggest most impactful hyper
parameter first try and optimize that
then pick the next most impactful one
and how do you figure out which is the
most impactful one well typically if you
just try two values of each hyper
parameter like very quickly you can see
how much effect each hyper parameter has
initially so when if you if the number
of estimators is very low like 10 then
changing the learning rate by a lot is
not going
to cause overfitting very quickly so
yeah it is subjective depends on the
data set but it's a question of just
experimenting a little bit figuring out
which hyper parameters you should
optimize first for gradient boosting
that is typically number of estimators
max depth learning
rate and by the time we get to learning
rate .99 rmsc is looking pretty good but
as I said you can try putting in 500
here and it'll take 10 times longer but
that will tell you if learning rate of
0.99 is always a good idea especially at
a high number of
at a at a very high number of models and
I'm just going to run all of these cells
so that we
don't have to wait a long
time okay next up we have this argument
called
booster now I said that gradient
boosting machines use decision trees but
instead of using decision trees XG boost
can also train linear models for each
iteration so the idea is the same the
idea is pretty much the same that you
initially guess the average as your
prediction p 0 and then you compute the
residual then instead of training a
decision tree to compute the residual
maybe you train a linear regression
model so maybe you you train a linear
regression model that tries to fit the
data and then you compute the residuales
from the linear regression model right
and then you train another linear
regression model to do it and then you
train another line linear regression
model to correct the residuales and so
on so every everything Remains the Same
we just switch out the decision tree
classifier the decision tree regressor
internally for the linear regression
model and even all of these things like
the alpha and everything Remains the
Same so all of the hyper parameters can
remain the same and if you think that
there are more linear relationships
within the data then you can just test
out linear relationships as
well and seems pretty fine to me not not
too bad 2727 is
the output here the validation rmsc so
that's not bad at all so maybe you can
try experimenting with some other
hyperparameters experiment with the
linear and the tree based model and
figure out which one works
best now what will happen over time is
as you train dozens of models or maybe
hundreds of models you will start to get
a feel for how all of these
hyperparameters interact with each other
and which kind of hyper parameters are
better suited which for which kind of
data uh a lot of this is fairly subtle
uh in the sense that it is not something
that is documented explicitly it is not
something that a lot of people are even
able to express themselves um Express
clearly in words but it is something
that they know something that they
understand it's kind of like a muscle so
the best way to become good at machine
learning is to just train a lot of
models like every day just be training
some model on some data set and a great
way to uh Orient yourself and training
models is by participating in a kaggle
competition where you can just train a
bunch of models and make a submission
and see if your model worked better or
not and trying to stay organized using
spreadsheets or whatever tools you you
need to use to stay organized uh where
you note down all your ideas all your
experiments and their results and you
just keep doing that over and over and
whenever you're stuck you look for help
and the places you look for help are
typically kaggle forums where you look
at the discussions or maybe you look at
some tutorials online maybe you look at
uh some videos online and apply the
techniques that you read there and
sometimes like when you get to a point
where you've applied a lot of these
techniques and none of them work you may
have to start reading papers so
sometimes you may end up doing
that and uh that's how you get good at
machine learning right so there's
definitely more theory that you should
learn about machine learning eventually
over time that will be useful
but understanding the theory will not
help you beyond a point machine learning
is an applied uh an applied science and
applied field so the more models you
train the more experiments you do the
better you will get at it okay and a
great way to learn is also by look
looking at what others are doing all
right so here's an exercise for you try
an experiment with all the different
hyper parameters and there are several
other hyper parameters as I said earlier
it's these are not the only ones gamma
is another one I think this is gamma
indicates what is the minimum reduction
in loss that is required to create a
split
then you have main child weight which
indicates yeah which I think indicates
how many what percentage of rows each
child should contain or something like
that then you have Max Delta step what
should be
the yeah you'll have to check this out
I'm not sure about Max Delta step then
you have sub sample for each tree
instead of using all the rows you can
also just use a a fraction of the rows
so that's sub sample you have call samp
SLE by tree which means for each tree
that you create instead of using all the
columns you can simply use a fraction of
the columns instead of using all 120
columns uh that we have right now maybe
you just use 100 columns each time
randomly Chosen and that again creat
some kind of randomization
right yeah so those are some of the
things that you can try out and let's
train a final model on the entire
training set and this is also common
practice that you will have a validation
set or maybe you will do cross
validation and you will try many
different kinds of experiments and then
you you will arrive at certain hyper
parameters now once you've arrived at a
certain set of hyper parameters which
you know or you believe are the
best at the very end one last time you
can train your model on the entire
training set which means including the
validation set because now we are done
evaluating now we done evaluating
different types of models and different
hyperparameters and we've decided that
these these are the hyper parameters
that work well for this data set so at
this point it just makes sense to maybe
just train with the entire data set get
a little final boost because more data
is always helpful for the model and then
make predictions on the test set and
then submit that to kaggle okay so
always do that have a validation set use
it till the very end but when you're
making predictions just train the model
with the entire
set okay so this is this made take some
time I think I've set the number of
estimators to a th000 I believe it took
about 8 seconds when we had 50
estimators so it would
take 5 minutes or so to run
this okay so now we're training one
final model on the entire training set
with custom hyper parameters these are
the hyper parameters we've chosen 1,000
estimators a learning rate of0 2 a max
depth of
10 a sub sample of 0.9 which means we
each decision tree only use uses 90% of
the rows randomly Chosen and a column
sample by tree of 7 which means that
each decision tree only uses 70% of the
columns and then we fit the model and it
took about 5 minutes on my
computer and this is still running on
collab so maybe it'll take twice as
long and this is the model that got
created then we can evaluate the model
as well so we can create training
predictions model. predict X and then we
can do a rmsse on the train PRS and
train
targets
yeah okay there seems to be some issue
here
but but yeah ultimately you can make you
can evaluate the model using the
training set and of course that will not
be the true reflection of the
performance of the modal it's just that
we don't have a validation set right now
because this is a final training we're
doing but we train the model and once
the model is trained we can make
predictions on the test set so remember
we have the test set as well if I just
check X
test so this is X test it contains all
the information in exactly the same
format as the training inputs X train so
we can pass X test into model. predict
and that will give us a bunch of
predictions for the test set let's let's
check test
PRS so here is all the predictions that
we've generated for the test test set
and of course test PRS
applies to these IDs so we know that for
ID 1 for the first draw of the test set
the prediction is 4207 for the second
row of the test set the prediction is
7587 for the third R of the test set the
prediction is 8849 and so on and we have
to create the submission file so we have
already have the submission
DF here we have IDs and then these
random
sales actually let me just load that up
again so PD . read
CSV Rosman store
sales submission.csv so we given this
sample submission
file yeah so we given the sample
submission file uh submission.csv and
the sample file contains IDs 1 12 41088
and it contains the value zero for sales
now we have to fill in instead of the
value zero we have to fill in our
predictions so these are our predictions
test PRS
and we can do that here so we just say
submission DF Sales equals test Breads
and once we do that we can now see we
have submission
DF so here we have the IDS from the
sample submission file that was given to
us and instead of having zero sales for
everything which is the sample
submission We have replaced those zeros
with the predictions of our model 420
7.07 and so on
and we know that these predictions line
up with the IDS because these
predictions were generated using the
test Set uh X test and X test came from
test TF and in test TF these IDs were in
uh the numerical order okay so
especially with kaggle you need to be
careful make sure that you're not
shuffling your test set so that the
predictions that you make on the test
set line up with the original IDs or
whatever identifier is there in the
submission file okay so now we've
created this submission file the
submission data frame
now this's is one thing we have to
handle here recall that if the store is
not open then the sales must be zero and
this is not something that we
are accounting for in our model our
model simply assumes that the store is
open so we need to hard code this rule
that whenever the value of open in the
test set is zero then we can set the
sales to
zero okay so in some cases here maybe we
have to check if that particular ular
row had store open set to zero and if it
did we simply set that to zero so here's
one way you can do that if you just
check test
DF in test DF you have ID and you have
some information and you have store and
store is store open is either one or
store open is zero if store open is
one then we can simply keep our
prediction whatever prediction we have
made if store. open if the value of the
open column is zero then we should
simply set that value to zero so here's
a trick that I can apply if I simply
take the sales column of the submission
and multiply it with the open column of
the test data frame which is also lined
up by IDs so wherever the wherever the
store is open the value will remain and
wherever the store is closed the value
will turn into zero so that's what I'm
doing here I'm just going to do
submission DF Sales multiplied by test
DF open okay so the Ones Will retain the
values but the zeros will convert the
values to zero and that is what we want
when the store is closed the Sal should
be zero now there is one issue one minor
issue here some in some cases the value
of open in the test data frame is
Nan so this is where again we'll have to
figure out why is this data missing on
those dates were these stores open or
closed but for now I'm just going to
assume that uh wherever the data is Nan
I'm just going to assume that the store
was
open not maybe not the best assumption
but let me just assume that that
wherever the data for open is Nan the
store is open so I'm just going to fill
na with
one and now we have the submission data
frame and it is going to have a bunch of
zeros as well and you can see it it if I
just check the sample let me see
sample 20 you will see that you have
zeros in certain places and these zeros
have come by multiplying the value of
open
okay I think we have been able to train
the model here as well so let me just
let me just return to collab here so we
make predictions on the test set and
then we put these predictions into the
submission data
frame and then we have the submission
data frame that we've
created okay all right so we just did
all of that stuff locally but the same
thing we just repeated on collab as well
so now we have have submissions from
our model ready to be added ready to be
submitted to
kaggle so now we can just save this file
submission df2 CSV as submission.csv and
we set index To
None here you have submission. CSV and
I'm just going to download this
file and that's downloaded to my desktop
submission.csv
and then I'm going to go on the
competition
page
here and on this competition page I'm
just going to click late submission
because this competition has ended but I
can still submit and CS score and upload
the submission. CSV file so it's going
to take a minute or so to upload and you
can also describe your submission
because you can see your past
submissions and it'll be easy to just
check things out so let's
see maybe this is what I'll do I will
simply L copy
over I will simply copy
over this I think this is a great way to
describe my submission because it has
all the hyper
parameters yep I think you can even
write it as code so maybe let me just do
this yeah so this is the information
this is everything I need to know about
my submission and I click make
submission and that gives me a score1
3152 let's see where that lies on the
leaderboard
13152 13152 well it's already pretty bad
but actually yeah it it may be good
enough because there are 3,20
participants and
.13 okay looks like it's a long way
down
yeah somewhere here so we are in the top
50% and that's not bad if you're in the
top 50% of a kaggle competition then you
have a decent model and you will see
that the gains are actually pretty small
beyond that point like from .13 to .11
the overall gain is of about 10% right
so you're about you you have achieved
about a 90% possible reduction in the
error and mostly here in a lot of cases
the top submissions often have a lot of
models maybe they Ensemble like 10
models and we've not trained a very big
model even though it took about 15
minutes we've only put in what 1,000
estimators and a max depth of 10 and a
learning rate of 02 people do a lot more
you can imagine setting a model to train
overnight with maybe 10,000 estimators
and a different learning rate and a
different Max
step of course you have to first do some
experiments to figure out that you're
not overfitting but of often especially
with gradient boosting these models can
run into hours the training times and
you can use gpus so one thing that I
would encourage you to check out is how
to train an XG boost model on a GPU and
you will see a significant speed up if
you use a GPU sometimes even 10 to 100
times faster um and gpus are gpus or
graphic processing units are very
efficient at performing Matrix
computations which is the kind of
computations that XG boost requires
okay and now here we have not done cross
validation so one thing we could do is
we could also do kfold cross validation
that would give us five models and then
we could average out the results of
those five models or another thing that
you could do is you could train five
models with five different hyper five
different sets of hyper parameters and
then average the results of those models
yet another thing you could do is you
could train uh the best possible random
forest model the best possible gradient
boosting model the best possible deep
learning model the best
possible svm support Vector machine kind
of model and then average all of their
results and one other thing you can do
there is instead of just blindly
averaging all their results maybe apply
weights to the results of each of the
models give each Model A Certain weight
and optimize the weights now one way you
can optimize the weights is by hand
tuning each weight but the other way you
can do that is you can do something
called stacking which is train a linear
regression model on top of those weights
uh to figure out the best weights to
apply to each model right how much
should how much weightage should be
given to the XG boost regressor how much
weightage should be given to the random
Forest etc
etc and those are all the techniques
that people apply to get to the top like
the first 100 or 200 submissions would
all have uh several models as you can
see here there you can even form teams
on kaggle so on kaggle you'll find that
these five people would each have
trained maybe five models
and they would each have worked
independently trained five models and
then the team would essentially mean
ensembling the results of each of those
five models by each of those five people
so you give your results and this person
gives their results and this person
gives their results and so on and then
they average the results and they simply
submit that and that itself gives them a
huge uh boost because the more different
kinds of models the more different kinds
of ideas that you combine the more the
effects of ensembling work or the wisdom
of crowd kicks in or the errors cancel
out
okay so that's making a kaggle
submission I encourage you to try out
different hyperparameters and beat the
score should not be too difficult take
inspiration from the top notebooks in
the code tab of the
competition and here is another exercise
for you just save the model and all the
required objects using jobb we did this
for decision trees the process is
exactly the same where you create a
dictionary with all the important
useful things that you need to
do to take any input and make
predictions on the input and then save
that dictionary using
jblb yet another exercise for you is to
write a function predict input so
predict input should take a
dictionary and in that dictionary we can
put in all the columns of data that are
there in the training data set for
example
a date let's see what that look like so
let me just
see Ross
DF yeah so here is sample input let's
say I give you a sample
input in the sample input
store is two and then day of
week is uh four and and then date is
something else like let's say one of
these and then you have of course you
won't have sales or customers you will
only have open so let's say open is
one and then you have promo and state
holiday and School holiday Etc okay so
given an input like this can you make a
can you write a function to make a
prediction from the model what are all
the things that you will have to do well
first thing you will have to do is put
this input into a data frame so let me
just do PD do uh data
frame and here I'm just going to put
give it a list of dictionaries and just
one dictionary here so sample input and
let's call this input
DF yep there we go input DF and then you
would then have to perform all the
pre-processing that we had performed
earlier of course I should also put in
this in information let me just add that
quickly state holiday zero and School
holiday
zero yeah so that's your input data
frame the next thing you would have to
do is you would have to merge with
stores
DF so that would look something like
this this input DF do merge store
DF on
store and let's just put that in input
merged
DF so that's what that will look
like next you would have to do all the
feature
engineering so that you have done which
is the
dates the competition related
stuff and then the promo two related
columns you have to add all those
columns
here next you will have to do some
pre-processing so for the pre-processing
you would have
to fill missing values or
imputation and then you would have to do
scaling using the same imputer that we
had created in the same scaler and then
you would have to do the encoding for
the categorical
data then you can pass it into the
model uh of course only after selecting
the right uh set of
rows selecting the right side of columns
which is just the numerical plus encoded
columns okay it's always good to just
write this out and then it becomes a lot
easier to actually do it so now for
feature engineering let's do the dates
so
what was that function called I don't
recall
but let's say was
it date
something let's look it up
here yeah split date so let's call split
date now on the data frame so split date
on input
DF then let's add the computation
related data so here we have comp
months comp months on input
DF then let's add
the promo check so promo calls is what
it's
called promo calls input
DF and let's look at input DF after this
or this is called input merge DF
actually input merge DF here input merge
DF here input merge DF
here okay this should
be I think this shouldn't be 31 this
should be 30 this is not a valid date so
let's just get that
fixed yep so now we have input merge
TF
now we have input merge TF now we have
all these rows now we need to perform
the imputation well there's no
imputation to be done because there is a
competition distance already uh so this
is not
required there is a scaling required so
I'm just going to do input
merged DF numeric
calls
equals scalar do transform then scaler
already has the scaling parameters input
merge DF
numeric
calls and then there is also an encoding
required so input merged DF encoded
calls so remember the encoded columns we
have already saved the names and we say
encoder do
transform input merged
DF categorical
calls okay so that is the
imputation and the
scaling okay I think I may have to just
do it a little more carefully but once
you do the imputation and scaling then
you can maybe just select the numerical
and encoded columns and once you select
the numerical and encoded columns then
you should be able to uh make
predictions on the data set
okay I believe I forgot to add promo let
me just add that
here yeah let me just add the promo here
yeah I just missed one factor in the
input and there seem to be some other
issues is there as well in any case we
will fix all of these and once you have
that you will have you will get an X
input and the X input will simply
be input merged
DF numeric
calls plus Cate plus encoded
calls these are the one encoded columns
and then you can pass it into the model
so you can say model. predict and you
can give it X input and that will give
you a list of predictions of course
there's only one element in the list so
you can just select out the zeroth
element and that should give you the
prediction let's maybe take just a a
small second to fix
this is Nan is not supported for input
types the inputs could not be safely
coed
okay maybe i' I've still missed some
column somewhere so I am yeah I'm just
not too sure maybe I just have to do
this a little more carefully and this
should be
fine test
DF so we have the store we have the day
of the
week we have date open promo state
holiday
and yeah I think we have all the
information so so I'm not sure what the
issue
is ah I see maybe this should be
a and this should be
zero yep all right okay now we fix the
input and this is the prediction for the
input so the prediction that our model
makes is
60265 so the model predicts that given
this
input sample
input
the output or the sale on this
particular date is going to be 6026
based on everything that it has learned
from our data
okay and that's how you use the model so
you have to perform all these
pre-processing steps onto this simple
input before you can make a
prediction so that's all for today we
learned about gradient boosting and
gradient boosting is a very simple idea
where we first predict the average as a
prediction and then we find the errors
that our prediction has made and we
train a decision tree to correct the
errors and then we make new predictions
using the initial prediction and the
predictions of the decision tree scaled
down by a learning rate and that gives
us new errors and then we try to correct
those errors with a second decision tree
and so on so we looked at how to
download a real world data set from a
kaggle competition and we looked at how
to perform feature engineering and
prepare a data set for training this is
an very important part and this is
something that you will have to learn
with practice by looking at what other
people are doing
we looked at training and interpreting a
gradient boosting model using XG boost
there is also another Library called
light GBM which works exactly the same
way but it has certain optimizations
that might be useful for larger data
sets and some of the ways in which it
operates some of the internal
implementations are
different ultimately both XG boost and
light GBM are implementations of several
papers in the space of uh tree based
learning algorithms and gradient
boosting so check out what the
differences are uh then you also
have we saw we also saw how to um
perform kfold cross validation and how
to combine the results of the K
folds we also learned how to configure a
gradient boosting model and how to tune
hyper parameters of the model which is
essentially by going up and down and
figuring out where we are getting the
best fit and going with the most
impactful hyperparameter first and then
slowly going through all the other
parameters okay and that's what machine
learning Engineers or data scientists
and ml practitioners do all day uh
create new features tune
hyperparameters and think of ways to
just improve the data for the machine
learning model and maybe get the machine
learning model to train a bit faster as
well here are some resources you should
check out there is definitely a lot more
about gradient boosting that that we've
not covered here but this should serve
as a good
introduction the topic for today is
unsupervised learning using pyit
loan and specifically we're going to
talk about a couple of unsupervised
learning techniques clustering which
is taking some data points and
identifying clusters from those data
points this is a visual representation
here and D dimensionality reduction
which is taking again a bunch of data
points that exists in two 3 4 5 or any
number of
dimensions and reducing them to fewer
dimensions for example here we taking
all these points and then we are taking
a line and projecting all these points
on the line and simply looking at their
positions on the line instead of looking
at these two coordinates so that's what
we're going to talk about
today and we'll start with just an
overview of unsupervised learning
algorithms in psyit learn then talk
about clustering and then talk about
dimensionality reduction
now this is going to be a high level
overview we're not going to look at a
very detailed implementation neither the
uh detailed internal workings we will
try and grasp the intuitive idea of how
these different algorithms work and what
they are used for and how they're
different from one another okay and I
encourage you to explore more as I've
been saying for the last few weeks we
are at that point where you can now
learn things from online resources from
books from tutorials from courses on a
need to know basis so whenever you come
across a certain term that you need to
know about you look it up and you find a
good resource and then you spend some
time on it maybe spend a day a couple of
days working through some examples and
become familiar with it okay so from
this point you have to start searching
you have to start doing some research on
your own and a great way to
then consolidate your learning is to put
put together a short tutorial of your
own like the tutorials that you have
been seeing in this boot camp try
creating your own tutorial on any topic
of your CH choice for example on
principal component analysis and publish
that and share it with the community and
we would love to include it back within
the boot camp as well so yeah I
encourage you to try out check out any
topics of your choice and craft
tutorials so let's install the required
libraries I'm just installing numpy
pandas matplot lib cbon these are the
standard data analysis libraries and I'm
also installing Jovian and pyit learn
because these are the libraries we'll
need to use
today now unsupervised machine learning
refers to the category of machine
learning techniques where models are
trained on a data set without any labels
unlike supervised
learning and you might wonder what
exactly are we training for if there are
no labels if we just have a bunch of
data
so unsupervised learning is generally
used to discover patterns in data and to
reduce high dimensional data to fewer
dimensions and here is how it fits in
into the overall machine learning
landscape of course you have computer
science is or where artificial
intelligence machine learning and
everything that we're doing comes under
but within computer science you have
artificial intelligence where you have
sometimes you have rule based systems
sometimes you have machine learning
models where models are learning
things learning patterns and learning
relationships between data now again
machine learning is comprised of
unsupervised learning and supervised
learning supervised learning is where
you have labels for your data and
unsupervised learning is where you do
not have labels now there are also a
couple of other categories or overlaps
called semi-supervised learning and
self-supervised learning so we'll not
get into that right now but I encourage
you to check this out and then there is
one branch of machine learning deep
learning which we we have not talked
about in this course but uh we have
another course on it called Deep
learning with py toch 0 to Gans so I
encourage you to check that out sometime
later which kind of cuts across all of
these categories and it's just a new
paradigm or a new way of uh doing
machine learning so encourage checking
it out as well it it kind of it's a sort
of a wide reaching approach that applies
to various different kinds of problems
and here is what we are studying in this
course we are looking at classical
machine learning algorithms as opposed
to deep learning and the reason we're
doing that is because a lot of the data
that we work with today is tabular data
like 95% of the data that companies deal
with is tabular data Excel sheets
database tables CSV files
Etc and the best known algorithms for
tabular data at this point especially
algorithms that can be interpreted and
controlled well are classical machine
learning algorithms and we've looked at
supervised learning algorithms already
things like uh classification where
we've looked at again linear regression
U we've looked at logistic regression
we've looked at a decision tree
classification gradient boosting based
classification and regression where we
try to predict a number so
classification is where we divide
observations into different classes and
and predict those classes for new
observations regression is where we try
to predict a continuous value and today
we're looking at unsupervised learning
where there is no label for any data and
you either try and cluster the data
which is create similar stacks of data
or you try and reduce the dimensionality
of reduce the dimensions of the
data or sometimes you try and find
associations between different data
points and uh use that for doing things
like recommendations
and psyched learn offers this cheat
sheet for you to decide which model to
pick for a given problem now most of the
time you will if you've you done a
little bit of machine learning you will
automatically know what models to pick
so this is a very simple or very obvious
kind of a tree but it's still good to
see these are the four categories of
algorithms available in pyit learn so if
you are predicting a category and you
have some labeled data that is when you
use class classification but on the
other hand if you're trying to predict a
category and you do not have labeled
data that is when you use clustering
right so that's one difference between
classification and clustering that's a
common confusion in clustering there are
no labels for us to look at we just want
to group whatever data points we have
into different clusters and of course if
you're predicting a quantity you should
be using regression and if you're just
looking at data if you just want
to visualize data or reduce its size
that's when you look at principal
component analysis and embedding and
things like that
okay so let's talk about clustering
now as I've said a couple of times
already clustering is the process of
grouping objects from a data set such
that the objects in the same group are
more similar in some
sense to each other than to those in
other groups
so that's the definition the Wikipedia
definition for you and psyched learn
offers several clustering algorithms and
in fact it has an entire section on
clustering algorithms that you should
check
out so it talks a little bit about the
different clustering methods you can see
there are about 10 or more than 10
clustering methods and it tells you
about the use cases for different
clustering methods it tells you about
the scalability how well these methods
scale to different different kinds of
different sizes of data sets and
different number of clusters and the
parameters that they take and all of
these are fairly different in how they
are implemented but the goal is
ultimately the same the goal is to take
some data for example here let's say we
just had a bunch of points here where uh
here this example plots incomes and
debts so this is a scatter plot between
incomes of various people and the amount
of debt that they have at the moment so
each Points each point represents one
person so these people are people who
have high income but low debt and these
people are people who have low income
and low debt and these people are people
who have low income and very high debt
right so clearly there are three
clusters of people here and typically
these clusters don't come predefined so
you would simply have income and debt
information and what you might want to
do is identify which cluster a
particular person belongs to or even
figure out what the Clusters should look
like so that's what clustering is and
that's what we'll try and do today given
all these points we will try and figure
out what how many clusters there are in
the data and which clusters do each of
the points belong to and potentially if
there is a new data point that comes in
which cluster will that data point
belong to okay so that's what we'll talk
about now why are we interested in
clustering in the first place here are
some real world applications of
clustering one is of course customer
segmentation now suppose you are an
insurance company and you're looking at
or you are a bank and you're looking at
applications for loans then this kind of
a cluster analysis is something that you
may want to do just plot incomes and
debt and see where the person lies which
cluster the line and you may have a
different set of operating rules for
high income low debt people low-income
low debt and high low-income High dead
people and then you may just want to
just to simplify decision- making
instead of each time having having to
look at both variables you can simply
feed the variables into a computer
algorithm get back a category for them
and use that category
to make decisions for them
right so often the classes in several
classification problems are obtained in
the first
place through clustering processes uh
especially when you're looking at things
like low risk medium risk high risk
Etc
then product recommendation is another U
important application of clustering
where if you can identify clusters of
people who like a particular product
then you can recommend that same product
to people who have
similar
behaviors feature engineering is yet
another uh application what you could do
is you could perform some clustering on
your data and then you could actually
take the cluster number and add added to
your data your training data as a
categorical column and it's possible
that adding that categorical column May
improve the training of a decision tree
or a gradient boosting
tree then you have anomaly or fraud
detection now of course if you have if
if you plot again let's say you have a
bunch of credit card transactions and
then you cluster credit card
transactions you will notice that
fraudulent transactions stand out maybe
there are certain credit cards that make
a lot of transactions so they don't fall
within the regular cluster they fall
within the anomalous cluster and that
can be used to then detect that for this
kind of a fraudulent Behavior what is
the activity how do you deal with the
how do you deal with the problem right
another use of clustering called
hierarchical clustering specifically is
for taxonomy creation now you know that
there are several
hierarchical divisions in biology
between for first you have of course the
animals and plants and then between
plants you have a bunch of different
families and then in each family you
have a bunch of different species and so
on right so that kind of a hierarchy is
created using clustering where you take
a bunch of different attributes like
what kind of reprod reproduction a
particular animal uh has and whether
they what kind of tee they have what
kind of weight they have where do they
live and things like that and use that
to create clusters and create families
of related animals and then related
families get grouped into related
kingdoms and so
on so those are some applications of
clustering and we will use the iris
flower data set to study some of the
clustering algorithms available in psyit
loan so here is the iris FL data set I'm
just going to load it from the seabon
library it
comes included with
Seaborn so here is the iris this data
set in this data set you have four you
have observations about 150 flowers you
can see 150 rows of data each row
represents some observations for a
flower and the observations are the
length of the saple the width of the
saple and saple and petal are two parts
of the
flower and the length of the petal and
the width of the petal okay so these are
four measurements we have and then we
also know which species these flowers
belong to now for the purpose of today's
tutorial we are going to assume that we
don't know what species these flowers
belong to okay let's just pretend that
we don't know what species the flowers
belong to we just have these
measurements now what we'll try and do
is we will try and apply clustering
techniques to group all of these flowers
into different clusters and see if those
clusters which our clustering algorithms
have picked out just by looking at these
four observations match these species or
not okay so we're not going to use
species at all uh we are going to treat
this data as
unlabeled so here's what the data looks
like you can see that you have if I just
plot saple length versus petal length
this is what the points look
like and if I did not have this
information about species then this is
what the points would look like right so
if you look at the points here you might
say that maybe there are two clusters
there's one cluster here and then
there's one cluster here maybe if you
look even closely you might say that
okay maybe there's like three clusters
here maybe this is a cluster and maybe
this seems like a cluster and of course
we're just looking at two Dimensions
here we're looking at saple length and
petal length we're not really looking at
all four dimensions because we can't
even visualize four dimensions but we
could look at saple length we could look
at saple width and petal
width and there seem to be a couple of
clusters maybe three clusters here and
and again we could look at diff
different combinations or if we could
take three of them and visualize them in
3D and try and identify some clusters or
well we have no way of actually
visualizing things in 4D so that's where
we will have to take the help of a
computer right but just even within
representation here of saple length and
petal length you can see that clusters
do start to form and it's an interesting
question to ask how do you train a
computer to figure out these clusters
given just these four measurements saple
length saple width petal length and
petal width
okay so as I've said we are going to
attempt to Cluster observations using
numeric columns in the data so I'm going
to pull out a list of numeric columns
and just take the data from the numeric
columns into this variable x and x is
typically used to represent the input
into a machine learning algorithm okay
so there's just this X and there's no y
here so the first clustering algorithm
we'll talk about is K means clustering
and the k Ames clustering algorithm
attempts to classify objects into a
predetermined number of
clusters so you have to decide the K in
K means is the number of clusters that
you wanted the data to have so in this
case let's say we have some intuition
that maybe by looking at some Scatter
Plots we feel like maybe there are two
maybe there are three clusters so we can
give an input number of clusters to the
K means algorithm and then it will do
something and it'll take this data let's
say we give the input of ks3
it's going to then figure
out it's going to then figure out three
Central points for each cluster so here
is the centrer point for cluster number
one here is the centrer point for
cluster number two and here is the
center point for cluster number
three and then each of these Central
points are also called centroids and
then each object or each observation in
the data set is going to be classified
as belonging to the cluster represented
by the closest Center Point okay so
that's why you can see that all these
belong to this cluster all these are set
to belong to this cluster and all these
are set to belong to this cluster and of
course now if you go out and make a new
observation maybe you get another FL
measure it SLE petal and all and put in
this put in the observations here and if
the flower lies somewhere here then it
will belong to the cluster of the cent
center that it is closest to okay so
that's the K means algorithm now the
question you may have is how exactly are
these centers determined so let's talk
about that and maybe let's take an
example let's take maybe a
onedimensional example initially and
then we will expand that to two
dimensions and go from
there so let me draw a line
here and let's say this line
represents the petal length okay and I'm
just going to take petal length from
let's say 0 to 5 all the values seem to
have petal length between 0 to 5 and let
me take about 12 flowers let me let's
not consider all 15 and let's say you
have these four floors they have a
fairly low petal length Okay very close
to one maybe and then you have another
four
floors they have a medium petal length
and then you have yet another four
floors they have a high petal length
okay
now visually just by looking at by
looking at just the pedal length you can
kind of cluster you can kind of visually
say that okay this is one cluster and
this is one cluster and this is one
cluster right now the challenge is how
do you train a computer to figure out
these clusters so here's what we going
to
do first we determine in K means
algorithm what is the value of K so
let's say I set the value of K to 3 okay
for some reason I have some intuition
that maybe the value of K is 3 and we'll
talk about how to pick the right value
of K later then what we do is we pick
three random points so let's pick three
random points
maybe I pick this one that's a random
Point sure I pick this one okay that's a
random point and then I pick this all
right that's a random
point so now we are going to treat these
three random points as the centers of
our clusters so now this becomes the
center of cluster one this becomes the
center of cluster two and this becomes a
center of cluster
3 okay great so here's what we've done
so far pick K random objects as the
initial cluster
centers and then the next step is to
classify each object into the cluster
whose Center is closest to the to that
object so now let's start let's try and
classify this point or this flower now
which uh which cluster is this flower
closest to well you can clearly see that
it is Clos closest to the center of uh
it's closest to Center one so this
becomes one and then check the next one
and this is also closest to one so this
also gets assigned the the cluster one
and this also gets assigned the cluster
one this also gets assigned the cluster
one I would say that even this is closer
to one than two so this also gets
assigned the question cluster one and of
course this point is already in cluster
one then you have this one cluster two
and this also this gets assigned cluster
two this one I would say is CL closer to
three so this gets assigned to Cluster
three and this is cluster three and this
is cluster three as well okay okay so
now we have a clustering but definitely
this clustering is not that great you
can clearly see that these two should
rather belong to the class two so here
is where we do the next interesting
thing once we have determined the
Clusters so like this is cluster
one and then this is cluster two and
then this is cluster
three we then for each cluster of
classified objects compute the centroid
or simply the mean the centroid is
nothing but the mean right now we're
looking at one dimension so that the
centroid is simply the mean and we'll
talk about two Dimensions but here's
what we do then we basically take all
these values so this is like this is
about 7 this is about 1 this is about
1.2 etc etc and then we take their
average so if you take the average of
all these values and let me draw another
line
here so if we take the average of all
these values the average of all these
values would be somewhere around here
right and then we take the average of
all these values in the cluster two and
that would be somewhere around here and
then we take the average of all these
values and that would be somewhere
around
here now here's the interesting thing
once we've taken the averages we make
these the new centers of the cluster so
this becomes the center for cluster one
this becomes a center for cluster two
this becomes a center for cluster three
okay
and now you can see things are already
starting to look
better let's just put back these points
here okay so now what what we've done is
we have taken each cluster that we
created using randomly picked points and
we took the averages of those clusters
and said these are the new cluster
centers Now using these new cluster
centers we reclassify the points okay so
that's what we're doing
we are now going to reclassify each
object using the centroids as the
cluster centers so now this point is
given uh the class one this point goes
to class one and this point goes to
class one this point goes to class one
two now this point goes to class two
Class 2 Class 2 and class two and you
have class three class 3 class 3 and
class three okay and that's it so just
like that now we have ended up with
cluster one cluster cluster
2 cluster 3 okay so that is exactly how
K means works but one last issue here
suppose the points that we had picked
out in our random selection initially
were very bad points let's say they were
somewhere here let's say we had picked
this this and this as the points what
would happen then well what would happen
is all of these would belong to the
first cluster and this would be the
second cluster and this would be the
third cluster and the average would lie
somewhere here so your first cluster
would be here and the second and third
would be here so you would still end up
even after performing the entire average
and reclassifying the points you would
still end up with this huge cluster
maybe this maybe these might get
excluded like maybe these might go into
two but you would still get both of
these sections into one big cluster
right so K means does not always work
perfectly right uh it depends on that
random selection so that's where what we
do is we repeat these steps steps 1 to
six a few more times to pick the cluster
centers with the lowest total variance
and we'll talk about that last piece
again so here's what we do just to recap
pick K random objects as the initial
cluster centers like this one this one
and this one classify each object into
the cluster whose Center is the closest
to the point so now we've classified
each object based on the randomly picked
clusters then compute the SE centroid or
the mean for each set of clusters so
here the centroid lay here and here the
centroid lay here here the centroid lay
here then use the centroids as
the new cluster centers and reclassify
all the points
okay then so you do that and you keep
track of those centroids and then you do
the whole process again K random objects
classify compute the centroid
reclassify keep that option around and
keep doing that over and over and over
multiple times and let's say you do it
about 10 times or 20 times and out of
the 20 you simply pick the one where you
got the
best lowest total variance so what do we
mean mean by the total variance well
here's how you can compare two sets of
clusters right
so and I'm not going to draw the points
anymore but let's say you have one set
of clusters that looks like this and you
have one set of clusters again through K
means that looks like this okay so what
you do is you compute the variance now
you have a bunch of points in this
cluster right so these points are
nothing but values on a line remember
this is petal length so whenever you
have points you can compute the variance
a variance is simply the measure of
spread how much spread is there in this
data and then you compute the variance
of these points the points that you have
here and you compute the variance of
these points and add up these values
okay so here this is like a relatively
low variance right this is let's say
this variance is 7 this variance is. 2
and this variance is uh five this is
like a relatively low variance on the
other hand consider this the variance
here is pretty high so the variance here
is like
2.1 and the variance here is U about4
the variance here is about .1 let's say
right so the total variance here in this
case is about 2.6 and the total variance
here 7 +2 +0.5 is going to be about 1.4
okay and the variance is simply the
square of the standard deviation if you
remember from basic uh statistics right
so what do we mean when we have a low
total variance when we have a low total
variance what we are essentially
expressing is that all the points in
every cluster are very close together
and when we have a high total variance
what we are expressing there is that
there are points in a certain cluster or
in certain clusters that are very far
away from each other so as as we try all
of these random experiments we simply
pick the cluster centers which minimize
the total variance and with enough
random experiments you
can almost be sure that you will get to
a point which is very close to the
optimal solution okay you may not get
the best possible Division and sometimes
even when you run KES multiple times you
may get different cluster divisions
depending on the kind of data but once
you run it enough time you will get to a
pretty good place
uh and that's basically the that's
basically how K me's algorithm works now
of course how does this apply to
two-dimensional data exactly the same
way now let's say you have petal length
and you have petal width so you're
looking at both of these and you have a
couple of flowers here and then you have
some flowers here and then you have some
flowers
here okay so what do you do you pick
three random points let's say you your
you have set k equals 3 so you pick
three random
points uh maybe let me pick that using
those three random points you set them
as the cluster centers and once you set
them as the cluster centers you
get you label all the other points 1 one
one and then all these I think are also
close
to
one and then yeah and then these are
close to two and this one is close to
three or something like that then what
you do you take all these points and
then you take the centroid so when you
take the centroid the centroid ends up
here and then when you take the centroid
of these two the centroid ends up here
and you take the centroid of these two
the centroid ends up here now once you
get the centroid you once again then do
the classification so now when you do
computations against the centroid some
of the clust some of the Clusters may
change I mean this is probably not a
great example but maybe let's say you
got a centroid here and you got a
centroid here so what will then happen
is all of these will now fall into a
different cluster and all of these will
fall into a different cluster and all of
these will fall into a different cluster
okay so the exact same process K random
objects
classify compute the centroid and what
is the centroid well you take all the X
values of the of the of the points in
this cluster and take their mean you
take all the y- values of the points in
the cluster and take their mean so
centroid is simply a dimension wise mean
uh that you take okay okay and you then
you do this multiple times using random
initial cluster centers and you pick
simply the centers with the lowest total
variance to get the measure of uh and
use that as a measure of goodness okay
so that's how K means works and here is
how you actually perform K means
clustering you don't have to write code
for any of that all you do is you import
Kes from SK learn.
cluster and then here you you simply uh
initialize K means you give it n
clusters the number of clusters you want
to create and then you give it a random
State you don't have to give this uh
this is just to ensure that each time
the randomization is initialized in the
exact same way and you call model. fit
you call model. fit and you just give it
the X and remember the X simply contains
the numeric data there is no target
given
here and once the model is fitted you
can actually check the clust clust
centers so now remember this is
clustering not on one dimension not on
two Dimensions but on four different
dimensions and the algorithm is exactly
the same it's just that the number of
Dimensions has increased so what the
model has found is that the cluster
centers are as follows for cluster
one the center is at a saple length of
5.9 and the saple width of 2.7 and a
petal length of 4.3 and petal width of 4
point uh of
1.4 and this is the second cluster
similarly and this is the third cluster
now when we want to classify points
using the model this is what we do we
check the distance 5.1 to 5.9 okay
that's about 8 we check the distance of
3.5 to 2.7 that's about 7 we check the
difference of 1.4 to 4.3 okay that's a
lot that's a that's about um 3 point uh
that's about 2.9 and we check the
distance 0.2 to 1.4 okay so we see how
far away each of these values are from
the original values so we we are
basically going to
subtract the cluster
center from the actual values and then
we add up the squares of those
differences okay and basically what that
means is if you have a cluster Center
here let's say this is a cluster Center
and this is a point
okay now the cluster Center is going to
look something like this XY in two
dimensions and the point is going to
look like this X Y in two Dimensions so
let me call that X1 y1 and X2 Y2 what we
do is we compute X1 -
X2
2ar + y1 -
Y2
squared and we take the square root of
that
okay so what is that exactly well that
is nothing but the actual distance
between the two points in the two
Dimensions because if you just see this
triangle over here this right angle
triangle this part of the triangle this
edge of the triangle is simply X2 - X1
this length and then this length over
here is simply Y2 - y1 so this distance
over here is the by the py pagus theorem
it is root over the sum of squares of
these two sides so this is actually the
distance D between the two points right
so we check for each point its distance
from the cluster center from each
cluster Center so we compute for this
point the distance from this cluster
Center the distance from this cluster
Center and the distance for this from
this cluster Center and we find that
this cluster Center is the closest so
this is the cluster that it gets
assigned to okay uh so don't worry about
the math the the basic idea is each
point is going to get assigned to the
cluster that it is the closest to and
that closeness is determined using
this sometimes it's called the L2 Norm
sometimes it's called the ukian distance
it's basically just the Pythagoras
Theorem it's it's calculating the
distance in these four dimensions
okay so the way we can now classify each
point or each flower into these clusters
is by calling model. predict so we call
model predict on X and the model now
figures out that compare calculating the
distance of this point or this flower to
Cluster Center 1 and cluster Center 2
and cluster Center 3 it turns out that
it is closest to Cluster Center number
one uh sorry 012 so it's closest to this
cluster Center okay and and you can
verify that if you want to actually use
there's a distance formula and S learn
to so all these points belong to
the cluster number one and then a bunch
of these points belong to Cluster number
zero and some of these in between you
can see belong to Cluster number two and
then a lot of these points belong to
Cluster number two and some of these in
between belong to Cluster number zero
okay so each flower has now been
classified into a
cluster and if I want to plot that here
is what that will look like so I've
plotted the cluster centers here this is
cluster Center number one this is
cluster sorry this is cluster Center
number zero this is cluster Center for
the cluster number one this is cluster
Center number two and you can I'll let
you verify here that it is classifying
based on closeness of the points and not
just here we are just looking at saple
length and petal length but you if you
actually measure the closeness it's
taking into consideration all four
dimensions so that's why you may not get
the perfect picture here but if you
measure the closeness across all four
dimensions all of these flowers have
been detected as belonging to this
cluster
and all of these flws belong to this
cluster and all of these belong here
okay and that looks pretty similar to
the chart that we had earlier the
scatter plot with species it's it seemed
like there was this one species of FL
then there was a second species and a
third species it's possible that there
is some
misclassification but already you can
see the power of clustering right and
imagine now these were not flowers but
these were these were attributes about
customers coming to a website and we
took these four attributes about
customers maybe we took attributes like
how long they stayed on the site how
many things that they how many things
they clicked on what extent of the page
did they scroll to and where did they
come from right or something like that
so we take four such attributes and then
we cluster our customers based on those
four attributes and we get these three
clusters now we can then look into each
of these clusters and figure out maybe
these customers are spending a very
little time on the site maybe these
customers are spending decent amount of
time on the site and are also scrolling
to a long to a large degree and maybe
these customers are actually making a
purchase so then maybe we can go and
interview some of these customers and
then figure out how uh maybe we should
focus of more of our marketing efforts
on these customers maybe understand
their demographics maybe understand uh
the things the products they look at the
kind of celebrities they follow maybe
get one of those celebrities to endorse
our products and then then you can get a
lot more customers who are in this
cluster right so in general you want to
grow the cluster of your paying users
and you probably want to ignore the
people who are not really interested in
your
product okay so that's sort of a uh how
this extends into real world analysis so
you can think of clustering more as a
data analysis tool like sometimes you
can just take the data cluster it and
then present your observations and sort
of use that as a kickoff point for
further analysis but technically
speaking because it is figuring out
these patterns out of data so it is a
machine learning algorithm
okay and I mentioned to you about the
goodness of the fit
so the total variance of these three
clusters what we do is we take the
variance of all these points and we take
the variance of all these points and
variance of all these points across all
four dimensions and then we average out
the
variance and and then we add up we
average out the variance across all
dimensions and then we add up the
variances for the individual clusters so
the total
variances of all the individual clusters
is called the
inertia so remember variance tells you
the amount of spread of the data so the
less the spread within the
Clusters the better is
the goodness of the fit right so here it
turns out that we have an overall
variance or an overall inertia of 78 now
let's try creating six clusters instead
of three
clusters so here we now have K means and
we have put in number of clusters as six
and we're trying to predict here and you
can see that it has made a bunch of
predictions and these are what the
Clusters look like so we have a couple
of clusters here so this got broken down
and then we have a couple of clusters
here and then we have a couple of
clusters here so you can see that even
with six clusters it basically took
those three clusters and broke them into
two more clusters and maybe now if you
go back and look at the actual species
and maybe like act look at the actual
flower you may realize that okay maybe
these are fully grown setosa flowers and
maybe these are young setosa flowers
maybe these are fully grown virginica
flowers maybe these are young vinica
flowers or things like that right so
when you do
clustering you may uncover more interest
in things even if you already have some
kind of classes or labels for your data
right so here's here's what we get with
six
clusters and you can check the entropy
here hopefully the entropy here should
be lower sorry the inertia here should
be lower so if we just check model do
inertia here you can see that the model
do inertia is 39 instead of
78 so there's definitely you can see
that these CL this definitely a better
classification because there is total
over overall variance across all
clusters is actually pretty
low now in most real world scenarios
there is no predetermined number of
clusters and in such a case what you can
do is maybe just take a sample of data
like if you have millions of data points
maybe just take 100 or maybe a th data
points and then try different numbers of
clusters and for each each value of K
which is the number of clusters train
the model and compute the inertia of the
model the total overall variance and
then plot the inertia so what we're
going to do here is take cluster sizes
of 2 to
10 and then try them all out and then
we're going to plot the number of
clusters on the x-axis and the inertia
on the y- AIS and it's going to create a
graph like this and this is called an
elbow curve it may not always be this
nice reducing this nice exponential kind
of curve in a lot of cases it will
actually flatten out like this Beyond a
certain point creating new clust
clusters won't really help so what you
can then decide is okay the point at
which things start to flatten out is
maybe the right number of clusters so in
this case I would say that definitely
around like there's a huge decrease when
we go from two clusters to three
clusters and three to four and maybe
even four to five but definitely around
six things start to flatten out so maybe
for this data I should just go with six
clusters okay so this is the kind of
analysis that you can do and you don't
have to use the entire data to do this
analysis and do the analysis pick the
point where you get this elbow kind of
shape so in a lot of cases what you will
end up with is a graph that looks like
this here you have the value of K the
number of clusters here you have the
inertia and this is what the graph will
typically look like
so you want to pick either this point or
this point as the number of clusters
okay so I can't really say that you need
three clusters or five clusters but you
draw this graph and then based on this
you figure out where the elbow point
is so that's the K means algorithm
and if you remember the algorithm one
thing we said was that we want to
randomly test a lot of these things each
time so remember we said that you pick K
points and then you use them as cluster
centers classify all the points compute
the centroids then reclassify all the
points and then repeat that process
randomly many
times that may not be a good idea
because if you are working with a really
large data set because it can get really
really slow so that's why you have a
variation of Kes called the mini batch K
means algorithm now in the mini batch K
means algorithm instead of taking
all the points instead of classifying
all the points you pick just a fixed
number of points and the fixed number is
called the mini batch size so you just
pick a fixed number of points compute
their centroids and compute the cluster
centers for those let's say those 100
points and then you pick a next 100
points and for those next 100 points you
start by using the previous centroids
rather than using the other than using a
random K points you start by using the
previous K centroids okay so there's a
small change that you apply here that
each time you pick about 100 or 200 or
300 points whatever is the batch size
and use that to update the centroids or
update the cluster centers from the
previous patch and again this is the
point where you can now go through and
read about mini batch K means clustering
and figure out how that is different
from the traditional K means cluster ing
that we've just looked at okay so here's
a data set this is this is called a
malls customer data set where you have
information about a bunch of customers
who visited a mall and you can try
performing K clustering by downloading
this data set and then using the C's
class from psyit learn and then maybe
you can also study the segments once you
have these cluster segments use them as
a new column in the data and then do
some more analysis maybe look at for
each cluster study whe what the spends
look like study what uh the age group
looks like and things like that okay so
do check this out and you can also try
and compare KES clustering with mini
batch CES clustering using this data
set one other thing you may try out is
you can also configure how many random
picks you want the K means algorithm to
take so by default we say up to 300
iterations like maximum iterations is
simply the number number of times this
whole experiment should be
repeated of trying to find a good
cluster centers and you can set maximum
iterations to any value you want so see
what kind of impact that has on the
quality of
clusters
okay all right so that's the K
clustering algorithm so let's talk about
a couple more clustering algorithms very
quickly very briefly the next one again
a very common one is called DB scan
which is short for density based spatial
clustering of applications with noise so
that's a mouthful but it's actually not
that complicated a technique it's again
fairly straightforward if uh once you
understand the basic steps involved and
it uses the density of points in a
region to form clusters so it has two
main parameters it has a parameter
called
Epsilon which we'll see in a moment what
that means and another parameter called
Min samples and using these parameters
Epsilon and Min samples it classifies
each point as a core point a reachable
point or a noise point or
outlier okay so let's try and understand
how DB scan works by looking at this
example for a moment now forget all this
all these circles and all these arrows
and everything and even all the colors
just imagine you have these points you
have this point maybe let's try and
replicate
this so you have a
point here here
here okay not
really
okay so these are the points we have and
here is how K here is how DB scan works
first you set an Epsilon and let's say
we send we and of course all of this is
on a coordinate plane let's say we still
talking about petal length and petal
width in two Dimensions let's say we
said Epsilon to 0.5
and let's say we set Min samples to
four okay now look at this
point this point is uh let's just
consider this point and you can start at
any point take this point and around
this point draw a circle with the radius
Epsilon so let me just I think this
would be about 0.5 let me just draw the
circle
here with the radius Epsilon
okay so we draw a circle with the radius
Epsilon around the point then we check
if in that Circle you have at least four
points so if you have at least four
points in the circle which we do 1 2 3
and four including the point itself as
you can see here 1 2 3 and four around
the point a so if you have at least four
points then we say that this is a core
point so this is a core point so let me
just put it in dark all the core points
I'm going to make them
dark so now we've classified a core
point and then everything else that is
connected to the core point is now part
of the same cluster okay so these three
points are part of the same cluster then
let's go to this point and across this
point let's also draw the circle of size
Epsilon and this is what it looks
like and now once again you have 1 2 3
and four so then this point is also a
core Point okay so this point is a core
point and then this point is within five
of the core point so this is now this
point now belongs to the same
cluster then let's do this one again if
you draw a circle around this
one you will notice that four points lie
here so this is also a core point so
these are all part of the same cluster
and uh then this one also turns out to
be a core point you can verify it will
have four points around it and this will
be connected to this and uh this will
also be a core point it will have all
these inside this will also be core
point so this like this you continue
creating uh connecting core
points and there will be some points now
which will not be core like this point
right here this is not a core point this
is a point which is connected to a core
point it is it lies within the circle of
a core point but it by itself like if I
just draw the circle around this point
it does not contain the Min sample
values so this is called
an edge Point yeah so this is called
sorry this is called a reachable
point so this is kind of the edge of the
cluster right this is not a core point
this is not connected to three other
points in that Circle but it is still
part of an existing cluster and
similarly this one as well like if you
draw the circle around this the circle
would look something like this so this
is not a core point but this is still a
connected Edge point so this way we have
now identified this one cluster of
points
okay and we're done with all these and
let's say there is another cluster of
points here where you have like these
four core
points this is all connected to each
other and then these are connected to
this so you have two Edge points here in
this cluster as well and then you have
four core points in this cluster so this
becomes another cluster right
here this point however it is neither
core nor is it an edge point it does not
have four things around it or three
things around it close by and it is not
connected to a core point so this is
called an
outlier okay and it's all sometimes it's
also called The Noise point so that's
what these triangles and these colors
and these lines represent you have core
points which are all which have within
their Epsilon radius main sample numbers
of observations you have these noise
Point noise points which are not
connected with any points and then you
have these Edge points or reachable
points which are connected to core
points but themselves are not
core so that's what DB scan does and
again the way to implement or use DB
scan is simply to import from Escalon
cluster DB scan and you can see here in
the signature you can configure Epsilon
you can configure Min samples and you
can configure how the distance is
calculated and by default it is UK
ladian I was showing you in two
Dimensions but because we have four
dimensions so in four dimensions it's
going to take the square root of First
Dimension difference squared plus second
dimension difference squared plus Third
Dimension difference squared plus so on
the extension of Pythagoras
Theorem and then you can also specify
how to go about and you can also specify
some other things so I'll let you look
up the remaining arguments here but
that's a basic
idea and then you do a DB scan for the
model so then you uh you instantiate the
DB scan model with the Epsilon and with
the Min samples and then you fit it to
the data now here's one thing in DB scan
there is no prediction step because
remember the definition of a core Point
depends on certain points being there in
the data set so in K means you try and
figure out the center of a cluster but
in DB scan there is no center of a
cluster the cluster is defined by the
connections between points so you cannot
use DB scan to classify new
inputs to classify new observations DB
scan simply assigns labels to all the
existing observations so you can just
check model. labels and it will
automatically just tell you that for the
inputs that were given when we performed
the DB scan algorithm on all of them
because all of them need to be
considered to perform the DB scan
algorithm
the DB scan clustering these are the
labels that got assigned so this all of
these got assigned zero and then all of
these got assigned one and then you can
also check which ones are core points
and which ones
are um which ones are Epsilon sorry not
Epsilon which ones are
U reachable points and which ones are
noise points I think you can do
something like
this yeah we can probably just so a good
way to to check all the attributes on
all the properties that you have on a
particular model all the methods you
have is by using di so yeah I think you
have these core sample indices so this
will tell you the core sample
indices and you can see here that these
are all the core points so not every
Point yeah here it seems like most
points are core points and maybe we can
try changing the Epsilon value maybe we
can reduce the Epsilon or increase the
Epsilon and that will maybe tell us that
not all points are core points so let me
do a scatter plot here and now I'm using
the saple length the petal length and
instead of the as a hue I'm using the
model do labels so you can see that only
two classes were detected here 0 and one
and maybe if we change the value of
Epsilon maybe if we change the value of
Min samples that number might change so
that's an exercise for you try changing
the value of Epsilon which is the circle
the size of the circle that is drawn
around each point and try changing the
value of Min samples which decides when
something is treated as a core point and
try wild ranges maybe try close to zero
maybe try close to uh like 100 Epsilon
does not have to be between 0 or 1 it
can be very large and similarly for Min
samples maybe try value one maybe try
value
100 experiment and try and figure out
how each of these hyper parameters
affect the clustering okay and see if
you can get to the desired clustering
which is ideally cluster these points
according to the species that the
flowers belong to
okay so that's the DB scan algorithm and
the natural question you may have is
when should you use DB scan and when
should you use K
means so here's the main difference
between DB scan and K means K means uses
is a the concept of a cluster Center and
it uses distance from a cluster Center
to define the
cluster DB scan on the other hand uses
The Nearness between the points
themselves to create a cluster so here
is an example of K means where if you
have data like this again let's say this
is x- axis and y AIS now visually you
can clearly tell that this is the right
clustering you know the outer points
these are all connected seems to be one
cluster and the inner points on
connected all all connected seem to be
another cluster but DB scan can do this
because it is concerned with The
Nearness between points but K means
actually cannot identify these two
clusters because if you set this as a
cluster Center then any cluster that
includes this point would also need to
include all of these points because
these points are closer to this Center
than this point right so there's no way
you can create a cluster using K means
of these of these outer rings
on the other hand uh this is what K's
clustering would look like maybe you'll
end up with one centroid here and one
centroid here so half the points will go
here and half the points will go
here here is another example you have
these two Horseshoe shapes and this
again DB scan is able to detect them but
K means is
not on the other and then there are a
few more examples for you to check out
now one other thing about DB scan in KES
is that in K Mees you can specify how
many clusters you want but in DB scan it
will figure out on its own and you can
only change the values of Epsilon and
Min samples to maybe try and indirectly
affect the number of clusters that get
created so that's the DB scan algorithm
so just keep in mind whenever you want
to detect these patterns which are more
concerned with The Nearness of the
points themselves DB scan may make more
sense but if you want a distance-based
clustering technique then you use K
means one more thing is you can classify
new points into clusters using K means
but you cannot use DB scan to classify
new points you would have to run the
entire scan again because it's possible
that by the introduction of a new point
two clusters may join together or uh
change in some
fashion okay one last clustering
technique I want to talk about is
archical clustering and as the name
suggest it creates a hierarchy or a tree
of clusters and not
just a bunch of different clusters so
what does that mean that means that as
you can see in
this as you can see here in this
animation we have a bunch of points and
First We Take the two closest points and
we combine those two closest points into
a cluster then we say we combine the
next two closest points which in this
case turns out to be cluster the cluster
point and then another point and combine
this combine them and then in this way
we create this tree of clusters so at
the bottom of the tree are these
individual points and above you have
these cluster of two points and
sometimes above these you have clusters
of three or four points and above these
you have clusters of cluster of cluster
of points and things like that and this
is the kind of thing that can typically
be used to generate a taxonomy for
example like if you have observations
about many different animals um many
different types of animals you have a
bunch of observations and you start
performing clustering you may realize
that there are very few very close
relationships between humans and
chimpanzees and then between humans
chimpanzees and bonobos there is another
relationship so that is what is captured
by this point and then of course between
um these between this family and between
let's say mammals there is a
relationship that is captured by this
and then here on the other hand you have
a relationship between plants and
finally at the top you have like a
single
cluster okay and this is how
hierarchical clustering works you first
Mark each point in the data set as a
cluster by itself like all of these
points p 0 to
P5 are clusters in the data set then you
pick the two closest cluster centers
like here you can see you pick the two
closest ones and treat them as a single
cluster you pick the two closest cluster
centers without a parent and combine
them into a new cluster now the new
cluster is the parent cluster of the two
clusters and its Center is the mean of
all the points in the
cluster then you repeat the step two
which is you pick the two closest
cluster centers in the data set without
a parent so this time you could be
combining a cluster center from a
cluster and a leaf and that could then
become their parent cluster and then you
pick the two closest and you keep
picking the closest cluster centers each
time that do not already have a parent
and that's how you get to the top level
okay and the structure that you end up
with is often called a
dendogram so yeah that's what this will
look like and these are all the cluster
points uh the cluster centers here
now for each type of clustering I've
also included a video that you can watch
for a detailed visual explanation if
you're willing to just get deeper and
maybe follow along on your own and
psyched learn allows you to implement
hierarchical clustering so you can try
and implement it for the iris data set
so I'll let you figure it out okay so
we've looked at three types of
clustering now we have looked at K me
clustering we have looked at DB scan and
then we've looked at hierarchical
clustering
there are several other clustering
algorithms in psyit learn so you can
check them out too here you
have about 10 or so clustering
algorithms so you can check out all of
them
okay so with that we will close our
discussion on clustering by no means
exhaustive but I hope you've gotten a
sense of what clustering is how couple
of common clustering algorithms work and
how to use
them let's talk about dimensionality
reduction in machine learning problems
we often encounter data sets with a very
large number of dimensions and by
Dimensions we mean the number of
features or number of
columns sometimes they may go into
dozens sometimes they may go into
hundreds and especially when you're
dealing with sensor data for example
like let's say you are trying to train a
machine learning algorithm which based
on the based on the data of an actual
flight like a flight that started from a
certain point and ended at a certain
point now flights have hundreds of
sensors or sometimes thousands of
sensors like same kinds of sensors at
every step at different places on the
flight and if you look if you just
collect the information from all of
these sensors you will end up with
thousands of
columns and that may be very inefficient
thing to analyze and a very inefficient
thing to even train machine learning
models on because more s means more data
which means more processing which
requires more resources and more time
and it may just significantly slow down
what you're trying to do so one thing we
typically have learned in the past is to
just pick a few useful columns and throw
away the rest of the columns so that we
can quickly train a model but what if
you didn't have to throw away most of
the information what if you could reduce
the number of Dimensions from let's say
100 to
without losing a lot of
information what if you could do that
and that is what dimensionality
reduction and manifold learning are all
about so what are the applications of
dimensionality reduction reducing the
size of data without the loss of
information so let's say you have a
certain data set here which
has let's say 200
columns okay what if you could reduce
those 200 Columns of data to just five
columns without losing information as
much information right what if it this
could still retain 95% of the
information and we'll talk about what we
are saying what we mean by information
retention but what if you could do that
then then you can clearly see already
that this anything that you do on this
model or or on this data set is going
going to be 40 times faster so are you
willing to trade maybe 5% of the
information for 40 times of speed
probably yes right so that's one reason
to do dimensionality
reduction and that will then allow you
to train machine learning models
efficiently but yet another very
important application of dimensionality
reduction is visualizing High
dimensional data in two or three
dimensions now of course as humans we
can only visualize in three dimensions
but even three dimensions can get a
little bit tricky like 3D Scatter Plots
are very hard to read so we are really
the most comfortable at least right now
while looking at screens we are most
comfortable looking at data in two
Dimensions so even right now with the
iris data set we've seen the problem
that we have four dimensions but we can
only
really visualize two Dimensions at a
time right so visualizing High
dimensional data in two to three
dimensions is also an application of
dimensionality
reduction so let's talk about let's talk
about let's talk about a couple of
techniques for dimensionality reduction
the first one is principal component
analysis principal component analysis is
a dimensionality reduction technique
that uses linear projections and we talk
about what linear projections mean of
data to reduce Dimensions while still
attempting to maximize the variance of
the data in the
projection so that's what this is about
it's about
projecting data and this is what PCA
looks like while still maintaining as
much of the variance as possible so
let's say you have this data let's say
X1 represents petal length and X2
represents petal width and then you have
all these points ignore the line for a
moment now instead of having X1 and X2
if we could simply draw this line and if
we could just draw this line and then uh
maybe at on this line we could set this
as a zero point and then we could simply
draw dra these project these points onto
the line so just see how far away they
are from the zero point let's say we set
this as a zero point and then we simply
give this point the value minus1 this
point would be - 1.8 this point would be
-2 this point would be minus 2.7 and
this point would be maybe 0.1 this would
be 3 this would be 1 this would be 2
this would be 2.3 2.4 okay so now we've
gone from taking this data in two
Dimensions to this data in one dimension
okay so how do we do that let's take a
look so let's say we have some data uh
let me look at petal length and petal
width just two Dimensions right
now so we have1 2
3.4 uh and so on and for each one we
have some petal length petal width petal
length petal width petal length petal
width and so on now we take that and we
plot it
here so we plot these points here maybe
it looks a bit like
this okay U there are more points here
so this is what it looks like now what
we would rather want to see is maybe we
just want to see one value right and we
we don't know what this is called let's
just call this PC one okay we just want
to see one value so for 1 2 3 4 5
we just want to see one value here
instead of these two columns of data and
if we can do go from two columns to one
column then we should be able to go from
three columns to one column or three
columns to two columns or 200 columns to
five columns so the idea Remains the
Same so how do we do that well the first
thing we do is we shift our axis a
little
bit to Center these points so what do I
mean by Shifting the axis well we take
this x-axis and we uh the y- axis and
then we move it here somewhere
here what exactly is meant by moving the
axis well in the new axis you will
notice that the X values of these points
have changed so we are calculating the X
the mean x coordinate of all these
points and simply subtracting the mean
from all these points similarly we take
the xaxis and move it around and moving
the x-axis means subtracting the mean of
the y-coordinate okay so what we do for
each
point is we take the point
p and we subtract from
it the average so let's say p has an X
and A Y and the mean also has an X and A
Y so the X subtracts from the average X
the Y subtracts from the average y so
that is going to Center the points okay
some of the points will now have
negative value some of the points will
now have positive values then we try out
a candidate line
so we try a candidate line okay this
looks like a candidate line on which to
project and then we project all of these
points on the candidate line so we
project project project project project
project okay so now we have projected
all of these on the candidate line now
once we've projected things on the
candidate line let me for a
moment just get rid of the X and Y
coordinates now that we know that they
are centered let me just move them
away yeah so now that we have all these
projections and we know that this is a
zero point we can see that okay this is
the this point can now be represented by
this point it's perpendicular and this
point can now be represented by this
point and this point can now be
represented by this point so for each
one if this is zero and this is one and
this is two and this is three on this
new line we can now represent each point
using a single number which is its the
distance of its projection from the zero
point on this projected line okay so we
can now start filling in these values so
the distance of point one distance of
Point 2 distance of Point 3 and distance
of point 4 so we start filling in these
values okay all right so now we already
have this we have now already reduced
from two coordinates to one coordinate
but we want it to retain as much of the
information or as much of the variety
from these two coordinates as possible
so this is where what we try and do is
we try and
maximize D1 squ plus D2
s + D3 squ plus so on okay so D1 square
+ D2 square + D3 square is basically the
now if you like keep in mind that we
have subtracted the mean and then now we
are squaring the distances and things
like that so it It ultimately turns out
to be the variance Sigma so what we want
to do is we want to try different
options for this line so let's say we
want to take the same line um okay it's
going to be hard to select this line but
uh we want to take the same line and we
want to rotate this line so we want to
rotate this line and each time as we
rotate all the D's will change because
all the perpendiculars will change and
we pick the line the rotated line for
which the sum of squares of the D's the
sum of squares of all these values is
the highest all right
so just to maybe clean this up a little
bit what we're trying to say
is once we have the centered
points you can see here if I pick this
line all of the projections are very
close to
zero so if all of the projections are
very close to zero then that means most
of the information is lost because all
the values all the D1 D2 D3 D4 all of
them are very close to zero on the other
hand
on the other hand if we pick a line that
goes like
this you can see that the projections
are quite far away so we are capturing
the spread of the data very nicely for a
nice fitting line and we are not
capturing the spread of the data very
nicely for a ill-fitting line so that's
what PCA tries and figures out okay so
it figures out one and this is from
going from two Dimensions to one
dimension here is an example of going
from three dimensions to two Dimensions
so now here we have feature one feature
two feature three ignore the word Gene
here and then you have points so what we
try and do is we first find pc1 we find
a line along which we can project all
the points the best possible line which
maintains the highest variance then PC2
is a line which is perpendicular to the
first line now remember we in three
dimensions here so there are in there
are an infinite number of lines that are
perpendicular to the first line pc1 so
again we pick the line which maximizes
the variance of the points when the
points are
projected on PC2 so for three dimensions
you can have pc1 PC2 and then when you
go to four dimensions you can have pc1
PC2 PC3 when you go to Five Dimensions
you can have pc1 PC2 PC3 pc4 and then
what you can do is like if you have 200
Dimensions you can just choose the five
most relevant axes of variance right and
remember each of these are highest
variance preserving possible lines so
let's say you have 200 Dimensions you
can do a principle component analysis
and you can reduce them down to the five
Dimensions along which the variance of
the data is preserved as much as
possible so that's principal component
analysis for you and once again how do
you do principal component analysis in
pyit learn let's say we take this data
set again and we are just going to pick
the numerical data no no species for
now so we just look at these numerical
columns we simply import from SK learn.
decomposition we import the
PCA model and then we create the PCA
model we provided the number of Target
Dimensions we want and the number of
Target dimensions in this case is two
and then we call fit so we say pc. fit
and we give it the data and so we are
going here from four dimensions saple
length staple width petal length p petal
width to two to two dimensions and what
are those two Dimensions
well at this point we can't really
interpret them as physical dimensions I
mean it's not like we've picked saple
length and saple width no it's it's like
we've picked two possible linear
combinations and remember because lines
and projections are involved so
everything is still linear so we've
picked two possible linear combinations
of these four features which are
independent which means that the lines
along which we have projected are
perpendicular so we have picked two POS
two two linear combinations of these
four variables two independent linear
combinations and it is the projections
on those uh lines that we are left with
okay so what just happened when you
called fit so those two things
got calculated so what got calculated is
the lines now PCA internally knows what
are the lines uh the the line number one
and line number two and you can look at
the internal like you can look at what
those line number one and line number
two are like if you do Dr PCA you can
look at some information about the lines
I think it would be a part
of
comp yeah I think it would be a part of
get params probably I mean I'm not
sure okay no
yeah so these are the components right
so these are the
components so this tells you the this
basically these four numbers convey the
direction of the first line This is the
direction of the like these four numbers
together conveyed and these four numbers
convey the direction of the second line
in four dimensional space and you can
verify that these two lines are
perpendicular like if you did a DOT
product then you will find that the dot
product is Z but now that we have the
components we can project these points
on these lines by doing pca. transform
so now if we give pca. transform this
data and this data which has four
dimensions Iris DF numeric calls it is
going to give us transform data in two
Dimensions you see here now you have
this transform data in two Dimensions
this is the data projected on line
number one which has this direction and
this is the data which is projected onto
Line number two which has this direction
so if you know a little bit of U linear
algebra these are both unit vectors in
the direction of the lines that have
been
picked um in any case now we've gone
from this to
this and let's check it out let's maybe
now plot so now when we do a scatter
plot you can see now now when we do a
scatter plot and I'm plotting this data
and I'm plotting this
data we can now finally visualize in two
dimensions of course not perfectly
there's still some something is lost for
sure but we can still
visualize data from all four dimensions
or we can visualize information from all
four dimensions so if we really want to
study the clusters right right now I
plotted the species but we could just as
well have plotted the Clusters that were
detected so let's Maybe look at the DB
scan
clusters I think it was U model.
labels yeah so these are the DB scan
clusters so now we can better visualize
the
Clusters that we generate from
clustering so that's one other thing
that's one that's one good thing with
dimensionality reduction it can let you
visualize the results of clustering and
maybe evaluate the results of Cl
clustering better you take a high
dimensional data and then you perform
clustering on it and then you take maybe
a principal component of
it and then you use that to visualize
the Clusters now of course principal
component is has some limitations the
first limitation is that it uses these
linear projections which may not always
achieve a very good separation of
uh of the data like obviously ly one
thing that we noted here was if you have
this kind of a line then information
gets lost because most of the
projections fall in the same place
here's one problem that I can tell you
with principal component analysis like
if you have a bunch of points
here and you have a bunch of points
here all of them will project
exactly the same value right so there is
some information that does get lost and
suppose these points belong to different
class and then these points belong to a
different class so as soon as you do PCA
and then you are trying to maybe train a
classification machine learning
algorithm you are going to lose some
information right so there are some
limitations with pcva but for the most
part it works out pretty well uh so I
would use PCA whenever you have like
hundreds of features or maybe thousands
of features and you need to reduce them
to a few features and as an exercise I
encourage you to apply principal
component analysis to a large high high
dimensional data set Maybe take the
house prices kaggle competition data set
and try and reduce the numerical columns
from like 50 or whatever to less than
five and then train a machine learning
model using the low dimensional
results and then what you want to
observe is the changes in the loss and
training time for different number of
Target Dimensions okay and that's where
we come back to
this if you could trade 200 columns for
50 columns for maybe a 5% loss in
variance now we know what information
means by information we saying variance
if you could trade 200 columns for five
columns for a 5% loss in variance that
would give you a 40x speed up and maybe
that speed up could be a make or break
for your analysis because now you can
actually analyze 40 times more data in
the same time right so when you have
really large data sets PCA is are
definitely a very useful thing to
do now there is this Jupiter notebook
you can check out if this goes into a
lot more depth about principal component
analysis the way this is done is using a
technique called singular value de
composition or SVD yeah so there's a
bunch of linear algebra involved there
but the Intuition or the process that is
followed is exactly the same you find a
line you rotate the line till the point
that you get the minimum sorry the
maximum variance and then you find the
next line which is perpendicular to this
line and still guarantees the maximum
possible variance and you keep going
from there okay okay let's talk about
another dimensionality reduction
technique and this is called the T
distributed stochastic neighbor
embedding
technique or t SN or t for short and
this belongs to a class of algorithms
called manifold
learning and manifold learning is an
approach
to perform nonlinear dimensionality
reduction now PCA is linear and then
there are a couple more like PCA there's
something called ICA LD Etc they are all
linear in the sense that they all come
through some sort of linear algebra or
Matrix
multiplications but there are some
limitations sometimes with linear
methods so you can use some of these
nonlinear methods for dimensionality
reduction and they're typically based on
this idea that the dimension the
dimensionality of many data sets is only
artificially high that there are that
most of these data sets which have
100 200 or 500
columns can really be captured quite
easily with four or five columns and we
just have to try and figure out in some
way what those how to come up with those
four and five four or five columns of
data whether through like some formula
being applied to all the columns or
whether through like it's kind of
feature engineering except that the
computer is trying to figure out these
features for you based on
certain rules that have been trained
into these different kinds of models so
you have a bunch of different manifold
learning techniques in psychic
learn and you can see here this is the
original data set so it is plotted in 3D
so this is the original data sets and
they they've just colored the points
maybe to give you a sense of which point
goes where and this 3D data set when you
apply these different feature
engineering or these different manifold
learning techniques collapses to this
kind of a graph in 2D so you can see
here that
this basically is able to separate out
red from Red from yellow from Green from
Blue which would be very difficult for
PCA to do like if you try to draw two
lines and draw projections you would it
will be very difficult for you to get a
separation like this but ISO map is able
to do that uh here is tne you can see
with tne as well it is able to separate
out red it with from the yellow from the
Green from the blue and uh these are all
different kinds of separations that you
get
now T specifically
is TSN specifically is used to visualize
High very high dimensional data in one
two or three dimensions so it is for the
purpose of
visualization and very roughly speaking
this is how it
works we're not going to get into the
detailed working of T because it's a
little more involved take a little more
time to talk about it in a lot of detail
but here's how works now suppose you
have again these clusters of dat of data
of points let's say this is petal length
and this is petal
WID what would happen normally if you
were directly going to if you just
directly projected them onto this line
is that all of these Blues would then
overlap with a bunch of oranges and
those would overlap with a bunch of Reds
what T tries to do
is first project them on a
line and then move the points around and
it moves the point points around using a
kind of a nearness rule so every point
that is that that is projected down on
the line is moved closer to the points
that are closer to it in the real data
set in in the original data set and it
is it moves away from the points that it
is far away from in the original data
set okay now I know that's not very it's
not a very concrete way of putting it
but here's what it means as you project
this line this point down it will end up
here the blue point as you project this
point down it will end up here the
orange point now what tne will do is tne
will realize that the blue point here
should be closer to other blue points
and should be further away from Orange
points because that's how it is in the
real data set so it's going to move the
point it's going to move the point
closer to the blue points and it's going
to move the orange points closer to
Orange points okay so the closeness in
the actual data is reflected as
closeness
in the reduced
dimension in the dimensionality reduced
uh Dimension reduced data okay so just
keep that in mind uh and if you have
that intuition you'll be able to figure
out when you need tne when you need to
maintain the closeness no matter how
much you reduce the number of Dimensions
by tne is
useful and here is a visual
representation of tne applied to the
mnist data set and the Mist data set
contains 60,000 images of handwritten
digits so it contains 20 28 pixel x 28
pixel images of the handwritten digits 0
to 9 and 28x 28 pixel each pixel
remember is uh simply represents a color
intensity like red green blue or in this
case they are gray so just represents
like how gray that particular pixel is
each pixel is a number so that means
means each image is represented by 784
numbers 28 * 28 so we can take those 784
dimensions and we can
perform we can use tne to reduce that
data to two dimensions and then plot it
and when we plot it this is what we get
tne is able to very neatly separate out
all the images of the number zero from
all the images of the number one from
all the images of the number 2 3 4 5 and
so on Okay so there is I I I encourage
you to check out this video and then
there's also a
tutorial uh that I've linked Below on
yeah sorry there's a tutorial here you
can check this out on how to actually
create this graph it will take you maybe
an hour or so to create this graph to
download the data set and maybe look at
some samples and create this
graph but what we're trying to get at
here is that t is very powerful for
visualizing data so whenever you have
high dimensional data use tne to
visualized data Now tesy does not work
very well if you have a lot of
Dimensions like maybe even 784 it's not
ideal to directly reduce it to two
Dimensions so typically what ends up
happening is you first have maybe let's
say 784
Dimensions you would take those 784
dimensions and you would perform PCA
principal component analysis and reduce
it to about 50
dimensions and then you would take those
50 dimensions and reduce it to two
Dimensions using tne for
visualization now these two Dimensions
uh the the one the data that you get via
tne is not that useful for doing machine
learning or even for doing data
analysis it is useful for uh
visualization because you can
see which points are closer together in
the original data that's what it is
trying to tell you okay so that's why
you'll see tne used as a visualization
technique in a lot of different uh
machine learning
algorithms and how do you perform tne
exactly the same way as the other as PCA
so you just import the TS any class and
then you set the number of components or
the number of Dimensions that you want
and we want to take this four
dimensional
data and we want to transform it to two
Dimensions now again with tne it there's
no predict or there's no transform
there's no fit and transform step both
of them are combined into a fit
transform because closeness of the
points is very important so in some
sense you you don't use tne on new data
you only use tne on the data that you
already have so that's why we are doing
a fit transform here and that gives us
the transform
data so this is the transform data here
so we've gone from four dimensions to
two
dimensions and then when we plot
it
you can now see that tne has really
separated out the points here so you you
have one class here and then you have
these two classes here so these points
it may hold true that these points were
actually quite near to each other in the
original data set and that is why they
are near to each other here and these
points are far away from each other in
the original data set so that's why
they're far away from each other here
okay yep so the takeaway is PCA is good
when you're doing
machine
learning and tne is good when you want
to visualize the results so try and use
tne to visualize the mnist handwritten
digits data set I've have linked to the
data set
here okay so with that we complete our
discussion
of unsupervised learning at least two
aspects of it clustering and
dimensionality reduction again there are
many more ways to perform clustering in
psychic learn there are many more ways
to perform dimensionality
reduction and all of them have different
use cases but in general you mostly
would just start out by using K means
clustering and by using PCA for doing
dimensionality reduction and
then in a lot of cases maybe a better
clustering algorithm or a better
dimensionality algorithm will give you a
slight boost
but you should be fine with just using
the most basic to begin with in a lot of
cases and do check out some of these
resources to learn
more hello and welcome to this workshop
on how to build a machine learning
project from scratch today we are going
to walk through the process of building
a machine learning
project and we're going to write some
code live we're going to start by
downloading a data set then processing
it training a machine learning model in
fact a bunch of different machine
learning models and evaluating those
models to to find the best model we will
also tune some hyper parameters and do
some feature engineering now before we
start if you're looking to start a new
machine learning project a good place to
find data sets is gagle so I just want
to show you this before we get
into the code for
today so there are a couple of places on
kaggle which is an online data science
community and a computation platform so
there are a couple of places where you
can find good data sets for machine
learning projects the first is
competitions on kaggle now kaggle is a
competition platform that has been
around
for close to 10 years I believe at this
point and they have hosted hundreds of
competitions so you can go on kaggle.com
competitions and then go back all the
way you can go back to competitions from
2010 or 11 uh I
believe
and use those data sets to work on your
machine learning
projects for example one of the the data
set that we'll be looking at today is
called the New York
City taxi fair prediction
challenge this competition was conducted
three years ago by Google cloud and the
objective here was to predict a Rider's
taxi fair given information like the
pickup location drop location date and
the number of pass
MERS and you can learn a little bit
about the competition you can look at
the data for the competition before
downloading it you can also look at a
lot of public notebooks that have been
shared by other participants in the
competition reading others notebooks is
a great way to learn and in fact a lot
of the techniques that we are covering
today will be from public notebooks and
you can also look at the discussions if
you have any questions about how to go
about doing a certain thing now one of
the best parts of kaggle is that you can
actually make submissions to the
leaderboard so you can do this you can
go to my submissions and click late
submission and although you will not
rank on the
leaderboard your submission will still
be scored and you can see where you land
among the entire set of participants in
this competition so in this competition
for example there were over 1,400 teams
that landed on the leaderboard and
getting to anywhere in the top up 30 to
40% on a kagle competition even one that
has ended
already is a sign that you're probably
building really good machine learning
models so that's one place on kaggle
where you can find data data sets for
machine learning and you have at least
100 options here to choose from so if
you're building your first or second
project I would just go here but apart
from this on kaggle.com sets you can
find hundreds of other data sets
now one of the things
that I like to do when I'm searching for
data sets on kaggle especially for
machine learning or classical machine
learning as we call it to differentiate
from Deep learning is go to filters here
and select the file size file type CSV
and set a minimum limit on the file size
so minimum limit of 50 mb generally
gives you a large enough data set to
work with apply those
filters then I sought by the most
votes and finally I so that leaves us
with about 10,000 data sets to choose
from and finally I put in a query or a
keyword to filter data sets by a
specific domain so here for example are
all the data sets that are related to
travel now since these are sorted by the
most
wordss you somebody has already done a
lot of
exploring for you you can just look
through the first five or 10 data sets
not all of them may be suitable for
machine learning but many
are and you can in fact open up data
sets and read their descriptions and in
many of these descriptions several tasks
will be mentioned that can tell you how
you can do machine learning another
thing you can do here is you can go into
the code Tab and on the code tab you can
search for machine learning terms like r
forest and you can see here that people
have used this data set to build machine
learning models so that's another good
place to find data sets so you have
hundreds of real world data sets to
choose from because most of these data
sets and most of the data sets in kaggle
competitions have come from real
companies that are looking to build
machine learning Pro Models to solve
real business
problems so with that context let's get
started today we are going to work on
this project called New York City taxi
fair prediction and this was a kaggle
competition as I mentioned a few years
ago you can learn all about this on the
competition page what you're looking at
right now is a notebook hosted on the
Jovian platform this is a notebook a
Jupiter notebook hosted on my profile
and on in this notebook there are some
explanations and there is some space to
write code and we are going to start
writing the code here now of course this
is a read only view of the notebook so
to run the notebook you click run and
select run on collab we are going to use
Google collab to run this notebook
because this is a fairly large data set
and we may require some of the
additional resources that Google collab
provides now when you go to this link
and I'm going to post this link in the
chat right
now
when you go to this link on this link
you will be able to uh click run run on
collab and you may be asked to connect
your Google Drive so that we can put
this notebook into your Google Drive and
you can open it on collab
okay but once you're done once you're
able to run the notebook you should see
this view this is the collab platform
cab. research. goole.com it is a
cloud-based Jupiter notebook
where you can write code and any code
that you execute will be executed on
Google servers in the cloud on some
fairly powerful machines in fact you can
go to runtime change runtime type and
from here you can select you can even
enable a GPU and high Ram
machines which I encourage doing if
you're using either of
these all right so whenever you run a
notebook hosted from on Jovian on
collab you would see this additional
cell of code at the top this is just
some code that you should always run at
the beginning so whenever you go to a
jovia notebook run it on collab
definitely make sure to run this first
line of code because it is going to
connect this collab notebook to your
Jovian notebook and anytime you want to
save this a version of your collab
notebook to your Jovian profile you will
be able to do
that but you need to run this uh single
line of code
okay all right with that out of the way
let's get
started so we'll train a machine
learning model to predict the fair for a
taxi ride in New York City given
information like pickup date and time
pickup location drop location and number
of passengers and this data set is taken
from kaggle and we'll see see that it
contains a large amount of data now
because this is a short Workshop we and
we're doing all this live we'll attempt
to achieve a respectable score in the
competition using just a small fraction
of the
data along the way we will also loc at
some practical tips for machine learning
things that you can apply to your
projects to get better results
faster and I should mention that most of
the ideas and techniques covered in this
notebook are derived from other public
notebooks and block so this is not all
entirely original work nothing ever
is
now to run this notebook as I said just
pick run and run on collab and connect
to your Google
Drive and you can also find a completed
version of this notebook at this link so
I'm going to drop this link in the chat
if you need to refer to the code
later
okay so here's the first tip I have for
you before we even start writing any
code create an outline for your notebook
whenever you create a new jupyter
notebook especially for machine learning
and fill out a bunch of sections and
then try to create an outline for each
section before you even start
coding and the benefit of this is that
this let you this lets you structure the
project project this lets you organize
your thought process into specific
sections and this lets you focus on
individual sections at a time without
having to worry about the big picture
okay so you can see here if you click on
table of contents I have already created
an outline in the interest of time where
there are sections and subsections so
here's a section and here are some
subsections and so
on and then in inside the subsections
there's also some explanation that
mentions what that subsection
covers so here's what the outline of
this project looks like first we're
going to download the data set then we
going to explore and analyze the data
set then we are going to prepare the
data set for training machine learning
models then we are going to first train
some hardcoded and Baseline models
before we get to the fancy tree based or
gradient boosting kind of model
models and then we'll make predictions
and submit predictions from our Baseline
models to kaggle and we'll talk about
why that's
important then we will perform some
feature engineering then we will train
and evaluate many different kinds of
machine learning
models and then we will tune
hyperparameters for the best models and
finally we will briefly touch on how you
can train on a GPU with the entire data
set so we will not be using the entire
data set in this tutorial but you can
repeat the tutorial with the entire data
set as well and finally we are going to
talk a little bit about how to document
and publish the project
online so let's dig into it and if you
have questions at any point please post
them in the Q&A and we will stop
periodically if possible to take
questions all right so as I said for
each section
it's always a good idea to write down
the steps before we actually try to
write the code and you can Jupiter is
great for this because it has markdown
cells where you can write things and
modify them as required so here are the
steps first we will install the required
libraries then we will download some
data from kaggle then we'll look at the
data set files we will then load the
training set with pandas and then load
the test set with pandas so let's get
started I'm going to install
the Jovian Library well that's already
installed but I'm going to put it in
here anyway uh we're going to use a
library called open data sets for
downloading the data set we're going to
use pandas we're going to use numpy
we're going to use pyit learn we're
going to use XG boost and I believe that
should be it so I'm just going to
install all of these libraries and I've
added hyphen hyphen quiet
to avoid any outputs from this
installation now whenever you're working
on a notebook it's important to save
your work from time to time and the way
to save your
work is to import the Jovian Library by
running Jo import Jovian and then
running Jovian doc
commit now when you run Jovian doc
commit you will be asked to provide an
API key and I'm going to go here on my
Jovian profile and copy the API key and
come back and paste it here
now what this does is this takes a
snapshot of your notebook at this
current
moment and then it publishes it to your
Jovian profile as you can see here NYC
taxi fair prediction blank this notebook
was created just now you can see this is
version one now every time you run
jan.com in your notebook a new version
of this notebook will get recorded and
the benefit of having a notebook on
Jovian is that you can share it with
anybody like I can take this link and I
can post this link in the
chat of course you can also make your
notebooks private or secret if you would
like
to and you can add topics to your
notebook so that other people can find
them
easily okay so coming back
now to download the data set we are
going to use the open data sets Library
which can connect using your kagle
credentials to kagle and download the
data set from this link for you so
here's how it works I first import open
data
sets as
OD and now I can run od. download and I
need to give it a URL so let me first
put a URL
here here is the URL for the competition
and I just provide data setor URL now
when I run this open data sets is going
to try and connect to kagle using my
kaggle credentials but to do that it
needs my kaggle credentials and the way
to provide your kaggle credentials to
open data sets is to go to kaggle.com
and then click on your avatar go to your
account and scroll down to API and click
create new API token and when you click
this create new API token it is going to
download a file called kaggle do Json to
your
computer now you need to take this file
kaggle do Json and come back to
collab and on
collab go to the files tab and upload
this kaggle Json
file now unfortunately you'll have to do
this every time you run the notebook so
I suggest downloading the kaggle Json
file once and keeping it handy like I
have here on my desktop so you can
upload it whenever you
needed now this kagle Json file
downloaded from my kagle account has my
username and a secret key so you should
never put the secret key into a jupyter
notebook otherwise somebody else will be
able to use your kagle account but
within your own jupyter notebook when
you run od. download it is going to read
the credentials from the kaggle Json
file file and download the data set for
you you can see here this data set is
pretty large this is about 1.5 6 gbt and
of course it's a zip file so after
expanding it's going to become even
larger and it's it's going to download
this data set to a folder called New
York City taxi fair prediction so I'm
just going to put that into a
variable New York City taxi fair
prediction so that we have it handy when
we want to look at the
files all right so on the files tab here
you can see we have New York City taxi
fair prediction here's a folder and
inside the folder there are some files
specifically there are 1 2 3 4 five
files okay now there was a question
should you try and follow along right
now well I would say right now you
should probably watch and you will have
a recording of the session and you
should try and follow along with a
different data set
later but it's totally up to
you all right so now the data has been
downloaded and now we have this data
directory which points us to the
directory where the data lives and now
let's look at the size number of lines
and the first few lines of each file so
first I'm going to use the ls minus LH
command so this is a shell command this
is not python so every time you have an
explanation exclamation mark at the
beginning this is going to be passed
directly to the
system this is going to be passed
directly to the system terminal so I'm
just going to run LS minus LH and I need
to access this folder which and this
string is part of this variable so you
can pass the value of a python variable
using
these curly brackets so when we put
something inside these braces or curly
brackets
Jupiter is going to replace this entire
expression with the value of this
variable which is New York City taxi
fair prediction all right so LS minus LH
data di shows us that this is a total of
5.4 gabt of data out of this almost
entirely it is the training set with 5.4
gbt that's a pretty large training Set
uh and then the test set is just 960
kilobytes and then finally there is a
sub sample submiss file as I mentioned
you can submit some predictions on the
test set to kaggle and there are some
instructions which we can ignore okay so
that's the sizes of the files let's look
at the number of lines in some of the
important files so the way to get the
number of lines is using the WC minus L
shell command and once again I'm going
to get the data directory and under the
data directory I want to look at
train.csv
so there you go New York City taxi fair
prediction tr. CS we contains what's
this 55 M
4238 56 rows that's a lot of
rows and then let's look at the test
set the test set contains
9,914 rows which is a lot lot smaller
than the training
set let's also look at the submission.
CSV file
the submission. CSV file also contains
9915 rows so just one additional row
compared to the test set this could just
be a this could just be an empty line so
I wouldn't worry too much about
it and that's it so let's let's also
look at the first few lines of each
file I am going to use the head shell
command this time
so here we have the first 10 lines of
train.csv remember it has 55 million
lines and these are just the first 10
and it seems like you have information
like a key so this is the first key this
is a CSV file so you will find the first
row contains names of colums and then
the future rows contain the data so this
is the key so seems like every row has a
very has a unique identifier called the
key and then there is the fair amount
for that right so for example here the
fair amount is 4.5 then you have the
pickup date time so this is the date and
time of the pickup then you have the
pickup longitude or and the pickup
latitude these are the two places these
are the geoc coordinates of the pickup
then we have the drop off longitude and
drop off latitude so here are the
coordinates of the drop off of - 73 and
40 and finally you have the passenger
count which is the number of people who
took the ride okay so that's the
training data looks simple enough let's
look at the test
data all right so test data looks
similar to we have the key every row has
a unique
key and then we have a pickup date time
there we go we have a pickup long
longitude pickup latitude drop off
longit UD drop off latitude and
passenger count great now one thing
that's missing from the test data is the
fair amount and this is what is
typically called the target column in
the in this machine learning problem
because remember the project is called
taxi fair prediction so we need to build
a model using this training
data and then use that model to make
predictions of the fair amount for the
test data and that's why the test data
does not have predictions now once you
make predictions for the test data you
need to then put those predictions into
a submission file and here is what a
sample submission file looks
like here's a sample submission file
there is a key so you will notice that
these Keys correspond exactly row by row
to the test data set and here is
supposed to be the prediction of your
model now this sample subvision file
just contains 11.35 the same answer for
every test row but this is supposed to
be the prediction for your model the
prediction generated by your model for
the test set and you need to create such
a file and then you need to download
this file so I'm going to download it
right
here onto my
desktop and then you can come to this
competition page and click on late
submission and you can upload this file
here containing the sample submission
which is the key for each row in the
test set and and your prediction and
then you can make a submission once this
is uploaded of
course and once you make a
submission your submission is going to
be scored so the score for the
submission is
9.4 now what does the score mean you can
check the overview Tab and go into the
evaluation section to understand what
the score means so this score is the
root mean squared error so the root mean
squared error is simply a way of
measuring how far away your predictions
are from the actual values so you can't
you are not given the actual Fair
amounts for the test data but kaggle has
them and when you submit your submission
uh when you submit the submission. CSV
file the predictions are compared to the
actual values which are hidden from you
and the difference is calculated those
differences are squared up added
together and then you take an average of
the square differences and then you take
a square root of the average difference
of the average squared difference and
that's called the root mean squared
error on average it tells you how far
away your predictions are from the
actual value so for example in our case
our recent submission had a root me
squared error of 9.4 which means our
predictions are on average off by
$9.4 okay and we'll see whether that's
good or bad in
sometime but we definitely want to do
more than that and now one thing you can
do is check your submission against the
leaderboard to see where you land seems
like people have gotten to a pretty good
point where they they're able to predict
the taxi fair within
$2.8 and we are at
$9.4 which is pretty high if you ask me
because most taxi Rides cost $10 or $10
to $15 maybe so if you're off by 9 your
prediction is practically useless okay
okay but that makes sense because right
now we've just put a fixed prediction
we've basically submitted the sample
file so that's how kagle works and one
tip I have for you
here is that you should write down these
observations so anytime you have an
insight about the data set you should
write it down document it so that it's
there for you later if you need to come
back to it and again Jupiter is a great
way to do that
okay so that's how we downloaded the so
that's what we did we downloaded the
data from kaggle using open data sets we
looked at some data set files and we
noted down the observations the training
data is 5.5gb uh test data is it has 5.5
million
rows the test set is much smaller less
than 10,000 rows and the training set
has eight columns key fair amount pick
up date time latitude
longitude drop off latitude longitude
and passenger
count now the test set has all columns
except the target column the fair amount
and the submission file should contain
the key and the fair amount for each
test
sample
okay now I'm going to just save my
notebook at this point I'm going to save
regularly so that I don't lose any work
you should do that too next up we are
going to load the training set right so
here you can check the table of contents
if you're ever lost we are going to now
load the training set and then load the
test
set so here's one tip when you're
working with large data sets always
start with a small sample to experiment
and iterate faster now loading the
entire data set into pandas is going to
be really slow and not just that any
operation that you do afterwards is
going to be slow so just to set up my
notebook properly I'm going to first
work with the sample and then maybe come
back and work with the entire data set
so we're going to work with a 1% sample
that's we are going to ignore 99% of the
test of the training data but that still
gives us 500,000 roles 1% of 55 million
is 500,000 roles and I think 500,000
rows should still allow us to create a
pretty good model to make predictions
for 10,000 rows of data in the test set
so we're going to use a 1% sample and
we're also going to ignore the key
column because we don't really need to
use the unique identifier that is
present in the training set and just
loading that into memory you can slow
things down so we're going to ignore
that we are going to par pickup and date
time while loading the data so that you
know pickup date time uh pickup date
time is a date time colum and pandas has
a special way of dealing with it we can
just inform pandas and that makes things
faster and we're going to specify data
types for the particular columns so that
pandas doesn't have to try and figure
out by after looking at all the rows and
that is going to again speed up things
significantly so with that
let's set up let's set up this data
loading um so first let's import pandas
as
PD okay and we are going to use the pd.
read
CSV function and to the read CSC
function we need to provide the file
name so here I'm going to provide
data/ train.csv
then here are some of the other
parameters that we can provide now we
want to pick a certain set of columns so
I'm going to use I'm going to provide a
value used calls that's one then we are
also going to provide data types so I'm
going to use the I'm going to use D type
and finally we are also going to want to
pick a sample so there are two ways to
pick a sample we can either just pick
the first 1% or the first 500,000 rows
for which we can use n rows if you just
provide the value of n rows and provide
500,000 that's going to pick up a
500,000 sample for you or there's
another way to do it which is using
something called skip rows so here we
can provide a function which can go
through each row and based on the row
index it can tell you whether or not to
keep the row so I'll show you both let's
start by putting
in the use calls
um so let me create a variable called
calls
or selected
calls and I'm going to put in all the
columns here except the key so I'm just
going to take
this put that into a
string and I'm just going to split that
at the comma so this has a nice
effect
of
giving us this list of
columns there you go so we going to use
selected
calls then I am going
to select dtype so
let's set up D types or data
types I'm going to grab all of
these
and use float 32 for the data
type of course not all of these are
float 32 we wanted to use u in 8 for
passenger
count and let's just indent that so
those are the D types so that's the
value of the D
type and now we could provide this n
rows equals 5 00,000 and you can also
write numbers like this to make them
easier to read so we could do this and
we would get the first 500,000 rols but
I want a random 1% sample so for that I
am going to use the uh skip row
function
and I'm going to call it I'm going to
pass in a function called skip
row this gets the row index
or the row
number and here's what we're going to do
now of course we want to keep the first
row so if row index is zero then we do
not want to skip the row so we return
false otherwise here's a quick trick we
can we can apply here let's say I want
my sample
fraction to be 1% so 1% is just
0.01 here's what I'm going to do I'm
going to first import the random
module let me do that
here and the random module can be used
to Generate random
numbers from 0 to one okay so that's a
random number and that's these random
numbers are between 0 to one now if I
write this random. random less than
sample
fraction and let's run that less than
sample fraction then because random
numbers are picked uniformly there is a
exactly a 1% chance that random. random
is going to be less than sample fraction
so we should keep the row only if this
expression returns
false uh sorry only if this expression
returns false so we should skip we
should sorry we should skip the row if
this expression returns true so if
random. random is greater than 01 which
is a 99% probability we should skip the
row otherwise we should keep the row so
that's what our skip row function does
okay all it does is for 1% of the rows
it is going to randomly return true or
return false which means keep the row
and for 99% of the rows it is going to
return um true which is to skip the row
okay now one last thing I'm going to do
here is I'm going to set random.
seed and set it to a particular value so
I'm going to initialize the random
number generator here in Python with the
value 42 so that I get the same set of
rows every time I run this notebook okay
so encourage you to learn more about
seeds and this is going to take
a okay sorry this is not a date time of
course we also need to provide uh par we
also need to provide a list of date time
separately yeah so let me run that and
then we'll talk about
this yep so I encourage you to learn
more about random number
seeds let's see where
is parore
dates there we go yep and always fix the
seeds for your random number generator
so that's the third tip so that you get
the same results every time you run the
notebook otherwise you're going to pick
up a different one% each time you run
the notebook and you're not going to be
able to iterate that
much so there was a question can you
explain the significance of using shell
commands instead of checking the data
set for checking the data set instead of
python yeah so simple reason here is
because these files are so large loading
them into python can it self slow down
the process a lot so normally I would
recommend using the OS module from
python but in this case I've recommended
shell commands because these notebooks
are so large and shell commands are
really good at working with large
files okay there's another question how
do we know it's a regression problem so
here we're trying to predict for fair
amount and the fair amount is a
continuous number right the fa amount
can be $2.5 $3.2
$5.7 so that is what is called a
regression problem a classification
problem is one where trying you're
trying to
classify every row into a particular
category for
example trying to classify let's say an
insurance application as low risk medium
risk or high risk that's called a
classification
problem okay this is taking a while in
fact it has been running for a minute
and a half and this is happening while
we're working with just 1% of the data
so you can imagine when you're working
with 100% of the data it's going to take
a lot longer so and not just this but
every single step of this it took about
1 minute 36 seconds to complete okay now
that's the exercise for you try loading
3% 10% 30% and 100% of the data and see
how that
goes all right so let's load up the test
set as well so I'm just going to load up
here test set as pd. read
CSV data plus / test.csv
and I'm just going to provide the D type
here and that's it I think don't really
need to provide anything
else because test set is pretty
small let's look at the training data
set as well maybe let's print it out
here
okay it's just called DF at the
moment yep so there you go we have fair
amount pickup date time latitude
longitude and all the expected values
now the test DF
has key so we're going to keep the key
for the test data frame because we're
going to use this for making submissions
but we have the pickup date time
longitude latitude drop off and
passenger count looks great and I can
just commit
again all
right okay so we're done with the first
step downloading the data set that took
a while but we are now well set and
let's explore the data set a little bit
okay we're just going to do some quick
and dirty exploration we're not really
going to look at a lot of graphs and
I'll talk about why but the quickest way
to get some information about a data
frame is to go DF
doino and this tells us that these are
the seven rows and then these are the
number of entries here this is the total
space it takes on memory this is an
important thing to watch as you go with
100% of the data set so you can imagine
that it's going to take 100 times more
or 1.5 GB of memory or Ram that's why we
are using collab and what else yeah
these are the data types seems like
there are no n there are no null values
or missing values so that's great now
another thing you can do is DF do
describe and that's going to give you
some statistics for each column for each
numerical column so turns out fair
amount the minimum value isus $52 and
the maximum value is
$499 all right then the mean or the
average value is $11 and the
50% value is $8.5 so we already know
that 50% of Rides cost less
than uh less than $8 and in fact 75% of
Rights cost less than $12.5 okay now
that gives us a sense of how good our
model needs to
be if you trying to predict right uh
the right if you're trying to predict
the taxi fair and 75% of Taxi fairs are
under $12 so I would want my prediction
to be in the plus or minus $3 range
otherwise I'm off by a lot and that's
what we'll try and aim for
okay um you can also look at pickup
latitude longitude drop off and then
passenger counts now there seem to be
some issues in this data set as is the
case with all real world data sets seems
like the minimum pickup longitude is
minus 1183 which is just not valid at
all it doesn't make sense there are no
such longitudes neither are there such
latitudes so we may have to do some
cleaning uh this could just be wrong
data and there also seems to be a Max
passenger count of 208 which again seems
quite un likely to me you can see 75% of
the values are under two so again this
is something that we may have to fix
later we'll take a look at that now one
thing that is missing here is the date
time so let me just grab the pickup date
time and just look at the minimum and
maximum values
here so you can see here that our date
start from the 1st of January 2009 and
end on the 30th of June
2015 so it's about 6 years worth of
data and once again all these
observations are noted here 550k rows as
expected no missing data fair amount
ranges passenger count ranges there seem
to be some
errors and we may need to deal with
outliers and data entry errors let's
look at the test data
here so nothing surprising here 9 914
columns uh rows of data across these
seven columns no fair
amount and here are the ranges of values
and these seem a lot more reasonable the
pickup latitude and longitude seem to be
betweenus 75 and 72 so - 74.2 is the is
the lowest and - 72.9 is the highest so
that's good then passenger count also
seems to be between 1 and six now here's
one thing we can do if our model is
going to be evaluated on the test set
and which is supposed to represent real
world data then we can limit the inputs
in our training set to these ranges
right anything that is outside the range
of the test set can be removed from the
training set and because we have so much
data 55 million rows or 1% of that which
is still a large amount of data we can
later just drop the rows which fall
outside the test range okay so keep that
in
mind and finally let's check this
to pick up date time and maximum and
minimum and you see here that these test
data set values also range from the 1st
of January 2009 to the 30th of June 2015
which is interesting because this is the
same range as the training set now
that's an important Point here which
we'll use while creating the validation
set all right so let's Commit
This that was quick enough and that we
already have a lot of insight but now
what you should do at this point or
maybe later when You' have trained a few
models is to create some graphs like
histograms line charts bar charts
Scatter Plots box plots geom Maps you
have location data here or other kind of
maps to study the distribution of values
in each column and study the
relationship of each input column to the
Target this could be useful thing to do
not just right now but also once you've
created new features when we do some
feature
engineering and another thing that you
should try and do is something like this
you should try and ask and answer some
questions about the data set what is the
busiest day of the week what is the
busiest time of the day in which month
are the fairs highest in which pickup
locations have the highest fairs which
drop locations have the highest Fair
what is the average right distance and
keep going the more questions you can
ask about your data set the deeper
understanding you will develop of the
data and that will give you ideas for
feature engineering and that will make
your machine learning models a lot
better so having an understanding of the
data is very important to build good
machine learning models and if you're
looking to learn exploratory data
analysis and visualiz ation you can
check out a couple of tutorials or a
couple of resources we have a video on
how to build an exploratory data
analysis project from scratch and we
also have a full sixe course on data
analysis with python 0 toes.com that you
can check
out now one tip I would like to share
here is that you should take an
iterative approach to building machine
learning models which is first do some
exploratory data analysis a little bit
like we've done without even plotting
any charts
uh then do some feature engineering try
and create some interesting
features then train a model and then
repeat to improve your model OKAY
instead of trying to do all your Eda for
maybe a week and then do doing a lot of
feature engineering for a month and then
trying to train your model and
discovering that most of what you did
was useless just use an iterative
approach try and train a model every day
or every other day Okay so I'm going to
skip ahead right now and maybe I'll do
some Ed
after we done with this
tutorial all right so that was step two
we've made good progress now we've
downloaded the data we've looked at the
data let's prepare the data set for
training so the first thing we'll do is
split training and validation sets then
we will deal with the missing values
there are no missing values here but in
case there were we this is how we deal
with them and then we will extract out
some inputs and outputs for training as
well okay so we will set aside 20% of
the training data as the validation set
so we have 550,000 rows out of those 20%
will be set aside as a validation set
and this validation set will be used to
evaluate the models we
train on the training data so the models
are trained on the training data which
is the 80% and then the evaluation is
done so we calculate the root means
squared error on the validation set
which is the 20% for which we know the
targets unlike the test set for which we
don't know the
targets and what that will do is the
validation set will allow us
to estimate how the model is going to
perform on the test set and consequently
in the real world okay so here's the
next tip your validation set should be
as similar to the test set or real world
data as possible and the way you know
that is when you find the root means
squared error on the validation set and
you can do that because you can get
predictions from your model and you have
the actual targets for the validation
set and you can compare those and
calculate the root means squar error so
the way you know that the validation set
is close enough to the test set is when
the evaluation metric of the model on
the validation and test set is very
close okay and if the root mean squ
error on the validation set is like $2
but when you submit it to kaggle the the
root mean squar error is $9 then your
validation set is completely useless and
you're basically shooting in the dark
because you're trying to train different
models to do better on the validation
set but the validation set has no
relationship to the test set score so
make sure that your validation set and
test sets have similars or very close
scores and an increase in the score on
the validation set reflects as an
increase on the test set otherwise you
may need to reconsider how your
validation set is created now one thing
here is that we can because the test set
and training set have the same date
ranges right the test set lies between J
2009 to June 2015 and the training set
also comes from J 2009 to uh June 2015
we can pick a random 20% fraction of the
training set as a validation
set suppose the test set was in the
future suppose the training set was data
from 2009 to
2014 and the test set was data for 2015
then to make the validation set similar
to the test set we should have picked
maybe the data for 2014 as the
validation set and then the DAT data for
2013 and before as the training set
right so
keep those things in mind it's very
important to create validation sets
carefully so for creating the validation
set I'm going to import from sklearn do
model selection import train test
split and this is something that you can
look up you don't have to remember this
and I'm just going to do train
DF while
DF equals strin test split and I'm going
to split the original data frame and I'm
going to set the
test um let's see here the test size or
in this case which is going to be the
validation size to
0.2 okay and now I can check the length
of the train
DF and the length of the Val validation
DF to make sure that we have the right
sizes so we have 4 441,000 rows in the
training set and a randomly chosen
11,000 rows in the validation set I'm
also going to set random State equals 42
just so that I get the same validation
set every time I run the notebook this
is important because your scores may
change slightly if each time you're
creating a different validation set and
also if you're combining models across
validation sets that leads to data
leakage Etc so to fix the validation set
the random set that is picked I'm going
to start set the random state to
42 okay now that's one piece now the
other thing that we we need to do is to
fill or remove missing values now we've
seen that there are no missing values in
the training data or the test data but
it's possible because we've only looked
at 1% of the data it's possible that
there may be missing values elsewhere so
here's one simple thing you can do train
DF equals train DF do drop Na and while
DF equals wdf do drop any okay now why
what does this do this is going to drop
all the empty
rows from the training or all the rows
where any of the columns has an empty
value or missing value from the training
and validation sets you shouldn't always
do this but if because we have so much
data and at least so far I've not really
seen a large number of missing values
I'm estimating that the number of
missing values is going to be less than
1 or 2% so it should be okay to drop
them like number of missing values in
the entire data set so it should be okay
to drop them okay so I'm not going to
run this right now but you know what
this does next we before we train our
model we need to separate out the inputs
and the outputs because the inputs and
the outputs have to be passed separately
into machine learning models so I'm
going to create some something called
input calls here and maybe let's just
first look at train DF do columns so
that we can copy paste a
bit now the input columns are these well
actually we can't really pass a datetime
column by itself into a machine learning
model because it's a it's a time stamp
it's not a number um so we'll have to
convert the date time date time column
into some or split the date time column
into multiple columns so I'm just going
to use these for now the latitudes and
uh longitudes and the passenger
count and for the Target column I am
just going to use the fair
amount and there you go so now we have
the input and Target columns now we can
create train inputs so from the training
data frame we just pick the input
columns so this is how you just pull out
just a a certain set of columns from the
training set and then we have the train
well let's call that train inputs and we
have the train targets which is train DF
Target
call and we can view the train inputs
here and we can view the train targets
here okay so you can see now we no
longer have the call column fair amount
here but we still have all the rows and
here we no longer we just have the
single fair amount column in front of us
okay let's do the same for the
validation set so while inputs is while
DF input
calls where targets is W DF
Target
call and then let's look at Val inputs
and Val
targets okay so 110,000 rows that's
already a lot larger than the test set
by the way so should be
good yep and here are the validation
targets finally test DF now the test
data frame remember it doesn't really
have any Target columns but we still
want to pull out just the input columns
that we can use for training so let's
just do test
PF input
calls test inputs okay and there are no
targets there's no fair amount in the
test data frame that is something that
we have to
predict so there it is
okay not bad we're making good progress
in under an hour we have downloaded the
data set explored it a little bit at
least prepared the data set for training
and now we are going to first train some
hardcoded and Baseline models so here's
the next tip always always create simple
hardcoded model which is basically like
a single value or something or a very
simple rule or some sort of a baseline
model something that you can train very
quickly to establish the minimum score
that any proper machine learning model
should beat I can't tell you how many
times I've seen people have trained
models for hours or days and then the
model ends up producing results that are
worse than what you could have done with
a simple average and that could be for a
couple of reasons one you've actually
not trained the model properly uh like
you you've trained a really you created
a really bad model or second you made a
mistake somewhere in the feature
engineering or somewhere in preparing
the data or somewhere in making
predictions right so it serves as a good
a good way to test whether what you're
doing is correct and whether you're and
it gives you a baseline to
beat so let's create a simple model I'm
going to create a a
class
and mean regressor will have two
functions fit I'm going to make it very
similar to a psyched learn model so it's
going to take some inputs it's going to
take some
targets and so fit is used to train our
uh simple model and then we're going to
define a function called
predict it takes a bunch of inputs and
then creates some targets so here's what
I'm going to do here I'm going to
completely ignore the inputs and I'm
simply going to set self. mean I'm going
to store a value self. mean where I'm
just going to do targets. mean here okay
and that's just going to calculate the
average value of the targets and here
I'm just going to return so let's say we
have let's take the length of inputs or
another way to do this uh is inputs.
shape 0 and I'm just going to do
something like this np. full okay let me
import
numai yep and I'm going to do this np.
full where let's see you can give it a
shape and then give it a value so let's
say I have 10 inputs and I always want
to return the value three so I do np.
full 10 comma 3 and that's going to list
uh return 10 threes so I'm always going
to
return I'm always going to return
inputs. shape zero so again if you have
a numi array let's say train inputs
right this is train inputs this is a NP
Panda's uh data frame if I do train
inputs. shape that tells me the number
of rows and columns do shape Z is going
to tell me the number of rows so I get
the number number of
rows so I'm just going to get the number
of rows here from the inputs that were
passed here and I am going to return
self. mean
okay so yeah it's some objectoriented
programming some fancy numpy stuff but
ultimately what it's doing is this let's
first create a mean regression model
let's call it mean model is mean
regressor so now we've created this mean
model and let's call mean model fit so
we're now going to train train this
model uh this so-called
uh model that always predicts the
average and let's give it the train
inputs and the train
targets okay now once we pass oh sorry
let's call
fit okay so now once we call mean
regressor do fit it's going to
completely input the uh ignore the
inputs and it's going to take the
targets and simply calculate the average
of the targets a single value and it's
going to store that in the
mean attribute so the average is
11.35 okay that's the average fair for
the taxes and then when we get want to
get some predictions so let's say we
want to get some predictions for the
train training set we can say mean model
dot predict train
inputs and that gives us a prediction so
it's simply predicted the value 11.35
for every Row in the training set okay
similarly we can get some predictions
for the validation set so let's say mean
model do
predict while
inputs and once again it's going to
Simply predict the value
11.35 for every row in the validation
set now we may want to compare these
predictions with the targets how off is
this model by of course it's going to be
way off
because we are just predicting the
average so here are the train
predictions and here are the training
targets 6 3.7 you can ignore this this
is simply the row numbers from the data
frame but yeah 6 3.7 and we always
predicting 11.35 now to tell how badly
we are doing we are going to need to
compare these two and come up with some
sort of an evaluation metric so that's
where we're going to use a root mean
squared error evaluation metric because
that is the metric that is used on the
leaderboard so I'm going to import from
skarn do
matrix mean squ error okay and I'm going
to define a function called rmse just to
make my life easier it takes some inputs
some
targets and it returns
mean squared
error uh with between the uh not input
sorry it takes some targets and it takes
some
predictions and it returns a mean
squared error between the targets and
the predictions and to return the mean
squared ER to sorry to get the root mean
squared error we need to set squar to
false in mean squared error okay all
that said and done I'm now going to be
able to get the root mean squared error
so we have some
training
targets these are the fair amounts for
the training set rows we have some train
threads some
predictions let's call rmsse on this and
let's call the train
rmsse and let's print that
out so this is the root me squared error
for the training set which means that on
average the predictions of our model
which is always
11.35 are off or are different from the
target the actual value that the model
should be predicting by n which is
pretty bad
because the values we're trying to
predict the average is about 11 the 75%
Mark is about seven uh sorry is about 12
so if you're if they're trying to
predict values in the range of let's say
10 to 20 and you're off by 9 so that's a
pretty bad model right and that's
expected because it's just a dumb model
but here's the thing any model that we
train should hopefully be better than
this kind of a model right should be
hopefully be have a lower training uh
lower rmsse let's get the validation RMS
as
well while targets while
PRS yeah so the model is
our hardcoded model is off by
9.89 on average which is pretty bad
considering that the average fair is
11.35 okay great so that was our
hardcoded dump
model all right next let's train a very
quick linear regression model to see
whether machine learning is even useful
at this point so I'm going to from SK
learn. linear model I'm going to import
linear
regression and I'm going to create a
linear model
here that's it I think that's pretty
much it you can set a random State I
believe to avoid some
randomization oh no there is no random
state so this is it right linear
regression model is just this in psyit
learn and here is how you fit a model by
the way we are expecting here that
you're already familiar with machine
learning and if you're not then I highly
recommend checking out 02g bms.com this
is a practical and coding focused
introduction to practical to machine
learning with python where we cover all
of these topics all of the models that
we are looking at
today okay so we do linear
model do fit train inputs and train
targets great and then once it is fit we
can now make predictions so we can get
train PRS equals linear model do predict
and that's going to take the training
inputs and it's going to come up with
some predictions for
us and you can look at the predictions
here and compare them with the targets
here you can see that the predictions
are all still close to 11 but they're
different at least they're not the same
prediction each time but there still way
off right they're still way off um let's
maybe also get
the let's look at the rmsse on the train
PRS
and Rain
PRS so the RMC is
9.78 so that's not much better 9.78 9
was our average model and our linear
regression just this is hardly better
and still completely useless right let's
get while
predictions rmsc on the well
targets and W
PRS so the root means squared error here
is
9.89 or 9.89 which is just 01 less than
a cent less than 0.1 Cent better than
our average model okay and now at this
point you might want to think about why
that is the case and in this case I
would say that this is mainly because
the training data which is just geoc
coordinates at this point which is
latitudes longitudes
Etc is not in a format that's very
useful for the model right how does a
how is a model going to figure out that
latitude and longitude are connected and
there's a pickup latitude and
pick up longitude and then there is a
sort of a some distance between them or
all those relationships are very hard
for models to learn by themselves and
that is where feature engineering is
going to come into picture and we are
also not using one of the most important
columns which is the pickup date and
time
because fairs are very seasonal in terms
of months in terms of days in terms of
hour of day in terms of day of the week
Etc so that's why our our data in the
current format is not very useful from a
machine learning perspective and we are
able to establish that using the
hardcoded and Baseline model however we
now have a baseline that all our other
models should ideally
beat now before we train any further
models we're going to make some
predictions and submit those predictions
to
kaggle now here's the next tip whenever
you're working on kaggle competitions
submit early and submit often ideally
you want to submit make your first
submission on day one and make a new
submission every day because the best
way to improve your models is to try and
breed your previous score if you're not
making a submission then you're not
going to figure out if you're heading in
the right direction or if you have a
good validation set or if there's
anything else you should be
doing but on the other hand if you're
making submissions every day you will
have to try and beat your previous
submission right and that will force you
to move in the right
direction so how do you make predictions
and submit to kaggle first you have to
make some predictions for the test set
so
we have the test inputs here right in
front of
us so all we need to do is we need to
pass the test inputs into the let's say
let's take a linear model so into the
linear model we say predict it's trained
already using the training set and we
get some predictions from
this and of course we don't have any
Targets so the way we have to evaluate
these predictions is by creating a
submission file so the way we can create
a submission file is this way we first
read in the submission data
frame which is the sample submission
file right and now so this is a sample
submission file now all we can do is we
can simply take the test
predictions
here are your test predictions and we
can simply replace this column of data
with this because remember the rows in
the submission file correspond one to
one or one one on one to the rows in the
test file right so the first row of the
submission file points to the first row
of the test file and so on so I'm just
going to do something like this sub DF
dot oh sorry sub DF Fair amount equals
test
threads and now you should see sub DF
will now have the
data from the test set you can see that
there are all these are all different
values okay and now you can save that to
CSV so you can say sub DF do to CSV you
can give them a file name like
linear model
submission. CSV and one thing you need
to do when saving submission files
especially for kagle is to specify index
equals none otherwise your otherwise
pandis is also going to add this 0123
this column as an additional column in
your file which you don't
want okay and now you will have this
file here sample or or linear model
submission.csv and now you can download
this
file
so let's save that and you can submit
this file so our previous submission was
giving us
9.49 that was
the that 9.49 that was the
rmse and this one let's see what this
one gives us let's click on late
submission let's go
here and let's just call this linear
model
let's call it simple linear model let's
make
oops let's give that a second yeah it's
uploaded and the submission is coded
9.47 so not not very different and one
thing that we can now verify is that our
test set metric is close to the
validation set metric right so the
remember the validation set rmsc was
9.89 um and the test set metric is 9.4
now that's not too different I mean
they're in the same range it's not that
validation set rmsse was two and the
test set rmsc was 10 so they're close
enough of course the validation set is a
lot larger it's about 110,000 rows
whereas the test set is just uh 10,000
rows so it's always harder to make
predictions on larger uh unseen data
than smaller data so that could have an
effect but at least they have they're
close enough for us to work with
Okay so that's how you make predictions
for the test set now the next STP here
is to create reusable functions for
common tasks remember we said that you
should be making submissions every day
and if you need to make submissions
every day you should not be copy pasting
all this code around each time because
that just takes up a lot of mental
energy and you make mistakes and you
have to fix figure change values and all
that so it's always good to create
functions like this so we create a
function predict and submit which takes
a model takes a file name calls model.
predict on test inputs and then that
gives you test predictions and then you
can call read CSV or you could even
provide test inputs here as an uh yeah
as as a argument and then you call pd.
read CSV and that's going to read the
sample submission into the submission
file you are going to put the fair
amount
and then you're going to save it to the
given file
name and uh yeah let's put that
here you're going to save it to the
given file name and that and then you're
going to return the data Fame so we
could do the same thing predict and
submit let's let's just call this let's
give it the linear
model and let's give it test
inputs and let's give it the file name l
your sub 2.
CSV and you can see that it does exactly
the same thing but now it's just one
line anytime you want to generate
predictions and create a submission file
so here's linear sub to. CSV you can see
what this file
contains so yeah it it shows you a nice
pretty view
here um yeah so it shows you nice pretty
view here but it's ultimate uh actually
just a CSV file which contains the key
and fair
amount
okay great so that brings us to make
predictions and submit to kagle we're
done with that that was simple
enough and we now have this function
that we can use anytime to make
predictions on the test
set and next one thing you will want to
do here is just track your ideas and
experiments systematically to avoid
becoming overwhelmed with doubl dozens
of models because you're going to be
working on a machine learning project
for at least a couple of weeks but
probably a couple of months or longer uh
so you need to keep track of all the
ideas you're trying so here's a tracking
sheet that we've set set up for you
where you can uh and you can just create
a copy of the sheet you can go to file
make a copy and create a copy but here
you can put in ideas
like the uh L the kind of models you
want to try um the sample sizes so maybe
like try sample size 10% so just keep a
keep a list of all the ideas you have
whenever you have them don't have to try
them right away you probably can't and
keep a list of what you expect the
outcome to be whenever you have an idea
and also then once you try out an idea
mention what learning you have from the
idea so this is called just idea
tracking where you like list out all
your ideas and um the potential outcome
you expect and what you learn from it
and then here you have experiments so
each time you train a model you just
want to put in like give a title to the
model give a date give some uh note down
whatever hyper parameters you want to
note or the type of model you want to
note uh note down the training loss
validation loss and the test score this
could be from the kagle leaderboard and
a link to the notebook so every time you
save a notebook every time you save
using jan. commit let's say I go here
and I say Jovan do commit
this is going to give me a
link yep yeah so you can note down here
that there's version 10 here so you can
just note down something like this you
can just note down let's say version 10
right um version 10 of the notebook and
you can refer back to it so over time
you have all these versions dozens of
versions and for each version you know
exactly
what the parameters for that version are
and once you have maybe 30 40 models you
can look at this sheet and you can get a
very clear idea of Which models are
working and Which models are
not okay let's see if you have any
questions at this point before we move
ahead can you please explain okay I
think we've
answered uh why we are using shell
commands can we directly fit the model
to 99% of the remaining data with One S
with 1% sample data of training
um yeah so I don't I'm not sure if I
understand the question but what we have
done right now is there are 55 million
rows available for training I have
simply taken 1% of that or 500,000 rows
for training the model so that we can
train things fast what you would want to
do later is instead of using just 1% of
the data use maybe 10% of the data or
20% of the data or all 100% of the data
at the very end
and train a model on the entire 100% of
the data and then make predictions with
that trained model on the test set and
that should definitely be better than
training the model on just one person of
the data so I hope that answers
that next for regression problems we
created a model which gives
you gives the mean as an output and then
we tried linear regression what should
be our approach for classification
problems good question so for
classification problems you can maybe
just predict the most common class or
you can predict a random class and just
go with that yeah most common class or
random class is what I would suggest for
classification
problems okay let's see if there are any
other interesting
questions any specific reason we are
using float 32 and uint 8 yep so I
actually looked up how many decimal
places the float 32 supports and it
supports about eight decimal places like
eight digits of precision roughly and
that is good enough to support
longitudes and latitudes now if you just
specify float it might pick float 64
which will take twice the amount of
memory which can be a problem for large
data sets similarly with uint 8 so I
looked at the fair amount values and it
seems like it's in the um not fair
amount the number of passengers and
seems like that's in the range of maybe
1 to 200 um so if you just specify int
that's going to you use int 64 which is
going to use 64 bits but we can actually
get away with
one8 of that just eight bits because the
numbers are we are dealing with are
fairly small so that's why u in 8 so
these are just techniques to uh reduce
the memory footprint of the data
set
okay
perfect and there was a question about
prerequisites for this uh Workshop so
zero pandas
docomo watch this right now and start
working on a machine learning project
and then learn machine learning along
the
way okay let's move on to feature
engineering now we're halfway through so
hopefully we'll be able to train a few
models feature engineering means taking
The Columns of data that you have and
Performing operations on them to create
new columns which might help train
better models because machine learning
models are fairly dump they have there
is a certain structure they have they
assume a certain relationship between
inputs and outputs like linear
regression assumes that the output is a
linear is a weighted sum of the inputs
and that may not hold true in the
current form which is latitudes and
longitudes but suppose we were able to
somehow calculate the distance between
the pickup and drop off point then there
will definitely be some sort of a linear
relationship between the the distance to
be covered and the fair right so by
creating good features you are going to
make you're going to train much better
models because you have now applied
human insight to provide features that
are conducive to solving the problem
in the structure that the model
assumes now the tip here is to take an
iterative approach to feature
engineering don't go overboard don't
spend weeks creating features just add
some features one or two train a new
model evaluate it keep the features if
they help otherwise drop them then
repeat with new
features so here are some features that
we are going to create and I am not
taking an iterative approach here in the
interest of time I'm just is going to
create a bunch of uh features right away
first is to extract parts of the date we
have totally ignored the date so far
because we didn't know how to put it
into a linear regression model but we
can extract things like year month day
week day hour I think these are all
useful things because over years I would
assume that the fair increases across
months there must be some sort of a
seasonal Trend uh across days of the
month as
well because maybe there are a bunch of
deliveries or there are a bunch of
things that people have to do during the
start of the month or the end of the
month like going to the
bank across weekdays of course there
should be a difference between weekdays
and weekends there should be a
difference during the week and across
hour of the day so we going to extract
out all these parts out of the date so
that's one thing we'll do uh we will
also deal with outliers and invalid data
it's a form of feature engineering we're
kind of cleaning up the data a little
bit we will add distance between pickup
and drop location so we'll see how to
compute distance using latitudes and
longitudes and we will also add distance
from some popular landmarks because a
lot of people take taxis to get to
places where they can't normally drive
and these could be crowded places or
these where they can't park or these
could be things like airports and there
are also tolls involved here and tolls
are included in the in the fair so it
might be useful to track that as well
okay U so we are going to apply all of
these together but you should observe
the effect of adding each feature
individually okay so let's extract some
parts of the date and this is really
easy and once again I'm just going to
follow my previous advice and create a
function that allows me to do that so
here we have a function add date parts
that takes a date a data frame and a
column name and then it takes the column
and it creates a new column name called
column name undor ear
where it extracts from that date from
that date time column here so just to
give you a sense of how this works we
have train DF this is a data
frame and suppose I set column
to pickup date time then train DF of
call is just all the pickup date times
and if I call dodt
Dot year and it's going to give me just
the year for every row of data you can
see 2011 12 15 and so on and I can
actually now save that to train DF um
let's say I want to save it to pickup
date time underscore year equals this
right and another way to do this is to
just say call plus right so that's what
we've done not just for year but month
day week day and hour and we've put that
into a function so I'm just going to
call add date parts to train
DF let's run
that and of course we need to give it
the column
name yep Let's ignore the volume for now
uh the warning for
now and let's do that for the validation
set as
well add date parts to the and let's do
that for the test set as
well uh
let's yeah
well let's
see
H yeah looks like there might be some
issue in the test data frame so I'm just
going to load it again uh I see I see
what
happened so yeah uh this is one of the
things with doing things live there are
always some issues let's go back to
creating the test Set Let's see we have
a useful table of contents here again
this is why it's useful to have a table
of contents you want to also specify
here past
dates
equals pick up date time so that this
can be passed as a date
column and let's come back here to
extract parts of
date and let's add the training data
frame uh let's add it in the validation
data frame and let's add it in the test
data
frame
okay I think we have it everywhere so
let's
check train
DF and you should now see that train DF
has not just a fair amount and pickup
date time Etc but it also has pick up
date time year month day time of day
week day and hour and you can verify the
same for while DF and test DF as
well there you
go right
and yep so with that we have added
different parts of the date so we've
already done some basic feature
engineering so dates are always a low
hanging fruit for doing feature
engineering you can add more you can add
things like start of quarter end of
start of year end of year uh weekend
weekday Etc the next thing that we're
going to add is the distance between the
pickup and the drop
location and to do that we're going to
use something called the have a sign
distance there are many formulas to do
this um like again the way I found this
was just looked up online distance
between a distance between
two c geographical or map coordinates
right or latitude longitude distance
something like that so there is this
formula and it looks something like this
essentially this is what the formula
looks like it has a AR sign and a s
square and a COS Etc and then I looked
up a way to calculate have sign for
pandas so I searched online fast havign
approximation how do you calculate it
and somebody was very helpful they
created an entire function which I
directly borrowed over here as the sign
distance okay so it takes of longitude
latitude so this is going to be the
pickup location it takes the longitude
latitude of the drop location and it is
going to calculate the approximate
distance in kilometers between the two
points this uses great circle geometry
which uses the spherical nature of the
earth and how latitudes longitudes are
defined
Etc um we don't have to get into it but
there are these resources if you want to
and the interesting thing here is that
this works not just with one latitude
and longitude but also a entire series
or an entire list of latitudes and
longitudes so if you provide one list
containing a list of longitudes and a
list of latitudes and a list of
longitudes and a list of latitudes so
basically a bunch of rows it's going to
perform that for each row and it's going
to perform that in a vectorized fashion
because it uses numpy so it's going to
be very efficient so we can directly use
this to add the trip distance
into our data frame so from our data
frame we pick up the pick up longitude
pick up latitude then we give the drop
of longitude and drop of latitude and
pass it into the Hine function that is
going to do this for each individual row
it's going to compute the distance using
the havign formula and it's going to now
add a trip
distance so let's add trip distance to
train
DF
and let's add trip
distance to wdf and let's add trip
distance to
SDF and now we can see train
DF yeah so here now you can see there is
a trip distance and this is a distance
in kilometers so this seems like a
a fairly long trip this seems like a
shorter trip and so on well 1.3 km and
then there are some trips like 7.1
kilomet and you can already probably
tell that this the fair for this trip is
probably going to be maybe four or five
times the fair for this trip I would
imagine let's
see yeah so the fair here is 18 the fair
here is 3.7 so it's about five times
right so there's already a very useful
feature for us to use
now next and this is something I learned
by looking at some discussions and some
notebooks on the competition page we're
going to do a little more a slightly
more creative set of feature engineering
we are going to add the distance from
popular landmarks specifically we're
going to add check
if we if the trip is going to end near
one of those landmarks if people are
going to one of these landmarks and
specifically airports because airports
have tolls so we're going to add JFK
Airport the laguadia airport the nework
airport we're going to add the location
of Times Square Met Museum and World
Trade Center okay there are many more
you could have the Statue of Liberty you
could
have
um Central Park you could have a bunch
of other locations in New York so this
is something that you to look up and we
will add the distance from the drop
location but feel free to also add the
distance from the pickup location that
is left as an exercise for you and let's
see if this helps and here's the next
tip that creative feature engineering
which generally involves some human
inside because no machine learning model
will be able to figure out at least not
the simple models that we are training
will be able to figure out that a
certain location is very important by
itself but we can able we can figure
that out quite easily given the context
we have so involving human Insight or
involving external data so here we have
picked up the latitude and longitud
values for gfk LG Etc and this is
essentially this is what is called
external data um again this this data
will never automatically become
available to the machine learning model
so creative feature engineering is often
a lot more effective in training good
models than excessive hyperparameter
tuning like you're doing a lot of grid
searches and like training a model for a
long time for multiple hours or
overnight or over multiple
days with 10 tens of gigabytes and like
hundreds of columns so keep in mind that
just one or two good features improve
the models performance drastically so
focus on finding what those one or two
good features are and they can one they
can improve the models performance far
more than any amount of hyperparameter
tuning and and the way you get these
features is by doing your exploratory
data analysis by understanding the
problem statement better by reading out
reading up uh discussions by discussing
it with people
and also keep in mind that adding too
many features is just going to slow down
your training and you're not going to be
able to figure out what is the useful
thing to use right that's why iterating
is very important so here are the
latitudes and longitudes or longitudes
and latitudes for JFK
LGA uh Newark the mech Museum and the
World Trade Center
and once again we can use the H sign
distance function we are going to give
it the data we going to give it a data
frame name and we're going to give it a
landmark name and landmark lawn lat so
from the lawn lat we're going to get the
longitude and the latitude of the
landmark and we're going to create a
landmark name underscore Drop Distance
column where we are passing into the
havign function the longitude and the
latitude of the landmark as the pickup
location and this is the interesting
thing about this function that it
doesn't have to be all numbers or all
series like a couple of these can be
numbers and a couple of these can be
series and it will still work fine so
here is the landmarks location and then
here is the longitude and latitude of
the drop location right so we're going
to add the Drop Distance from the
landmark in this fashion and of course
we need to do it for a bunch of
landmarks so here we have created this
add landmarks function that's going to
do it for each of the landmarks right so
this is why creating functions is really
useful because now we can just do add
landmarks PR
DF
um I guess this should just be called
ADF yeah add landmarks train DF and add
landmarks
wdf and add
stdf okay and now if you check the
training data
frame it's looking nice now we have just
pick up latitude longitude Etc but here
is where it starts to get interesting we
have the trip distance JFK Drop Distance
we have the LGA Drop Distance we have uh
EWR Drop Distance this one seems to be
near the Met uh and then we have the WTC
Drop Distance this one seems to be at
the
WTC yep so now we have a lot more
interesting things here and
I think that's enough feature
engineering for now enough new features
but let's also remove some outliers and
invalid data remember if you look at
like just the data frame DF do in DF do
describe and we look at test DF do
describe the test set seems fine test
set has fairly reasonable values you can
see here it has pickup latitude
longitudes are in the minus 72 to 75
range um similar pick up longitudes and
drop off long longitude pick up
latitudes is probably between the
minimum is 40 and the maximum is 41 so
between 40 and 42 um passenger counts
are between 1 and six since we are only
going to make predictions on these
ranges of data it makes sense to
eliminate any training data which Falls
outside these
ranges and of course the training data
also seems to have some incorrect values
likeus 1183 is not a longitude uh 208
people cannot fit
and Uber and even this Fair seems high
but I wouldn't bet so much on it with
search it could possibly go there but
there's definitely some issue here so
here's what we're going to do we are
going to limit the fair
amount between 1 and $500 which is
already the case except that there are
some negative faires and we don't want
our model dealing with negative fairs it
just makes things
harder we may sacrifice maybe
predictions for one or two rows in the
test set but the overall gain in
accuracy will be better then we're going
to limit the longitudes to- 75 to 72
we're going to limit the latitudes to 40
to 42 and we're going to limit the
passenger count to 1 to six so now we
have this remove outliers function which
takes a data frame and then from the
data frame it picks out those rows which
match all these
conditions where the fair amount is
greater than one and this is how you
combine conditions in pandas while
quering or filtering rows and the fair
amount is less than or equal to 500 and
the pickup longitude is greater than -75
and the pickup longitude is less than-
72 same for drop off and the pickup
latitude is greater than 40 and the
pickup latitude is less than 42 and same
for drop off and the passenger count is
between 1 and six okay so this is how we
remove outliers you don't always have to
remove outliers if your model has to
deal with outliers in the real world
then
you should keep the outliers but if your
model doesn't have to deal with outliers
or you're going to train a different
model for outliers then it makes sense
to remove the outli the ranges of values
that don't appear in the test
data so let's remove outli from the
training data
set let's remove outliers from the
validation data uh data frame and
finally let's remove uh outliers from
okay there are no outliers in a test
data frame so I wouldn't worry about
that but I would want to save my
notebook
again there we go okay all right so now
we have done a whole bunch of feature
engineering we've extracted parts of the
date we've added distance between pickup
and drop locations we've added distance
from popular landmarks we have removed
outliers and invalid data we have done
some okay next up here are a couple of
exercises for you you can try scaling
numeric columns into the 0 to one range
right now all these numeric columns have
different ranges the month date Etc um
this generally helps with linear models
or any models where the loss is computed
using the actual values of the data um
and you can also try encoding
categorical columns so things like
months can possibly be treated as
categorical columns month year even day
of week Etc and you can probably use a
one hot encoder there and that makes it
a lot easier for decision trees to work
with categorical columns now we won't do
this because uh for a couple of reasons
one we just want to keep it simple right
now get to a good model first and then
we can come back and try this later if
we have time but second tree based
models are generally able to do a decent
job even if you do not scale numeric
columns or encode categorical columns
assuming that you have a tree that can
go deep enough or you're training enough
trees which we will try and do okay but
here but that's an exercise for you try
scaling numeric columns and encoding
categorical columns and if you don't
know what these terms mean then check
out the 0 to GBM
scores now another tip here that I have
for you is we've spent what one close to
two hours now preparing this data for
training we still haven't trained our
first machine learning model but what
you can do now is you can actually save
these intermediate outputs and download
those files or you can even put those
into Google
Drive and then load put them back later
when you're when you're using your next
notebook right so this way you save all
that time of executing of downloading
the data and preparing the data set and
running through all this code you can
start from this point where you have
this pre-prepared data and you may want
to definitely do that do this for the
entire data set once and get those
processed files and then save those
processed
files for the entire data set so that
you don't have to download and do this
processing on the entire data set of 55
million rows okay and a good format that
you can use is the Apache parket format
so you could just do train DF
do2
paret train do parket so the parket
format is really fast to load and to
write and it is also very small in its
in its uh footprint in ter on the
storage so it's a good intermediate
format to use when you know that you're
going to load it back using pandas CSV
unfortunately is a very heavy format
because everything has to be converted
to a string and similarly we can do a
Val DF
do2 paret
while. parket and you can see that these
files are here and you can download
these or you can even just push them to
your Google Drive all of those things
are
possible now another tip here or sort of
corer here is that you may also want to
create different notebooks for Eda
feature engineering and model training
so that your Ed your feature
engineering uh your initial Eda is just
something where you just experiment with
different graphs Etc your feature
engineering notebook is where you create
new features and then uh output these
parket files and then your model
training notebooks can simply use the
outputs of your feature engineering
notebooks and there is a way to connect
Google collab to Google Drive so that
you can organize all your work
well okay
so let's Now train and evaluate some
models so we'll train three kinds of
models although there are many more you
can
train but because we have limited time
we are going to train just three kinds
of models linear
regression or a form of linear
regression called Ridge and random
forests and gradient boosting
models maybe I should just change this
here I'm going to change this to Ridge
and you can try things like lasso
elastic net
Etc okay but before we train the model
once again we have to create inputs in
targets now we've added a bunch of new
columns so let's just go train DF do
columns and now well the input columns
we are going to skip the fair amount
we're going to skip the pickup date time
I'm still going to keep pickup latitudes
and longitudes because decision trees
might still be able to use these
so those are all our inputs looks
good and then we have our Target
column and here is the fair amount that
is a target
column so now we can create train inputs
so train inputs
is train DF and let's just put in the
input
calls and then let's create the train
targets that's train DF and let's just
put in the Target
call let's create Val inputs that is
while
DF input
calls and while inputs while
DF Target
calls and finally we have the test
inputs which is just
stdf input calls okay perfect
then um before we train models I am just
going to create a helper function to
evaluate
models which takes the model train
inputs and while
inputs so this is what it does it takes
a model it takes training inputs and
validation inputs assuming this is a
trained model and then first it makes
predictions using the trained model on
the train inputs that gives us train
predictions it then computes the mean
squared error between the training
targets and the training inputs well
maybe we can just drop this we can just
use the globals because the model is
what is changing most of the time so we
have a function evaluate which takes a
model it gets predictions on the
training set and then it computes a mean
squared error using the training targets
and the training predictions it gets
predictions on the validation set then
it computes a mean squared error using
the validation targets and validation
predictions and then it Returns the root
mean squared error for training
validation sets and the predic prics for
the training and validation sets so now
evaluating models is just going to be a
single line of code so let's start with
Ridge
regression from sklearn do linear model
import Ridge once again if you want to
learn about Ridge regression you can
check out the documentation here or you
can uh do the0 to GBM
course and let's create a model so let's
call this model one Ridge and I think
let's see there are a few coordinates
here so I I think we can specify a
random State here so I'm just going to
do random
State equals 42 so that I get the same
result each time now Ridge uses
something called L2 regularization in
combination with linear regression in
the in the objective function so you can
specify the value of this Alpha here so
I would encourage you to play around
with it let's do alpha equals 9 Maybe
and then Ridge also has a bunch of other
things that you can set you can set a
solver and you can set a bunch of other
things so I'll encourage you to try it
out but that's a model then let's train
our model by calling model.fit
train
inputs of course we need to provide the
targets as
well so the model is now going to train
and it is going to try and figure out a
set of Weights that can be applied to
the input columns to created to create a
weighted combination of input columns
that predicts the target value which is
the fair amount so the fair amount is
being expressed as a some weight W1
multiplied by let's say the distance
plus some we W2 multiplied by um the
pickup latitude and plus some we W2
multiplied by number of passengers etc
etc right so it's a weighted average
that's going to try and predict the fair
and the ridge when we call fit it
figures out a good set of Weights now we
can evaluate our Ridge model by just
calling
evaluate model
one okay
um yeah I'm not sure what the issue here
is let's see
here yeah let's go step by step and we
should be able to figure out this issue
doesn't seem like a big issue to me but
here we have train predictions is model
one. predict train
inputs yep and so similarly you have
validation
predictions I'm just going to change
this to RMS
C let's try and get the rmsc
here yep this works
too let's try and get these
going
okay something wrong with validation
predictions what did we break
here ah I
see
yeah yeah so that's just like a quick
node on debugging whenever you have
functions that you need to debug a good
way to debug them is to break them down
line by line and then identify which
line is causing an issue and then go
back to where you created this variable
or whatever was the previous instance uh
that leads to Right Live debugging is
always fun okay so let's evaluate the
model and upon evaluation this model
gives us 8.0 as the training set rmsc
and 8.2 as the validation set RM well
that's a lot that's somewhat better than
our previous model uh okay in this case
it is
I was probably getting 5.2 earlier maybe
without this Alpha let me try that
again yeah so it's 8.8.2 it's somewhat
better than our Baseline model not great
but still
better let's check if our train input
still has the same
shape yeah it does okay now remember our
submit and predict
function oh sorry predict and sub
submit so now we can use this reuse this
function and give it our model one and
then give it our test
inputs
and give it a file
name yep so those are our predictions
for the ridge model let's take this
these set of predictions and let's
upload them let's see what we get
so I download the r submission and go
back
here let's upload it
here let's see what that
does okay it's almost up yeah let me
just call that
Ridge so 7.72 not bad not bad at
all that's better than 9.7 so we're
getting there we're getting better let's
try a random Forest let's save this
let's try a random of course at this
point I would also go and add it in my
experiment sheet I would note down that
Ridge gave
me
7.72 and it was like 8 four or something
and so
on okay let's try random Forest
now so I'm going to import
from
skar do Ensemble I
believe import random
forest
regressor and then model two is random
forest regressor and I'm going to set
the random state to 42 and I'm going to
set something
[Music]
to minus one yeah well n jobs and jobs
is just the number of
workers that reminds me though maybe I
made a mistake while removing
outliers um yeah I think I made a
mistake while removing outliers so what
we're doing here is when we remove
outliers we are returning a new data
frame so what we really need to do here
is we need to do train DF equals train
DF
um remove outliers and we need to do Val
DF equals remove outliers from Val DF
and finally we need to also yeah so that
that is now actually properly removed
outliers earlier we did not actually
remove the outliers we simply created
new data frames but we did not set them
back but that is that gives us an
opportunity now to see how actually
removing the outliers has an impact on
the model so now I'm training my Ridge
regression model once again and lo and
behold our models accuracy went down or
or models error went down from 7.2 to
5.2 so just by limiting the training
data The Columns of the training data to
the range of values within the test
data we are able to train a much better
model okay and once again we can test
this out I'm going to download this
Ridge uh submission. CS
file here once
again let's download that and I think
this is a
great uh this is a great example
of how much feature engineering can
change things right we've gone from 7.2
to 5.2 that's a 30% reduction in the
error so let's upload this let's click
late submission
again and let's upload the new
file
here
and it's
done yep and that puts it at
5.15 and let's look at the leaderboard
before we going into random Forest so
5.15 where does that put us out of, 1400
submissions or 1478
submissions let's load those submissions
quickly and let's search for
5.15 okay so that puts us at
1167 so we've already moved up almost
300 places from our original submission
which is very low which is like 9.8
which is way down here 9.8 yeah 9.4 was
somewhere around here, 1400 X to
5.15 yep somewhere here 5.15 so we are
at position 11 167 so we jump we jumped
300 places just by doing some good
feature engineering of course I say good
and just
but this has probably taken people
several weeks or probably a month or
more to figure out that these features
would be useful so if you can think of
more creative features even with a very
simple Ridge regression
or even a linear regression you'll be
able to move up even higher maybe into
the top thousand and of course let's not
forget that we still only working with
1% of the data right and this just keeps
keeps getting better so let's go and try
a random Forest so I'm going to try a
random Forest regressor here and here in
a random Forest we are going to train a
bunch of decision trees and then each of
those decision trees is going to um make
a prediction and then we're going to
average the prediction from all the
decision trees
so I'm setting a random State 42 so that
we always get the same set of
predictions and N jobs minus one make
sure that trees can be trained in
parallel then we have max depth so by
default the decision trees in a random
Forest are
unbounded but for a very large data set
you may not want to create unbounded
trees because they may take a very long
time and they may also very badly
overfit the training data so I'm just
going to specify a max depth
of I don't know
maybe 10 let's say and by default it is
going to
train let's see how many is it going to
train n estimators so the number of
trees it's going to train is let's see n
estimators the default is 10 let me
train
100 um trees
okay and let's just time the training
here so I'm just going to put time here
it's going to time the training tring
and model two do train or fit train
inputs and
train
targets okay and while it trains let us
see if we have any
questions so first question would this
support paret which is a pre-compressed
file um yeah so I'm not sure what the
question here is but yes aache parket is
yes I think it would support a
pre-compressed parket file if you have a
pre-compressed parket file you can load
it back using pandas you may have to
specify the type of compression possibly
so
yeah second question um shall we use Pi
carat well I don't think I don't know if
you can use P carat but parket works
just
fine if we limit the range of the
training data to match that of the test
data aren't we reducing the
generalization of the model for instance
we won't be able to use the same model
for future data set that might not have
the same range as the past test set
absolutely and that is why having a good
test set matters right so your test set
should be as close to what your model is
going to do in the real world as
possible because otherwise the test set
is useless now if we going to use the
model in the real world for something
other than what is already present in
the test set or the kind of data the
kind of ranges that are present in the
test set then our predictions on the
test set are not very indicative right
so our accuracy of the model is not very
indicative so even if you're getting 90%
accuracy on the test set then in the
real world the model can just be 30%
accurate and this happens all the time
probably 80% of machine learning models
face this issue so what I would suggest
instead is to create the test set in a
way that can capture the entire range of
values that the model can encounter in
the real world even if that means coming
up with some
estimates and I know this may not always
be possible but that's a great question
so
thanks how do we know the number of
landmarks to create you don't you have
to try a few and then train some models
try a few more do some exploratory
analysis see where draw maybe a
geographical heat map see where there's
a lot of traffic
Etc okay so our random forest model has
trained it it took 9 Minutes 57 seconds
and let's see What U this model does so
first let's evaluate the model so let's
call evaluate on model
2 okay and the model is able to get to a
pretty good place seems like we are down
to
4.16 that's not bad at all let's make a
submission so 4.16 is the validation
rmsc here training rmsc is 3.59 and
let's make a submission here predict and
submit model 2 and uh let's call it RF
submission.csv
uh it also requires
the test
inputs y okay so now we have generated a
random Forest submission so let's take
that let's download that
and we are just two hours in at this
point but making good progress of course
to put this together to put this outline
together uh definitely took more time
but even for a couple of days of work
this is not a bad result at all and
remember we are only using 1% of the
data I might at this point I might even
just want to take this random Forest and
put this into the comment so that when
I'm looking back at my submissions I can
see exactly what this model
contains interesting
thought okay seems like this might take
a minute or two
to yeah there's probably some issue here
but why don't we train a XG boost model
in the
meantime the next model we're going to
train is a gradient boosting model now a
gradient boosting model is similar to
random Forest except that each new tree
that it trains tries to correct the
errors of the previous tree and that's
what makes it this a technique called
boosting and that's what makes it
sometimes a lot more powerful than
random Forest so so we're going to use
the XG boost Library so from XG boost
import
xgb
regressor and then let's create a model
3 equals
xgb regressor and let's give
it a max depth of three let's make it
five maybe uh learning rate looks fine n
estimat is 100 looks
fine let us uh objective so we may want
to change the objective here
to r squared
error because we're dealing with the
root means squared
error and again you can look up the
documentation to understand what each of
these mean so in this case the objective
if you see here let's
see
um let's see XG post rmsc
objective yeah you can always look
up yeah I think this is the one that I'm
going to use reg squared error so yeah
this is the
objective or the loss function um let's
n estimators let's maybe change that to
maybe give it a little longer to train
let us uh yeah random
State and uh let us Set n jobs for some
parallelism okay let's train the
model
and then we will evaluate the
model and then of course we will also
predict and
submit model
3 test inputs and let's call that
xgb
submissions
submission
CSV okay so let's give that a minute to
train in the meantime let's check this
out okay so it looks like we got to
3.35 and where does that put us on the
leaderboard 3.35 let's go
down it's getting pretty close getting
pretty 2.8 and we are down to
3.35 still only 1% of the data still
model just took a few minutes to
train
3.35 so we up in the in
560 so 560 out of
1478 that's in the top 40% so we're in
the top 4% already that's not bad at all
top 40% model is actually a very good
model because most of the top
submissions one trained for a very long
time and also use a lot of ensembling
techniques Etc here's our XG boost model
it took about 34 seconds very short
model I'm sure we can probably bump up
the number of estimators to buy a lot
more and it is able to get to 3.98 so is
that better than the random Forest I
don't know yeah it seems like it's
better than the random Forest so in just
46 or maybe a few minutes I don't know
46 35 seconds probably
in let's
see yeah in just 35 seconds we were able
to train the best model so far probably
so let's go down here and let's go to
xgb submissions and let's download
it and let's save it
here come back slate
submission put that in
here
and I'm just going to drop the
description as well so I am going to
drop the xgb regressor description right
into
this and let's submit that and see what
happens perfect seems like we have made
a submission and that brings us to
3.20 quick look at the leaderboard once
again
3.20 and before while that loads let me
also just tell you what is coming up
next so so far we have just evaluated a
bunch of different models and I would
encourage you to try out a few more I'm
going to commit the notebook here as
well but the next thing that we should
be doing is tuning some
hyperparameters so let's see 3.20 I
believe okay we are up to
440 pretty good pretty good 440 out of
1478 is okay we've hit the 30% Mark
already that's not bad uh so the next
thing we're talking about is tuning
hyper
parameters now here is this now tuning
hyper parameters unfortunately is more
of
an is unfortunately more of an art than
a science there are some automated
tuners available but they will typically
try a whole bunch of things like grid
search and um take a long time
and you ultimately have to train a lot
of models and build some intuition about
what works and what doesn't but I try to
give you a couple of tools here that you
can use here's first strategy which is
about picking the order in which you
tune hyper
parameters so what you should do is
first tune the most important and
impactful Hyper parameter first for
example for the XG boost model number of
estimators or number of trees that you
want to train is the most important
hyperparameter and for this you need to
also understand how the models work
really well at least in an intuitive
fashion if not the entire mathematics
behind it you should have a good
intuitive understanding and all of these
models can be once you understand them
intuitively can be described in a single
paragraph or maybe
two so for X boost one of the most
important parameters is n estimators and
you tune that first and we'll talk about
how to tune that then with the best
value of the first hyper parameter we
tune the next most impactful hyper
parameter which in this case I believe
would be max depth and so on and so on
so tune the most impactful
hyperparameter use its best value and
what do you mean by best well use the
value that gives you the lowest loss for
the validation
set okay while still training in
reasonable amount of time so it's time
versus accuracy so wherever you feel
that this is the best uh this is giving
me the best result on the validation set
um use that hyper parameter and then
with the best value of the first hyper
parameter so all future models that you
try to tune you should have the best
value of the first hyper parameter and
then tune the next most impactful hyper
parameter so let's say the number of
estimators the best value is 500 keeping
that 500 fixed tune the next most
impactful hyper parameter like max depth
and then keeping the max depth fix tune
the next most impactful hyper parameter
and so on and go down for to five six
seven hyper parameters and keep going
then go back to the top and then further
tune each parameter once again for
further marginal gains right so that's
the order you sort of go through the
parameters get the best value and go
forward and as I said it's more an art
than a science unfortunately so try to
get a feel for how parameters interact
with each other based on your
understanding of the parameter and based
on the experiments that you're do
now in terms of how to tune
hyperparameters there's a there's a
image that captures this really well
which is called the over fitting
curve yeah so this is the image that
captures the idea really
well let's
uh yeah this is the one I'm looking
for so the idea here is how hyper
parameters let you control the
complexity of the model so certain hyper
parameters when you increase the hyper
parameter it increases the complexity of
the model or increases the capacity of
the model in some sense for example if
you increase the N if you increase the
max depth of the tree or you increase
the number of estimators then you are
increasing the capacity of the model
you're increasing how much it can learn
and the model starts out let's say you
try number of estimators 0 5 10 20 100
uh 500 2,000 5,000 10,000 so when you
have very few estimators or very few or
a very small model or a very limited
model both training error and test error
or validation error are pretty high
because your model has very low capacity
and it has to deal with a lot of data it
simply doesn't have all those parameters
to learn enough about the data as you
increase the model's capacity which is
increase the number of estimators or
increase let's say the max depth both
the model can start to learn more so it
starts to the training error starts to
decrease and the validation error starts
to decrease up to a
point and then what happens is at
certain point a validation error starts
to increase so this is what's called
overfitting This is where the model is
getting to a point where it is
now this is where the model is getting
to a point where it is now instead of
trying to learn the general relationship
between the inputs and outputs it is now
starting to memorize specific values or
specific patterns between the training
data mostly specific examples in the
training data or specific sets of
examples to further reduce the loss
right and as you make the model more and
more and more complex by increasing the
number of parameters it has by
increasing let's say the max depth it
can memorize every
single training input and that's what
decision trees do if you don't bound
their depth so when you get when your
model gets to that point then it's a
very bad model because all it's good for
is it's it's kind of a model that has
simply memorized all the answers so
anytime you give it a new question it
completely fails right it's like
memorizing answers for an exam versus
understanding the
concept as you go through the material
as you as you study as you do some
practice questions as you spend more
time your understanding of the material
gets better but if you get to a point
where you just blindly memorizing all
the answers then you're understanding of
the material may actually get worse
because you won't know how to solve
General problems so it's not
generalizing well enough so that's what
we want to find and what we've done here
for you is created a couple of functions
one called test params which give which
takes a model class and a set of
parameters and then trains the model
with the given parameters and Returns
the training and validation
RMC and then another called test param
and plot where you can provide a model
class you can provide a parameter name
you can provide a set of values for that
parameter that you want to test and then
a list of the other parameters that you
want to set constant while weying this
parameter okay and then it's going to
train a model for each of those values
and it's going to plot the figure for
you now I'm going to show you in just a
second what it does so don't worry too
much about the function code right
now but here's what we're going to do
we're going to try and tune the hyper
parameter number of trees now what's the
number of trees we have here 200 so I'm
going to try and figure out should we be
increasing the number of trees or should
we be decreasing the number of trees
okay and the way I'm going to do about
this do go about doing this is calling
test params and
plot and let's time that as
well
and in test Paramon plot we
have
first the type of model that we want to
train which is xgb
regressor we have the parameter name
that we want to vary so we want to vary
the num estimators
parameter then we want to try the values
let's try the value 100 let's try the
value 200 which we've already tried
let's try the value 400 let's see let's
say we just doubling the number and
seeing if that helps and let us set the
other parameters so let's set the random
state to 42 number of jobs to minus one
and objective to Reg squared error so
I'm just going to pass other
params this is called a these are called
quars or keyword arguments so each key
inside the sorry not other params each
key inside best params is going to be
passed as a argument to test params and
plot and ultimately it's going to get
passed down to the ultimately it's going
to get passed down to the best uh to the
xgb Reg regressor
model okay this is going to take a while
uh so how about we just start filling
out some um code in the
meantime so what we going to do after
this is into best params I'm going to
then add so the best params I'm going to
add what I think would be the best value
of num estimators that we should use so
we're going to add that then we're going
to try out some experiments with max
depth so we have set the max depth above
to what did we start with we started
with the max dep of five so maybe let's
try three and seven or three and six for
the max dep so test
param and
plot
xgb
regressor and we want to test max
depth and we want to test the value
vales 3 five and maybe six let's say
seven may take a long
time oh there it is
okay okay so seems like number of
estimators isn't really making a big
difference at the moment seems like
maybe we
should uh maybe we should like reduce
the learning rate of something and then
try changing the number of estimators
let me change the learning rate here the
initial learning rate to
0.05 instead of
0.1 let's see if that gives us any
benefit but yeah we can try Max up of 3
five maybe seven let's say
and uh let's give it the best
parameters and then we going to add the
best
param for max
depth
and we can try the same thing with
learning rate as well
so like we can try learning rates of
0.05 0.1 and
0.2 and so on okay yeah so this isn't
really doing much so maybe the number of
Maximum maximum estimators isn't really
helping so no need to worry about it but
let's just go with 100 for now then
let's try max depth of 3 five and 7even
let's see what that
does and then we arey going to try
different learning rates so this is what
we want to do right I hope you're
getting the idea here what you want to
do
is first train uh train a basic model so
have a set of initial params that you
want to start with then for each hyper
parameter try out
the a bunch of different values try
decreasing it try increasing it
similarly try decreasing it try
increasing it maybe try five values
maybe try seven values look at the curve
and look at the curve that gets created
and try to figure out where the best fit
is and the best fit is the point where
the validation error is the lowest right
for once you put in enough values you
will see a curve like this and you want
to pick not the point where like these
two are the closest not the point where
uh this is the lowest not the point
where this is the highest you want to
pick the point where the validations
error is the lowest
okay now one caveat here is that
sometimes the curve may not be very nice
like this sometimes it may have it may
sort of flatten out here and if it's
flattening out that means it's still
continuing to get better but if it if
going from this point to this point is
going to take three or four times the
amount of time to train the model then
you're probably better off just picking
this value instead where it's kind of
starting to flatten out so that you can
try more experiments faster okay so
that's something worth thinking about
yeah so here it is you can see with max
depth seems like if we if you were to
pick a max depth of seven that would
actually train much faster and sorry
that would actually give us a much
better model and so I'm just going to
pick maybe let's say max depth of
seven here let's say then we can try out
some learning rates I'm going to try out
a bunch of learning rates
here and then based on that I'm going to
test a learning rate
and then of course uh we can continue
trying to tune the model okay so you
want to try this with all the different
parameters not just these parameters and
here is a set of models that works well
so here's one where we
have 500 estimators and then we are
trying a max depth of let's go maybe a
little bigger let's try a max depth of
eight let's try my learning rate
slightly lower because as you increase
the number of estimators you want to
decrease the learning rate um and then
here there's a subsample so for each
split of each tree we only want to use
80% of the rows and then there's
something called a call sample by tree
for each tree that we use we only want
to use uh 20% of the cam of the columns
or 80% of the columns so these are just
a couple of uh things you can try 8.7
the same way that we've tried test
Paramon plot and see where that takes us
so I'm going to run this model right now
and see what um yeah so I'm going to
train this model here xgb model
final and I'm going to fit it to the
train
inputs and train
targets I am then going
to make some I'm going to evaluate the
model I am going to
then predict and
submit
xgb model
final
xgb XG GB tuned
dot uh
submissions. CSV okay so I'm just going
to let this run and see where that gets
us now in in my case I think the last
time I trained this it was able to get
us to about the 460th position I'm
hoping we can beat that I'm hoping we
can get maybe into the top 25 26% let's
see um but it should be somewhere around
that that point and again what is pretty
amazing here is that we are still just
using 1% of the data we throwing away
99% of the training data never looking
at it and the reason we able to do that
is because the test set is really small
the test set is just 10,000 rows and to
make predictions on a test set inste of
10,000 rows you don't really need 55
million rows yes it will help to add
more data or the entire data it'll
definitely make it better but if you're
always working with 55 million rows then
to do what we just did in less than two
and a half hours it would take you
probably a couple of weeks maybe longer
because one of the things we were able
to do here right now while working with
a sample is we were able to fix errors
very quickly we were able to try out new
ideas very quickly we we were able to
brainstorm and like
go from thought to action very quickly
but if you're working with 55 million
rows every action that you take every
cell that you run is going to run for a
couple of hours and by the time you come
back you're going to be tired you're
going to forget what you had in mind so
speed of iteration is very important and
creative feature engineering is very
important and then hyper parameter
tuning is really often generally just a
fairly small step which uh is a fairly
small step which uh gives you that last
bit of boost but it's generally not the
biggest
Factor so let's just fix that predict
and submit this is looking pretty
promising it has gotten to 3.8 let's see
if that is any better than the best
model that we had xgb tuned
submission let's submit
that
so that's why it's very important to
plan your machine learning project well
it's very important to iterate it's very
important to uh try as many experiments
as quickly as you can and track them
systematically it can make the
difference of a machine learning model
taking months and still not getting to a
good result versus getting to a really
good model something that can be used in
the real world in a matter of
hours okay um let's see where this gets
us so we just submitted and this got us
to about 3.20 let's check where that
puts us on the
leaderboard
3.20 yeah I bet it would still be under
the 30% Mark so which is pretty good
considering this is a single model most
models on kaggle use ensembles and
consider ing our model has taken just
what is this 1 minute to train not even
10 minutes our model was trained for
just 1 minute and we haven't even fully
optimized the hyper parameters yet right
so there's a lot more we can do in terms
of hyper parameters as well so let's see
3.20 okay that puts us at position
440 yeah so that is within the top 30%
right and I encourage you to like simply
Maybe just go 10x here instead of 500
estimators maybe go for 2,000 estimators
and see what that
does so here are some exercises for
you tune hyper parameters for the ridge
regression and for random Forest C
what's the best model you can
get repeat with 3% of the data 10% 30%
and 100% so basically 3 Xing each time
from 1 to 3 3 to 10 and so on so see how
much reduction in error does 3x data
produce this 10x data produce this uh
100x data produce and you will see that
the reduction is not 100x but the time
taken definitely becomes a lot more
right and finally the last couple of
things you can save the model weights to
Google Drive so there are a couple of
ways uh you can I'm not going to do this
right now but I'm just going to guide
you to the right place here so the way
to save model weights is to use
something like this uh use this Library
called jobb so you can do simply from
jblb import dump and then you can take
any python object and dump that into the
jblb file right so you can import uh you
can you can maybe just put the
dictionary or sorry just put the model
itself the X boost model and dump that
into a file and then load it back and
then use it just like the X boost object
it is or you could create a dictionary
put into it the XG boost model any other
like if you were using a scaler if
you're using an imputer of some kind
anything else that you need to make
predictions put all of those into a jobl
file and then dump it so that's how you
save models and then here we
have
IO inputs and
outputs for Google Drive for Google
collab so you can mount your Google
drive this way you can say for from
google. cab import drive and then drive.
Mount content drive when you do that
then on/ content drive your Google Drive
is going to show up here on the left let
me let me try
that yeah so your Google Drive is going
to show up here on the left um I'm not
going to run the whole thing right now
but your Google Drive is going to show
up here on the left I believe you need
to yeah I believe this one is going to
ask you to do some take some additional
steps like this you will have to um open
a link enter an authorization code
similar to adding your Jovian API key
that attaches your Google Drive and once
your Google Drive is attached you can
take the jblp file that you created here
and put that into your Google Drive so
now you can have a Ed notebook and then
you can have a feature engineering
notebook which takes the data adds a
bunch of features saves those files in
parket format to Google Drive then you
can have your machine learning notebook
which can pick up those files and then
train a bunch of models and whatever are
the best models you can write those
models back to Google Drive and then you
can have an inference notebook which can
load those models from Google Drive and
make predictions on new data right or
make predictions on individual inputs
that is again something that I would
suggest if you're if you hit a wall at
some point uh try looking at some
individual samples from the test set put
that put those into the model see the
prediction on that individual input and
see if that prediction makes sense to
you just eyeball the predictions and
then you'll get some more ideas then you
can do some more feature engineering and
that's the iterative process that you
want to follow you want to make
submissions every day day after day
right now one other thing that we've not
covered here is how to train on a GPU
you can train on a GPU with the entire
data set to make things faster so
there's a library called D that you can
use another Library called CF or Cuda
data frame which can take the data from
the CSV file and put it directly into
the GPU remember on collab you also get
access to a GPU so you can take the data
put it directly onto the GPU next you
can create training and validation sets
perform feature engineering directly on
the GPU it's going to be a lot faster
and most importantly the training that
you do the training can be done using XG
boost on the GPU itself and that's again
going to be a lot lot faster probably
orders of magnitude faster so the entire
process of working with the entire data
set itself can be reduced to maybe 10 or
20 minutes of work right now dusk CF and
CML are all have very similar apis to or
very similar functions Etc arguments Etc
as pandas and XG boost but some things
are different and some things have to be
done differently unfortunately it's not
a 100% compatible API so I've left you a
few resources that you can check out
specifically do check out
this project by Alan Kong he was uh one
of the members of the Jovan
Community who has created a model using
dask using the dask library and he has
used 100% of the data and his model
trains in under 15 minutes I believe and
in under 15 minutes he is able to get to
a point where I think he was able to get
to 2 point .89 which was in the top
6% okay of course it took several days
to write out the code and try out to
learn the different things required to
do this but a Model A single model
trained in under 15 minutes was able to
on the entire data set 100% of the
data under 17
minutes placed him in the 94th
percentile or the top 6% of the data set
so you can check out his notebook here
as well his notebook is listed here so
you can check out his notebook it's a
good tutorial on how to use
dask so that's an exercise for you and
finally here's the last thing I want to
you to take away from this Workshop
always document and publish your
projects online because they help
improve your understanding when you have
to explain what you've done there are a
lot of things that you've probably just
copy pasted or taken for granted or not
really thought about that you have to
now put into words and that forces you
to think and understand and fill the
gaps in your understanding so that's
very useful to improve your
understanding it's a great way to
Showcase your skills if you're going to
write on your resume that you know
machine learning under a skills section
without offering any evidence for it
there is no way somebody is going to
believe that you know machine learning
and they don't have the time to actually
interview hundreds of people and figure
out if they know so the best way to
offer evidence is to do a blog post
write a blog post well explained and
list uh link it from your
resume and the last thing is that as
people read your blogs or you share them
on LinkedIn or Twitter or wherever that
will lead to inbound job opportunities
for you people will reach out to you
recruiters will reach out to you
employees will reach out to you I saw
the project that you did it looks looked
pretty interesting we have a similar
problem here at our company would you be
interested in talk
and you won't believe um how many how
much easier it is going to become for
you to find Opportunities if you
consistently write blog posts and
publish your projects online any project
that you're doing please put it up
online please add some explanations
using markdowns spend another hour or
two clean up the code and create
functions show that you are a good
programmer and publish the Jupiter
notebook to Jovin it's just one we've
made it so simple for you because we
want you to publish these um articles
with us uh so you can run jan.com or you
can download the notebook and then you
can uh like you can go
file uh download notebook as ipnb and
then you can upload that Notebook on
Jovian you can go here on new and you
can upload a notebook it's really easy
uh but yeah when you do
that
you yeah you you can now share this
notebook with anyone
right and you can also write blog posts
like this one and the benefit of blog
posts is that you don't have to show the
entire code you can make it much shorter
and you can focus on the bigger
narrative or the bigger idea here I
think this is a great blog post about
the different steps involved here and uh
the things that Alan tried without
showing a bunch of maybe like hundreds
of lines of code right so it's a good
summary blog post of the code
and it's it's a great uh it's a great
way to share what you've done with
somebody and summarize it now one thing
you can can do is on your blog post you
can actually embed code cells from
Jovian and outputs and graphs and
anything from a jovian notebook and you
should check out this tutorial on how to
write a data science blog post we have a
tutorial here we write something from
scratch we did a few months ago that
will guide you in that
process so that
was the machine
learning project from scratch not really
from scratch because we had written out
an outline but let's review that outline
once again we started the we're trying
to predict taxi fairs for New York City
by looking at information like pickup
location drop location latitude
longitude
Fair the number of passengers and the
time of pickup so we downloaded the data
set by first installing the required
libraries downloading the data from
kaggle using open data sets looking at
the data set files seeing that we had
had 55 million rows in the training set
but just 10,000 rows in the test set we
had eight columns we loaded the training
data set and the test set we then
explored the training set and we saw
that there were some invalid values but
there were no missing values the test
set although had fairly reasonable
ranges then something we could have done
is exploratory data analysis and
visualization which is a good thing to
go and do right now to get ideas for
feature engineering and a great way to
build insight about the data set um is
to ask and answer question
because that will give you ideas for
feature engineering then we prepared the
data set for training by splitting the
data into training and validation sets
then we filled and or removed the
missing values in this case we removed
removed them and there were no missing
values in our sample of course one of
the things that we did while loading the
training set was we worked with a 1%
sample so that we won't have to so we
could get through this entire tutorial
in 3
hours but that also had the unexpected
benefit that we could experiment m a lot
more very quickly instead of having to
wait for tens of minutes for each cell
to run then
we extracted the inputs and outputs out
we separate out the input columns and
the output columns because that's how
machine learning models have to be
trained for the training validation and
test sets we then trained some hardcoded
models a model that always predicts the
average and we evaluated it we made
submissions from that model and sorry we
evaluated it against the validation set
and saw that it gives us a average rmsc
of about 11 we trained and evaluated a
baseline model which gave us an average
RM of about 11 as well this was a linear
regression model and the learning here
was that our features are probably not
good enough we probably need to create
new features because our linear
regression model isn't really able to
learn much beyond what we can predict by
just returning the average so before you
go out and do a lot of hyperparameter
tuning make sure that your model is
actually learning something better than
the Brute Force of The Simple
Solution then we made some predictions
and submitted those predictions to
kaggle and that established a basine
which we would then try and beat with
every new model that we create then when
it came to feature engineering the low
hanging fruit was extracting Parts out
of date the year the month the uh day
the day of the week and also the hour of
the day we then added the distance
between the pickup and drop using the
have a sign distance we we found a
function online that we just borrowed
we've also added distances of the drop
location from popular landmarks and like
the JFK Airport the new Yark airport the
laguard airport uh and a bunch of other
places you can possibly also add
distance from the pickup location we
removed outliers and invalid data we
noticed that there was a bunch of
invalid data in the training set and we
noticed that the test set had a certain
range of values for latitudes longitudes
fairs and all that so we put put those
in so that our model is focused on
making good predictions on the test set
which should be reflective of how the
model is going to be used in the real
world we can we could have done scaling
and one hot encoding and that would have
helped train the models a little better
I'm sure and then we saw how to save the
intermediate data frames and also
discussed that we can put them onto
Google Drive so that we can separate out
our notebooks for exploratory analysis
feature engineering and training we then
trained and evaluated a bunch of
different models first we once again
split the inputs and targets and then we
trained a ridge regression model we then
trained a random forest model and we
trained a gradient boosting model each
of these we did some very quick and
dirty hyperparameter selection but even
with that we were able to get to a
really good place we able to get to the
top 40% or so without much tuning then
we looked at hyperparameter tuning where
we decided that we would tune the most
impactful parameter first and then
keeping its value fixed tune the next
most impactful and by tuning we mean
picking the value of the hyper parameter
where the validation loss is the lowest
where it is not it has not started to
overfit but it is is still it has
learned a little bit about the data in
more general terms so we tuned number of
trees max depth learning rate and we ran
some experiments here we saw that all of
these parameters could be further
increased of course we are short on time
so we can't really look at like going to
very deep trees that would take a couple
of hours or so to train but I encourage
you to try those out till the point that
you start seeing the increase in the
validation error and finally we picked a
bunch of good parameters and we trained
a model and that model was able to put
us in the top 30% which was pretty cons
amazing considering we still just using
1% of the data and we looked at how we
can save those model weights to Google
Drive and we also discussed that the
model can be trained on GP
which would be a lot better when you're
working with the entire data set so that
you don't have to wait for hours to
train your model of course it requires
some additional work because you need to
install a bunch of libraries and make to
make things work but there's definitely
a few resources that you can check out
here maybe it could be a topic for
another Workshop where we could talk
about using a training classical machine
learning models on a GPU finally we
talked about the importance of
documenting in publishing your work I
cannot overstate this any work that you
do please document it please publish it
publish it to Jovian if you were writing
a blog post go to blog.
jin. and check out the contribute tab
here and you can feature blog post here
we share it not just with the
subscribers of the blog but it also goes
out in our newsletter which goes out to
over 100,000 uh members of the Jovian
community so it's a great way to get
some visibility for your work and become
found
so finally I just want to share some
references and then we'll take a few
questions if you have questions do stick
around the first one is about the data
set this is the New York City taxi fair
prediction data set definitely one of
the more challenging data sets that
you'll find on kaggle but with the right
approach you can see that it's all about
strategy and approach and fast iteration
you can do a lot with uh just a little
bit of data if you want to learn shell
scripting a little bit I check recommend
checking out missing semester from MIT
uh to learn bash and how to deal with
the terminal then the open data sets
Library this has been developed by
Jovian to make it easy to download data
from
C you can use it in all your projects
all you need to do is uh specify your
kaggle credentials then for exploratory
data analysis do check out this tutorial
on building an Eda project from scratch
again it's a follow along kind of
tutorial that you can apply apply to any
data set just as this entire strategy
you can pretty much apply to any data
set from kaggle maybe only the specific
Parts like feature engineering are going
to
change then do check out the course
machine learning by uh with python 0 to
gbms that's a useful course if you want
to learn machine learning from scratch
and do check out the blog post by alen
Kong on this particular data set it's
really useful there is this experiment
tracking sheet that we talked about very
important to stay organized as you try
hundreds or dozens at least of
experiments so that you don't lose track
of what are the best hyperparameters or
the best models or the best features
even then if you want to learn more
about datetime components in pandas you
can check this out there's some more
resources about havign distance and here
is the Rapids project which builds all
these alternative libraries that work
directly with gpus which we have have on
Google collab fortunately and if you're
looking to write a blog post there's
again a follow along tutorial we have on
how to write a data science blog post
from scratch that you can follow a few
examples of good machine learning
projects these are all projects created
by graduates of the zero to data science
boot camp um that we run it's a
six-month program
where you learn data analysis machine
learning Python programming a bunch of
analytics tools and build some real
world projects and then go out and um
also learn how to prepare for interviews
and apply for jobs so here's one you
should check out Walmart store sales is
a great project on forecasting Walmart's
weekly sales using machine learning it's
very detailed and covers all the
specific aspects that we have talked
about in this um table of contents
here's another predicting used car
prices one thing that you get to see
with machine learning is
how generally applicable it is to so
many different kinds of problems so
again a very interesting um model to
check out also very well documented so
great project to check out here's one
about applying machine learning to
geology about predicting lithologies
using Wireline logs I can't say that I
understand the entire project but I can
definitely see the pieces the pieces
that you can pick up is defining the
machine learning problem understanding
what the inputs are what the outputs are
what kind of problem it is what kind of
models you need to use and then going
through the process of training good
models and experimenting and staying
organized here's one about add demand
prediction predicting whether U certain
machine learning ad is going to be
clicked on here's one on financial
distress prediction predicting whether
somebody will face financial distress
within the next year or two and another
machine learning project on credit
scoring and I hope you notice a similar
Trend that is there across all of these
projects which is how to apply machine
learning to the real
world all of these are on real world
data sets from Kagen right so with that
I want to thank you for attending this
Workshop we are almost running up on 3
hours we will take questions but for
those who want to go thanks a lot for
attending uh we are planning to do more
workshops every week or every other week
so do subscribe to our YouTube channel
and of course if you are learning
machine learning or data science do go
on . a do sign up do take some of our
courses build some interesting projects
and also share these courses with other
folks who might find it useful um we
also have a community Discord where you
can come chat with us and we have a
community Forum as well and if you are
pursuing a career in data science
definitely talk to us about joining the
zero to data science boot camp we think
it could be a great fit if you're
looking to make that career transition
so that's all I have for you today thank
you for joining I will see you next time
have a good day or good
night okay and let's take the questions
now there is a comment come question
from part
tick really love the session understood
everything right from creating a project
pipeline feature engineering saving
files in parkit format uploading our
submission files with descriptions as
model parameters hyperparameter tuning
Etc I just have had one question not
regarding the session that one uh not
regarding session but how can you find a
problem that will solve some
unique okay how can you find a unique
problem statement right yeah so I don't
think that there are many unique problem
statements in in the world right now uh
like even the data sets that you find
online you will find that many people
have created many machine learning
projects on those but that should not
stop you on working with the data set
because everyone brings their own
perspective effective everyone's going
to do their own analysis everyone's
going to train their own kind of models
try their own ideas so you will almost
certainly one learn a lot from the
process even if there are 100 other
projects on a data set like New York
taxi fair where 1500 people have made
submissions right out of the 1500
probably many people may have trained
models for uh several days or probably
like months and still may not have been
able to make the top 500 but with some
smart feature engineering you might be
able to get to the top 400 in just a
couple of days so that shouldn't stop
you from trying that data set and the
second thing is
um it's ultimately
about yeah so so the second thing is
about finding good problems I would say
that you should try and find problems
where a lot of people are already
working on that problem because that is
an indication that it's a good problem
to solve so when I came across a New
York taxi fair data set I saw that it's
a large data set I saw that like over a
thousand people had participated in the
competition so that probably means that
it's a very very interesting problem to
solve so in in a somewhat
counterintuitive sense the more people
have tried a particular problem the more
interesting it is unless it gets to a
point where it becomes like a
instructive problem which is taught in
courses for example the mnist data set
or the CFR 10 or c400 data sets they are
generally used for teaching and because
they're used for teaching uh pretty much
everybody goes through creating models
for those problems so you want to pick
something that is not used in some
course or some tutorial which is very
popular but at the same time is not
very um like obscure where you don't
understand what the problem statement is
or even if whether it is a machine
learning problem somewhere is there's
that Sweet Spot somewhere in between
just like model training I guess there's
where you find some really good problems
but most important thing you should look
at is independent of whether it's Unique
or not how much you're going to learn
from
it what would be a good reason to test
split a test set to be so small from the
training set well um I believe it could
just be that uh this was Google Cloud
that had run the competition so maybe
they just wanted to see how much
additional
benefit can you get by 10 times or 100
times more data right how much
additional juice can you extract out of
it that's one piece the second I guess
could just be that because Google just
has so much data um but I don't know why
the test set is so small I don't know
these are all
guesses can you teach me how to make a
customized data set well I would I think
that would be a topic for another day
because there is a lot that will be
involved every time kagle works with the
company I know that they spend a lot of
time creating the data
set because the on the one
hand it should be possible to make
predictions using the inputs and the
targets there should be enough signal in
the data but on the other
hand sometimes you introduce something
called leakage where one or two features
might completely end up predicting the
outcome so for classical machine
learning I would say it's not very easy
to come up with your own custom data
sets and of course there's the whole
issue of labeling is itself right so if
you have to sit and label all the data
data yourself that's going to make
things much harder for you but for deep
learning when you're working with image
recognition problems or with natural
language problems there it's a lot
easier to create custom data sets and
again that's a topic for uh another day
but uh we do have a tutorial on building
a deep learning project from scratch on
our YouTube channel that you can check
out so thank you thank you again for
joining you can find us on www.
jan. and I'll see you next time thanks
and
goodbye hey guys welcome to the tutorial
of deploying a machine learning model in
this tutorial we are going to deploy a
already trained model into live
production I will try to keep things as
simple as possible and I hope you'll be
able to follow along when I'm going
through the
tutorial if not please post your
question on the chat and I'll take the
questions at the very end of the
tutorial so with that let's
start so for this tutorial I'll be using
this notebook so our topic for today is
deploying a machine learning model and
we are going to create a web application
using flask a python web framework and
deploy it in the cloud using render you
will also learn how to add HTML
templates and see how to style it using
CSS very basic uh by the end of this
tutorial you will have a basic
understanding of how to create a web
application using flask integrate
machine learning models into the web
application and know how to deploy a web
application to the
cloud the following topics are covered
in this tutorial uh first we'll set up
the project on GitHub and uh cond
environment and then we'll create a
simple web application using flask just
a simple like uh print something on the
web page uh then add HTML templates to
the web app then we will uh use we will
see what ml model we are using we will
just learn a bit about it we will not go
deep into the ml model
um and then run the model locally on a
web browser publish to GitHub and deploy
to render and finally we'll create an
API route for the model so that these
are the topics that we are going to
cover there are certain prerequisites
for this uh for this tutorial I would
say very basic you have to you should I
think you should have very basic
knowledge in Python by basic I just mean
defining a function I guess uh very
basic knowledge of HTM tags like body
div headings forms Etc and uh CSS Styles
like background color text align Etc and
some level of understanding of machine
learning Concepts uh just like if you
have if you are given with the model you
should know how to predict uh with the
value okay I think uh you'll be able to
understand even though you don't have
don't know some of this so try to follow
along okay so definitely we are going to
solve a problem uh in this tutorial the
problem states that you are given a
pre-trained email spam classifier model
and its requirements basically what are
the things there in the model uh our
task would be to deploy the model and
prepare it for end users so anyone can
go to the site give a email or body
email body and we'll be able to
understand whether it's a spam email or
not a whether it's not a spam email to
achieve this we need to design a web
page definitely using HTML and uh
predict using the model whether it's a
Spam or
not the web page interface should be as
friendly and simple user friendly and
simple as possible and in short we have
to design a form that takes only one
input that is the email body the email
text uh and returns whether the email is
Spam or not
okay cool enough of all this um
theoretical part let's start with
creating the simple flask app for that
we'll start with creating a new
repository on GitHub I'll go to
github.com and I have already signed in
you can sign in or sign up to github.com
I'll create a new repository here and
give a repository name so let's say
model deployment it can be anything any
unique name I will skip the description
keep it public add rme file you can add
the r file later but I'm adding it now a
g ignore template uh this is basically a
common template used for different
programming languages I'll use the
python one and then license you can skip
but I'll use the MIT
license um just because like it's the
best one for open source
projects okay so we have created a uh
GitHub repository right so now let's
start coding we will be using uh code
spaces here but there are different
options for code like for coding okay so
you can use replate or vs code locally
uh for the coding part but I'll be using
GI up Cod space as as it is easy to set
up I'll just click on code here go to
code space and say create codes space on
Main well let that open let that set up
I'll also have to uh create a cond
environment now what is cond cond is a
package manager just like pip and it
also allows us to create environments
now an environment is used ful to manage
a c like a certain
project uh so if you have a project if
you can build different environments for
different projects and uh have the uh
packages required for particular
projects in that particular environment
okay so this is our uh
repository so we will see if K is
available for first so we can just say k
version
and yes K is already available let's
start by uh creating a k environment so
here is the command you can just uh
start create the
environment so I'll allow and cond
create minus n this environment name can
be something like let's say model
deployment and I have assigned python
3.7.1 but uh you can use the latest
version also I'll tell in the towards
the end I'll tell why I used this
particular
version so while it's installing let us
also install the python extension to
codespace yep there it is let's install
this and yeah it's asking permission to
install the different libraries I'll
just click
yes
okay just a minute I think there is an
issue you canot you're not able to see
the GitHub
screen just give me one
moment
yep I think it should be visible now so
I will just repeat the steps very uh
quickly so first okay I'll just start
from creating a new GitHub workspace
right so let's go to
that yeah sorry for all the issues uh it
was a technical glitch I I guess so we
will just log GitHub first okay
github.com
will'll start uh here click new
repository and let's say model
deployment as we as we already have
model deployment uh I will just say
V2 I click on add a readme I'll click
on python I'll select the python gting
node template I'll select a license
MIT okay and I'll click on create
repository we are starting again from
the GitHub uh creating a new depository
right so now next we will use a code
editor we can use cod spaces we can use
replit we can use vs
code so here I'm going to use code
spaces and in this tutorial I have
mentioned the different steps to install
like to use replate to use vs code
okay so while it opens I will just
install the python extension
here let it open I
guess I will uh stop the other Cod space
because it might take
some usage so I'll just go to code
spaces
yep just give me one
moment yeah I'll just delete this code
space uh the previous one and here yeah
the Cod space is now open we'll install
the p py um extension and I'll also
check if K is available here so K minus
D Dash version and yes
uh yes K is available so I will in
create a new cond
environment so yeah here is the code
cond create minus an environment name
python
3.7.1
so here I'll just give environment name
let's say
deployment it can be anything you can
give any name and I've assigned python
3. 7.10 I'll let it
install and here I
will yep so I'll let it install
first and here we'll say yes I let it
install all the
packages yep cond is installed I will
try to activate this but I think it
should return some error let's
see yep it says K is not initialized so
I'll just say cond in it bash I'm using
bash sh cool I think it's initialized
I'll have to just reopen a b shell I'll
delete that previous one and now you can
see the cond base environment here right
so we created another en environment
called deployment so cond activate
deployment this will activate the
deployment environment that we have
created right okay so now we only have a
few packages installed here so you can
see this 35 okay and uh so I would like
to install different packages in this
environment I'll just select this
packages installation type install and
enter this will install a bunch of
packages that are required for this
tutorial
okay while it installed let's go to the
next steps that is create and run a
flask web server right so first we'll
need to create a app.py file so here
I'll create a app.py
file app.py file will write all the flas
code in this file basically uh
everything everything python related
stuff will be in this file so let's
just right and now the libraries are
installed so what we will do first is
import flask so from
flask import
flask cool
the next step is creating an instance of
flask so app
flask underscore name this will create
an instance of the flask class okay and
name is basically referring to this
current uh file okay a current module
cool let's go let's
now create a route so what is a routee
basically so whatever you see on this
website this is a route so jan.com is a
route now if I uh go to jan.com
notebooks it's another route okay is
basically going to the notebooks uh
route so I will create a route like this
slash this basically means the Home
Route that is jan.com okay or for here
it'll be different so app.
route so the route is kind like so the
route is defined as a decorator so I'll
just say that and I'll create a function
called home and I'll return hello
world okay so we're trying to create a
flask uh application where there will be
a text called hello world
right so now what we have to do is we
have to run this so we have to run the
flask application so I can just copy
this but I'll just go step by step so if
name equals equals
mean and here I can just say app.
run cool with
this zoom in the screen with this uh
I'll just zoom in the
screen yep I think that's visible uh
that's better okay so with this we can
just uh run the python file let's say
Python
app.py and you can see that it's running
it's showing up on
the right side that
open in
browser I can click
that and you'll be able to see a hello
world here
I'll zoom in
here yep that's there hello world cool
now the next step is if I want to change
I want to change this hello world to
something else I'll call this
updated right I'll save
it and let's refresh but it's not
showing up the update is not showing up
here so what we have to do is whenever
we save uh change something and save it
it should show up so for that we can
activate the debug mode so debug equals
true okay and I'll just close this
and uh and run the server again to close
I'll just say contrl s contrl c and run
it again python app.py now again let's
see so you can see this hello world
updated and now if I change something
here updated version
2 it should show up here also yep it's
showing up so that is a simple basic
flask
app uh we have created a very basic
flash cap and I think it was very
straightforward up till
now um yeah the notebook is shared on
the chat window so you can just access
the notebook from
there okay uh that's creating a simple
flask application but now we will try to
render an HTML template okay for that we
will create a new file here new uh
folder called templates cause flask
uses this folder this templates name for
uh better uh for for their rendering
templates right okay so we have created
a folder called templates here and then
we will create a new file it can be
anything let's call it
index.html and here we can write our
HTML code so I'll just copy this code
here basically what we are doing is we
are giving a head uh title of my first
web page and it says hello world from
template now if I save this and if I
load it will not update because we have
not updated in
app.py okay so here what I will do
is I'll I'll have to render the template
right so I'll render
template and just give the path of the
file now as I said render template looks
in the templates folder okay so we don't
have to give the path exact path like
template / index.html we we can just say
index.html and rer template is not uh
imported I mean yeah not imported so we
can just import it Ender template I'm
seeing some errors here right so I want
to remove those errors that is causing
by es lint so for now I will just
deactivate yes
lint yep and the error should go
yeah cool so now if I update
this yeah the this has uh so what
happens in codespace is you are we are
using a free version of codespace it
reloads or uh stops sometime okay or you
can we see we have got an error here so
it has stopped we can just say python
app.py
again and it's
starting yep hello world from template
so this came from template right so you
can see this template had a title my
first web page so this title is showing
up here on top my first web page and
here the H1 is hello World from template
so that is what is coming here so yes we
have created a uh web app and rendered a
template HTML template here cool um the
next thing we are going to do is
creating a simple form so our end goal
is creating a email spam classifier it
should have a input text area it should
have a heading like this it should have
a button so this is the next thing we
are going to do so we are going to
update this index.html file here
and we will give a H1 let's say the
heading will be email Pam
classifier so let's see what we have got
here Yep this is again reloaded for
what yeah I think it's again I have to
reload this just I'll stop this and
again python
app.py okay so I'm getting an error so
let's see what the error is so first
I'll let update this cond environment
here so the cond environment is this one
we are
using
and yep let's
see so we will try to fix this error
Let's see we will run this app
again
and yep it's now loading again okay cool
so uh I think I was not I think the H
environment was the issue so we have got
the email spam classifier
heading now we will create a
form in this we will add a text
area okay and we will also add a button
here that's what is there in this thing
so a text area and a button so this text
area let's now look at the web page
once yeah we have a text area and a
button so let's uh modify it a bit we
will give a button we'll call it check
spam and this text area can have a
placeholder like this enter your email
so let's do that enter your
placeholder equals
enter
your
email uh body
okay once we load save that and refresh
this we got this this is good enough I
guess we are getting there so we can say
row equals
to uh we we can increase the size of the
text box so I'll just modify this rows
to let's
say 15 and calls number of calls
basically rows is the height and calls
is the width
so I'll say width as let's say
25 let's see uh how it looks now yep it
is looking a bit better I can increase
the width to
35 and yeah I think this is better so
one more thing I want this check spam
below this so I can create a different
block for this so what I will do is I'll
put this in a
div
yep that's there and this is looking
let's refresh this this is looking fine
in this the this is centered so we can
also add a style tag here to Center
everything is a KN way of adding CSS but
I'll be using this for now
just in the interest of time uh so I'll
be adding let's say
body I'll align the text to
Center okay now see let's see how it
looks yep everything is aligned to the
center we can also improve the button so
button we can give a background color of
blue and a text
color or color
of white
y let's see how it looks yeah this is
looking better so now we have uh our
simple form okay but what does this form
do this does nothing as of now right if
I just click here and write something
will do
nothing what we want is we want
something this whatever we have written
here we want to display it below right
so let's do that I'll just zoom in a bit
more yeah this is better okay so
let's get let's write something here
right below so we can just give a
paragraph tag or a heading h2 tag I'm
giving a heading h2 tag here H2 is
basically second header and I'll say
hi so let's refresh the page again and
you can see high here so instead of high
I want to display whatever is showing up
here right so what we can do is we have
to update uh we can use Ginga template
okay so we have to update two few things
in this first we'll go to the app.py
file okay and
here we will give the method so we are
basically we are sending a post request
by clicking on this button okay so we
can update that we can go to the
index.html and say this button this form
will send a post request the method is
post all right cool now the post request
is sent okay what we want is we want to
get the text from the post right we can
say the method so this particular route
okay Home Route accepts two methods it
accepts a get and a post
request so why get get is basically when
you open this web page or when open this
URL okay it will fetch the web page from
the server and get it okay so that is
get and post is on clicking this button
it will uh show something here so that
is the post request right so both get
and post and I'll just say if request do
method equals equals
post there will be a text which
is request
dot let's see
it is request. form doget right so it's
the code is here we can just say text
equals to request. form
doget
okay cool I will uh return the text here
but one thing you can see that there is
something called email content I don't
know what that is okay so basically
email content is should be the name of
the text area so we'll add a name here
so we are fetching this email
content okay email
content so we will be getting text from
this email content text area right and
request is not present here that's why
it's giving the error so we can just say
request we can import the request from
flask cool so that's great okay but if
we still refresh this okay this has I'll
have to uh run the server again
so let's see let's run the server
again getting some
error okay let's see we are getting some
error uh let's fix that so what we have
done is we have added a method post okay
and it shouldn't give a error let me
just run that server
again
yep just this happens sometime with uh
code spaces let's just run the server
again so this yeah it's running now okay
so this problem doesn't happen with your
local uh development vs code okay it
happens sometime with code spaces so now
if I write something here okay uh let's
say hello
world I'll click click check spam and it
should show Hello World here but it's
not showing up because we have we are
fetching the high till now so we will
use this Ginger template okay and ginger
template engine to get the text from
here okay so this we have returned the
text in app.py this is the text we have
returned I want to fetch that text right
okay so I'll fetch that text
here and that should show up now let's
type hello world
yep it's showing up here one more thing
we want is we want to show the hello
world here okay so what we can do we can
just give the hello world here the text
here
also in the text
area okay so now if I just say hello
world it's showing up here also and it's
still remaining here also it's not
showing enter your email content okay
that's great we have we are Midway
through now what what else to do we can
uh I want to reset this now if I refresh
this page okay this hello world will
still remain here so I want to reset
this very ni way of doing this is I'll
just add a HF
here okay and I'll give a path I'll give
the Home Route
okay and I'll give a reset uh text
so what this will do this will add a
hyperlink or this will add a uh link
okay of reset okay and we'll just fetch
the Home Route okay I'll get the get
request so let's
refresh and we have got a reset
button and let's see if I just click on
this reset everything is reset okay so
this is looking a lot better now hello
world check spam it shows hello world
and reset okay cool we have
now uh fetched like we have now shown
whatever is uh input we are giving in
the text area we are now showing it on
the web page okay so what's the next
step now let's learn a bit about the
model itself okay so an email Spire
classifier model spam classified model
is a classification model and uh what it
does is it categorizes either a email is
Spam or not spam okay that's the basic
thing now the data set has a uh labeled
emails okay and uh and it also has some
email body so basically the data set has
a email body the label that it is a spam
or not a Spam and it's a classification
supervised model okay so I'm not going
deep into the models and what models are
trained I'll uh link a notebook here you
can check that how the model was trained
but what are the things to note the
things to note is it the E model takes a
plain text we'll send the plain text
using this uh text area okay it will
tokenize okay so we'll have to Tok uh
tokenize the text okay so that step we
need to do then it will run the model.
predict okay uh the tokenized text and
it will return either one which is Spam
or not one which is not spam so that's
the basic thing you need to know about
this model okay cool now let's head on
to running the model locally but before
doing that we need a few things we need
the model and the tokenizer okay or we
are using count vectorizer here we need
these two things so I have linked those
two things here count vectorizer and
model uh what we will do is we uh I
already have it downloaded okay so I
will use that but you can download it
from this
links now we will create a new folder
named model okay inside our repository
so let's create a new folder
here so the folder is
models and inside this models I already
have a couple of files the models I'll
just paste it here cool the models are
there the models are loaded now what I
will do is I
will yep so now I will have to load that
model right now I have to load that
model integrate that model to our web
page right so we will update the app.py
file we'll start with updating the app.
pi file and here we we have defined this
uh thing in the Home Route okay we have
defined this hello world uh this post
response in the uh in this particular
home uh a default route but I'm going to
create a new route that will take a post
request so let's say app.
route and we will give a new route
called
predict and this will take
methods as post only the post method
right so basically this method this
route will only be fetched only when we
click on the check spam button cool so I
will say post
here and we'll create a new function
called
predict cool and we will again return
the same template lender
template that is index.html template we
can use the same template for multiple
functions so we are using the same
template okay so now we don't need these
things this text uh request. post okay
so basically home the Home Route will
now only uh get this page if I am in the
Home Route I will only see this page
nothing else right so I will remove this
methods also we don't need a post method
for the Home
Route and that's it so this is the Home
Route and we are creating the predict
route now in this what we have to do is
first we have to get get the email text
so this text whatever we giving here you
have to get that for that we can say
email text equals to request dot get dot
sorry request. form doget yep request.
form
doget and we need to specify the text
area name here so email
content email
Yep this is the one email
content okay so we got the email text
now so whatever we we are writing here
this will be coming here cool now what
we have to do next we have to tokenize
this text right so to tokenize this text
we have to basically let's define a new
variable tokenized email
we have to tokenize now we have to use
this tokenizer this uh count vectorizer
CV okay so this is the model count
vectorizer model which will tokenize so
we can just say CV
dot transform okay so this is coming
from SK learn we use the transform but
we don't have CV yet right so first
we'll have to import the pickle Library
so this a pickle file we have to load
the CV and model okay so let's import
pickle and we have to basically load
this Pi so let's do that import
pickle TV
equals
pickle.
load
open cv.
pickle uh I can call it let's say
organizer and read binary because uh a
pickle file is a binary file so so we'll
say read binary similarly the model can
be
pickle do
load
open um clf
dople and again read by so CF is the
classifier that is the
model and this specific models uh you
can you might not recognize these names
because I have created these models and
you don't might you might not have idea
but when you are having your own model
when you to deploy that okay you will
have the particular plle file name and
everything you will have it with
yourself right so this is tokenizer this
is the model I've uh got
this this request spelling is wrong RQ s
yep now this
tokenizer do
transform and I can say email
text and again I'll have to predict the
model also so predict predictions let's
say predictions equals to model do
predict this is what we do in SK learn
to predict a model tokenized email okay
so this is the pre-processed text okay
and we are passing that uh so you can
also call it the x value this is the X
okay we're passing it to model. predict
fine uh cool now one last thing here is
if the prediction is one it is Spam and
if the prediction is not one then it is
not spam so let's do
predictions equals 1 if
predictions equals equals 1 else minus
one so if it is a spam will it will be
one fine if it is already one it will be
one if it is not one it will be minus
one okay so this things this all these
things I have got from the model okay
which I have defined so this things
might be particular this will change
from to person whatever models they are
creating whatever way they are training
okay uh so these things we'll have to
get directly the idea from the model
itself correct cool so now we have this
predictions what we have to do is we
have to pass this predictions the
predictions equals
predictions and text okay so we will
also pass the email text remember I want
to show the email text here so so that
it doesn't disappear okay so I'll also
return the Emil text okay so text equals
email
text okay let's call this email text
also cool so I
think the spelling of predictions is
wrong yep that's correct now so I think
this is good I don't need to change
anything on the app.py file I what I
have done is I have uh kept the default
route as uh just fetching the index.html
page okay and I have um created a new
route called predict okay which will
take in a like which will take uh get
the text from the text area we'll do the
tokenizing like we'll do the uh
tokenizing part okay and also do the
prediction part and it will return the
prediction uh to the basically it will
return the prediction to the HTML okay
so now here what we have to do is we
have to change this text to
prediction I hope it's called
prediction called predictions okay so
predictions and again to save the email
text we have changed it to email text so
I'll call it email text here in the text
area cool let me just go to the new
line here yeah so this is called text
email text and
uh yep so we
are I think this is good now one thing
here so so we have to give so initially
this form was posting to the default
route that's why we have not given
anything else here but now we are uh
making a post request to the predict
route okay so we have to give actions
here so let's call it
actions and uh I will say predict I'll
give the route here okay we are
basically making a post request to the
predict
route okay so let's see if this works or
not I'll have to run this again this has
reload
I'll call python
app.py okay so it
says oh the path okay so it there is an
error okay it says the file not found
error so I the path is wrong here so
I'll have to say models. CV dople models
C.P and
models dople why because we have saved
the models in the models directory okay
so that's there now let's try to run
this again and see if it's
working yep it's running let us open it
in browser let's give a simple
text
hello
world or this is a email
body okay and let's see what we get oh
it says method not allowed okay let's
see what error we have got it says for
05 that means we are not able to get uh
we are not able to make a post request
let's see what's the error so here we
have given predict as the route the
method is
post okay one thing I'll do here is if
request
dot
method equals equals
post I will get this Emil text
although I don't need
this but yeah I'll just give this okay
so that means when there is a post
request I'll get the email text okay
that is fine but actions method post
actions
predict
okay method post actions predict I think
this should work let me run this
again
let me see if this works this is a
email yep okay finally cool so I think
this action was wrong in the previous
one so it should be uh action not
actions okay uh but I am still getting
an error here it says that um tokenized
email CV transform here it is wrong
Let's
see we will fix that error but but
finally we were able to get this so cv.
transform email okay cool and we are
getting the error as non type object
right
Co
so non type object has no attribute
lower okay so let's see I have not given
any text is it this is a
email button okay I'll just run this
again
python
app.py
okay I think I'll have to open it again
python
app.py this is an issue with code space
I'll have to open in
browser okay n type attribute has no
object lower cool let's look at the code
again so email we are getting the email
here and uh this we are getting the name
is content now so
content this should be content okay cool
I think this should
work
yep finally we are we have got the
result minus one so this is not a Spam
okay so I think this content was wrong
okay uh this is now content okay because
I've copied the code from here so this
was having content and I had to set
content here okay so everything else is
still the same we are getting the email
uh content from this okay and we are
creating the tokenization we're doing
the tokenization we're doing the
prediction and we're returning the
prediction okay and the email text so
here we are just getting the email text
in the text area and getting the
predictions in the predictions in the H
H2 okay so this is the result now we'll
click on the reset to we'll check just
reset is working or not so if we click
reset everything is reset that's working
fine okay great so now what we want is
now we want to show this as not minus
one and one so we are getting minus one
here if we type this is an
I want to show spam here instead of
minus one for that what we can do is we
can change this we can add python code
here using gja template so I'll just
type
here percentage
percentage
and here I'll say
if
prediction equals this is just simple
python if predictions equal equal equals
1 okay then I will
say then this will be like
spam
okay I write spam
here
and else if L if that is L
if
prediction equals equals
minus1 will
be
this will be not
spam I'll copy
this yep so this will be not spam
correct now I'll end the if so this is a
bit different than python but almost
similar so I'll just say this is and L
if sorry end if correct okay so this is
the format so for writing a if here if
predictions equ one within this curly
bracket and percentage and this will be
spam if it is prediction is one if it is
minus one then it is not spam correct
let's now try to run this
once there is an email if
I yep it should
be end if okay I'll just refresh this
once this is an email and just clicking
on this button it says not spam okay so
we have got it it should be end without
space if okay
cool uh so now we can modify this a bit
we can add a small style here okay so
style let's say
color is for spam let's say the color is
red and for not
spam the color can be
green okay uh let's check what it
[Music]
does yep not spam this this is working
okay so I have um kept uh
temp spam email and a non-spam email
example here I'll just copy and see if
it's working everything is working fine
this is a spam email I got in my mail
folder okay and I'm not saying the model
is 100% correct okay it can also return
wrong so this is again a part of machine
learning okay so I am not going into the
machine learning part this can be not a
spam email but it's showing it must show
SC spam here okay according to the model
I have
created uh again I'll check this and
this shouldn't so
spam let's check this once and yeah it's
not spam okay so great I think we have
finally created the model and run the
model locally so we have done most of
the part now the next thing that is
remaining is uh deploying this web
application to
Cloud Okay so
yeah so the next part is deploying the
web application to Cloud so what we will
do is we will prepare for publishing
first okay so we have to have a
requirement. txt file in this
requirements.txt file we have to save
all the libraries that are required for
this particular um project okay so we
already know that P free shows I'll just
let me open let me stop this server once
okay I'll show you what P free shows so
if I do P freeze here it will show me
all the libraries that are required for
this particular project okay so what I
can do is I'll save all this things in
requirements
dot requirements.txt
file requirements yeah the spelling is
correct and here you see that all of
this are saved okay so there is a
library called this I think this is
wrong in this case I'll just uninstall
it and install it again P uninstall
certify
just uninstall this and pip install
certify okay let's see if it's now it's
correct so if freeze greater than symbol
requirements.txt and yeah now it's
showing correct okay so now we have all
the libraries that are required for this
particular project okay so we have
created a project we are ready to deploy
this okay we'll take it live so next is
pushing this changes to GitHub to do
that we can check the changes that are
made here okay so we have made changes
in app.py find re. txt uh settings dojon
yeah this is looking fine we can just
commit it from here we can just give a
commit message and commit it from here
but I'll just do it from the terminal
for this time get add
dot get
commit minus M let's say first
commit yep get
push origin
main yeah uh so you might have to set a
get config like who is who who is
pushing who is trying to commit okay so
if you are doing it for the first time I
have made uh I've set up like link here
okay if if it is if you're getting an
error while trying to commit you can
check this guide cool okay now the next
thing is publishing with render so we
will directly head on to let's first
check the GitHub repository now okay
this was our repository in the beginning
you can make changes in the readme.md
file but let's check this first if it is
working yep all the changes are here you
can see the app.py file changes
here okay cool now uh let's open render
for deployment so render doc so render
uh lets you deploy some websites for
free okay uh and
yep it is very easy to use so that's
there also so I'll just open
render I'll log in with GitHub that's
what I have done uh so I have few
previous previous deployments here so
what I will do here is I will create a
new web
service and I will configure GitHub here
I will connect with the my GitHub
account it's not connected you can see
so I'll connect with GitHub by pressing
configure GitHub and all of these steps
are also mentioned in this notebook so
if you uh you can follow this notebook
also so then I'll go to my account okay
and here I will say I give access to all
repositories for now okay I'll say
install yep now uh GitHub is connected
with replate let me just refresh this
once and let's press new web
service yep now it is now GitHub is
connected with replat right okay uh so
if it was not working you should once
refresh the page because it's already
connected so this was the one I I was
working on model deployment V2 okay I'll
click on connect okay now here I'll give
a service name I'll say model
deployment okay I can select a region so
I'll just select I let it be the default
region Singapore southeast Asia try to
select a region that's nearer to you or
whever the most traffic is the main
branch I want to connect with the main
branch okay if I don't have any other
Branch as of now uh then I don't have
any root directory so I'll not set
anything here my root directory is
already the one directory that is there
that is the um this directory basically
okay if you uh have your R directory was
SRC you could have given that SRC or
anything else now I am using Python 3 as
the runtime we have created a
requirements.txt file so this is the
build command here BB install minus
requirements.txt this is fine and also
you can see that something here is G
Unicon app colon app we have already
installed G Unicon in
our uh while while creating the
environment okay so if you check the
requirements of txt file you can see G
Unicon G Unicon uh helps you is a you
can say it's a library that helps you um
deploy your website okay so here there
are two things app colon app so this app
is the file name you are trying to run
okay so our file name is app so this
will be app okay and this app is the
flask instance okay so we have this in
our app we have something called app
here this app okay so this is the app
that is flask instance okay I will
select the free instance type that is uh
that only has 512 MB RAM and 1.1 CPU and
I'll just click create web service
okay so now we have created the web
service and let's go to the next step
okay so all the steps are mentioned here
what I have done next step is awaiting
deployment so now it will you can see
that deployment will start okay and
we'll have to wait okay this this at
this point we'll have to wait for the
deployment to run it because we're using
the free instance it might take some
time okay and we might also get some
errors so that we have to fix now why we
have used python 3.7 10 I mentioned at
the very beginning uh that K create
python 3. 7.10 because by default uh
render is using python 3. 7.10 okay uh
so that's why we have used python 3.
7.10 uh as our um cond and like for for
this in particular uh project okay but
if you want to use the latest python
version you can just you have
to you have to mention this on the
python like en environment file okay so
there is a dock here on how to uh use
the latest python version cool so you
can see it says build uploaded so build
successful okay so build like all the
packages were installed okay all the
required packages now it's starting to
deploy uh it's trying to
start let's see yep the service is live
okay cool that was fast okay so the
service is now live let's check this
okay is working fine let's zoom
in yep so now this link this is my email
body okay let's check once Yep this is a
spam I don't know why but this is a spam
so this link is live this is published
live and everyone can access it so I'll
just post it in the comments and
everyone can access this uh this
particular uh link to check whether the
email that I have got is this spam or
not so I have successfully deployed my
email spam classify model OKAY in the
same way you can deploy all other models
okay so we are done with the deployment
okay now one last thing we are going to
cover is API how to uh create an API
route okay so I'll just go back to my
app.py file again and here basically the
very basic way of uh like what this what
does creating an API route mean is we
are not going to use the web interface
this thing okay we are going to send the
request as a Json okay and we are also
going to get the output as a Json okay
so that is what by creating a API means
okay API route so we will do
that so let's again create a new route
app.
route SL API so now we'll give a API so
this is a general convention we can say
so we can say API SL predict this is the
new route this is not the same as this
predict okay
and we can call
methods uh again this will be
post okay uh now again this is API we
can give a function name API
predict function name can be anything
I'm calling it API predict the first
thing is getting the email so email will
be request
get
Json okay and I'll force Json
okay I'll force that it should it to get
Json okay so this called Force equals to
True uh then I got the email body so
next part is same okay so I'll just copy
this the same
thing okay and
return again I'll just
return a Json uh file right I'll not
return this render template I'll not
render template I'll just return the
Json I'll say
jsonify and let's just return the
prediction prediction equals
prediction okay so it's returning the
Json okay but uh this jifi is not we
have not imported this jifi so we can
import it from flask jifi it's present
in the flask
module yep so now we have successfully
created a API route okay now let's try
to see if this API route is accessible
via web page okay so I'll just say
Python
app.py and we have got our new this
thing this is an
email okay and if we click on button you
can see it's going to the predict route
and it's getting not spam okay
but if I just call like this API SL
predict we are not getting anything okay
so this is this is now not how we call
an API correct so what we can do is we
can use um uh different API tools okay
we can use maybe Postman insomnia or
other tools to call an API we can also
call it uh By Request or by using
terminal but I will use a tool called
Thunder client I'll install the
extension Thunder
client and while it's installing I'll go
back to my notebook okay so here is how
you can fetch the API okay you can use
command line you can use Python you can
use any API testing tools okay for
example Thunder Cent insomnia Postman
I'll be using Thunder Cent here so let's
go back I think Thunder client is
already installed y let me just refresh
this codespace once
yeah and thunder CLI should show up
here yeah Thunder CL is here okay so I
will do a new
request and here I have to give my URL
okay so this URL so for that first we'll
have to run this first we'll have to run
our uh app python app.py okay
now it's running in this particular link
okay so the URL will be this link SL API
SL
predict okay so this is the
URL yeah I'll just copy
this and give the URL and we are sending
a post request not a get request okay so
I'll post and the body so what will the
body have right so let's go back to the
code ones and here you can see we
are yep so we have to give a Content
so let's just go back
here yeah request. get Jon so we okay
we're getting the data in this form okay
we have to get the content so this is
the data and out of that we are fetching
the content okay so this will be the
data we getting the data and the email
is basically
the content from the
data okay so this content should be a
key in the Json okay so now let's see so
we will be sending a Json with a key
called content okay and this
is the email
body okay now let's try to send this and
we are not getting a response let me
just run this once again
yep I'll close everything and let's run
this once
again python
app.py let's see open in
browser Now this/ API SL
predict I'll copy this uh copy and paste
this new URL here we have this new
URL and I am sending this so it sharing
method not allowed so have I done okay /
API predict methods
post let me check SL API predict method
post and force true
okay I will just copy this
once yep so this should
return let me just run this once
again Yep this is
running SL API SL
predict I think I will okay let me check
new request here change the link and
let's send okay I'll have to uh deploy
this because I think this is not taking
this Local Host okay so let me just once
again make a g push
okay I'll just make a g push once again
with the new
code
so added API
route
commit yep I'll stage everything and
make the changes so what it will do is
it will automatically deploy the new
code to render let me just go to
render okay and here let's just sign
in yep deployment is progress so the new
version is deploying now
okay so let me let's let's wait for
deployment yeah it's still deploying so
you will see when it's
deployed
okay let's wait for this while uh so one
more thing I want to talk to you about
is code refactoring so what we can do is
so you can see in our code that this
part is repeating twice okay so we can
refactor this okay and create a new
utils file where we will predict our
model okay so let's do that so first
what we'll do is we'll create a new file
called utils.py
okay and here we will copy a few things
first is the pickle part import pickle
and uh this CV we'll copy the model uh
models okay we'll copy this and paste it
here the model loadings and also import
pickle we are trying to uh reduce all of
this from this particular file and
create another file for the model
prediction
okay now I'll copy this code tokenized
email equals to
this and paste it in the utils.py
file okay I'll post put it inside a
function called
def make
prediction with the email
body okay and it will return a
prediction okay so once that's done what
we can do is we can just call this
function make prediction here so let's
say prediction equals make
prediction and we will give email here
so the it accepts a email we'll give
email here so you can see make
prediction is not available here so we
will have to import it we'll import it
from
utils we'll import make
prediction
okay so now that is done so now we can
use this make prediction function to
make prediction we don't need this
anymore again we will just say
prediction equals make prediction email
okay so now you can see the code has is
like reduced a lot so we just have like
three lines of code in each functions to
four lines that's there now let's check
the deployment once yep the deploy
employment is done I'll go to the page
here so we have this uh API right so
that was API SL
predict so now what we can do is we can
go to Thunder
client we can try to make a new
request with this API / predict make a
post request and in the body we will
say
content this is a email
body okay
and uh yeah I think that's it it takes a
content from the data I'll send this
request yep finally we got the API um uh
call okay uh so F uh so we got a
prediction of one that means it's a Spam
okay so yep so that's how you can create
an API also and F an API I think it was
not working because we are using Code
space and the code space uh the Local
Host URL was I think it's a bit
different but once uh now everyone can
access this API uh and give a Content
okay and a email body here and you'll
get a Spam on not spam like prediction
will be either one or minus one okay so
that's it okay so that's what is there
in this uh notebook also you can follow
this notebook and uh uh see how to
create an API code refactor and fetch
the API so one exercise for everyone is
I am not too good in creating a good UI
you can see that this is a very bad UI
and if I even uh zoom out it will look
even bad okay so what you can do is you
can try to improve the UI okay and what
you can add is you can add a heading
here you can add a introduction here you
can make the box like this you can make
the button like this you can add the
example uh spam email and example not
spam email on the left side and also
what you can do is you can add another
model if you have like multiple machine
learning models you can add different
models on the top okay let's a Spam
classifier then uh image classifier
whatever is there okay uh all of this on
the top so you can change the UI you can
modify the UI yourself so try to uh go
through the entire notebook and uh
create this um email spam classifier
model deployment also okay we you
already have the model try to create the
deployment okay so what we have covered
in this tutorial so I think we are
towards the end of this tutorial we have
covered how to uh use flask okay how to
create a very basic website using flask
then we have uh also seen how to set up
a GitHub and cond environment okay I've
seen how to use HTML and CSS and python
to uh uh then we have uh seen how to uh
run a model locally how to integrate a
model into our uh web page and run it
locally uh then we have seen how to
deploy the web application to Cloud use
uh like push changes to GitHub and then
prepare it for uh like then uh publish
to render then fix the errors in the
render so we have not got any error uh
while publishing but if you face any
error you have to make the changes again
and then again push it okay so those and
then we have seen how to create an API
and also uh seeing how to fetch an API
and do code refactoring so that's all
the things that is covered in this this
notebook okay uh here are a few
references I have mentioned here and
also I have mentioned how to do a vs
code setup or if you want to run this
code in VSS code and also if you want to
run this code in repit I mentioned that
I hope this was very um like very simple
beginner friendly tutorial although we
faced a few Technic like technical
difficulties in the middle but I hope
this was a very um simple
deployment process now I'll take a few
questions I think most of the questions
are already replied but let's
see okay uh thank you uh for the good
comments um yep uh hope this notebook is
useful to you if you can refer it to
this notebook anytime we'll make uh
we'll add the link in the
description okay web service is not
working I am not sure why it is not
working we can discuss it later you can
just um post on probably you can post on
the YouTube comment and we can see we
can talk
further
okay okay there is a question okay where
we can find the pickle models to test
the service and write out yourself okay
so the pickle models are there in this
jupyter
notebook uh you'll find
it here okay the count Vector as a model
in the classifier model you can try it
out and also if you have any different
model if you are if you have work
created different model you can use that
also it doesn't have to be the same IM
SPM classifier
model and
um okay so there are definitely this is
not the I would not say this is the
ultimate Way of creating a like
deployment there are a few steps you
might have to add authorizations also
you might have to add uh like the models
might be very big okay so you might have
to add them in a database or create a
Docker uh okay and um like uh yeah you
can do a lot of things so there is a
scope of future work you can see you can
Implement authentication and user
management okay if you want to restrict
some vure you can uh scale the
application for high traffic okay then
you can um you can also so obviously
improve the user interface we have not
done a lot of in user interface site
then um we you can also see like
Implement real time updates for example
like if someone is typing the email it's
you can just say spam or not spam okay
and a few more things okay those are the
things that you can do for future this
was a very beginner friendly I tried to
keep it very simple uh just for anyone
who has created a model okay and uh just
they can use this steps to deploy their
model and showcase it in their probably
LinkedIn or resume or anywhere okay this
I try to keep it very beginner friendly
but there are a lot of things that can
be done to improve this uh from this
okay cool I think that's
everything
um yep thanks for attending the session
and I'll end it
here I'll end the session here um okay
thank you for attending and see you on
our next
video